HEARING ON SENATE EDUCATION WE
HAVE TWENTY FIVE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA WE HAVE FIVE
ITEMS ON CONSENT.
ITEM FOR AB ONE TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FIVE BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBR
CARILLO HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR.
WE'RE EXPECTING A VERY LONG
HEARING TODAY SO WE WILL LIMIT
TESTIMONY TO TWO PEOPLE PER SIDE
TWO MINUTES EACH.
WITNESSES THAT EXCEED TWO
MINUTES WILL CAUSE THE NEXT TWO
WITNESSES TO HAVE LESS TIME SO
PLEASE DO NOT EXCEED YOUR
ALLOTTED TIME ALL OTHER
WITNESSES WILL STATE THEIR NAME
AND SUPPORTER OPPOSITION ONLY
PLEASE.
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE
GOING TO GET STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE STARTING
WITH -- ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS
AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE AND BEFORE I
GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
I JUST WANTED.
TO LET EVERYONE KNOW THAT THIS
BILL IS VERY MUCH A WORK IN
PROGRESS THE AUTHOR THE SPONSORS
THE OPPOSITION THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
HAVE PUT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
WORK INTO THIS BILL SO WE
APPRECIATE EVERYONE I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S TIME AND EFFORT
BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY BIG ISSUE
AND WE ARE TRYING TO GET IT
RIGHT.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
AUTHORS RECENT AMENDMENTS OR THE
MAKINGS OF A DEAL WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND MY SENSE
IS THAT FOLKS ARE CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC.
THAT THE REMAINING ISSUES CAN BE
RESOLVED OVER THE SUMMER THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN BY THE AUTHOR
TO DATE INCLUDE.
EXTENDING THE TIMELINE FOR
CHARTER PETITION REVIEW AND
APPROVAL AND ENSURING THAT
CHARTER PETITION HEARINGS
INCORPORATE ALL IT INPUT FROM
ALL SIDES.
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO DENY
CHARTER PETITIONS THAT DUPLICATE
PROGRAMS ALREADY OFFERED WOULD
UNDERMINE EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES OR WOULD HARM THE
DISTRICT FINANCIALLY.
PROHIBITING EIGHT CHARTER
PETITION FROM BEING AMENDED
THROUGHOUT THE APPEALS PROCESS
AND LIMITING THE STATE BOARDS
ROLE.
CLARIFYING THE CREDENTIALING
REQUIREMENTS OF CHARTER SCHOOL
TEACHERS CREATING ACADEMICALLY
FOCUSED CHARTER RENEWAL CRITERIA.
PLACING A TWO YEAR MORATORIUM ON
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
I AM NOT ASKING FOR THE AUTHOR
TO TAKE ANY COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TODAY BUT I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
MORE ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT MOVING FORWARD.
SO WITH THAT BACKGROUND AND
PERSPECTIVE IN MIND I WANT TO
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR ALL OF YOUR
HARD WORK YOUR STAFF.
MY STAFF FOR THEIR TREMENDOUS
WORK AND LET'S GET STARTED THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR OUTLINING WHAT IS -- VERY
NECESSARY CONVERSATION.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- THE BILL BEFORE
YOU TODAY AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE
REFORMS THE CHARTER SCHOOL
AUTHORIZATION OVERSIGHT.
APPEALS IN RENEWAL PROCESS SEES.
THE LANGUAGE IN THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL REFLECTS
ONGOING CONVERSATION WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS.
THERE ARE PIECES IN THE BILL
THAT ARE A WORK IN PROGRESS AND
THERE WILL BE CHANGES AS YOU
HAVE OUTLINED -- WITH YOUR
INTRODUCTION MANAGER WE ARE ALL
AWARE THE CHARTER REFORM IS A
TOPIC OF MUCH DISCUSSION INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE THE CAPITAL JUST
LOOK AT THE NEWSPAPER.
IN FACT THERE ARE MANY MEDIA
REPORTS ABOUT THE NEED TO REFORM
THE CURRENT PROCESS NOT TO
ELIMINATE IT.
OKAY BUT TO REFORM ACT.
THIS OF ANYONE TODAY SAYS WE'RE
TRYING TO ELIMINATE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE TRYING TO SHUT DOWN
ALL CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS NOT.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES -- RECENT
ARTICLES IN AGAIN LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS MANY LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS WHERE WHERE WHERE OF
THOSE -- DOCUMENT THE REASONS OR
WHY IT IS TIME TO REFORM THE
CHARTER SCHOOL LAWS IN FACT SAN
DIEGO RECENTLY HAD ELEVEN PEOPLE.
INDICTED FOR SOME NEFARIOUS
ACTIVITIES APPARENTLY.
THE SUPERINTENDENT'S CHARTER
TASK FORCE CONCURS THAT REFORMS
CONSISTENT WITH THIS BILL ARE
NEEDED.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THOSE SEEKING
TO OPEN A CHARTER SCHOOL TO GO
AUTHORIZE OR SHOPPING.
SIMPLY PUT THIS MEANS THAT AFTER
BEING REJECTED BY ONE BOARD THEY
CAN GO SEARCHING FOR ANOTHER
BOARD FOR APPROVAL.
WHY IS AUTHORIZED YOUR SHOPPING
A PROBLEM?
THE DISTRICT WHERE THE CHARTER
IS LOCATED NOT ONLY LOSES THEIR
STUDENTS TO A SCHOOL THEY DID
NOT BELIEVE WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEIR STUDENTS BUT MAY BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE FACILITIES
OR OTHERWISE ACCOMMODATE.
THE CHARTER SCHOOL AND PROVIDE
SOME -- SOME OVERSIGHT THE FACT
IN THE LA TIMES THERE WAS AN
ARTICLE ABOUT SCHOOLS SHARING.
SPACE AND HOW THAT CAN BE A REAL
STRUGGLE IS PUSHING POLLS --
WITH REGARD TO THAT.
A FURTHER THIS OF THE OVERSIGHT
OF THE CHARTER THAT IS BY AN
ENTITY THAT IS NOT LOCATED IN A
DISTRICT IN FACT MAYBE HUNDREDS
OF MILES AWAY.
PROVIDES A LACK OF OVERSIGHT
AGAIN TIME AND TIME AGAIN IF YOU
CAN YOU CAN READ THE NEWSPAPER
YOU SEE ARTICLES WERE CHARTER
AUTHOR RISERS NINE HUNDRED MILES
AWAY AND COULDN'T PROVIDE THE
OVERSIGHT.
SO WE WE CERTAINLY NEED TO
ADDRESS THAT FACT IN SAN DIEGO
IT WAS A SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT ON
THE ASSEMBLY A HUNDRED AND FORTY
STUDENTS.
YET IT WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS BECAUSE
IT'D AUTHORIZED SO MANY SO MANY
CHARTER OPERATIONS THAT THEY
COULD NOT PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
WHERE THEY DID NOT HAVE THAT
NECESSARY.
INFRASTRUCTURE SO COMMUNITY
IMPACT.
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS AND
ADMINISTRATORS NO THERE
DISTRICTS AND STUDENTS BEST AND
SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DETERMINE WHICH CHARTERS ARE
BEST FOR THEIR STUDENTS.
THIS BILL GIVES DISTRICTS
GREATER FLEXIBILITY CONSIDER HOW
NEW CHARTER SCHOOL WILL IMPACT
THE COMMUNITY OF STUDENTS.
WE MUST ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
CONSIDER THE FISCAL IMPACT OF A
CHARTER SCHOOL MAY HAVE ON A
NEIGHBORHOOD.
PUBLIC SCHOOL.
AND ONCE CHARTERS ARE APPROVED
THE BILL ALLOWS AUTHORIZES TO
CONSIDER THE FINANCIAL STABILITY
OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL DURING
RENEWAL.
THIS WILL ALLOW THE AUTHORIZED
HER TO IDENTIFY AND RESPOND TO
FISK TO A PHYSICAL PROBLEM
BEFORE IT BECOMES AN EMERGENCY
SO LET'S ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS
UP FRONT.
AND LET'S ADDRESS SOME SOON SO
THEY DON'T REALLY BECOME A
PROBLEM AND THAT THAT CHARTER
WILL BE AUTHORIZED RE AUTHORIZED.
WHEN THE CHARTER CERTAINLY
CLOSES ORDERED OR SHUT DOWN IT
IS DEVASTATING FOR STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES?
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS MUST PICK
UP THE PIECES TO MAKE SURE THOSE
STUDENTS ARE EDUCATED OFTEN.
IN A DAY'S NOTICE LAST YEAR IN
FACT IN SACRAMENTO.
A CRISIS SITUATION COULD HAVE
BEEN AVOIDED IF THE DISTRICT HAD
LOCAL CONTROL.
THURMOND COLLEGIATE ACADEMY.
WAS INITIALLY DENIED BY SAN JUAN
UNIFIED AND DENIED AGAIN BY THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
DUE TO POTENTIAL FINANCIAL
PROBLEMS THE SCHOOL WAS APPROVED
THEN.
BY THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
THE OF THAT APPEAL ONE ALL THE
WAY UP AND THEY DID NOT CONSIDER
THE FINANCIAL HEALTH OF THAT
CHARTER.
PARENTS WERE NOTIFIED THAT THE
SCHOOL WAS CLOSING ON THE DAY IT
CLOSED DUE TO FINANCIAL PROBLEMS.
THIS SCHOOL CLOSURE LOVE
STUDENTS STRANDED AND IT COULD
EASILY HAVE BEEN AVOIDED.
THIS SCHOOL SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED ON APPEAL UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE MANY MORE STORIES LIKE
THIS.
SO THE APPEAL PROCESS.
THIS BILL REFORM THE APPEAL
PROCESS AT THE STATE LEVEL SO
THE SITUATIONS LIKE THIS WILL
NOT OCCUR AGAIN.
THIS BILL GIVES CHARTER
AUTHORIZES THE TOOLS TO HOLD
CHARTER SCHOOLS MORE ACCOUNTABLE.
BY SHORTENING THE RENEWAL FEARED
FOR STRUGGLING SCHOOLS. TO
ENSURE THE CHARTERS CHARTER
TEACHERS ARE QUALIFIED THE BILL
CLARIFIES THAT ALL TEACHERS IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
MUST HOLD THE RECORD CREDENTIAL
FOR THEIR ASSIGNMENT ALLOWING
CHARTERS TO HER UNTRAINED
TEACHERS WITH NO BACKGROUND
CHECK CAN ONLY LEAD TO BAD
THINGS IN FACT WE NOW HAVE A
SITUATION -- APPARENTLY OUR
STATE WHERE CHARTER SCHOOLS OF
HIRED AND AND AND CREDENTIAL
TEACHERS AND THIS MEANS THEY MAY
NOT HAVE AYE BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THEY COULD HAVE.
BEEN INVOLVED IN ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY WITH CHILDREN IN THE
PAST IF THEY HAVEN'T HAD ANY
BACKGROUND CHECK NOR TRAINING.
TO TO TO TEACH.
OF THE LANGUAGE THE LANGUAGE ON
TEACHER QUALIFICATION IMPRINT
DOES NOT REPRESENT MIND AND IN
THIS PIECE THE BILL WILL CHANGE
BUT LET ME BE CLEAR MY INTENT IS
TO HAVE A ALL CHARTER SCHOOL
TEACHERS.
HAVE THE CREDENTIAL REQUIRED FOR
THEIR ASSIGNMENT WITH A FULL
BACKGROUND CHECKS AS WE WOULD
FOR TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOL.
SIMILARLY THE NATURE OF THE
COUNTY APPEAL PROCESS AND THE
APPROPRIATE ACADEMIC
ACCOUNTABILITY STUDENT SCANNERS
ARE SUBJECT OF ONGOING
CONVERSATION WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT OF AND
REYES WITH THIS BILL.
CLOSE EXISTING CHARTER SCHOOLS
NO THIS BILL WILL NOT SHUT DOWN
EXISTING CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THIS BILL WON'T AUTOMATICALLY
CLOSE ANY SCHOOL.
THIS BILL GRANDFATHERS ALL
EXISTING CHARTERS THAT ARE
AUTHORIZED BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND A COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
THERE ARE TWENTY NINE CHARTERS
AUTHORIZED BY THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION THAT WILL NEED TO
RETURN TO THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THIS WILL RETURN
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITIES TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
ANOTHER QUESTION WILL THIS BILL
ARE DISTRICTS TO CLOSE CHARTER
SCHOOLS AT RENEWAL FORD FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICT FINANCIAL
IMPACTS ON THE RICH WOULD IT.
CAN THEY DENY RENEWAL A TRY
BECAUSE I GUESS A WELCOME HARM
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT. TO
FINANCIAL STATUS THE ANSWER IS
NO.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN'T CONSIDER
THE FISCAL IMPACT DURING THE
REVIEW OF A PETITION FOR ONLY A
NEW CHARTER SCHOOL BUT NOT FOR
EXISTING.
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
OKAY ANOTHER QUESTION HOW TO THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT'S TASK
FORCE ON FISCAL IMPACT AND
CHARTER AUTHORIZING IMPACT THIS
BILL INFORMED THIS BILL.
I APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT FOR CLEARLY
SIGNALING THAT MORE CHARTER
REFORMS ARE NEEDED.
THIS AGREEMENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
REPRESENTS THE INCLUSION OF MANY
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
TASK FORCE REPORT.
DESPITE HOW SOME MIGHT
CHARACTERIZE THE TASK FORCE THE
LEGISLATURE IS A SEPARATE BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT.
AND WE SHOULD DETERMINE OUR OWN
PRIORS BUT AGAIN MOST OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE INCORPORATED
IN THE BILL.
THERE'S SOME OTHER QUESTIONS
I'VE HEARD -- JUST OVER THE LAST
TWENTY FOUR HOURS AGAIN.
BEN ALL BUT SOME THERE'S SOME
ALTERNATIVE SCHOOLS THEY MAINLY
SERVE CONSERVATION CORPS
STUDENTS AND SOME OTHER STUDENTS
SCI TECH IS ONE OF THEM.
ARE WITH US A BILL AFFECT THOSE
SCHOOLS THE ANSWER IS NO.
THE BILL DOES NOT TOUCH THE
LANGUAGE THAT APPLIES TO SCHOOLS
LIKE SCI TECH AND THE CONVERSE
CONSERVATION CORPS.
OUR INTENT HAS NEVER BEEN TO
IMPACT THESE TYPE OF SCHOOLS
WHICH IS WHY THE BILL DOESN'T
AMEND THAT CODE SECTION AT ALL.
FURTHER THE LANGUAGE THAT
PROVIDES -- FOR SCHOOLS LIKE SCI
TECH OR THE CUT THOSE SCHOOLS
MAINLY SIR CONSERVATION.
CORPS -- MEMBERS -- BUT IT
PROVIDES A WITH THE FLEXIBILITY
ON WHERE TO LOCATE -- STATES
THAT THEY MAY OPERATE -- DESPITE
WHAT ANY OTHER LAW DICTATES
DICTATES -- ANOTHER QUESTION --
WHAT ARE THE DETAILS OF THE
APPEAL PROCESS -- ALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS RECEIVE A FOOL APPEAL TO
THE COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION
UNDER THIS BILL.
AND THIS IS AN ISSUE WE ARE
HAVING ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
WITH WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
FURTHER THE BILL LIMITS THE
APPEAL AT THE STATE BOARD LEVEL
SO THAT.
THE STATE WILL ONLY HEAR APPEALS
AND DEMONSTRATE THE IN IT THAT
DEMONSTRATE THE DISTRICT OR THE
COUNTY.
OR THE COUNTY ABUSE ITS
DISCRETION -- WITH THIS BILL
CLOSE EXISTING CHARTER SCHOOLS
NO.
ALL THIS BILL GRANDFATHERS IN
ALL EXISTING CHARTERS.
BETTER AUTHORIZED BY THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE COUNTY ALSO THE
EDUCATION THERE ARE TWENTY NINE
CHARTERS THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED.
BY THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
THAT WILL NEED TO RETURN TO
THEIR LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT BUT
IT DOES NOT.
SHUT THEM DOWN -- LET'S SEE --
WILL THIS WILL THIS WILL THIS
ALLOWED DISTRICTS TO CLOSE
CHARTER SCHOOLS AT RENEWAL FOR
DISTRICT -- OR COMMUNITY IMPACT
THE ANSWER IS NO [inaudible]
NOW -- AND I'LL JUST KIND OF
LEAVE IT RIGHT THERE I DO HAVE A
MISTER BONTA IS HERE -- I DON'T
WITH THE CHAIRS RIGHT NOW MISTER
CHAIR MISTER BOND IS HERE TO
TESTIFY ON THE BILL AS WELL AS A
COUPLE WITNESSES SO I TURN IT
BACK TO YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SORRY TO CRAZY DAY -- BEFORE WE
GO DO YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IDEA
NOTICE A QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL LEYVA.
LEYVA HERE WILL PRESENT.
WILL CARE CHIANG LASSELL.
WRESTLE HERE GLAZER GLAZER HERE
MCGUIRE PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AS A JOINT AUTHORS
ALSO PRESENT ON AB. FIFTEEN OH
FIVE TODAY.
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS ACT HAS
LARGELY BEEN ON TOUCH SINCE IT
WAS FIRST ENACTED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO CALIFORNIA
NOW FINDS ITSELF FAR REMOVED
FROM THE ORIGINAL MISSION AND
VISION OF THE ACT WHICH WAS IN
PART MEANT TO HELP GENERATE.
INNOVATION TO BENEFIT STUDENTS
IN ALL SCHOOLS BUT OVER THE PAST
TWO DECADES.
THE GROWTH OF CHARTER SCHOOLS A
STUDLEY DRAIN MONEY AWAY FROM
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS AS A
RESULT.
NUMBER SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
FACING.
SERIOUS FINANCIAL CHALLENGES
INCLUDING MY OWN IN MY DISTRICT
THE OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATIONS OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE.
WITH NEARLY 30% OF STUDENTS
ATTENDING CHARTER SCHOOLS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN OPEN UNIFIED
FACED A FISCAL SHORTFALL OF
ABOUT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS.
OTHER DISTRICTS LIKE SAN DIEGO
SANTA CLARA IN INGLEWOOD ALSO
FACE SIMILAR FISCAL PRESSURES.
THESE DISTRICTS ALSO HAVE A
LARGE CHARTER SCHOOL PRESENCE.
SCHOOL GOVERNING BOARDS ARE
MAKING CUTS AND STAFFING IN
FACILITIES AS STUDENT ENROLLMENT
DECLINES BUT MANY DISTRICTS.
ARE AT THE BREAKING POINT SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS HAVE A FIDUCIARY
DUTY TO ENSURE THE FISCAL HEALTH
OF THEIR DISTRICT.
THE STUDENTS FUNDAMENTAL.
MANY OF US HAVE SERVED ON OTHER
BOARDS -- BEFORE WE CAME HERE
AND WE KNOW THAT FINANCIAL
HEALTH IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT -- OUT COMES WE CAN
HELP ENSURE AND FOR A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER TO BE WILLFULLY
BLINDED.
AND UNABLE TO ATTEND TO THAT
DUTY -- SEEMS AWKWARD AT BEST AB
FIFTY NO FIVE WOULD AUTHORIZE
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS TO CONSIDER
HOW THE PROPOSED CHARTER SCHOOL
COULD IMPACT.
A DISTRICTS EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
OR FISCAL HEALTH WHEN WAY IN NEW
CHARTER APPLICATIONS THIS BILL
SEEKS TO STRENGTHEN THE ABILITY
OF CHARTER AUTHORIZES TO HOLD
CHARTER SCHOOLS ACCOUNTABLE. FOR
THEIR FISCAL MANAGEMENT AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE WOULD PERMIT THE
CONSIDERATION OF A CHARTER
SCHOOLS FINANCIAL STABILITY.
DURING THE RENEWAL PROCESS SO
THAT A SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN
IDENTIFY AND APPROPRIATELY
RESPOND TO A PROBLEM.
WITH ASSISTANCE BEFORE BECOMES
AN EMERGENCY.
MOREOVER SCHOOL DISTRICTS NEED
PARTNERS IN INNOVATION NOT
DUPLICATION OR REDUNDANCY ALONG
WITH THE GOALS OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOL ACT CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
MEANT TO GENERATE INNOVATION.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE CHARTERS
IN THE PETITION TO DESCRIBE WHY
THEY'RE PROPOSED MODEL COULD NOT
BE ACCOMPLISHED WITHIN THE
EXISTING TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOL STRUCTURE.
LASTLY LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS ARE
ELECTED BY AND ACCOUNTABLE TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THEY ARE
ENTRUSTED TO MAKE FINAL
DECISIONS ABOUT THE EDUCATION OF
THE STUDENTS LIVING WITHIN THE
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES A. B..
FIFTEEN OH FIVE SIX TO ENSURE
THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
AUTHORIZED AND OVERSEEN BY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION THAT BEST
UNDERSTAND THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS.
OF THE LOCAL STUDENTS AB FIFTY
TO FIVE IN SOME WILL CREATE MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND A STRONGER
EMPHASIS ON EMPOWERING LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN COUNTY BOARD
OF EDUCATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B. FIFTY NO FIVE I
APPRECIATE THAT THE CHAIRS AND
YOUR STAFF'S.
WORK ON THIS BILL IT IS AN
ONGOING WORK IN PROGRESS A VERY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION TO HAVE
PLEASE BE PART OF THIS QUESTION
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER BONTA
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TWO MINUTES
EACH.
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE A
SUPERINTENDENT CITY MARTIN FROM
SAN DEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THEN -- DANA DEAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY LADIES.
THANK YOU CHAIR WOMAN LEYVA AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M SUPERINTENDENTS
ANDY MARTIN OF SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT THE STATE'S
SECOND LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT
REPRESENTING MORE THAN A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
THAT WE SERVE EVERY DAY.
INCLUDING TWENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN CHARTER SCHOOLS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN OH
FIVE BECAUSE IT EMBODIES THE
PRINCIPLES OF LOCAL CONTROL
WHICH HAS BEEN THE KEY TO
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL REFORM AND THE
STRIDES THAT WE HAVE MADE AS A
DISTRICT.
SAN DIEGO WAS RECOGNIZED AS THE
ONLY BIG CITY DISTRICT IN THE
NATION WITH OUTSTANDING TEST
SCORE GROWTH AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND LATINO STUDENTS IN
PARTICULAR ARE BEATING THE ODDS
AND OUTPERFORMING THEIR PEERS IN
SAN DIEGO ACCORDING TO THE
RECENT STUDY CO AUTHORED.
BY THE ESTEEM DR LINDA DARLING
HAMMOND THAT IS BECAUSE SCHOOL
REFORM HAS GIVEN US THE POWER TO
MAKE OUR OWN DECISIONS IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE STUDENTS WE
SERVE.
CONSISTENT WITH AN EXPANDING ON
EFFORTS TO RESTORE LOCAL CONTROL
AB FIFTY NO FIVE IMPORTANTLY
ALLOWS DISTRICTS TO CONSIDER THE
FISCAL IMPACT THAT CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE ON SURROUNDING
NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOLS.
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS TO HAS HAD TO
BALANCE A ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET EVERY YEAR
I CAN TELL YOU THIS MATTERS A
LOT ONE STUDY SHOWS THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOLS HAVE LOST
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FUNDING TO CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
JUST FOUR DISTRICTS AROUND THE
STATE THE DRAIN OF THESE
CRITICAL RESOURCES CANNOT BE
IGNORED AND DISTRICTS MUST BE
ALLOWED TO CONSIDER TO BE ABLE
TO CONSIDER WHETHER A NEW
CHARTER SCHOOL WOULD DENY
SERVICES AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
THE EXISTING SCHOOLS.
EXISTING CHARTERS AN EXISTING
DISTRICT MANAGED SCHOOLS I'D
ALSO LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
SERIOUS CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE COUNTY APPEALS PROCESS
IN AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE CURRENT LANGUAGE
IS OVERLY BROAD AND UNDERMINES
THE PRINCIPLE OF LOCAL CONTROL
MOVING ACCOUNTABILITY FURTHER
AWAY FROM THE PARENTS AND THE
STUDENTS.
COUNTIES SHOULD ONLY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO OVERRIDE DECISIONS OF
LOCAL AUTHOR RISERS IF THERE'S
BEEN A CLEAR ABUSE OF DISCRETION.
OVERTURNING LOCALLY ELECTED
DECISIONS MAKERS HURTS STUDENTS
AND I'M SPEAKING AS SOMEONE WHO
RECENTLY WENT THROUGH THE
DIFFICULT PROCESS OF DENYING A
RENEWAL OF A CHARTER SCHOOL THAT
WE HAD PREVIOUSLY DENIED.
BUT OUR DECISION WAS OVERRIDDEN
ON APPEAL WHICH LEADS TO MY
FINAL POINT THE CHARTER WE WERE
FORCED TO SEE CLOSED OPERATED
FOR FIVE YEARS PERSISTENTLY
FAILING.
FOR FIVE YEARS FOR NEARLY HALF
OF THE ACADEMIC LIVES OF THE
STUDENTS THEIR STUDENTS DON'T
GET THOSE YEARS BACK.
WE HAVE A COLLECTIVE MORAL
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT THEM FROM
FAILURES OF OUR SYSTEM FOR THAT
REASON WE BELIEVE WE NEED THE
DISCRETION TO SHORTEN THAT
LENGTH AND CHARTER RENEWALS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU YOU ABOUT A MINUTE AND
FIFTEEN SECONDS.
YEAH HE WENT OVER.
WELL THAT'S A GOOD MORNING.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M DINA
DEAN AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CSPA TODAY I'M CURRENTLY THE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA COUNTY
BOARDS OF EDUCATION C. C. B. E.
WHICH IS AN ARM OF CSPA.
I SIT ON THE SOLANO COUNTY BOARD
OF EDUCATION I WAS PREVIOUSLY ON
A LOCAL BOARD OF BENICIA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD I HAVE A
LONG LIST OF APPRECIATIONS BUT
GIVEN THE SHORT TIME I'LL JUST
SAY THANK YOU TO EVERYONE.
WHO HAS WORKED SO HARD ON THIS I
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT CSPA
HAS LONG WORKED ON THE ISSUES
THAT ARE BEFORE YOU?
AND WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE INCLUSION OF MANY OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE BODY OF THE OF THE WORK YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT WE ARE VERY
POSITIVE ABOUT THE EVOLUTION OF
THIS BILL AND THINK THESE FRESH
AMENDMENTS.
LEAD US A LITTLE CLOSER TO THE
ULTIMATE GOAL I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT TWO OR THREE THINGS BY ARE
PROBABLY.
TO THAT -- ARE STILL CONCERNING
THE FIRST IS THE WHERE -- COUNTY
BOARD DECISION IS APPEAL TO THE
STATE BOARD WE HAVE FIFTEEN DAYS
TO REVIEW THE ENTIRETY OF THE
RECORD -- PUT TOGETHER A
MEANINGFUL RESPONSE TO THE
PETITION.
AND SITE SPECIFICALLY TO THE
RECORD THAT'S A HERCULEAN TASK
EVEN IF YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES
BUT THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
COUNTY BOARDS DON'T.
THEY WERE NOT IN THE BUSINESS OF
OPERATING CHARTER PETITION
APPEALS AND YOU'RE ASKING AN
ENORMOUS OF NOT YOU BUT THE BILL
ASSN ENORMOUS AMOUNT FROM ALL OF
US THE SECOND APPLIES TO
EVERYONE COMES UP SO REAL QUICK.
OKAY SEVEN APPLIES TO EVERYONE
WHICH IS ABOUT THE SORT OF
AMBIGUOUS LANGUAGE IN THE NEW
APPELLATE APPEALS LANGUAGE WHICH
ALLOWS FOR ACTUALLY REQUIRES A
SECOND PUBLIC HEARING AND
DOESN'T DETAIL OUT HOW THAT
WOULD WORK AND THAT'S TRUE AT
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT LEVEL AND
ALSO AT THE COUNTY BOARD LEVEL.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NAME AND SUPPORT PLEASE.
THE MORNING SENATORS SET BRAMBLE
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION PLEASE TO
CO SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRISTEN BROWN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ALSO PROUD CO SPONSOR
WE ARE CHEN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA ANA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
DR BRUTALITY WITH NEWPORT MESA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL.
JOHN RUN IN WITH YOU SEE IF T.
THE UNION THAT REPRESENTS
LIBRARIES LECTURES IN AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WE STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ROBERT PETERS TWENTY FIVE YEARS
SOCIAL SCIENTISTS WITH A C. T.
A. AN URGE YOU STRONGLY TO VOTE
YES.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH US
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIANS TRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
SUPPORT SORRY THEIR LETTER AND
GET IT ON TIME TO MAKE THE
ANALYSIS.
HI GOOD MORNING ANDREA BALL AND
A HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE ORANGE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ASK OF ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT.
DILLER STRAND FLOREZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION CO SPONSORS IN IN
SUPPORT.
MARINA GABLE FOURTH FULL
SECRETIVE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SCHOOL BUS DRIVER IN
SUPPORT.
JOANNE HUDGINS FOLSOM CORDOVA
UNIFIED SCHOOL [inaudible]
DISTRICT SUPPORT. FOR PRESS IN
SUPPORT.
VICTORIA EAGER IN SUPPORT.
HI THE YOUNGER IN SUPPORT.
BILL SIMMONS SIX GRADE ENGLISH
HISTORY TEACHER FROM SAN JUAN
UNIFIED -- AND A GRANDPARENT OF
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
SUPPORT.
DAVID DAMON INDEPENDENT DATA
ANALYST AND ON BEHALF OF THE
GRASSROOTS EDUCATION MOVEMENT
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MERCEDES GERALDO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND A PARA
EDUCATOR YUBA CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MICHELLE SAKURADA THE KEY TO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
SCA I'M SUPPORT.
KAREN SMITH CSEA SAN JUAN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT EMPLOYEE
AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
PAMELA ROTHWELL THE THOMAS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
CLASSIFIED -- IN SUPPORT.
ELAINE PIKE CLASSIFIED OF PLOY
AT THE ROSE BOWL JOINT UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MATTHEW COGAN UNITED TEACHERS
LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT.
MY CONSCIENCE IN WITH OPEN
OAKLAND PUBLIC EDUCATION NETWORK
IN THE JOURNEY FOR JUSTICE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE AND WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN OH FIVE
TIFFANY WAS CSEA.
A AMPLE SUPPORT.
TURN FRIEDMAN THE WASHINGTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
STOREKEEPER IN FULL SUPPORT OF
AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE JASON BENSON
SCHOOL BUS DRIVER TWEENER
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT A FATHER
OF FIVE IN FULL SUPPORT.
ERICA JONES KINDERGARTEN TEACHER
MEMBER OF THE SUPERINTENDENTS
CHARTER TASK FORCE IN FULL
SUPPORT.
DEBBIE SCHNEIDER SO LEASE UT LA
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER AND
FULL SUPPORT AND PARENT OF THREE
AND PUBLIC SCHOOL. EIGHT INTO MY
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER UNITED
TEACHERS LOS ANGELES FULL
SUPPORT. ONE OF MY YOU TELL
LAYING AND FULL SUPPORT AND I'M
A FIRST GRADE TEACHER IN A
COLOCATED SCHOOL IN PUBLIC
SCHOOL.
VIKKI PHYLLIS SMITH SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
FULL SUPPORT.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE
AND DOUBLE ACP IN SUPPORT.
GEORGIA FLOWERS LEE UNITED
TEACHERS LOS ANGELES SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER IN FULL
SUPPORT.
PRINTER THIS HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER
SWEETWATER UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT FULL SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE TEARS SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER SANTEE UNIFIED
AND FULL SUPPORT.
ANGELA NORMAN EDUCATION
SPECIALIST SPECIAL DAY CLASS AND
FULL SUPPORT.
CHAS GARCIA OAKLAND EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION AND AT PARK.
YOUR COACH AND FULL SUPPORT.
MY WALKER I WORK IN HIGH SCHOOL
LIBRARY SERVICES IN HAYWARD
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
FULL SUPPORT.
YET THE SILENCE FIRST GRADE
TEACHER IN OAKLAND IN FULL
SUPPORT.
PETER ROBINSON TEACHER OAKLAND --
IN FULL SUPPORT OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THE MONICA ROBINSON OAKLAND
PUBLIC SCHOOLS CHILD DEVELOPMENT
CENTER AND FULL SUPPORT.
DENISE BRADFORD KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER IN SADDLEBACK VALLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT PARENT
OF THREE PUBLIC SCHOOL GRADUATES
IN FULL SUPPORT.
HELLO MERRY MONTEZ CHAPTER
PRESIDENCY SCA PLASTER COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION MAIN IT'S A
STUDIO IN IN FULL SUPPORT AND A
PUBLIC STOOD UP.
EIGHT PUBLIC SCHOOL GRADUATE
THANK YOU.
ASHLEY BACK WITH SCHOOL BUS
DRIVER GOAL HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN FULL SUPPORT.
MY IDEA BECAUSE THE SCHOOL BUS
DRIVER OF FOR GOLF HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN FULL SUPPORT.
DIANNE JAB WALKER SPEECH AND
LANGUAGE SPECIALIST WITH THE
SECOND A CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND A MEMBER SCTA
PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
J. MARKS PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
IN SEXY UNIFIED IN FULL SUPPORT.
ERIN DARKE SCHOOL TEACHER AT
ALICE BERNIE PUBLIC WALDORF NON
CHARTER PUBLIC WALDORF IN FULL
SUPPORT.
BARBARA DOESN'T MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER INVESTOR CALIFORNIA
GRANDPARENT AND PARENT OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL I AM FULL SUPPORT.
DON DAWSON SAN DIEGO RETIRED
MATH TEACHER IN FULL SUPPORT.
LINDA TITLE FORMER MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER AND PRENT OF SEX CITY
STUDENT FULL SUPPORT.
BOB PERSONALLY TEACHERS SAID SAM
RAN THE MIDDLE SCHOOL SEX CITY
UNIFIED FULL SUPPORT.
MARCY LINE A SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
MICKEY MULLIN SKI SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST AND PARENT OF TWO
STUDENTS IN SAXONY UNIFIED AND I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT.
DAVID ISHER PRESIDENT SECOND A
CITY TEACERS ASSOCIATION SECOND
GRADE TEACHER AND PARENT OF TWO
CHILDREN IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
FULL SUPPORT.
BECKY SESSENTA TEACHER INSECTS
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
PLEASE VOTE YES.
JERRY HIGH SCHOOL FRENCH SPANISH
ENGLISH TEACHER TRAVIS UNIFIED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN FULL
SUPPORT.
AT MALLORY FOURTH GRADE TEACHER
MILLER CREEK SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR
SUPPORT PLEASE.
CHRIS BOUCHER HIGH SCHOOL
CHEMISTRY TEACHER BEVERLY HILLS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I
SUPPORT.
KINDA COLLINS HIGH SCHOOL
ENGLISH TEACHER AND CHARTER
EDUCATOR UNITED TEACHERS LOS
ANGELES AND SUPPORT.
TIFFANY DURO CHAPTER PRESIDENT
SAN LORENZO VALLEY TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND STATE COUNCIL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND TWENTY
NINE YEAR HIGH SCHOOL ENGLISH
TEACHER.
IN FULL SUPPORT.
CEREBELLAR I'M A TRUSTEE ON THE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND I URGE YOU YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CONSOLO LARA AND I AM
A TRUSTEE ON THE SCHOOL BOARD
WEST CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN FULL SUPPORT.
KOBE PRESIDING YOU WITH THE OUR
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE WASHINGTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN WHAT
SACRAMENTO IN FULL SUPPORT.
LESLIE LIMóN HIGH SCHOOL
HISTORY TEACHER HEART HIGH
SCHOOL SANTA CLARITA IN FULL
SUPPORT.
CALLING BRITISH MADE -- THE CAN
I TAKE A TEACHER IN THOUSAND
OAKS CALIFORNIA FULL SUPPORT.
HILLARY HALL SIXTH GRADE TEACHER
IN THE WHOLE SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
A PUBLIC.
SCHOOL PARENTS AND REPRESENTING
THREE UNDER FIFTY TEACHERS FROM
THE NEW HOLE SCHOOL DISTRICT
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION FULL
SUPPORT.
BOB AND GUESTS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER AND PRESIDENT OF THE
INGLEWOOD TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING FIVE HUNDRED PLUS.
TEACHERS AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT.
ESTHER CAM FROM THE SANTA
CLARITA ALLEY SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTY FIVE JAMIE ALTMAN FROM THE
HEART SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SANTA
CLARITA REPRESENTING ELEVEN
HUNDRED SCHOOL TEACHERS IN FULL
SUPPORT. TWO OF OUR TELL HIGH
SCHOOL INTO A MUSIC TEACHER FROM
BREA OLINDA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN FULL SUPPORT.
MELINDA DART TEACHER A. F. T.
THIRTY TO SIXTY SEVEN CM A TAIL
LABOR COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CARL WILLIAMS PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS COUNCIL OF CLASSIFIES
EMPLOYEES AND FULL SUPPORT.
POLYGON SIX GRADE TEACHER
PRESIDENT OF THE FIFTY THREE TWO
SIX SEVEN JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN FULL SUPPORT.
KELLY COLONUS PETALUMA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY ONE I RISE IN SUPPORT.
LINDA DUDE I'M A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER AT PETALUMA HIGH SCHOOL
AND A PARENT OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS
IN FULL SUPPORT.
MISC APPEAR SEND LOCAL TEACHER
TWENTY ONE YEAR VETERAN ELK
GROVE EDUCATION ASSOCIATION IN
FULL SUPPORT.
ROBERT WALDO -- EL CAMINO HIGH
SCHOOL SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
URGENT AYE VOTE.
CHRIS CORCORAN DELL DELL
ELEMENTARY AND SEND MONEY FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICT PLEASE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
CHRISTY CORCORAN SACKS CITY
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MADDIE CORCORAN.
OF A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE HELLO TO
BE BOY CTA PRESIDENT.
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER NO GROWTH.
OF RAP SCENE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS I
SUPPORT AND WE TO SERGIO
MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION BOARD OF DIRECTOR
HAAS IN FIFTH GRADE HACIENDA
APPOINTED SCHOOL TEACHER.
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SUSAN SCHOLAR PRESIDENT TO LIVE
IS TO EDUCATORS LARGEST CASE SIX
DISTRICT IN THE STATE FOURTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MATTHEW HARDY CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS HIRED
YOUR SUPPORT.
LOOK AT A YOUNG A WRENCH OF
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS MP COOPER
AND I REPRESENT FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY ONE TEACHERS WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
DIANNE NEED THIRTY YEAR TEACHER
INSECTS CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND A MOTHER OF TWO
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS PRODUCT
THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS MYSELF.
A URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
MARGIE GOING AUTO KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER MODEL UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
BOARD OF DIRECTORS CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
DAVID GOLDBERG A BILINGUAL
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER BOYLE
HEIGHTS CITY A VICE PRESIDENT
EXTENSIVE PART.
YEAH FOR SURE PEOPLE.
RODRIGUEZ EIGHTEEN YOU'RE A E.
L. D. VETERAN.
UNAPOLOGETIC UNION MEMBER PROUD
MOTHER OF A SPREAD CHILD WHO
GRADUATED FROM PUBLIC EDUCATION
IN COLLEGE NOW AND A QUEER SON
AND I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT FOR
EVERY STUDENT THANK YOU CAN.
REJECTED FOR ELQ THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
TONY GOLDWYN AS TEACHER ABC
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
REPRESENTING OVER A THOUSAND
TEACHERS AND ALSO EARLY ED ED
PEACE TV K. TWELVE COUNCIL OF
REPRESENTING THOUSAND TEACHERS
ACROSS THE STATE PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS.
CHANNING STORY JUST ABOUT TO
START MY THIRTIETH YEAR IN THE
CLASSROOM AS A MATH TEACHER IN
SALINAS VALLEY FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
LOCAL. TEN TWENTY MEMBER PLEASE
STAND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THE RUNWAY IS I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE SUMMER DO YOU
KNOW COUNTY TACHERS ASSOCIATION --
URGING A STRONG -- YES SO ON A.
B. FIFTEEN FIVE THANK YOU.
KATHY PEERS FROM SAN DINO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS --
EARLY EDUCATION TEACHER STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'M BRENDA WALKER
PRESIDENT OF ASSOCIATE IT GINO
TEACHERS AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY FOURTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS
AND I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALICE MERCER AMID TO TRANSACT
MINISTER THE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT -- A PROUD SCTA MEMBER
AND I'M THE PARENT OF A FORMER
CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT I STRONG
STAND STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MISSION.
KATIE BASSLER PRESIDENT SALINAS
VALLEY FEDERATION OF TEACHERS I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS SHEILA CHARLIE ARE
GOOD MORNING I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE IN AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MARY WALTON I AM A TENTH
GRADE ENGLISH TEACHER FOR ELK
GROVE UNIFIED AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MONICA HARVEY I AM A LANGUAGE
SPEECH AND HEARING SPECIALIST
AND ALSO THE SPECIAL ED DIRECTOR
FOR SACRAMENTO CITY TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
I BULLARD DATA PRESIDENT CLINTON
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION I SUPPORT.
FOR ANNIKA SANCHEZ AUBURN CSEA
PROUD PARENT OF TWO PUBLIC
SCHOOL KIDS PROUD OF OUR COUNTRY
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS A
WRESTLING RCN AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT.
THE THREE SUPPORT AND AND MY
WORK WITH SPECIAL ED TEACHERS.
AND I HAVE A SONG WITH OF THE
STEAK AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BRITTANY YOUNG
CHAPTER PRESIDENT OF THE CSEA
FOR EIGHTY WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA ALLEN I'M A
PROUD GRANDPARENTS SEVERAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS AND I'M
IN SUPPORT.
MORNING IT'S KATHLEEN MORRISON
FROM WELL AS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT CSEA PRESIDENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MORNING RON WALKER ORLAND
CHAPTER FOUR FIVE SIX CSE A AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THE MORNING TRISH RYAN FROM AM
WHEN WALDORF PUBLIC SCHOOL OFTEN
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THESE BILLS.
GOOD MORNING NICOLE THE HORROR
OF A LOCAL FOURTH FIFTH GRADE
TEACHER UP CIVIC ELEMENTARY.
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
MORNING CAN CAN.
TO FIFTH GRADE ELEMENTARY
TEACHER AT CAMPBELL ELEMENTARY
MANIOC STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CATCH MY BREATH ACTS SO WELL WE
STILL HAVE CONCERNS WITH
ABSOLUTELY LIKE TO SEE THE BILL
BEFORE TODAY.
PERCENT ABOVE SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT OF
DOUBLE MOVE FOR JAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
COME ON DOWN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION WANT
TO SPONSOR THE BILL HERE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI I MORE RICE HALL AND I'M I'M
WITH.
THE OAKLAND EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION AND I'M STANDING IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SUPPORT WE OKAY WE AT
ONE MORE COMMON.
NO OKAY WE ARE GOOD OPPOSITION
PLEASE IF WE CAN MAKE A LITTLE
ROOM AT THE TABLE IF YOU WANT TO
MOVE OVER HERE LADIES THAT'S
FINE.
IF WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL YOU CAN COME UP TO THE
TABLE NOW [inaudible]
YEAH THE THANK YOU A TWO
WITNESSES AS YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH YOU MAY GO A SCOTIA
OVER BECAUSE THE SUPPORT WHEN A
SCOTIA OVERSAW LET YOU DECIDE
WHO'S GOING TO BEGIN TO BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING.
HI CARLOS MARQUEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION HERE TO REPRESENT
OUR OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN OH
FIVE AS AMENDED ON JULY FIFTH.
WE WANT TO FIRST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
AUTHOR SPONSORS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S TEAM FOR MAKING THE
IMPROVEMENTS REPRESENTED IN THE
BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY.
WHILE THOSE IMPROVEMENTS FALL
SHORT OF ADDRESSING OUR MOST
GRAVE CONCERNS WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY TO
SEEK GREATER PROTECTIONS FOR OUR
FAMILIES.
AND THE SCHOOLS THEY SO CHERISH
HAS NOT CLOSED AND THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AUTHOR AND
PROPONENTS OVER THE COMING WEEKS
TO RESOLVE OUTSTANDING ISSUES.
BUT TO BE CLEAR WE FIND IT
UNACCEPTABLE THAT AB FIFTEEN OH
FIVE GRANTS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BROAD DISCRETION TO DENY NEW
CHARTERS ON THE BASIS OF RUNNING
A SIMILAR PROGRAM WITH NO REGARD.
FOR WHETHER THE PROGRAM IS
FAILING KIDS FURTHER ALLOWING
CONSIDERATION OF FISCAL IMPACT
IN DISTRICTS THAT ARE EXHIBITING
NO CHARACTERISTICS OF FISCAL
DISTRESS IS INDEFENSIBLE
ESPECIALLY IF THOSE DISTRICTS
DON'T ALSO HAVE TO CONTEND WITH
THE ON MATT.
ACADEMIC NEED IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
WE KNOW FROM RESEARCH BY THE
CENTER FOR REINVENTING PUBLIC
EDUCATION THAT THE AVERAGE SHARE
OF CHARTER SCHOOL ENROLLMENT IN
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFER ACROSS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BASED ON THEIR
FINANCIAL STATUS.
WITH REGARD TO TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IN CHARTER SCHOOLS
CREDENTIALING ASSIGNMENT
FLEXIBILITY IS A CORE.
PILLAR OF THE CHARTER MODEL.
BUT LANGUAGE BEFORE YOU WITH
SOME MINOR REFINEMENTS WILL
ALLOW OUR SCHOOLS TO PRESERVE
THAT FLEXIBILITY AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR CAR THE
PROGRESS MADE HERE.
RENEWAL CRITERIA STATE LEVEL
APPEALS THE TRANSITION PLAN FOR
STATE BOARD AUTHORIZED SCHOOLS
AND THE ISSUES RELATED TO
DISTRICT DISCRETION THAT I'VE
OUTLINED FOR YOU TODAY ARE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY DETERMINE.
WHETHER A DEAL IS IN REACH WE
KNOW THE PROPONENTS AND
ADMINISTRATION ARE COMMITTED TO
A RESOLUTION THIS YEAR.
AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING
TOWARD THAT GOAL BUT GETTING THE
POLICY IN A PLACE THAT IS
PROTECTED FOR OUR FAMILIES AND
OUR SCHOOLS IS WHAT WILL GUIDE
US ABOVE ALL ELSE [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
I'M CATALANO HALLERAN AND I'M
SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND ALSO AS
THE PARENT CO FOUNDER OF THE
DIXON MONTESSORI CHARTER SCHOOL.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR I FOUND
AN APPARENT RUN CHARTER SCHOOL
IN MY HOMETOWN OF DIXON WHICH IS
RIGHT DOWN THE ROAD.
HE QUICKLY BECAME I WAS A FIVE A
VOTE FROM THE LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD
AND QUICKLY BECAME THE HIGHEST
PERFORMING CHARTER SCHOOL.
THANKS FOR A SCHOOL IN THE
DISTRICT.
WHEN SCHOOL CAME UP FOR RENEWAL
THE FIRST TIME?
OUR AUTHORIZED -- PRESENTED SOME
HIGHLY SUBJECTIVE FISCAL
ARGUMENT THAT SUNDAY OUR SCHOOL
WOULD SUBSTANTIALLY UNDERMINED
THE DISTRICT BUDGET AND THEY
VOTED FOR ONE TO NON RENEW.
A FEW WEEKS LATER WHEN THE API
SCORES CAME OUT THE DIXON MOSTLY
CHARTER SCHOOL WAS A HUNDRED
POINTS HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER
SCHOOL IN THE DISTRICT.
THE SOMEONE A STORY QUICKLY
ACTIVATED THE APPEALS PROCESS
BUT THE PROCESS TOOK NEARLY TEN
MONTHS THE SCHOOL HAD TO CLOSE
BECAUSE IT LOST ITS INITIAL
AUTHORIZATION TO OPERATE THAT
YEAR.
BUT A YEAR LATER UNDER SCHOOL
BOARD I'M I'M SORRY UNDERSTATE
BOARD RE AUTHORIZATION IT RE
OPENED AND TODAY IT REMAINS THE
HIGHEST PERFORMING SCHOOL IN THE
DISTRICT.
ODDLY I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
OTHER SCHOOLS THE TRADITIONAL
SCHOOLS IN THE DISTRICT ARE
CATCHING UP ACADEMICALLY.
TMZ HAS SERVED AS A MOTIVATOR
FOR EXCELLENCE AS CHARTER
SCHOOLS OFTEN DO.
AND I WAS ELECTED TO THE DIXON
SCHOOL BOARD IN PART SO THAT I
COULD INSURE THAT MY COMMUNITY
NEVER USES NEFARIOUS FISCAL
ARGUMENTS TO UNDERMINE ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE EVER AGAIN.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE THIS BODY TO
FOLLOW SUIT AND VOTE NO ON
FIFTEEN OH FIVE EVEN UNDER
CURRENT LAW IT'S TOO EASY TO
SHUT DOWN HIGH PERFORMING
CHARTER SCHOOLS. FOR THE SAKE OF
ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE PLEASE DON'T
MAKE IT EVEN EASIER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION NAME
ORGANIZATION AND IF YOU OPPOSE.
COME ON UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
OKAY I'M BERNIE SILVA FROM SIDE
TECH I APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL'S COMMITMENT TO OUR
SCHOOL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
RESOLVING.
ANY.
GEN ON ON LANGUAGE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
NAME IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
MY NAME IS MARGARET FORTUNE A
MEMBER OF THE GOVERNOR'S TASK
FORCE FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG OPPOSITION.
SEMANGAT REPRESENTING FORTUNE
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION EFFECTIVELY
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP --
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CINDY RACHEL WITH INNOVATIVE
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT
REPRESENTING SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS AND THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TEACHERS OPPOSING THIS
BILL.
BROWN . JONES ON BEHALF OF
LEARN FOR LIFE IN CALIFORNIA
VIRTUAL ACADEMIES IN OPPOSITION.
JEFF RICE FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR
OF THE A PLUS PERSONALIZED
LEARNING NETWORK ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
PERSONALIZED LEARNING PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN SEVENTY
THOUSAND K. TWELVE STUDENTS.
WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING I'M BEVERLY BRYANT
WITH FORTUNE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
WELL.
GOOD MORNING ALLEN NEW IN
CHARTER WITH TO MACULAR VALLEY
CHARTER SCHOOL THE SMALL WEIRD
COMMUNITY THAT WILL THAT I WORK
WITH IS STRONGLY OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
HI I'M JUDY A DEER WITH SPRINGS
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN TEMECULA
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M JACQUELINE AARON I'M A
PROUD GRADUATE OF CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS DOUBLE.
DONNA DEAR I'M INSTRUCTOR AT
SPRINGS CHARTER SCHOOL I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN WHO GRADUATED FROM
A CHARTER SCHOOL.
AND I AM PROUD TO SAY I HAVE A
GRANDSON THAT STARRED
[inaudible]
OPPOSE.
I DEFINITELY OPPOSE THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS AUDREY
RISEN I HOME SCHOOL WITH
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS LEAH XTRAM I AM ALSO
HOME SCHOOL MOTHER WITH
INSPIRING TO HOME SCHOOL FIVE
CHILDREN AND I A STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I AM ONLY EXTRA MY LISTED ABOVE --
DANCE INSPIRED CHURCH SCHOOL AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACQUELINE
GAVIN I'M A MOTHER OF FOUR FROM
CORONA WITH A COLLEGE STUDENT
AND I HOME SCHOOL MY CHILDREN
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M JULIE GAVIN AND I'M FROM
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS EMMA GAVIN AND
I AND I AM FROM.
HER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS PAUL MARMOR SO AND
AYE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS PAMELA MARCIA INSPIRE
HOMESCHOOL OM AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS PAIGE MECHANIC I
GRADUATED TWO STUDENTS WITH
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M LINDY ACKLAND HOMES GO
MOM OF THREE CHILDREN WHO ARE
BOTH IN PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL
VOLUNTEER AT HOME SCHOOL
CONSIDER SUPPORTING OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND CHARTER SCHOOL.
HOME SCHOOLERS AND DIRECTOR OF
HOME SCHOOLING AND INSPIRE
TRICYCLE SUPPORTING THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND PLUS HOME SCHOOLERS AND
WE ALL OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS JUST STREAK I AM A A
CHARTER SCHOOL FATHER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATOR NO CHARTER
AFFILIATION -- BUT FULLY
BACKGROUND CHECK BY THE DOJ LIKE
EVERY OTHER CHARTER SCHOOL
TEACHER.
OF BOTH THE IN COUNTRY TO THE
TAIL -- FULLY OPPOSED POST THANK
YOU.
DILLON AND TOWN WITH ROCK AND
ACADEMY FAMILIES CHOOLS
REPRESENTING TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENTS
UP IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
I AM IN ANTONE AND I AM A PUBLIC
SCHOOL FOURTH GRADER AT BROKEN
CAN BE GATEWAY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
KAELIN SAME TEACHER AT ROCKLIN
ACADEMY A PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALLIANCE [inaudible]
NO NO.
I AM MAKING A MALFOY.
LANDMARK CASE.
DECK NHL MAYES CHARGES SKILL
[inaudible]
THE BILL.
MY NAME IS HEATHER MILLS FOR IT
I'M FROM SCOTT WILKES DISTRICT --
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MARIBEL TOP FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MICHELLE TODD FOR FRESNO
JUDY GRAPH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
VISIONS EDUCATIONCHARTER SCHOOL
SACRAMENTO REPRESENTING SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS STAND IN
OPPOSITION.
CRISTINA MY CANICE EIGHTEEN YEAR
VETERAN ON VISIONS IN EDUCATION
AS BOTH A TEACHER A MENTOR AND A
PRINCIPAL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY CALL BRUBAKER AT AND PARENT
OF CHILDREN ADD TO AND
CALIFORNIA THE MONTESSORI
PROJECT AND ALSO DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS AT VISIONS IN
EDUCATION I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THURMOND PARLIN DIRECTOR OF
INSTRUCTION AT VISIONS IN
EDUCATION REPRESENTING SIXTY
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS I OPPOSE
THE BILL.
NAME'S HEATHER DRAKE I'M FROM
TWENTY NINE PALMS CALIFORNIA I
AM THE PARENT OF A SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILD THAT PUBLIC SCHOOLS COULD
NOT SERVE CORRECTLY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL STRONGLY.
HELLO I'M SORRY NEW CAM I'M A
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER AND A
PARENT OF PUBLIC SCHOOL CHILDREN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MORNING BECAUSE THE RED SICK
PUBLIC FULLY CREDENTIALED PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
JUSTIN DAVIS PRINCIPLE IT
VISIONS IN EDUCATION AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AARON DAVIDSON FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY HOME SCHOOLING DAD OF
SEVEN CHILDREN MANY WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOYCE I AM A
STUDENT INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL
I AM FROM BAKERSFIELD AND I
OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE SAVANNAH GARDNER
HOME SCHOOL PARENT.
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL KERN
COUNTY ARE POSE AB [inaudible]
FIFTEEN OH FIVE SADE TOOL.
I KNOW MY MEANING THAT SPELL
[inaudible]
PERSON HERNANDEZ.
OBAMA HOMESCHOOLING PARENT FROM
A BIGGER SO CALIFORNIA FOR
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CRISTINA LASTER TURNING
PRESIDENT FOR SAN DIEGO INLAND
EMPIRE AND GRAND PARENTING
pBILL FREE THESE YOUNG MINDS LET
MY PEOPLE GO.
MY NAME IS FAITH I'M A HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS ANGELA ROBINSON I'M
HOME SCHOOL PARENT I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS LABOR TELL I'M A
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND A FORMER
CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KEN BARTEL -- I'M A
CHARGE TO ADMIT CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENT AND I PUT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ERIN KYLE I'M A
CREDENTIALED TEACHER APPARENT TO
FOR WHO WENT THROUGH CHARTER
SCHOOL TWO OF WHICH YOU HAVE
GRADUATED AND GO TO CURRENTLY
USC THANK YOU I PO I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
I'M SHY BY TELL ON THE TENTH
GRADER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHAIR.
I GUESS.
BECAUSE FAN.
AT FIFTY ARE FINE.
MY NAME IS TACK ALLEN I AM THE
INTERNATIONAL YOUTH DIRECTOR FOR
THE INTERNATIONAL FAITH BASED
COALITION I AM ALSO A U.
THERAPIST AND I AM I HOME SCHOOL
PARENT AS WELL TO TRY TO PAIR
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CARLA RUN HELL I
REPRESENT FORTUNE SCHOOLS AND
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
YOU NEED SUPPORT FROM INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS A DOLLAR CARTER AND
FROM BRUCE I COUNTY WHERE WITH
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL IN
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KARENA CORRAL FROM
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL IN
NAPLES THIS BILL.
I NAME IS RE ANSIBLE THAT I'M A
HOME SCHOOL MOM OF FIVE THRIVING
KIDS AND INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL
AND KANA AND I OPPOSE.
I'M CLEAR VANDERGRIFT I AM A
SENIOR AT INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M CLICK VANDERGRIFT I'M A
CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JULIE VANDERGRIFT I'M
HOME SCHOOL MOTHER SIX ALL
EDUCATED AT CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GRACE I AM A TIGHTER
SCHOOL A CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S AUDRY TAYLOR I'M A
HOME SCHOOL MOM OF FOUR FOR OVER
FIVE YEARS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
JANAGASKELL SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE FOR PROFIT CHARTER SCHOOLS
OF WHICH 22% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JENNIFER BECAUSE OF FORMER UNION
REPRESENTATIVE FORMER TEACHER
CURRENT CHARTER ADMINISTRATOR
REPRESENTING TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THE
BILL.
THE MORNING GENOCIDE RECIEVE
FOUNDER OF COLITIS SCHOOL A
DEVELOPING CHARTER SCHOOL FOR
THE RANCHO CORDOVA AREA THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND HEARING
US THIS MORNING I REALLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
AARON COLBERN WITH VISIONS IN
EDUCATION I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM CEREMONY HERE FROM SISTER
SITES CALIFORNIA I'M A PARENT OF
A CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT AND A
TEACHER ASSISTANT AT A
MONTESSORI CHARTER SCHOOL.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I AM MAIDEN I AM A MAKE YOU.
AND I GO TO JOHNS ACADEMY IN
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BUT I'M JEFF
HERNANDEZ AND THE HEAD OF SCHOOL
THAT METHOD SCHOOL THEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TRACY ROBERTSON -- COMPLIANCE
MANAGER METHOD SCHOOLS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ROY DONE KEY -- A MATH TUTOR OF
VIRTUAL IN ON CAMPUS STUDENTS IT
TO THE CHARTER SCHOOL SANTA ROSA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LOU TO SHANE SCHOOL
DIRECTOR ROSSELLI CHARTER SCHOOL
IN FAIRFAX AND I URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM CHRIS LYONS I'M A TEACHER
AT ROSS VALLEY CHARTER SCHOOL IN
FAIRFAX AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S CHARLIE MINCE WITH KIP
AREA PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING ANTHONY WILSON WITH-KAY BEAR PUBLIC SCHOOLS DIRECTOR
OF ADVOCACY IS STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MAX DAY I'M IN
OAKLAND CHARTER SCHOOL SUPPORTER
AND I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING ABLE COATED
EIGHTEEN YEAR EDUCATOR LOS
ANGELES STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING LAURIE BUTLER BOARD
CHAIR OF TEACH PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING SPENCER GIRLS I AM
ON THE BOARD OF TEACH PUBLIC
SCHOOLS I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
GOOD MORNING LAUREN O'NEIL
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF ODYSSEY CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
PASADENA STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
KRISTIE THOMPSON HOME EDUCATOR
WITH INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS MY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE MORNING STEFAN DOUBLES ON
WITH THE FORTUNE SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARILYN THE BOWS I AM
A SCHOLAR AT WREXHAM MARGARET
FORTUNE EARLY COLLEGE HIGH
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IN THE RIDE.
MY NAME IS MARIAH MARCY AND
ITEMS TO THE DOUBLE CD FROM ONE
COLLEGE FIVE CHARTER SCHOOL AND
AYE POSES.
MY NAME IS A NIGHT OF BOS AND I
AM A SCHOLAR ALAMO COLLEGE PREP
AND I OPPOSE HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TIED TO BOTH I AM A
PARENT AB THE FORTUNE START
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LAURYN TREMBLAY HOME SCHOOL
MOTHER WITH SKY MOUNTAIN CHARTER
FROM PINE MOUNTAIN CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS HANNAH BLACK I AM
A CHARTER SCHOOL SUPPORTER IN A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NORMAN ADISA SUPERINTENDENTS
DOLLARS COLLEGE PREP HOW WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO PATH TO DEBORAH CAMARA
MEMBER SCHOOLS GOT SCHOOL SITE
COUNCIL FORTUNE SCHOOL
GRANDPARENT GREAT GRANDPARENT
PARENTS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS.
MY NAME IS MEDICAL MARIN I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS ISAAC YOUR TELL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RENEE COULD TELL IN A
STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HI I'M HANNAH -- PERRIN OF
CHILDREN OF FORTUNE SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER SOLANO A
PARENT OF SIX AT FOR THE FORTUNE
SCHOOLS AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HI MAKAYLA DROWSY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M AN EDUCATOR MY NAME IS
THERESA TARAJI THAT WITH MY
DAUGHTER ONE OF FIVE AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF SIX THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED OTHER KIDS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MONA NAVARRO AND AE
OPPOSED THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CAROL NELSON FROM BY
SO YOU CALIFORNIAN I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
JERRY LYNN FROM BY SAID
CALIFORNIAN I POSE THIS BILL.
JENNIFER DELUDE A GARDEN GROVE
CALIFORNIA MOTHER TO I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
NICOLE RAFFERTY FROM LAKE
ARROWHEAD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THIS BAND.
HI MY NAME IS VANESSA CHAVEZ
THAT WERE FROM LA COUNTY WERE
WITH INSPIRED CHARTER WHERE MY
CHILDREN ARE THRIVING AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELENA CHAVEZ AND
I'M A SENIOR INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S TAMARA JENKINS OF A
CHARTER SCHOOL GRADUATE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MIA AND I'M A CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENT I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROOM A MEASURE A
GRADUATE OF ONE SACRAMENTO
CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL UP WAS THE
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHELLE
PRADA MARIN CONTRABAND MEMBER A
MORE THAN EIGHTEEN YOUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER IN SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR AT ALL TRIBES
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I'M HERE IN
OPPOSITION LESS THIS BILL STRONG.
IS AMENDED THE STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL RIPPING Q. TWENTY
THANK YOU TRIBES.
HELLO MY NAME IS BENJAMIN
PHILLIPS I'M A FATHER TO FOUR
DAUGHTERS -- WE'VE DONE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS CHARTER SCHOOLS IN OUR
MOVING TO HOME SCHOOL IN
OPPOSITION OR IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE ELECTION I
APPROACH THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME.
THE MORNING MY NAME IS WELL --
BATTLES I'M BRIAN FOR RICE IN A
SUN SCORCHED TRENTON CHARTER
SCHOOL IN SAN JOSE.
AN OPEL SLEEP AB [inaudible]
ONE FIVE ZERO FIVE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LUIS
CRUZ I OPPOSE FIFTEEN NO.
FIVE THE REASON I CHOSE -- DCP
DOWNTOWN SAN JOSE DE SER
OPPOSITION ONLY PLEASE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EMMANUEL CREWS I AM
FROM DOWNTOWN COLLEGE PREP IN
SAN JOSE.
AND I OPPOSE.
AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE MY NAME IS JOSHUA CHAVEZ
FROM THE CBO CAMINO AND I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS
MICHELLE BERRY.
I'M FOR A PARENT OF THE DCP.
AND I A PERSONAL.
MY NAME IS LUTETIA YOUNG
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
OAKLAND REACH PARENT OF OAKLAND
STUDENTS AND I OPPOSE A. B..
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS
DENISE ALLOWS -- WITH OAKLEY
REACH A PARROT THREE AYE OPPOSED
HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS PATRICIA RODIN A
PARENT OF TWO AND I'M PART OF
THE OAKLEY REITS AND I PULLED
HIS BILL FIXING UP.
MY NAME IS MISS WONDERWORKER SEN
A CHOICE OF SCHOOL CHANGES LIVES
I'M WITH THE OAKLAND REACH NO ON
A. B..
FIFTEEN OH FIVE BUT AS THE AS MY
NUMBER IS KIND OF MOMENTUM THE
OAKLAND PLEASE.
A SIGN MONDAY LET'S SEE HOCEIMA
BUNGLE AND HAVE A KEEN SENSE OF
A SINGLE.
MY NAME IS LISA BABBITT A PRO
OAKLAND PARENT OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS KEY
TO BROWN AND I'M A PROP FOR AND
AYE OPPOSED AB. FIFTEEN OH FIVE
THANK.
HI MY NAME IS LEXI LOPEZ AND ON
BEHALF OF ENVOYS BE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS VERONICA
SANCHES I AM A MEMBER OF THE CAN
REACH AND I OPPOSE -- FIFTEEN OH
FIVE Là WHEN WILL THE SO YOU MY
IDEA IS THIRTY AND GONE THROUGH
THEM THEY THEY LAY.
GAINES SAYS SETTLED SINGLE CLASS
YES.
BUT I KNOW.
BERMAN IS ME EVERYBODY'S AND I
COME FROM CELLS TO CD -- MY
CHILD ELECTED ON BONE COLLEGE
PREP AND I'LL POST TO THE
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI AND GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS AND WE CAN.
IN A THREE KIDS AN APOSTLE OF
BUILT IN A FIGHT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DEBORAH AND I'M A
STUDENT FROM TYPICAL
ANTIANDROGEN.
HI MY NAME IS ROSE SAY ECHO I'M
A PARENT OF A HIGH SCHOOLER
DOWNTOWN COLLEGE PREP.
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL A ROCKET
SHIP SPARK AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CREATION STOKES
I SUPPORT ROCKET SHIP PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NINE MATH TAYLOR.
IT WAS CRITICAL.
TO MY NAME IS A TENER ACCESO
ROCKET SHIP DOESN'T PRACTICE
SCHOOL.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
YOU GO.
MY NAME IS.
MY NAME IS TANYA GENTRY AND I AM
A PARENT OF A SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENT AT ROCKET SHIP DELTA
PREP IN ANTIOCH CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS A MINOR PERKINS.
AND I'D GO TO ROCKET SHIP
THEY'LL SURPRISE IN ANTIOCH
CALIFORNIA.
I THOSE.
NO ONE IN.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA KATHY AND I'M A PARENT
OF TWO RACKETEERS IRAQ SHOULD
DOT THE PREP IN ANY I CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LIVING ARE WELL AS
I'M A PARENT OF THREE IRAQIS
SHOULD BE NINETY OKAY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MELISSA SOLUBLE
REPRESENTING K<c.cyan> BAY AREA</c>
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JONNA GOMEZ AND AYE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LET THE GOMEZ AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALEXANDRIA MARTINEZ I
AM A PROUD PARENT OF TWO
CHILDREN ANDA CURRENT THIRD
GRADE TEACHER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BELL.
MY NAME IS ADAM MOUNTS FULLER
[inaudible]
IN A GO TO SCHOOL AT ROCKY TO
FORCE A COMMUNITY PREP AND I
STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAY SEVERAL SEVERAL HAS AND
THAT PART IN OUT.
THE C. B. HIGH SQUARE PRIMERA
AND ON OPPOSED. TO ONE FIVE ZERO
FIVE THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROSE MERRY
CHAVEZ SCOTT.
I REPRESENT.
A ROCKET SHIP.
MY CHILD GOES TO ROCKET SHIP
DISCOVERY PREP SPECIAL NEEDS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S DENISE GARCIA MY
COMMUNITY OUT REACH MANAGER FOR
A SAN JOSE CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS NOT IN A SALON
YA AND MY MY FOUND THE ROCKET
SHIP PARENTING CURRENTLY SUPPORT
KßT BAY AREA SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THE SELLERS HELLO
DO AND I'M A ROCKET SHIP AND ALL
NAY AND IN SAN JOSE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI I AM NOT THE END OF YES IN
YOUR I AM A PRODUCT OF THE
CHARTER PUBLIC SCHOOL FROM SAN
JOSE AND I KNOW REPRESENT ROCKET
SHIP PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THESE BILLS.
HI MY NAME IS JUST BEAR WITH
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RYAN IN A STRONGLY
BECAUSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NATALIE.
AND FROM RADISHES AND AYE OPALS
AND POSE.
MORNING MY NAME IS ANDREA LEBRON
AND I'M FROM ROCKET SHIP CALL
GIRL ONE OF THE FOUNDERS PARENT
AS WELL ANY ACT AND I OPPOSE
THIS.
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S OLIVIA OF CM IN AND I
AM FROM ROCKETSHIP AND I AM A
POSTED FOR THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ERICA MY BELLY NOT
AND I OPPOSE A DISPUTE
[inaudible]
WHAT ELSE?
MY TURN.
NOW.
I'M CARLA ERA.
A RISING NINTH GRADER FOR
DOWNTOWN COLLEGE PREP IN SAN
JOSE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
ALL I MEAN I'M HONESTLY SAID BY
THAT I'M NOT SO I AM BY THAT
THEY HONESTLY ENTER THAT
DOWNTOWN COLLEGE CRAPPIE I SAY
I'M GOING THAT IS SEVERAL BOYS
THE GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
TAMMY STANTON I'M A PUBLIC
SCHOOL PARENTS.
AND THE CEO OF CAMINO NO WAY
ABOUT CHARTER ACADEMY IN LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE A.
B. FIFTEEN NO.
FIVE THANK YOU.
I GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ANY
ROOM YES I'M WITH COMING ON OF A
CHARTER ACADEMY AS WELL NAY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MY VIEW --
FROM ACADEMIA BONTA CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RUBY GOT
THE ADDRESS SOME A SYNERGY
QUANTUM ALUMNI AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. FIFTEEN OF LIFE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BRENDA
ALONE SO I AND I I AM AN ALUM
FROM ANIMAL FROM BUNCH TRY TO
HIGH SCHOOL IN LOS ANGELES.
NAY STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CARMEN LARA AND
I'M A PRODUCT OF A CHARTER
SCHOOL LEADERSHIP PUBLIC SCHOOLS
WERE TRAINED AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE FIFTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU.
HI JOANNA HOLA I AM A PARENT AND
GOLDEN VALLEY CHARTER SCHOOL
HERE IN SACRAMENTO ALSO A
TRUSTEE FOR THE SEGMENT COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION TO FIFTEEN OH FIVE
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CAITLYN AHOLA I'M AN
ALUMNUS OF GOLDEN VALLEY CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE OF AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE GOOD MORNING I'M
SABRINA LEONARD I AM AN EMPLOYEE
OF HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
ALUMINUM IS AT A FAIRLY LOW
OPENED A STUDIO IN HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL.
IN A GIVES A COMMENCEMENT BONE
WHILE I'M MAKING THIS LITTLE
THING.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY MY NAME
IT'S GOT IT'S A SUBTITLE.
YEAH -- SO USED TO THE INTO THE
LAND -- HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY
CHARTER SCHOOL EMAIL BONGO A
LOBBY GIVES A SUBTLE SINGLE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JAMES
DEARBORN I AM A LOAN NINE FROM
HIGHNESS COMMITTEE CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. FOR MANY MANY MISSION
AT THEIR I AM AN ARTISTIC PARENT
A FOSTER PARENT AND THE STUDENT
FROM HIGHLANDS CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I WOULD STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS TANYA BILL I'M
A KERN STUDENT AT THE HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME'S MICHELLE HUBBLE AND
I'M A STUDENT -- PROUD STUDENT
AT HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SYDNEY VALIDATION
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS STELLA TILLMAN I'M
A DOG STUDENT AT ON HI IN NORTH
HIGHLANDS.
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS EVANS
ALISON HIM STUDENT AT TRUMP.
CHARTER HIGHLAND MODE.
HIGH SCHOOL AND OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HI AM AZIZ A DAVIS GOINGS
PRESIDENT CEO FOR THE SACRAMENTO
BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SANDRA
AND ALAN.
AND I'M A STUDENT AT HIGHLANDS
COMMITTEE CHARTER SCHOOL.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SAY I'M A
BUILDING FIFTEEN OH FIVE AND
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN AND WE WANT ALL
THE SCHOOL BACK FALL IS YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS SHERRY TAURUS AND
I OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN KNOWLES BY.
RIGHT.
MY NAME IS GINNY STEIN I AM A
COMMUNITY AVERAGE DIRECTOR AND
PROUD STUDENT OF HIGHLIGHTS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SPELL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THE
DIRECT SUM A THIRTY YEAR VETERAN
TO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS FRAN RACKS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALEX ARE CARE FROM
CORE CHARGE CORNEIL STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS HEIDI Là CARE AND A
PARENT OF TWO CHILDREN A CORD
CHARTERS WELL AS A BOARD MEMBER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MADDIE WILL CARE I
ATTEND COURT CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
MY NAME.
MY NAME IS MERRY.
AND IN MY SCHOOL SCORE CHARTER
SCHOOL AND AYE OPPOSED TO SPILL.
MY NAME IS RICHARD SHARPE I'M A
PARENT OF A STUDENT FROM COURT
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS TIM TUTOR EXECUTOR
ACTOR OF ALL TO SCHOOLS AND SAN
DIEGO STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JACKIE ROBERTSON
CHIEF OF STAFF AT ALL TO SCHOOLS
IN SAN DIEGO AND WE OPPOSE THE
SPELL.
MY NAME IS VERONICA BALMAIN
SCHOOL COORDINATOR FOR AUDIO
CHARTER SCHOOL IN SAN DIEGO AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS HALEY BEAUPRE SCHOOL
COORDINATOR FOR GROSSMONT IN
SWEETWATER SECONDARY SCHOOLS IN
SAN DIEGO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS ANNA
MARIA ROW HOUSE I'M A TEACHER AT
THE CHARTER SCHOOL OF SAN DIEGO
AND I ALSO POSE A. B..
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
THE LORD DEROSE YAK AND I'M A
TEACHER AT THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
OF SAN DIEGO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MEDICINE THIS COVER HAN A FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AT DOWNTOWN COLLEGE
PREP IN SAN JOSE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
AMBER POWERS I'M WITH A THE
CHARTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS MADELINE VALDEZ
VASQUEZ WITH HIGHLY CHARTER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE ONCE OVER
SCORE ONE MIDDLE SCHOOL LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE I'M CHRISTINA
AGUILERA I LIVE IN EAST LA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HE SEE TAYLOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF ACHIEVED CHARTER SCHOOLS OF
PARADISE AND WE OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS BRYCE A LACK
CURRENT FOR BY CRIME MUCH HOTTER --
PACOIMA AN ENSEMBLE POLLS TO AB
FIFTEEN OFF I HI MY NAME IS AMY
TAYLOR AND A SPECIAL EDUCATOR
AND HARDER STUDENTS MOTHER.
NAY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JEFFREY TAYLOR WHO
STUDENT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE NUMBER IS ONE OF RODENTS
HE'LL.
BINGO IN LOS ANGELES BUT IF I
WHAT ABOUT THE KNOWING KANSAS IN
A SINGLE GOOD ASK YES -- ONE OF
THE OTHER MEN NUMBER ESOS BEEN
WHAT ISLANDS BINGO THE MONK
NOTICE SCIENCE ACADEMIC.
TO THE MOBILE MORE LOVE IS CAN
SAYS IT'LL SINGLE CLASSES.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANDY LEE NOT AS
SOME APPROACH CHARTER LOAN FROM
LOS ANGELES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARIA FLORES
FROM BECAME A CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING VICTOR RIGHT HERE
I'M A PART IN A CAPSULE ACADEMY
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
IT'S TO LATE.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AYE LIMóN CS I'M
HERE TO OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO FIVE
ON BEHALF OF FAMILIES ON THE
BOND F ON INCORPORATED EAST LA.
HELLO MY NAME'S EVA RADHA FROM
THE SENATE WAS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING LUIS MOLINA WITH
KIP FOLK ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION.
HI MY NAME IS HE SAID A
COMPARISON FROM SANTA ANA
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
PARENT UNION AND WE ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
PAUL CONTRARIES FROM SANTA ANA
CALIFORNIA HAD NOW SUPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS KAMAL
MARTIN PARENTS OF CHILDREN IN
SAN DIEGO PUBLIC SCHOOLS VOTE NO
ON FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS
KILEY.
I LIVE IN MERRY MY NAME IS KILEY
MY KAY AND I LIVE IN MARINO
VALLEY I AM AS STUDENT FROM
INSPIRE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THE BILL.
AND BRAIN MARKARIAN [inaudible]
THAT SPELL.
BRITNEY MARKARIAN.
APPARENT WITH INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL IN MARINO VALLEY AND AYE
OPPOSED WITH THEM.
IMAX CARPENTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM MILES CARPENTER.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ANYWAYS CAM CARPENTER I'M
HOMESCHOOLING MOM IN A VENDOR
WITH THE CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BARBARA MURPHY I AM A
HOMESCHOOLING MOM.
WITH INSPIRED CHARTER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAROLYN FRANK
I'M A GRANDMOTHER OF THE
CHILDREN THAT GO TO A SPIRE.
CHARTER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GINNY EDWARDS I'M
HOME SCHOOL MOM AND ALSO A
TEACHER WITH A PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS FAITH
TWICE IN CENTERS IN A VALUE
ACADEMY CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
GOOD MORNING GENET WHAT IS FROM
SENT US IN A VALLEY ACADEMY IN
SANTA SAID NO AND I OPPOSE HIS
BILL.
I'M JIM PRICE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MICHELLE SNYDER A TWO CHILDREN
AT DOWNTOWN COLLEGE PREP ALUM
ROCK IN SAN JOSE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DAN SNYDER AND I
OPPOSE HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DENISE.
AND I'M A SUPPORT FOR ROCKETSHIP.
AND I ARE BOTH.
MY NAME IS HIGH MAY I'M HERE FOR
D. C. P. AND AYE OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH FRANCE
FARMERS TO NOT SELL SUTTER
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS RESTAURANTS WELL.
I'M AS SOON AS OUTSIDERS HER
SCHOOL AN IMPOSSIBLE.
MY NAME IS SUZANNE FRIENDS WHILE
I'M THE MOTHER OF EIGHT CHARTERS
SCHOOL EDUCATED STUDENTS JOHN
ADAMS ACADEMY ROSE FILL IN SOUTH
SUTTER CHARTER SCHOOL HOME
SCHOOL CHARTER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S CLAIRE FRANCE WHILE
I'M AN ELEVEN YEAR CHARTER
SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M REX FORTUNE RETIRED
SUPERINTENDENT -- IN CALIFORNIA
BOARD MEMBER PACIFIC CHARLIE
INSTITUTE OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE PAUL KIEFFER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR PACIFIC CHAR
INSTITUTE BOARD MEMBER SEVERAL
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION AND
AYE OPPOSED. FIFTEEN ZERO FIVE
ONE OF SLUSH FUND YOU LISTER
SCHOOL GRADUATE AND AYE OPPOSED.
FIFTEEN ZERO FIVE AND DESERVE
ANY GUFF FROM KEPT OUR CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DENNIS MA FOR MIL
GROVE CALIFORNIA.
OPPOSE FIFTEEN OH FIVE
ESPECIALLY THE PART WITH THE
LACK OF CHECKS AND BALANCES.
MARA DONAHOE EAST LOS ANGELES I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SKYLER SMITH I GO
TO SAGE OAK CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANNA SMITH -- I
HAVE TWO CHILDREN IN STAGE OAK
CHARTER SCHOOL AND INSPIRED HER
TO SCHOOL I'M ALSO AN EDUCATOR I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WHEN ON THE U. S. ME NUMBER IS
KNOWN MY BANGOR THE LESS YOU
HAVE A OAKLAND BUT THEN THIS
CALL AYE BY THE BUT MOTHER MORE
THAN THIRTY YEAH THERE IS QUITE
A LOT THE LAKE HOUSE?
MIL BONGO I LAY AWAKE USES IT'LL
SINGLE PUT FORWARD US YES.
MY NAME IS ERIC RAMIREZ AND I'M
FROM SEND NINE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ME NO MEDICINALLY SEVEN VASQUEZ
BINGO THERE SANTA SCHOOL OAKLAND
MILK BONE WHILE AVE KANSAS IT'LL
SINGLE.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA ME SURE I'M
A PARENT FROM COMMUNITY SCHOOL
FOR CREATIVE EDUCATION IN
OAKLAND.
AND I OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
SERRA CARTER I'M FROM FRESNO
COUNTY WE ARE WITH INSPIRED
CHARTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
I AM CLEAR AND I'M ARM FOR THE
FROM FRESNO WITH INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL I'M NOT
CREDENTIALED TEACHER AND A MOM
OF THREE SHOWN TO TO TO IN THE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL
.
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA HALL I AM
A CONDITION OF MR KEN COOLEY AND
I AM A TEACHER AND CHARTER
SCHOOL PARENTS AND I OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LILLIAN
OF RO I AM A REPRESENTATIVE OF
THREE OVER.
THREE HUNDRED FAMILIES OF A
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL IN OAKLAND
AND WE OPPOSED.
A. B.. FIFTEEN OH FIVE ONE OF
THE ADMIN NUMBER IS MY DESANTIS
EVEN GO THAT LIST WELL AT THE AT
RISE THE OAKLAND INYO PUMP OR
LOOKING TO SETTLE SINGLE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ART
WITHOUT COMING FOR THE UNIT AT
HIGH SCHOOL IN OAKLAND -- BY
OPPOSED TO AT FIFTEEN OH FIVE
THANK YOU.
WHEN OF THE US ARMY NUMBER IS
GONNA SELL ALMANSA FOR A MOTHER
THAT FAMILIAR LIKE WHAT THREE
HOLES THAT CHARTER?
AND ALL GUN.
-ARAMBULA BOY AND A LOT OF
SQUARE CHAIRED THE LOGIN EMAIL
BUNGALOW AVENUE KANSAS IT'LL
SINGLE.
MY NAME IS SHANNON LAUDERDALE MY
CHILDREN ARE ENROLLED ENROLLED
IN A CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS PARRIS LAUDERDALE AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS YOUR MOTHER DILLON I
POSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EMMA BEATEN BENDER
I'VE BEEN A TURNER PARENT FOR
ABOUT TWELVE YEARS I ALSO RUN A
HOME SCHOOL GROUP REPRESENTING
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED HOME
SCHOOLERS 95% WHICH USE THE
CHARTER SCHOOL I WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JACOB BEATEN MENDER
I'M A JUNIOR AT SELTZER CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL PLEASE REPRESENT THEIR
PEOPLE.
MY NAME IS JC BEATEN BENDER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
HI MY NAME IS A MILLION JACKSON
I'M A PROUD GRADUATE FROM A
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL IN VISION
ACADEMY IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND CURRENTLY.
A JUNIOR AT UC BERKELEY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SEN I'M A SENIOR
FROM A PROUD PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL NAME DIVISION ACADEMY IN
OPEN CALIFORNIAN I DEFINITELY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MAYOR OF MY TENNIS
AND I PRESS SENIOR AT OAKLEY
UNITY PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B..
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
JULIE SO ABOUT US I AM A NO NO
MY FOR AMMO AND MORE RALPH
BUNCHE IN LOS ANGELES COOLEY
ATTENDANCE OF FRANCISCO CA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LAURIE VEGA AND
I'M FROM OAKLAND THE PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOL AND AYE POSES
BILL.
I MEAN IT'S NOT TOO BIG AND I AM
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT
FROM A COMMUNITY HAINA OPPOSES
BILL.
HI I AM KEVIN FORTUNA FROM OPS
OAKLAND I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HI MY NAME IS ARM MONEY
HAMMOND'S I AM A STUDENT AT
AMERICAN INDIAN PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS RL AND I'M A
STUDENT FROM ENVISIONED AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
HI MANY MISTAKES ON MISSION I A
A CURRENT CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT
ATTENDING LPS OAKLAND ARE INDIAN
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANGEL GARCIA MY
PROUD MOTHER OF FOUR CHILDREN
ONE WAS A CHARTER SCHOOL
GRADUATE AND ONE WAS A QUEER
CHILD WITH A DISABILITY WHO IS
NOT SERVED IN THE DISTRICT WHILE.
HI MY NAME IS THE CHANNEL AND
I'M A PARENT OF FOUR IN A STRONG
APPLES THIS BILL.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JAMES
FALCONER -- I HAVE A FOR
STUDENTS -- WE CAME UP HERE FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA -- BECAUSE
WE FEEL SO STRONGLY TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I GRAY GAZE HERE ON BEHALF OF
KIP SO CAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
OPPOSITION THANK.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
ALLOCATE DONNIE ON BEHALF OF
KßT BAY AREA SCHOOLS STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
RESTING CROSS FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR OF SORTS CHARTER
ACADEMY KATE SCHOOL IN SUMMER
DINO AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
TRICIA LANCASTER DIRECTOR AND CO
FOUNDER SORT TURNER ACADEMY AND
BOARD CHAIR SPOT PRESS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KEVIN SAID I'M SEE OF
NAVIGATOR SCHOOLS WE RENT THREE
HIGH PERFORMING.
NONPROFIT PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KATIE HAD TO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LISA
JENKINS I AM A MOTHER A BUSINESS
OWNER AND AS THAT IS INVOLUNTARY.
VOLUNTEER WITH PARENTS UNITED
FOR KIDS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M DR KATIE STOKES --
KATIE GUIDED FROM THE US
STANFORD UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KELLY THANKS I
LIVE IN SUCH A SCIENCE I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN IN A CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NAOMI HARRISON I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
TERROR RULE AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
I AM OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ALYSSA
WROTE US I AM AND INSPIRE PARENT
AND I AM FROM CAMP PENDLETON
HERE REPRESENTING OVER THIRTY
OTHER FAMILIES I COULDN'T MAKE
IT WE OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS SANDRA THAT EITHER.
AND I OPPOSE THE BILL AND I HAVE
A FROM STUDENT THE GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
MY NAME'S ITALIAN RATHER IN A
ROUTE I'M A RECENT GRADUATE AND
EVERY CHARTER SCHOOLS IN APPLE'S
ISRAEL.
HELLO GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY
NAME IS EASY LITTLE ITEM MEANT
THAT REPRESENTING AT NOT BE
CHARTER SCHOOLS WITH SCHOOLS A
SANTA ANA EAST LA IN SOUTH LA
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JODY LEON I'M A
MOM OF TWO WITH INSPIRED WE CAME
FROM ANAHEIM TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
KAYLA WILD MAN FROM YOU BECAUSE
I AM.
AND THE PARENT OF A SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILD WHO HAS BEEN SERVED
BY CHARTER SCHOOLS I OPPOSE THE
BILL.
MY NAME IS REBECCA BLOOM.
I AM WITH INSPIRE AND AYE
OPPOSED TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS SHEILA SCOTT FROM LOS
ANGELES ANTI OPPOSE THIS BILL
PLEASE VOTE.
NINE MY NAME IS MELISSA I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN THROUGH CONNECTING
WATERS CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MONICA MARTINEZ AND
FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN THROUGH SOUTH
SUTTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JULIE RICHEST SEND
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
MOTHER OF THREE AND I OPPOSE
THIS FALL.
HI MY NAME IS LAURA FRAZIER I'M
FROM STEVENSON RANCH CALIFORNIA
I'M A MOTHER F TWO AND A FORMER
TEACHER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JACKIE EVANS A MOTHER
OF TWO AND A FIRST GRADE TEACHER
FROM LOS ANGELES AND I OPPOSE
HIS BILL.
MY NAME'S AMY FOLEY I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS HOLLY NOW SLANG I
HAVE A ONE SIDED AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS STACY BACKGROUND THE
MOTHER OF TWO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS FELICIA WOFFORD FROM
LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA TWO
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S OLIVIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES.
ADRIAN WELL FROM BAKERSFIELD
WERE CHARTER SCHOOL FAMILY WE
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TôI A BARNES I HAVE
TWO SCHOLARS IN THE FORTUNE
SCHOOL SYSTEM AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE YES.
OUR WILL PAY ATTENTION HERE
GENTLEMAN.
CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND THANK YOU TO THEAUTHORS AND
THAT'S REALLY ALL THE PEOPLE OF
CALM FOR AND AGAINST TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CONVERSATION
TODAY -- I I KNOW AS THE AS
THERE'S BEEN INDICATED THAT THIS
IS A WORK IN PROGRESS AND SO.
I DO HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
BUT I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
TAX -- I UNDERSTAND THE THE
PROCESS YOU'RE GOING THROUGH AN
AND SO.
IT'S IF IT'S FROM SERVICE FLUID
IN THESE THINGS CAN CHANGE BUT I
I'M.
I'M OBVIOUSLY TRYING TO ABSORB
[inaudible]
THE YOU KNOW THE THE THE THE
REVIEW REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN
THE BILL AND ON PAGE THIRTY TWO
IF I COULD DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION.
THE PAGE.
THIRTY TWO BEGINNING ON LINE
EIGHT THERE'S A WHOLE.
STE OF EXAMPLES IN WHICH I GUESS
IN THE REVIEW OF A PROPOSED
CHARTER.
THAT -- THE SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN
DETERMINED UNDER THESE STANDARDS.
THAT IT'S NOT -- APPROPRIATE --
DOES INCLUDE -- ON LINE -- EIGHT
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE PROPOSED
CHARTER SCHOOL WOULD
SUBSTANTIALLY UNDERMINED
EXISTING SERVICES.
AND THEN ON LINE -- TWELVE
WHETHER WITH DUPLICATED PROGRAM
CURRENTLY OFFERED.
AND IT GOES ON AND I GUESSONE
OF MY QUESTIONS IS IT SEEMS LIKE
IT'S REALLY AN OPEN DOOR TO JUST.
SAY THAT WE ALREADY HAVE A
SCHOOL HERE IN THE AREA. THIRTY
OFFERING MATH AND ENGLISH SINCE.
SOCIAL SCIENCES AND THE REST.
SEEMS TO JUST BE AN OPEN DOOR TO
JUST TO SAY NOW AND WONDER IF
THE ARTIST COULD COMMENT ON THAT.
UNDER THE THE EFFORT HERE IS
THAT THE IMPACT BE SUBSTANTIAL
MEAN IT CAN'T JUST BE A DOLLAR
THE FISCAL IMPACT CAN'T JUST BE
A DOLLAR.
PUT IT THAT IT -- SUBSTANTIALLY
UNDERMINES EXISTING SERVICES
ACADEMIC OR PROGRAMMATIC OFFERED
OFFERINGS SO AGAIN.
THE THE EMPHASIS OF THE BILL IS
TO BRING BACK LOCAL CONTROL.
BUT FROM MY STANDPOINT THAT
LANGUAGE DOES GIVE A LOCAL BOARD
THE AUTHORITY TO DETERMINE --
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR COMMUNITY
AND AND AND STATUS.
THUS THE THE PURPOSE OF THE
LANGUAGE.
IN THE AREA AND THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ON PAGE -- ELEVEN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF -- IN THE SECOND
PARAGRAPH SAID THAT IN LOOKING
AT THIS.
THIS AUTHORIZATION CRITERIA IT
SAID.
DODD AND ASK THE QUESTION WITH
THE OPTION OF THE NINE A CHARTER
SCHOOL BASED ON A SUBJECTIVE --
ASSESSMENT OF THE FISCAL IMPACT
TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICT MET WROTE
RENDER MOST IF NOT ALL CHARTER
PETITIONS DENIABLE [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
WHAT'S THE QUESTION.
BY POINTING OUT THAT THE
ANALYSIS THAT WE HAVE IS A
CANADIAN ANALYSIS ON PAGE.
ELEVEN LOOKS AT THAT LANGUAGE
THAT I JUST REFERENCED.
AND SAYS THAT IT'S THAT IT'S SO
SUBJECTIVE.
IN THE ASSESSMENT THAT IT WOULD
IT -- NOT RENDER -- MOST IF NOT
ALL CHARTER PETITIONS DENIABLE
THAT'S THE CONCLUSION THAT THE
THAT THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS
HAVE MADE ABOUT THAT LANGUAGE.
YES YES I SEE THAT MEAN OFFICER
I READ THAT WHEN I REVIEW THE
ANALYSIS AND BUT I THINK THAT
THE OFFICES RIGHT TO LOOK AT THE
FACT THAT THERE WAS BOTH THE
OBJECTIVE COMPONENTS AND
SUBJECTIVE COMPONENT YOU'RE
FOCUSING ON THE THE SUBJECTIVE
COMPONENT.
AND THEY WERE.
ARE SOME FOLKS WHO WOULD ARGUE
THAT YOU SHOULD REMOVE ANY
SUBJECTIVE -- DISCRETION FROM --
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD WHOSE JOB IT IS TO
LOOK OUT FOR THE BEST INTERESTS
OF THE CHILDREN FAMILIES
PARENTING COMMUNITIES IN THEIR
DISTRICT.
AND IN SOME WAYS THIS IS A
COMPROMISE BECAUSE IT REQUIRES A
HIGHER THRESHOLD OF OF
SUBSTANTIAL.
UNDERMINING IT'S NOT DE MINIMUS
UNDERMINING ITS NOT MINIMAL
UNDERMINING IT MUST BE
SUBSTANTIAL AND SO IT IT'S
ACTUALLY A TRIGGER.
A HEIGHTENED TRIGGER IT'S
REQUIRED BEFORE I DETERMINATION
CAN BE MADE ABOUT -- WHETHER CAN
EVEN BE CONSIDERED AND THEN IT'S
A FACTOR AMONG MANY FACTORS AND
YES IF IF IT'S IF A SCHOOL
DISTRICT -- DESTRUCTIVE TERMS
THAT THERE IS SUBSTANTIAL
UNDERMINING THEY CAN CONSISTENT
WITH THIS LAW -- DECIDE THAT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO AUTHORIZE A
NEW CHARTER SCHOOL REMEMBER THIS
IS JUST FOR NEW CHARTER SCHOOLS
ONE THAT DON'T EXIST RIGHT NOW
THERE'S NO KIDS ADAM NO ONE'S
LEARNING ANYTHING AT THEM
BECAUSE THEY DON'T EXIST YET --
BUT IT IS SO IT'S A PROSPECTIVE
GOING FORWARD BASIS -- AND YOU
NOTICE SOME FOLKS WOULD SAY THAT
YOU'RE TAKING AWAY AUTHORITY OF
A LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD -- SO
THAT'S PART OF THE THE COULD THE
COMPROMISE HERE TO HAVE THAT
HEIGHTENED TRIGGER OF
SUBSTANTIAL UNDERMINING.
AND SO I O APPRECIATE THAT IT'S
NOT A NEW ONES BUT THE
SUBSTANTIAL -- DIRECTION THE
BUILD ONLY FOCUS ON NEW CHARTERS
AND NOT LOOKING BACK AND I THINK
THAT'S A MATERIAL -- FOCUS AND I
I ONE OF THE COLLEGES -- BUT I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT IT WE IN
AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE HAVE.
HOW MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA NOW FACING FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES IT'S QUITE
SUBSTANTIAL AND I THINK MANY
WOULD SUGGEST THAT -- WHEN WENT
WHEN WE DIP INTO ANOTHER
RECESSION THAT THAT THAT THIS IS
GOING TO GROW QUITE QUITE QUITE
LARGE [inaudible]
AND AND THAT'S A CHALLENGE THAT
WE FACE THEY GO WAY BEYOND THE
ISSUE OF CHARTERS -- WE DON'T
SPEND A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT THAT HERE -- BUT I YOU
KNOW ENROLLMENT DECLINES ARE
JUST ONE PART OF THE SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL ISSUES THAT THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE FACING.
AND YET WHEN YOU LOOK AT OF THE
SIX MILLION.
KIDS IN OUR SCHOOLS TODAY.
HOW MANY SCHOOLS?
SCHOOLS A DOES THAT COMPRISE I
DO KNOW THAT.
THAT THERE SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE THAT ARE CONSIDERED FOR
PERFORMING.
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE AND
THAT'S ACROSS THE STATE -- AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SCHOOLS THAT
ARE GETTING TITLE ONE FEDERAL
AID BECAUSE THEY'RE LOW INCOME
THAT'S FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
SCHOOLS.
THAT ARE POOR PERFORMING ACROSS
THE STATE AND OF THOSE ONLY
THIRTY FOUR CHARTERS.
SO WE HAVE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS.
POOR PERFORMING AND I GUESS THE
THERE'S TWO REASONS FOR RAISING
THAT FACT ONE IS IS THAT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PARENTS WHO
ARE FEELING PRETTY STRESSED
ABOUT THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION
THAT THEY'RE GETTING
[inaudible]
AND THEY'RE TRYING TO FIND
ALTERNATIVES AND I THINK THE
SOME OF THE WITNESSES OF SPOKEN
ABOUT EARLIER WHEN THEY TALK
ABOUT LOSING A YEAR OF A CHILD'S
LIFE.
OR TWO YEARS OR THREE YEARS.
IT SAYS IT'S A BIG DEAL.
AND I I KNOW IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE
THAT I I DO THINK IT'S WORTH
NOTING THAT THE GROWTH OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOL.
THE CHARTER SCHOOL.
COMMUNITY IS A IS AN ELEMENT OF
PARENTS.
SAYING THAT I JUST DON'T WANT TO
LOSE ANOTHER YEAR OF MY CHILD'S
LIFE.
AND HERE WE HAVE SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE FOR PERFORMING
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA TODAY IT'S
A LOT OF PARENTS PROBABLY.
PRETTY WORRIED.
AND SO EVEN THOUGH I ACKNOWLEDGE
THE VALUE OF LOOKING FORWARD ON
THE CHARTER SCHOOL.
ISSUE GOING FORWARD [inaudible]
I'D.
THAT'S A LOT OF PARENTS AND A
LOT OF STUDENTS WHO ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THE QUALITY OF THEIR
CHILD'S EDUCATION AND TRYING TO
FIND SOME ALTERNATIVE.
AND SO WHAT WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD THINKING WITH THIS
LEGISLATION.
IT'S DOING SO IN A WAY THAT
AFFECTS A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
PRETTY STRESSED OUT SO I GUESS
IT'S A POINT OF THE KNOWLEDGE
MEANT THERE.
I DO THINK THE FINANCIAL HEALTH
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS VERY
IMPORTANT AND I AND IF I WERE A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER AND I THINK
ABOUT THIS IF I WAS ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD.
AND I WAS LOSING ENROLLMENT AND
WE SEE IT IN OAKLAND I NOW.
WE SEE IT IN LOS ANGELES.
AND AND WE READ ABOUT IN THE
PAPER THE CHOICE IS THE THE
SCHOOL BOARDS ARE FACING TODAY
AND THEY'RE VERY DIFFICULT
CHOICES AND I THINK IF I WERE
THERE.
WOULD I HAVE THE STRENGTH TO SAY.
THAT SCHOOL THAT HAS LOST HALF
ITS ENROLLMENT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO CLOSE IT AND CONSOLIDATE.
THESE ARE VERY TOUGH CHOICES
THAT I KNOW THE HARD CHOICES.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
FINANCIAL VIABILITY OF A SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHICH THIS BILL THIS
BILL TOUCHES UPON IN A
SIGNIFICANT WAY.
THERE'S A LOT OF CHOICES THAT GO
INTO THAT FINANCIAL LIABILITY
INCLUDING THE ABILITY OF THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO MAKE TOUGH CHOICES.
IN DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES AND
PART OF THAT CENTRAL NAY AND
PART OF THAT OUR COST INCREASES.
RETIREMENT COST INCREASES IN A
LOT OF OTHER THINGS.
AND SO I DO JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT ISSUE OF
FINANCIAL.
IMPACT IS A VERY ELUSIVE ONE NOT
SO EASY TO PIN DOWN SUBJECT TO A
LOT OF SUBJECTIVE.
AN ANALYSIS AND ALSO SUBJECT TO
A LOT OF A LEADERSHIP CHOICES
THAT ARE SCHOOL BOARDS ARE
MAKING.
I AM THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH
THEY FIND THEMSELVES.
OF THE SECOND QUESTION I WANTED
TO ASK IS ABOUT ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT.
I DO SEE THAT IN THE IN THE
REVIEW OF REASONS FOR REVIEWING
CHARTERS.
THAT I DON'T SEE A LOT ABOUT --
WHETHER OR NOT.
THE ACADEMIC NEEDS OF THAT HAVE
A COMMUNITY ARE BEING SERVED I'D
I'D BE INTERESTED IN HEARING THE
AUTHOR OR OTHERS SPEAK TO THAT
ISSUE OF ACADEMIC NEED IN TERMS
OF HOW THEY ANALYZE THE NEED FOR
CHARTERS.
BUT CAN YOU SAY THAT THE THE
ACADEMIC ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
ARE STILL A POINT OF DISCUSSION.
AS WE GO FORWARD.
CAN YOU KIND OF DESCRIBE FOR ME
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT THE THE
POINTS OF FIVE IN KOREA -- ABOUT
THAT IN REGARD TO THAT.
WHAT'S IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE.
HOW WOULD YOU?
WHEN IT COMES TO RE
AUTHORIZATION HOW WOULD YOU
JUDGE A H. CHARTERS ACADEMIC
STANDING?
AND SHOULD A CHARTER THAT AS
HIGHER ACADEMIC STANDARDS AND
MAYBE ANOTHER.
HAVE A MORE REFINED PROCESS AND
MAYBE GET A A LONGER TIME
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE CHARTER
WOULD BE GRANTED FOR A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME BEFORE IT COMES
UP FOR REAUTHORIZATION.
AND THEY'RE PROBABLY SOME OF THE
POINTS FOR DISCUSSION TO BE HAD
THERE AS WELL.
I'M REALLY I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT
AND I DO THINK THAT WITH
EXISTING CHARTERS AND THE
RENEWAL PROCESS THAT.
AND WE HEARD FROM ONE OF THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ABOUT.
THE HIGH QUALITY CHARTER THAT
SHE'S LEADING AND AND HOW WELL
IT'S DONE AND THAT IF WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND DIFFERENTIALS.
I MET THE QUICK IT SEEMS LIKE A
PART OF THAT THE ESSENCE OF ALL
THAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS TO TRY
TO FIND THE BAD APPLES.
THOSE CHARTERS THAT ARE NOT
DOING THEIR JOB CORRECTLY AND I
THINK THAT'S A FAIR AT POINT OF
INQUIRY IN AND POINT OF WORK
BECAUSE NOBODY WANTS THAT I
DON'T WANT -- BAD.
PUBLIC CHARTERS -- TO TO BE
FEELING OUR KIDS IS THE SAME WAY
I DON'T WANT TO HAVE BAD
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
FAILING OUR KIDS SO.
THAT I THINK THAT IS THE RIGHT
POINT EMPHASIS SO WHERE.
THERE IS -- FOCUS ON OR LACK OF
FOCUS OR NO NEED TO FOCUS ON
HIGH QUALITY -- CHARTERS THAT
OUR DIVERSITY SERVING THE
ACADEMIC NEEDS WELL I THINK
THAT'S A I'M GLAD TO HEAR THT.
YOU'RE TAKING A CAREFUL LOOK AT
THAT AND I GUESS I WOULD SAY
THAT THE SAME FOR FUTURE CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT.
NO WE'RE YOU HAVE FAILING
SCHOOLS IN A COMMUNITY -- AND
WE'RE CHARTER I PROPOSE CHARTERS
PROVIDE AT THE POTENTIAL FOR
GREATER ACADEMIC OUTCOMES I HOPE
THAT YOU LOOK AT THAT.
TOO BECAUSE WHEN YOU GO BACK AND
YOU LOOK AT THIS LIST OF SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE POOR
PERFORMANCE SCHOOLS TO BIG
NUMBER -- IDOL I WANT TO GO OUT
TO THE POOR PERFORMING CHARTERS.
TO BUT YOU KNOW IT IS A
CIRCUMSTANCE WE WE DO FIND
OURSELVES AND MATT I'M SURE I
KNOW I'VE TAKEN A LOT OF TIME
BUT MAYBE A FINAL OBSERVATION.
THE NOT A TIME THAT WE SPENT
TODAY TALKING ABOUT ONE PART
ABOUT OUR OF OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM
THE PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL PART
EARLY IN THIS CASE THE FUTURE
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL PART -- IT
SO OVERWHELMS THE AMOUNT OF TIME
WE SPENT TALKING ABOUT OUR POOR
PERFORMING.
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
OUR STATE -- WE SPEND ALMOST NO
TIME -- HERE IN THE SENATE --
TALKING ABOUT OUR ENGLISH.
SCORESOR ARE MATH SCORES ARE
SOCIAL SCIENCE SCORES -- AND WE
HAVE.
A FAILURE AGAINST FAILURE
AGAINST FAILURE ALL ACROSS THE
STATE.
NOT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE GREAT
TEACHERS AND GREAT
ADMINISTRATORS AND
SUPERINTENDENTS COOL BOARDS BUT
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
AND YET WE SPEND SO MUCH TIME IN
THIS COMMITTEE AND TODAY.
FOCUSED ON ONE LITTLE ELEMENT OF
IT.
AND SO I THINK THAT OBSERVATIONS
ONE I HOPE WE TAKE THE HEART
THAT WE DO WE ALL FEEL THIS
ISSUE OF OUR STUDENTS EDUCATION
HOW WE ADVANCE IT AND HOW WE GO
AFTER PLACES WHERE IT'S NOT
WORKING RIGHT AND I KNOW THAT'S
THE INTENT OF THE AUTHORS.
BUT BUT WE WE ALL SHARE I THINK
IN THAT -- LACK OF ATTENTION ON
THE BROADER FOCUS OF OF FAILURE
AND POOR PERFORMANCE AND HELP
THAT WE CAN -- COLLECTIVELY AND
I SAY TO MYSELF AS TO OTHERS.
I TRY TO DO BETTER THIS IS THE
IDENTIFYING SOME ISSUE OF
CONCERN I GRANT YOU THAT BUT I
HOPE THAT.
IT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY FROM THE
MORE IMPORTANT FOCUS.
ON A BROADER RANGE OF FAILURES
AND AND THAT WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT SO THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER AND AS I
STATED WHEN WE BEGAN THE
COMMITTEE ONE BILL WILL NOT FIX
EVERYTHING THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION -- BUT WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
CONSIDER GLAZER NEED DIDN'T TAKE.
TOO MUCH TIME AT ALL IN FACT OUT
MY COMMENTS AND THOUGHTS ALIGN
ALIGN WITH YEARS I DID ONE ASSET
POINTS TO A COUPLE THINGS JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION BASED UPON --
WHAT WAS SAID -- DO YOU
[inaudible]
PUBLIC.
SCHOOL CHARTER EMPLOYEES GET
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION YES --
EXISTING STATUE REQUIRES --
FINGERPRINTING AND BACKGROUND
CHECKS FOR ALL TEACHERS IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THERE'S A
CROSS REFERENCE TO EXISTING
STATUTE.
IN -- THE BILL IN PRINT AS
AMENDED ON JULY FIFTH ON PAGE
TWENTY NINE LINE THIRTY SIX IT'S
A CROSS REFERENCE.
TO FOUR FOUR TWO THREE SEVEN BUT
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY CURIOUS ABOUT
THE EXAMPLES THAT THE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
HAS SURFACED AND VIGILANT ABOUT
ANY EXAMPLES IN VIOLATION OF
EXISTING LAW.
A GREAT THANK YOU ANOTHER THING
THAT WAS MENTIONED WAS A LACK OF
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS AND NAM MY
UNDERSTANDING IS COR.
CORE SUBJECTS TEACHERS HAVE TO
BE CREDENTIALED SO IT'S FOR
OTHER THINGS WERE THOSE ARE STEM
EDUCATION CAN YOU AND THE
COUNCIL ATTY.
SO -- AS MISTER O'DONNELL --
INDICATED IN HIS REMARKS THAT
THIS ISSUE IS AN ISSUE THAT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO WORK TO
RESOLVE -- AT BECAUSE WE ARE ON
POLAR OPPOSITES OF THIS QUESTION
AROUND -- WHAT LEVEL OF
CERTIFICATE OR CLEARANCE --
CREDENTIALING THAT CHARTER
SCHOOL TEACHERS IN NON CORE AND
NON COLLEGE PREP COURSES SHOULD.
HAVE TO ABIDE BY AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THIS IS A CORE PILLAR OF
THE CHARTER MODEL THAT WE CAN
PULL FROM BORROW FROM -- THE
TALENTS WITHIN A COMMUNITY OF
PROFESSIONALS WHO MAY NOT HAVE
MADE IT IT'S THEIR LIFE'S WORK
TO BE.
A CLASSROOM TEACHER BUT WHO
STILL MAY HAVE VALUE.
THAT THEY CAN BRING TO THE
CLASSROOM THIS IS WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS PART OF THE SECRET
SAUCE OF WHAT MAKES CHARTER SO
GREAT AND SO FOR US.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
EXISTING SCHOOLS AND FUTURE
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE NOT
COMPLETELY HOLLOWED OUT.
THAT FROM BEING ABLE TO EXERCISE
THESE CORE FLEXIBILITY SURROUND
CREDENTIALING BUT WE THINK THAT
THERE'S A PATH FORWARD THE
LANGUAGE IN PRINT BEFORE YOU IS
CERTAINLY OUR PREFERENCE WE
RECOGNIZE THE AUTHOR.
HAS HIS PREFERENCE AND WE HOPE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK -- TO FIND A
LANDING SPOT THERE.
I JUST WANT TO ADD ON TO THAT --
UNDER THE CURRENT ITERATION OF
THIS BILL OF A COLLEGE PROFESSOR
FOR EXAMPLE WHO HAD HAVE YOU
KNOW A PHD IN INTERNATIONAL
STUDIES BUT NOT.
A TEACHING CREDENTIAL WOULD BE
EXEMPT FROM TEACHING IN OUR
CHARTER SCHOOLS SO I THINK WE
HAVE TO WE HAVE TO LOOK AT YOU
KNOW WHAT MAKES SENSE IN TERMS
OF IF TRYING TO DIVERSIFY THAT
EDUCATION.
BUT STILL PROVIDES EXPERTISE.
IN MENTOR MAYOR.
ON THAT ON THAT TOPIC IN IN. TO
TO TO BE CLEAR THIS IS A POINT
OF CONTINUED CONVERSATION BUT
I'M A FIRM BELIEVER THAT EVERY
TEACHER SHOULD HAVE A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL.
EVERY CHILD SHOULD HAVE THE
ADVANTAGE OF HAVING A TRAINED
TEACHER WHO HAS GONE THROUGH --
AND I DID AND IT THAT YOU'VE
GONE THROUGH THE TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAM THAT'S
FUNDAMENTAL TO MY BELIEFS -- IN
THE BACKGROUND CHECKS I THINK
EVEN THERE I THINK WE DON'T
AGREE ON WHAT A FULL BACKGROUND
CHECK IS I THINK THEY SHOULD GO
THROUGH THE FBI CHECK. FOR
INSTANCE THEY COME FROM ANOTHER
STATE MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING
GOING ON THERE SO WE WE NEED WE
DO NEED TO FIX THIS.
AND JUST BECAUSE YOUR COLLEGE
PROFESSOR THAT THAT MIGHT MEAN
YOU KNOW A LOT ABOUT HISTORY BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN.
YOU KNOW HOW TO TEACH HISTORY
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE WALK
INTO A MIDDLE SCHOOL CLASSROOM.
AS A LONGTIME MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER AND I'VE SEEN THEM FAIL
MISERABLY THEY HAD A YOU KNOW A
LOT OF ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
BUT NOT NECESSARILY AN ABILITY
TO WORK WITH KILL THERE'S A
SPECIAL PLACE IN HEAVEN FOR
MIDDLE SCHOOL TEACHERS ON AUG
I'LL GIVE YOU THAT I DO NOT LIKE
TO SPEAK TO EIGHTH GRADERS.
IT AGAIN NON CORE CAN ALSO MEAN
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
SO WE WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT IN
PARTICULAR.
OUR SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS
THE SICK CALIFORNIA HAVE THE
ADVANTAGE OF ANY TRAINING SCHOOL
TEACHER IN THAT ROOM SO I SOME
ASSUME WANTED ADVANTAGES TO THE
CHARTER SCHOOL HAS OVER
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL.
IS BECAUSE OF THE WIND FOLLOW
ELIMINATION PROVISION FOR SO
SOURCES CARRY WERE HAVING A HARD
TIME RECRUITING STAND TEACHERS
AND AND PEOPLE THOSE VARIOUS
BACKGROUNDS WE'VE ALREADY HAD A
SUCCESSFUL CAREER.
BECAUSE THE SO SECURITY SYSTEM
DINGS THEM FOR THAT SO IT'S
PROBABLY EASIER FOR YOU GUYS TO
RECRUIT THOSE THAT KIND OF
TALENT TO YOUR SCHOOL'S CORRECT --
IT YET UNDER EXISTING
FLEXIBILITY RIGHT UNDER OKAY.
IN MY FINAL THING AND AND THE
SURPLUS ALREADY TOUCHED ON IN
TERMS OF THEIR SORRY I MEAN
CURRY THIS TENSION BECAUSE
EVERYBODY WANTS THE MONEY AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT IT SEEMS TO
ME IS GONNA BE EXASPERATED.
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE HAD A HISTORIC
ECONOMIC GROWTH THE GOVERNOR
ARNOLD GOVERNESSES SAY IS NOT
GOING TO LAST FOREVER DESPITE
NOT.
AND THEN EVERYBODY HERE THE DICE
KNOWS WE HAVE A PENSION BOMB.
THAT'S ABOUT TO THE TO GO OFF SO
IT SEEMS TO ME IS I'M READING IT
THIS IS PRETTY SUBJECTIVE AND I
HAVE CONCERNS THAT.
EARLY NO CHARTER SCHOOL.
WOULD -- B. B. AUTHORIZE BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO CONCERNED I KNOW L.
A. U. S. T. AND I'M I PRAISE AND
OUT LIAR THEY JUST SIGNED A
CONTRACTOR LATER THISYEAR WITH
THEIR TEACHERS THAT WE ALL KNOW
THAT THEY CAN'T TO FILL.
IN SO THEY'RE GONNA BE COMING I
GUESS TO HEAR WHEN IT WANTING A
BAIL OUT BUT I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW WHAT YOUR VIEWS WERE IN
TERMS OF THE THE FINANCIAL
VIABILITY ASPECT OF THE
LEGISLATION.
WELL -- I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS IS AGAIN A WORK IN PROGRESS --
AND APPLAUD THE THE THE THE
GROUND IS ALREADY BEEN LAID TO
GET US TO THIS POINT.
BUT TERE'S REALLY TWO TYPES OF
DISTRICT DISCRETION FOR THE
PURPOSES OF FISCAL IMPACT
CONSIDERATION IN THE BILL
IMPRINT.
THERE IS THE TREATMENT FOR
DISTRICTS THAT ARE IN NEGATIVE
CERTIFICATION AND STATE
RECEIVERSHIP.
AND ALSO A BROADER UNIVERSE OF
DISTRICTS THAT ARE.
QUALIFIED BUT WHERE THE OUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT IN CONSULTATION
WITH THICK MAT HAS DETERMINED
THAT THIS ONE CHARTER SCHOOL
COULD PUT THAT DISTRICT OVER
INTO NEGATIVE CERTIFICATION.
AND FOR THOSE DISTRICTS THEY CAN
HAVE WHAT'S CALLED A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION OF DENIAL WHICH IS A
BROADER.
DISCRETION THAN ALL OTHER
DISTRICTS WOULD ENJOY.
BUT OF COURSE THE PETITIONER
COULD STILL READ BY THAT WE ARE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH PART OF THAT
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO DISCUSS
THAT.
THE SECOND TIER OF DISTRICTS
THAT WILL HAVE ANOTHER STANDARD
OF DISCRETION IS THIS MULTI
FACTORIAL LISTS THAT YOU SEE
BEFORE YOU.
AND THE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TODAY
IS THAT AGAIN THE DISTRICTS CAN
SIMPLY DENY A CHARTER SCHOOL
BASED ON AN EXISTING PROGRAM
THAT THE DISTRICT IS RUNNING.
AS LONG AS IT'S IN REASONABLE
PROXIMITY TO WHERE THE CHARTER
IS LOCATED AND SAY WE ALREADY
HAVE A PROGRAM LIKE THAT WE'RE
GONNA DENY IT.
AND WE HAVE ISSUES WITH THAT
BECAUSE THE PROGRAM MIGHT NOT BE
SERVING KIDS TO EXCELLENCE THE
OTHER PIECE THAT WE HAVE ISSUES
WITH IS THAT.
LANGUAGE NOW SAYS THAT FISCAL
IMPACT CAN ALSO BE CONSIDERED IN
THE CONTEXT OF DISTRICTS THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY CHARACTERISTICS
AROUND FISCAL DISTRESS.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS WELL
WE SHOULD AT LEAST HAVE TO
BALANCE OUT THAT FACTOR WITH
ACADEMIC NEED BEFORE GOING TO
EMPHASIZE FISCAL IMPACT IN THE
CONTEXT OF DISTRICTS THAT DON'T
HAVE FISCAL DISTRESS.
THEN WE SHOULD EMPHASIZE THE
FACT THAT THOSE SAME DISTRICTS
ARE IN ACADEMIC DISTRESS AND
WHERE THEY ARE.
I THINK THE CHARTER SCHOOL WE
BELIEVE THE CHARTER SCHOOL
PETITIONER SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MAKE THE CASE THAT.
THAT VAL YOU IN AND OF ITSELF
COULD POTENTIALLY OUT WAY THE
OTHER FACTORS AND ACTUALLY MIGHT
HAVE A STRONGER CASE UPON REVIEW
BY THE COUNTY -- SO SO FOR US
THE THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT WE
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH.
GREAT I GOT ONE FINAL QUESTION
BEFORE I DO THAT I DO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A CONTENTIOUS
ISSUE AND I THINK I THINK THERE
ARE SOME THINGS YOU NEED TO BE
TOO WEAK TO TO MAKE IT BETTER SO
I I APPLAUD YOU FOR ALL YOUR
EFFORTS.
SO -- WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS ACTUALLY
HAVE MORE ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE
PEOPLE OPT IN.
AND THEY CAN OPT OUT SO LIKE
CENTER CLOSE TO MATCHING THE THE
BAD APPLES IF YOU'RE IN A
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL.
AS BAD YOU'RE STUCK OR WHEN
YOU'RE SCHOOL.
PARENTS CAN OPT AMOUNTS SO I
THINK YOU PROBABLY HAVE MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN MANYRESPECTS
BECAUSE THE MARKET PLACE.
I'LL HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE SO
JUST ANY.
WRAPAROUND THOUGHTS ON THAT AND
THEN I WELL DONE AND I'LL BE
I'LL BE BRIEF -- MADAM CHAIR SO
THAT -- THEY THEY COUNSELING --
OUT -- ABOUT GUARD RAILS THAT
THE THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
PLACING HIS TRAILER BILL THIS
YEAR.
THE BAN ON FOR PROFIT CHARTERS
THAT -- WE SUPPORTED THE
STRENGTHENING OF STUDENT
ADMISSIONS INTO PROCESS RIGHTS
IN CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT MR BONTA
OFF AUTHORED THAT WE ULTIMATELY
SUPPORTED -- AT ALONG WITH THE
FACT THAT YES WE FACE A FIVE
YEAR RENEWAL PERIOD -- AT THE
END OF WHICH WE COULD
POTENTIALLY BE CLOSER FOR NOT
PERFORMING.
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT THERE ARE A
WHOLE LOT OF WRITTEN WAYS IN
WHICH YOU CAN HOLD CHARTER
SCHOOLS ACCOUNTABLE.
TODAY AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AROUND THE SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY FRAMEWORK THAT
THE STATE HAS ADOPTED BEING USED
IN TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
FOR CONTINUED IMPROVEMENT -- BUT
IN THE HIGH STAKES ENVIRONMENT
OF RENEWAL AND POTENTIAL SCHOOL
CLOSURE FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT'S THOSE ARE AREAS WHERE
PARITY.
YEAH IT CERTAINLY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN PURSUE AND TERMS OF
THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK BUT
IT'S A PROBABLY AT SOMETHING WE
CAN GET PERFECTLY BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO MAKE.
IT A COMEDY FOR THOSE HIGH
STAKES RENEWALS THE CHARTERS
HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR WILK.
CENTER DRAWS THEM.
YES I I TO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS IN.
THE CHARTER SCHOOL LEADERSHIP --
FOR PUTTING ALL THE ENERGY AND
TIME INTO INTO THIS -- YOUR
BREAKING GROUND BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S BREAKING
GROUND TO CATCH UP. TO CATCH UP
ON ALL THE ISSUES THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN DEALT WITH FOR DECADES NOW --
KINDA REMINDS ME OF A IN
JUDICIARY WERE TRYING TO TACKLE
THE ISSUES OF PRIVACY.
IN YOU KNOW TECHNOLOGY WHEN IT'S
ALREADY OUT THERE.
IT'S ALREADY WAY AHEAD OF US AND
WE'RE TRYING TO PULL IN AND
CREATE SOME RULES WHEN PEOPLE
ARE USED TO DOING THINGS.
THEIR WAY -- AND I THINK THERE'S
WE'VE GOT A CONTINUE TO CHANGE
THE CULTURE SO THAT WE ALL LEARN
AND REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
ONE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. ONE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM AND RIGHT
NOW WE ARE BEHAVING.
LIKE TO SCHOOL SYSTEMS.
AND THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR OUR KIDS
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE FISH AND
SEA OF OUR TAX DOLLARS.
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR HAVING
STANDARD THAT EVERYBODY COMPLIES
WITH THAT EVERYBODY BELIEVES IN.
THE STANDARDS ALL OVER THE LOT
SO -- I APPLAUD YOU FOR DIGGING
IN AND AND TAKING UP.
THESE ISSUES -- YOU KNOW ON
WHETHER IT'S FINANCIAL IMPACT OR
WITH THERE'S PROGRAMS IS --
THESE ARE ALL SPECIFIC -- I DO
THINK THAT THE FINANCIAL IMPACT
AND PROGRAM.
IMPACT ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECES OF THIS.
THEIR NUMBER OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND MY DISTRICT -- THAT I THINK
ARE GOOD AND THEY'RE DOING WELL
AND THEY PRESENT SOMETHING
DIFFERENT TO OUR COMMUNITY -- I
KNOW THE FOUNDERS OF CAMINO
LEVEL AND AND A SEMI US I MEAN
THESE ARE.
THIS IS A GOOD MIX BUT WITHOUT
HAVING.
A CUP A BELIEF IN THE SAME
STANDARDS.
THEN IT'S ALL BUT YOU KNOW
LOPSIDED IT'S ALL CONFUSING AND
YOU'RE RIGHT ON CENTER GLAZER.
PARENTS JUST WANT ONE THING OUT
ONE OUR KIDS TO HAVE A GOOD
PUBLIC EDUCATION I'M NOT SURE BY
NOT REQUIRING CERTIFICATION.
THAT THAT'S GOING TO GET OUR
PARENTS THE BEST PUBLIC
EDUCATION FOR THE FOR THEIR KIDS
SO -- THERE'S SO MANY OTHER
ISSUES I KNOW THAT A WILL BE --
GRAPPLING WITH -- ON THE COLE
LOCATIONS UP BUT YOU KNOW IN THE
END I JUST WANT TO LEAVE YOU
WITH WITH THAT THOUGHT THAT WE
HAVE TO BE COMMITTED TO ONE
SINGLE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM.
PARENTS AND STUDENTS FROM ONE
SCHOOL SHOULD NOT BE PITTED
AGAINST PARENTS AND STUDENTS OF
ANOTHER SCHOOL THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE SHOULD BE SPENDING OUR OUR
TIME.
DOING -- AND I AGREE THERE ARE
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
I'M NOT LIVING UP TO OUR
EXPECTATIONS SO LET'S GRAPPLE
WITH THAT AND LET'S GRAPPLE WITH
IT AS ONE SYSTEM.
OUGHT NOT TO SYSTEMS THAT ARE --
THAT ARE COMPETING FOR EACH
OTHER SO JUST WAS -- THOUGHTS
ALL ALL BE -- SUPPORTING --
HOWEVER I DO THINK THERE'S THOSE
KINDS OF CULTURAL CHANGES THAT.
NEED TO BE DEALT WITH IN A MUCH
MORE HEAD ON WAY SO THANK YOU
ALL.
THANK YOU SENATOR DORADO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE -- YEAH I'LL BE BRIEF
HERE I THERE ARE OUTSTANDING
ISSUES SAID AS WE DISCUSSED HERE
TODAY AMONG THEM ARE THE THE
COUNTY APPEAL PROCESS.
ACADEMIC ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
FOR CHARTERS TEACHER CREDENTIALS
THAT'S A BIG ONE TO ME YEAH I
HAVE TO HAVE A CREDENTIALED
TEACHER IN A CLASSROOM -- THE
COUNTY CHARTER WIDE PETITION
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL -- BUT LET
ME JUST JUST JUST BACK UP HERE
MAN.
IF YOU SEND YOUR CHILD TO A
CHARTER SCHOOL AND IT WORKS
THROUGH FAMILY CONTINUE DOING
THAT.
THE EFFORT HERE TODAY IS NOT TO
CLOSE ANY CHARTER SCHOOL THE
EFFORT HERE TODAY IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
GOOD ONE STAY OPEN AND ONES THAT
ARE NOT SUCCEEDING CLOSE.
THAT IS THE SIMPLE EFFORT HERE
TODAY WITH THAT I JUST ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE MANAGER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA JOHN CLOSE.
REALLY BRIEFLY I WANNA JUST GO
BACK AND AND AND TWO IS THE
OPENING REMARKS OF OF MISTER
MARK HAS WHO -- HAD A WONDERFUL
EXPRESSION OF THE PROGRESS
THAT'S MADE UP TO THIS POINT AND
THE FORWARD LOOKING.
IDENTIFIED THE POSSIBILITY OF
MORE I I AGREE ENTIRELY THIS IS
AN ONGOING DISCUSSION I THINK OF
THAT.
THE DOLLAR HAS HAS BEEN
PRODUCTIVE SO FAR LOOK FOR FOR
MARKED MORE PRODUCTIVE SESSIONS
HAD RESPECTFULLY ASK DR THANK
YOU THANK YOU SINGLE MEMBER DO
WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE MOTION BY SENATOR DORADO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ITEM ONE A. B. FIFTEEN OH
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK NO WILK NO CHAIN
TO WRESTLE.
WITH US SO I GLAZER GLAZER NO
MCGUIRE HAN.
WILL BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL I DO
KNOWTHAT YOU'RE PRESENTING FOR
MISTER JONES SAWYER BUT WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH NEXT ACTUALLY HE HAS HIS
PRESENT TODAY AND IS.
PRESENTING FOR HIMSELF FABULOUS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH
.
LET'S WAIT FOR THE ROOM TO QUIET
DOWN A LITTLE BIT AND THEN --
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE BEGIN.
RIGHT GOOD MORNING NOT MINE IS
THE QUOTE UNQUOTE EASY ONE SO
LET'S SEE HOW THIS GOES.
BUT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES.
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION ON THIS MEASURE.
WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW
FOR THE AUTHORIZATION OF MORE
THAN ONE RESOURCE CENTER IN
DISTRICT PROVIDED THE LOCAL
AUTHORIZING SCHOOL DISTRICT
APPROVES THE EXTRA RESOURCE
CENTER IN WRITING.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE A ROADMAP
FOR ADA AND OTHER FUNDING
STABILITY FOR THOSE CHARTERS
WILL NEED TO SEEK A NEW CHARTER
APPROVAL UPON RE AUTHORIZATION.
AS WELL AS CONCERNS REMAINING
WITH CHARTERS OPERATING ON
TRIBAL LANDS.
AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN CONTINUES
THE GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATORS
WORK IN INCREASING CHARTER
SCHOOL TRANSPARENCY AND ADDING
CLARITY TO THE LONGSTANDING
CHARTER SCHOOLS ACT.
THIS BILL INCREASES LOCAL
CONTROL BY ELIMINATING LOOPHOLES
IN CURRENT LAW WHICH ALLOW
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO OPERATE
OUTSIDE OF THEIR AUTHORIZING
DISTRICT.
THIS BILL SPEAKS TO PROPOSAL H.
OF THE RECENT CHARTER SCHOOL
POLICY TASK FORCE SUPPORTED BY
THE MAJORITY OF THE TASK FORCE.
THE TASK FORCE REPORT NOTES
QUOTE SUCH A PROHIBITION WOULD
LIMIT THE POTENTIAL FOR THE
DETRIMENTAL PRACTICE OF USING
OVERSIGHT FEES AS A REVENUE
STREAM AND QUOTE.
THIS BILL RESTORES THE RIGHT OF
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE SCHOOLS
LOCATED WITHIN THEIR GEOGRAPHIC
BOUNDARIES AND CLARIFIES THE
JURISDICTIONAL SOVEREIGNTY OF
DULY ELECTED SCHOOL BOARDS AND
THEIR ROLE IN PUBLIC OVERSIGHT.
AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN SEEKS TO
ADDRESS CONSISTENT AN ON GOING
CHALLENGES THAT LEAVE IMPACTED
DISTRICTS WITH NO RECOURSE OTHER
THAN COSTLY LITIGATION.
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES ARE
TASKED WITH ENSURING STUDENT
SUCCESS.
BUT THAT SUCCESS IS BUILT OFF
TRUST FROM THE COMMUNITY WITHIN
THE AGENCY AND THE COMMUNITY
THAT IS IMPACTED BY ITS WORK.
TRUST IS BUILT OFF MEASURES OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
WHICH IS NOT PRACTICABLE IF
ANOTHER SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
AUTHORITY OVER THE SCHOOL.
IN YOUR OWN BACKYARD.
THIS WAS THE CASE DURING MY
TENURE ON THE NEW HOMES SCHOOL
BOARD.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE TOOLS NORTH
ALREADY TO EXERCISE OVERSIGHT O
A SCHOOL THAT WAS AUTHORIZED BY
ANOTHER SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BUT PHYSICALLY LOCATED IN OUR
SCHOOL BOUNDARIES.
WE COULD NOT DO ARE DULY ELECTED
JOB TO LOOK OUT FOR AN ADVOCATE
ON BEHALF OF STUDENTS IN THE
SCHOOL.
NOR COULD WE ADVOCATE FOR ANY
MITIGATING FACTORS TO DRINK
DECREASE THE IMPACT ON NOT
SCHOOLS NEIGHBORS.
AS A RECENT CAL MATTERS ARTICLE
INDICATES THE CHARTER IN MY
DISTRICTS CASE CLOSED IN A FEW
SHORT YEARS DUE TO WOEFULLY
MISMANAGED FINANCES THROUGH
THEIR CMO.
AS HAD BEEN PREDICTED BY THE
MULTIPLE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES WHO WOULD CAREFULLY
VETTED AND DENIED THEIR ORIGINAL
PETITION.
THE AUTHORIZED OR IN THIS CASE
WAS A SMALL RURAL DISTRICT IN
FINANCIAL DISTRESS DUE TO
DECLINING ENROLLMENT.
THIS IS OCCURRING IN DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AS NOTED NOTED IN THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS TASK FORCE REPORT IN THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
YEAR. ONE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
SCHOOLS USED THE EXISTING
EXCEPTION OR LOOPHOLE IF YOU
WILL. TO OPERATE AT LEAST FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE LOCATIONS
OUTSIDE OF THEIR AUTHORIZES
BOUNDARIES.
THE LOOPHOLE IN CHARTER SCHOOLS
ACT THAT'S A PAPER FIRST SET OF
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES FOR
STRUGGLING ELLIE ETS IN A MANNER
INCONSISTENT NOT ONLY WITH THE
INTENT OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ACT.
BUT WITH OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ADEQUATELY FUND ALL DISTRICTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN DECLINING
ENROLLMENT.
THE COSTS OF OPERATION DO NOT
DIMINISH IN DIRECT PROPORTION TO
ADA ALLOCATIONS.
AB FIFTY NO SEVEN ULTIMATELY IS
ABOUT HONORING LOCAL CONTROL
ANISHA INSURING THAT DISTRICTS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
LEGISLATIVELY EMPOWERED TO BEST
USE TAXPAYER DOLLARS FOR OUR
STATE STUDENTS.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY ARE GAIL --
BELLINO MOJICA SUPERINTENDENT OF
CLASS OR UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND MARK WINGER MY FOR FORMER
SUPERINTENDENT AND THE FOREMAN
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE NEW HALL
SCHOOL BOARD.
THANK YOU SIMPLY WOMAN I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY I KNOW YOU YOU
HIT ON TWO OF THE THREE TOPICS I
HAD THAT YOU WERE GOING TO STILL
WORK ON ONE OF THEM ALSO WAS.
EXPLORING THE CREATION OF A
TRANSITION PROCESS UP FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS CURRENTLY NOT
LOCATED WITHIN THEIR AUTHORIZING
SCHOOL DISTRICT BOUNDARIES
CONSUME CAN SUBMIT THE RENEWAL
PATRICIA PETITION.
DIRECTLY TO THE DISTRICT IN
WHICH THEY'RE LOCATED.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO WORK ON CORRECT IN
ADDITION TO MAKING SURE THAT
THAT FUNDING STAYS STABLE FOR
THEM IN THAT PROCESS PERFECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TWO MINUTES EACH ALL YOU
DECIDE WHO GOES FIRST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORNING SENATOR LEVIN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM MARK WINGER FORMER
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE WHOLE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN.
TWO THOUSAND TEN NEW HALL
REJECTED A PETITION FROM THE
ALBERT EINSTEIN ACADEMY DUE TO
FINDINGS ABOUT THEIR FISCAL
ASSUMPTIONS AND THEIR INABILITY
TO TEACH OUR ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS.
OUR THEIR PETITION WAS ALSO
REJECTED BY OUR NEIGHBORING
DISTRICTS SAUGUS AND ALSO ON
APPEAL FROM LA COUNTY AND BY
FOUR OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INVENTOR AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN ACT IN
AGUA DULCE SCHOOL DISTRICT
FIFTEEN HUNDREDS STUDENT
DISTRICT TWENTY MILES IN TWO
DISTRICTS AWAY FROM US.
WAS NEGATIVELY CERTIFIED BY THE
COUNTY.
THEY DECIDED TO APPROVED CHARTER
SERVING UP TO THIRTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS TO RAISE ONE POINT
MILLION DOLLARS I HAVE THEIR
BOARD PRESENTATION ON THAT RIGHT
RIGHT HERE.
OF THE DAY THEY APPROVE THAT
[inaudible]
OF THAT.
REMEDY TO THEIR FISCAL PROBLEMS
THE EINSTEIN ACADEMY WAS
ULTIMATELY APPROVED BY ACT NOT
WITH ALL SAY.
THEIR PETITION TALKED ABOUT
SERVING STUDENTS OF ACT NOT WITH
ALL SAY.
ABOUT THEIR STUDENT POPULATION
REFLECTING THE STUDENT
POPULATION OF ACT IN AGUA DULCE.
BUT THEN THEY DECLARED THERE WAS
NO SPACE AND SO THEY HAD TO
OPERATE OUTSIDE IN SANTA CLARITA.
THEY FAILED TO FIND SPACE IN
SANTA CLARITA IN THEIR FIRST
YEAR.
AND THEY HURRIEDLY OPENED THEIR
OPERATION.
IN THEIR FIRST YEAR.
IN SCHOOL AN EMPTY SCHOOL IN.
ACTON I WOULD ALSO SAY.
UP ONE YEAR LATER THEY OPENED A
NEW POLICY INTENDED TO DO ALL
ALONG TO SEARCH STUDENTS NOT A
FACT AND I WOULD ALSO A BIT OF
THE FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
SAND CREEK.
WE HAD ONE PETITION IN TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS OF THIS LAW ONE
PETITIONS WE DENIED IT ON VERY
GOOD GROUNDS AND YET THAT SCHOOL
OPERATED IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT --
MISS SMITH MENTIONED SOME OF
THIS.
INFORMATION AFTER A COUPLE YEARS
THEY HAD A FIX MATT
EXTRAORDINARY AUDIT FOUND ALL
KINDS OF FISCAL MISMANAGEMENT.
AND WHILE OUR NON DUPLICATE
ACCOUNT WAS 45% NEW HALL THERE'S
WAS NEVER HIGHER THAN 5%.
SO THE WORD REFLECTING THE
STUDENT POPULATION EITHER.
WE WERE POWERLESS TO INTERVENE.
AND ACTING ON WOULD ALL SAY.
DID LITTLE DUE TO THEIR
CONFLICTED INTEREST ABOUT
WANTING THE SCHOOL TO REMAIN
OPEN AS A REVENUE SOURCE
[inaudible]
AND EVENTUALLY.
DUE TO FISCAL MISMANAGEMENT OF
THE CMO.
THE SCHOOL FAILED IN CLOSED.
THIS IS HAPPENED ACROSS THE
STATE.
WITH A COMMON THEME SMALL
FISCALLY DISTRESSED.
DISTRICTS EXPLOIT A LOOPHOLE IN
MOBILE CURRENT LAW.
AB FIFTY NO SEVEN IS NOT ABOUT
LIMITING PARENT CHOICE OR
CLOSING CHARTER SCHOOLS A
REASONABLY GRANDFATHER'S
EXISTING CHARTERS.
IT IS ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL AND IT
IS ABOUT ETHICAL BEHAVIOR.
ELECTED BOARDS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY -- TO DOESN'T
MAKE THE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
WITHIN THEIR GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRICTS.
CURRENT LAW HAS A LOOPHOLE THAT
ALLOWS DISTRICTS SOME IN IT FOR
THE MONEY YOU'VE USED UP ALL OF
YOUR TIME IN OHIO ALL OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES TIME.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY THAT'S OKAY
I WAIT THE SOVEREIGNTY OF OTHER
BOARDS THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS GAIL GARBARINO MO HE
GONNA PLASTER COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS SCHOOLS IN
PLASTER COUNTY THE LOOPHOLE FOR
PROVIDING EXCEPTIONS TO THE
GEOGRAPHIC LIMITATIONS OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAS BEEN
EXPLOITED.
THIS EXCEPTION IN THE CHARTER
SCHOOL LAW PROMOTES BAD
GOVERNANCE AND IT DOES NOT MEET
THE IDEALS OF GOOD GOVERNMENTS
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT.
I HAVE SEVEN CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT ARE OPERATING OUTSIDE OF
THEIR DISTRICT BOUNDARIES AND
CAL AND PLASTER COUNTY.
WITH THESE CHARTERS I HAVE SEEN
INGRESS AND EGRESS ISSUES WITH
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS
BEING DROPPED OFF AND PICKED UP
EVERY DAY BECAUSE OF WHAT
RESULTED IN A DALY MASK BACK
MASSIVE BACK UP.
ON A FEW OF THE LARGER STREETS
AND ROOSEVELT.
I HAVE HAD RESIDENTS COMPLAIN TO
ME TO THE LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS
AND TO THE CITY COUNCIL AND THEN
UNDERSTAND HOW A PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL LOCATED IN ROSEVILLE WAS
NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE BY THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ELECTED TO
SERVE THE RESIDENTS OF ROOSEVELT.
BUT BY A SCHOOL BOARD MILES AWAY.
I OF SYMPATHIZE WITH THE
RESIDENTS WHEN THEY COMPLAIN
ABOUT HOW WAS SCHOOL BOARD
ELECTED TO SERVE A COMMUNITY
MILES AWAY IS SUPPOSED TO
COMPARE ABOUT TRAFFIC PROBLEMS
IN ANOTHER CITY THE ANSWER IS
THEY DON'T.
I HAVE SEEN CHARTER SCHOOLS
SOLICITING SMALLER DISTRICTS TO
AUTHORIZE THEIR PETITIONS AND
THEN IMMEDIATELY LOCATE THEIR
CHARTER SCHOOL OUTSIDE OF THE
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES.
I HAVE SEEN TINY TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS
AUTHORIZED EIGHT CHARTER SCHOOLS
FIVE OF WHICH ARE LOCATED
OUTSIDE THE DISTRICT. THREE OF
THE FIVE LOCATED AROUND LAKE
TAHOE WHICH IS APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTY FIVE MILES AWAY IN NINETY
MINUTES BY CAR.
I HAVE OFTEN EXPRESSED MY
CONCERNS ON CHARTER SCHOOLS
LOCATING OUTSIDE OF THEIR
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES BECAUSE YOU
MONITOR WHAT YOU SEE AND THE
SHEER DISTANCE OF TO THAT IS A
BARRIER. FOR OVERSIGHT AS THE
SAYING GOES OUT OF SIGHT OUT OF
MIND.
AB FIFTY NINE Q..
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA ANA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
WHICH IS TO CLING ON BEHALF OF
THE A CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE SAN YSIDRO SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE SANTA BARBARA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BOTH IN
SUPPORT.
SELENA PARK CALIFORNIA STATE IN
DOUBLE ACP IN SUPPORT.
DILLER STRAND FLORES WITH
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL MPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KATHY MCBRIDE REPRESENTING
ACCENTS SUPPORT.
CHRIS AND BROWN CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DR BRUTALITY WITH NEWPORT MESA
FEDERATION TEACHERS REPRESENTING
ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FORTY
EDUCATORS AND COSTA MESA NEWPORT
BEACH.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
JOHN RENDON REPRESENTING YOU SEE
F. T. WHICH HAS THREE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
LIZABETH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH US YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CARLOS MACHADO WITH A CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
BILL SIMMONS A SIXTH GRADE
ENGLISH HISTORY TEACHER IN SAN
JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
PRESIDENT OF THEIR TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT.
KOBE PRESIDING -- WASHINGTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD VICE
PRESIDENT HERE IN SUPPORT ALSO --
SUPER OUR TRUSTY CIRCLE BEGINS
ALSO CALLS.
SIR KIRBY GONZALEZ ALSO ASKED ME
TO REGISTER HER SUPPORT.
MELANIE I CANNOT ON BEHALF OF
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
STEVE HENDERSON REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS IN
SUPPORT.
ALICE MERCER TEACHER IN
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SCTA MEMBER STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT.
ROSALIE NICHES SEGMENTS OF THE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR CHILD
DEVELOPMENT.
IN SUPPORT.
MATTHEW KOGAN TWENTY YEAR PUBLIC
PUBLIC EDUCATION TEACHER --
UNITED TEACHERS LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT.
THE KEY VALLEY'S SACK CITY
UNIFIED TEACHER IN SUPPORT.
COLLEEN BURNISH MET FORTY FOUR
YEAR EDUCATOR -- AND AG CAN
AVAIL UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
STRUGGLING SUPPORT. TO FOR MY
STUDENTS THANK YOU.
TIFFANY DURO PRESIDENT SAN
LORENZO VALLEY TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND STATE COUNCIL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
AND TWENTY NINE YEAR HIGH SCHOOL
ENGLISH TEACHER STRONGLY SUPPORT.
ERICA JONES CAN A GARDEN TEACHER
MEMBER OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL
TASK FORCE STRONG SUPPORT.
SERGIO MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION BOARD OF
DIRECTOR THIRTY SEVEN YEAR
VETERAN.
ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
MARGIE GRANADA KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER MONEY BILL UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT CITY BOARD OF
DIRECTORS STRONG SUPPORT.
GRETA RODRIGUEZ EIGHTEEN YOUR E.
L. D. TEACHER STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE TAYLOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER SANTA UNIFIED
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THE COLD WAR -- TWENTY YEARS
HERE IN SOUTH ACT SEXY UNIFIED --
STRONG SUPPORT.
DILLON AT THE MY OWN YOU TELL A
FIRST GRADE TEACHER STRONGLY
SUPPORT. TO BE SET SO LEASE
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER
UTILITY STRONGLY SUPPORT.
LORI JONES TWENTY YEARS WITH THE
GOLD ON ENTRY SCHOOL DISTRICT
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
ESTHER CAM FROM THE SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY WITH NEW HALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT ALSO A SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER.
HILLARY HALL TWENTY THREE YEAR
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER STRONGLY
SUPPORT HOME OF THE RECENTLY
RELOCATED EINSTEIN STUDENTS.
ROBIN GETS A CLASSROOM TEACHER
PRESIDENT OF THE IN THE WAY
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ALL
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
JAMIE ALSO WHEN FROM THE HEART
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY.
REPRESENTING ELEVEN HUNDRED
SCHOOL TEACHERS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
ROBERT PETERS TWENTY FIVE YEAR
HIGH SCHOOL SOCIAL SCIENCE
TEACHER STRONGLY SUPPORT.
LESLIE LIMóN HIGH SCHOOL SOCIAL
STUDIES HEART SCHOOL DISTRICT
SANTA CLARITA VALLEY STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
SUSAN SCHOLAR TWENTY SIX YEAR
EDUCATOR PRESIDENT OF CHULA
VISTA EDUCATORS WE RISE IN
SUPPORT.
JULIE WALKER NATIONAL BOARD
CERTIFIED TEACHER REPRESENTING
SWEETWATER EDUCATION ASSOCIATION
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MY WALKER HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATOR
FROM HAYWARD CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY SUPPORT.
EVEN MY SM MEDINA COUNTY
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION --
PRESIDENT OF MY LOCAL AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
LINDA TITLE FORMER MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT.
DIANNE NEED THIRTY YEAR TEACHER
IN SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
DENISE BRADFORD PRESIDENT OF
THOUGHT ABOUT VALLEY EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY SUPPORT.
DAVE GOLDBERG CITY A VICE
PRESIDENT -- BILINGUAL EDUCATOR
FROM BOYLE HEIGHTS STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
CHRIS BOUCHER CHEMISTRY TEACHER
BEVERLY HILLS HIGH SCHOOL
BEVERLY HILLS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I STRONGLY SUPPORT A.
B..
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN EVEN TO MY OWN
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER LOS
AGELES UNITED TEACHERS LOS
ANGELES [inaudible]
AND SUPPORT -- THE REMEDY IS
SOCIAL SCIENCE TEACHER
SWEETWATER UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT FULL SUPPORT.
GEORGE OF FLOWERS LEE EIGHTEEN
YEAR SECOND CAREER SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
I BOUGHT A DATA PRESIDENT
CONTINUE GIVEN A SUFFICIENT
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
ANGELA NORMAN MIDDLE SCHOOL
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER BRENT
WHAT UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT
STRONG SUPPORT.
BRENDA WALKER ASSOCIATED CHINO
TEACHERS PRESIDENT AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
DON DAWSON SAN DIEGO CITY AND
COUNTY STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THE MONICA ROBINSON OPEN UNIFIED
CHILD DEVELOPMENT STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
MANY SOVIET GAS PRODUCT OF
PUBLIC SCHOOLS MOTHER OF THE
CHILD THAT WENT TO PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND A CREDENTIALED OPEN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TWENTY
TWO YEAR VETERAN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CHAS GARCIA A TWENTY FOUR YEAR
VET IN OAKLAND PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LARA RICE HALL OPEN UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER AND I STRONGLY SPOKE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WE AT THE SATELLITE IS FIRST
GRADE BILINGUAL TEACHER AND THE
OAKLAND -- AND I A SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
PETER ROBINSON THIRD GRADE
TEACHER FROM OAKLAND AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ALSO VETERAN TEACHER.
KATHY PEERS FROM SAM DINO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BARBARA OLSON MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER INVESTIGATOR BORN YET
AND A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MONICA HARVEY LANGUAGE SPEECH
AND HEARING SPECIALIST WITH
FACTS CITY UNIFIED.
AND SCTA SPECIAL ED DIRECTOR
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MULLIN SKI SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST IMPERATIVE TO
STUDENTS IN THE SACRAMENTS AND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
ERIN DARKE TEACHER ALICE BERNIE
WALDORF IN SACRAMENTO CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
SUPPORT.
JANIE MARKS PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHERS SEXY THE UNIFIED --
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO CENTER TEACHER A
SEX CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JERRY IN FRENCH SPANISH AND
ENGLISH TEACHER TRAVIS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MALLORY FOURTH GRADE TEACHER
MILLER CREEK ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT STRONG SUPPORT.
DAVID FISHER PRESIDENT SECOND
CITY TEACHERS ASSOCIATION SECOND
GRADE TEACHER STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO MAYOR SO RUBIO A
NEUROBIOLOGIST AND MOTHER IN
ADVOCATE OR BRING CANCER
SURVIVOR I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MERRY WALTON TEACHER IN
ELK GROVE UNIFIED I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
GEN WERE TELL HIGH SCHOOL
INSTRUMENTS A TEACHER -- BRAYLON
DEFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I SUPPORT.
KATIE BASSLER PRESIDENT SALINAS
VALLEY FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
ENGLISH TEACHER AND I SUPPORT.
JENNINGS STORY THIRTY YEAR MATH
TEACHER SALINAS UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
ON YOUR GOLDEN ABC UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TEACHER STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
LOOK AT YOUR OWN PRESIDENT A
BRANCH OF FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
AND PICK RIVER WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THIS COMPARES XIN ELK GROVE
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
DOUG PETS CASKEY MONEY BILL
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN CITY
A WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
HI NICK COLLINS HIGH SCHOOL
ENGLISH TEACHER AND CHARTER
EDUCATOR STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS SHEILA JODY ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
OF FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME IS
BRIAN LEHRER MY TEACHER WITHIN
SEXY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT OUT
WEST CAMPUS HIGH SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
COME ON DOWN. SEVEN BILLION TO
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CLAUDIA BRIGGS PARENT AND WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS THEIR OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
THERE IS COME ON DOWN.
THANK ANNOUNCED THE SUPPORT TO
TO JUST MOVE OVER TO THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE TABLE MAKE A LITTLE
ROOM THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT TO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH.
WHAT YOU DECIDE WHO GOES FIRST
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY?
IS A SOUND [inaudible]
GREAT -- GOOD MORNING SENATORS
MY NAME IS LAUREN O'NEIL I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND FOUNDER
OF ODYSSEY CHARTER SCHOOL IN
PASADENA I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE HOW
AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN WHAT IMPACT.
A HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL SCHOOL WITH
TWENTY YEARS F OPERATIONS
SERVING STUDENTS PARENTS AND
FACULTY.
ODYSSEY IS A HIGH QUALITY PUBLIC
SCHOOL CHOICE IN OUR COMMUNITY
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH FOR RENEWALS
WERE ONE OF THE TOP ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE.
AND OUR STUDENTS SCORE IN THE
TOP 10% OF ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA ODYSSEY WAS APPROVED
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE BY THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
FROM SOUTH PASADEN UNIFIED AT
THAT TIME THERE WERE NO LAWS
DICTATING WHERE CHARTER SCHOOLS
COULD LOCATE AS I'M SURE YOU'RE
AWARE FINDING FACILITIES AS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES --
CONFRONTING CHARTER SCHOOLS BUT
WE FOUND A SUITABLE FACILITY
JUST A FEW MILES OUTSIDE OF
SOUTH PASADENA UNIFIED AND WE
OPENED OUR DOORS TO TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
EIGHTH GRADE STUDENTS.
FAMILIES AND FACULTIES AND FOR
TWENTY YEARS NOW ODYSSEY HAS
LAWFULLY LOCATED IN THE PASADENA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BUT BECAUSE AB FIFTY NO SEVEN
HAS NO PROTECTIONS FOR SCHOOLS
LIKE OURS ODYSSEY WOULD MOST
LIKELY BE FORCED TO CLOSE
RESULTING IN THE DISPLACEMENT OF
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS TEACHERS.
AND STAFF WITHOUT ANY
CONSIDERATION FOR A LONG TRACK
RECORD AND STUDENT SUCCESS UNDER
AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN AT THE TIME
OF OUR FIFTH RENEWAL OF THE
PASADENA UNIFIED DISTRICT DENIED
OUR REQUEST FOR APPROVAL.
ODYSSEY WOULD BE FORCED TO
RELOCATE OR CLOSE AND WE WOULD
HAVE NO APPEAL OR OTHER RESOURCE
OF THAT DECISION CLOSURE WOULD
LIKELY BE BECAUSE FINDING A
SUITABLE FACILITY IN SOUTH
PASADENA FOR FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS WOULD BE UNLIKELY.
AND EVEN IF WE DID IT MIGHT BE
TOO FAR FOR A FAMILIES TO ATTEND.
AB FIFTY NO SEVEN GOES TOO FAR
BY RISKING THE CLOSURE OF
SCHOOLS LIKE ODYSSEY WITH PROVEN
TRACK RECORDS OF SUCCESS.
THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU VOTE NO ON AB FIFTEEN
OH SEVEN UNLESS IT IS AMENDED TO
ENSURE PERMANENT GRANDFATHERING
PROTECTIONS FOR LIMITED GROUP OF
LONG STANDING HIGH I QUALITY
SCHOOLS LIKE ODYSSEY. TO REMAIN
OPEN AND OUR CURRENT LOCATION
THANK YOU OR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION ON THIS
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS GOOD
MORNING CHAIR LEYVA MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LISA COR I'M A PARTNER
YOUNG MANY IN COR WE'RE LEGAL
COUNSEL TO APPROXIMATELY TWO
THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
I AM ALSO ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF
THE WEST LIKE CHARTER SCHOOL IN
THE THOMAS I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
MY CONCERN ABOUT EIGHTY FIFTEEN
OH SEVENS IMPACT ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS.
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS SERVE OVER. SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS STATES WIDE WHICH
REPRESENTS MORE THAN 10% OF
THEIR TOTAL ENROLLMENT.
MANY OF THEM CHOSE THESE CHARTER
SCHOOLS AFTER STRUGGLING IN A
TRADITIONAL PROGRAM OR FOR
HEALTH REASONS THEY JUST CAN'T
ATTEND.
ONE STUDENTS OFTEN EXPERIENCE
ACADEMIC SUCCESS FOR THE FIRST
TIME THROUGH THE PERSONALIZED
EDUCATION OFFERED BY THESE NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AB FIFTY NO SEVENS PROPOSED
LANGUAGE WOULD REQUIRE STUDENTS
TO TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES ACROSS
COUNTY LINES TO RESEARCH. TO
REACH THE RESOURCE CENTERS THE
RESOURCE CENTERS IS WHERE
LEGALLY REQUIRED SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES AND
ASSESSMENTS ARE PROVIDED
SPECIALIZED ACADEMIC INSTRUCTION
SPEECH THERAPY OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
JUST TO NAME A FEW.
IT IS WRONG TO FORCE THESE
FAMILIES TO DRIVE LONG DISTANCES
TO ACCESS SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES OR ASSESSMENTS WHEN YOU
DEPART DEPRIVE CHILDREN OF THEIR
EDUCATIONAL RIGHTS THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE FELT WIDESPREAD.
IN THE HOME OUR ECONOMY OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM OUR PRISON
SYSTEM FURTHER MORE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE LEGALLY REQUIRED TO
EDUCATE CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES WITH NON DISABLED
PEERS TO THE MAXIMUM EXTENT
APPROPRIATE.
THE RESOURCE CENTER IS WHERE
THAT INTERACTION OCCURS
BENEFITING ALL STUDENTS FINALLY.
THIS BILL IGNORES A LARGE
FINANCIAL IMPLICATIONS FOR
DISTRICTS WHO WILL HAVE TO RE
ABSORBS SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS ONE RESOURCE CENTERS
CLOSE.
IMAGINE THE LITIGATION NON
PUBLIC SCHOOL ANOTHER COST
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE SAVED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BY OFFERING A
NONTRADITIONAL OPTION SCHOOL
DISTRICTS JUST DON'T OFFER TO
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS.
THIS BILL HAS TOO MANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR
CHILDREN CHARTERS AND DISTRICTS
ALIKE.
WHAT I ALWAYS ADVISE MY CLIENTS
IS WHEN IN DOUBT ALWAYS MAKE
CHOICES IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF
CHILDREN AND I URGE YOU TO DO
THE SAME I'D WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
NAME ORGANIZATION AND IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION.
AND THE RACHEL WITH INNOVATIVE
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT
REPRESENTING SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA OVER 12%
ARE SPECIAL ED.
IN OPPOSITION.
JEFF RICE FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR
OF THE A PLUS PERSONALIZED
LEARNING NETWORK ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
PERSONALIZED LEARNING PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN MORE THAN
SEVENTY THOUSAND K. TWELVE
STUDENTS.
WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
A BRUNCH A JONES ON BEHALF OF
LEARN FOR LIFE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA VIRTUAL ACADEMIES IN
OPPOSITION.
MAR DONAHOE LOS ANGELES HOME
SCHOOL PARENT I'M IN OPPOSITION.
WHEN THE A CAN HOME SCHOOL MOM
OF THREE CHILDREN WHO ARE ROLL
THEM PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS
VOLUNTEER HOME SCHOOL CONSIDER
SUPPORTING OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
CHARTER SCHOOL HOME SCHOOLERS
AND DIRECTOR OF HOME SCHOOLING
AND INSPIRE CHARTER SCHOOLS?
SUPPORTING THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
PLUS CHARTER SCHOOL HOME
SCHOOLERS AND WE ALL OPPOSE THIS
BILL BELL.
HI MY NAME IS SKYLER SMITH I AM
A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT AT SAGE
OAK.
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL AND I UP.
I AM ANNA SMITH WITH TWO
STUDENTS IN PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL HOME SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
CARILLO HELLER AND WE HAVE THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER IN OUR HUNDREDS OF
MEMBERS OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JACQUELINE GAVIN I
MY CHARTER SCHOOL PARENT OF FOUR
WITH INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND THE KEVIN POSING FOR THIS
BILL.
HI THERE ARE WE ARE PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOL FAMILY AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LEAH XTRAM I'M HOME
SCHOOL CHARTER PARENTS WHO HOME
SCHOOL FIVE CHILDREN I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS PAMELA MARCIA I AM
OF HOME SCHOOL PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL PARENTS AND AYE OPPOSED
HIS BILL.
PAGE MCKINNEY MOTHER OF TWO
GRADUATES OF INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOLS STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HEATHER MILFORD WE WE HOME
SCHOOL THROUGH INSPIRE CHARTER
SCHOOL HOME SCHOOL CHARTER
SCHOOL IN SCOTT LOOKS DISTRICT
AND THIS BILL WOULD CLOSE OUR
RESOURCE CENTER PLEASE DON'T
KNOW.
MY NAME IS JEFF STREAK I AM A
FULLY CREDENTIALED TEACHER I'VE
BEEN IN CITRIX TRADITIONAL
CLASSROOM IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL FOR
EIGHT YEARS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
LEXIE LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF ADVICE
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN HI MY CLOTHES
BRUBAKER PARENT CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS AT VISIONS IN
EDUCATION AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CHRISTINA MACINNES PRINCIPLE FOR
THE UNIVERSITY PREP ACADEMY WITH
VISIONS IN EDUCATION COVERING
SIX COUNTIES WE PROVIDE
PERSONALIZED AND OF WEARING
PLANS FOR STUDENTS -- PLEASE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING SIR MET FARLEY AND
DIRECTOR OF INSTRUCTION
PROVISIONS AND EDUCATION
REPRESENTING TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TEACHERS.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI JODY GRAPHS SUPERINTENDENT
VISIONS EDUCATION SERVING OVER
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS ONE
THOUSAND OF WHICH OUR STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS STAND IN
OPPOSITION.
JIM SANDERS PROFESSIONAL
EDUCATOR I MEAN THESE ARE MY
STUDENTS SO I DON'T HAVE MUCH
STUDENTS.
OPPOSED.
AARON COBURN VISIONS IN
EDUCATION CHARTER SCHOOL I
OPPOSE.
JUDY ADAIR RIVER SPRINGS CHARTER
SCHOOLS INTO MACULA CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JOHNNY THEIR APPARENT OF CHARTER
SCHOOL GRADUATES AND A RECENT --
GRANDFATHER OF A NEW IN RALEIGH.
IN A CHARTER SCHOOL WE OPPOSE.
JACQUELINE RIGHT COLOR DEREK
PROUD GRADUATE OF A CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO ALLEN NEW ENJOY UNDER TO
MACULAR VALLEY CHARTER SCHOOL WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ANGELA ROBINSON HOME SCHOOL
PARENT OF COLD IN CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BASICALLY HOME SCHOOL STUDENT I
MY NAME IS JOYCE I AM A STUDENT
INSPIRED CHARTER I LIVE IN
BAKERSFIELD AND I OPPOSE AB --
FIFTEEN SEVEN THE SOUND A
GARDENER BAKERSFIELD INSPIRE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
AARON DAVIDSON.
PUBLIC CHARTER HOME SCHOOLER.
AND CALIFORNIA CREDENTIALED
TEACHER.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MARGARET FORTUNE MEMBER OF THE
GOVERNOR'S CHARTER SCHOOL TASK
FORCEAND CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING. SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS I OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN DOCTOR TO COURT
PORTER PASSED TO THE SENSES
CHURCH IN.
SOUTHSIDE SACRAMENTO ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL ACTION
NETWORK CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S CHAIR AND PRESSES.
MY NAME IS TACK ALLEN I AM THE
INTERNATIONAL YOUTH DIRECTOR FOR
THE INTERNATIONAL FAITH BASED
COALITION I AM ALSO A U.
THERAPIST IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AREA.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CRISTINA LASTER PERRIN UNION
PRESIDENT SAN DIEGO INLAND
EMPIRE ALSO VERY CONCERNED BLACK
PARENT AND GRANDPARENT AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
CARLA RUN HELL REPRESENTING
FORTUNE SCHOOLS I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
CELIA BARTEL STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND FORMER PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT I OPPOSE --
CATE MARTEL -- PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
CHAU BY TO SHOW BUDGETARY SOONER
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
KARINA CORRAL INSPIRE CHARTER
STUDENT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ADELA KOTA FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY
INSPIRE SHORTER PARENT OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JULIE VANDERGRIFT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M CLICK VANDERGRIFT SAID
CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CLEAR VANDERGRIFT A STUDENT
INSPIRED HER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NATALIA TAP AND
BECAUSE THEY SPEND.
MICHELLE TELL FAILED SO
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE.
MARIBEL TOP FROM FRESNO
TAMMY STANTON -- CHARTER PARENT
AND C. E. O. OF CAMINO NO WAY
ABOUT CHARTER ACADEMY IN LOS
ANGELES AND I OPPOSE THE SPELL.
ANY ROMANCE WITH CAMINO CHARTER
ACADEMY NAY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AIRING HEIL CREDENTIALED TEACHER
PARENT TO BAN PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL -- HOME SCHOOLERS TO FOR
CHILDREN AND WE DROVE ALL NIGHT
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JANA GASKELL SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE FOR PROFIT CHARTER SCHOOLS
WITH 22% SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS.
JENNIFER BECAUSE THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF JULIAN CHARTER
SCHOOL WITH SIX NON CLASS BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT ARE
ANDERSON COMPLIANCE.
HANNAH BLACK TURNER SCHOOL
SUPPORTER FROM SACRAMENTO I POSE
A SPA.
GOOD MORNING JANICE OLIVER AYE
RACY DEVELOPER OF COLITIS SCHOOL
CHARTER SCHOOL IN RANCHO CORDOVA
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JED FERNANDEZ HAVE
SCHOOLS ABOUT THE SCHOOLS AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
TRACY ROBERTSON FROM METHOD
SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
KRISTIE THOMPSON HOME SCHOOL MOM
WITH A HOME SCHOOL CHARTER
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IT WILL COVER IT EIGHTEEN YEAR
EDUCATOR CHARTER SCHOOLS LOS
ANGELES OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE MORNING PASSES TO FIND BOTH
SPEECH COMMUNITY CHURCH AND
MUSIC DIRECTOR FOR THE FORTUNE
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARYLAND BOTH A
SCHOLAR AT THE REX AND MARGARET
FORTUNE EARLY COLLEGE HIGH
SCHOOL CHARTER SCHOOL IN AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARIAH MORE IN I GO
TO THE FROM ONE COLLEGE
PREPARATORY SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE
IT.
MY NAME'S A NIGHT ABOUT SOME OF
FOUR POINT OH SCHOLAR ALAMO
COLLEGE PREP AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS TIED THE BOW SOME
APPARENT UP TO SCHOLARS WITH
FORTUNE CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LAURIE BUTLER FOUR
CHAIR OF TEACH PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SPENCER GROWS ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF TEACH PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN SOUTH PHILLY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
THERESA TAURASI TWENTY YEAR
ENGLISH -- PROFESSOR.
AND I HAVE FIVE CHILDREN TWO OR
IN PUBLIC SCHOOL TOURING CHARTER
I'M FOR CHOICE AND I OPPOSE AB
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MAKAYLA TARAJI AND
I'M A CHARTER STUDENT I LIVE IN
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MONA NAVARRO FROM
CLOVIS AND AYE OPPOSED TO SPILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MAX DAM
FROM OPEN CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO ANTHONY WILSON FROM COULD
BEAR SCHOOL THAT POSES BILL.
CHARLIE MEN'S AREA SCHOOLS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AVAILABLE BATTLES HOW
YOUR BOSS -- FOUR ONE FIVE ZERO
SEVEN MY SCHOOL IS RICIN A STAR.
FOR IS THE WHOLE SLATE
CALIFORNIA IN.
I'M MORE LATER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LUIS
CRUZ SENT FROM THE C. P. CYCLE
SAY AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EMMANUEL CRUZ I GO TO
DOWNTOWN COLLEGE PREP CHARTER
SCHOOL.
AND CENTERS A. AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS CAROL NELSON I'M FROM
BY SO YEAH CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JENNIFER DELUDE A MOTHER OF TWO
FROM GARDEN GROVE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
JERRY LYNN FROM BY SAID
CALIFORNIAN I POSE THIS BILL.
I'M SHOWN MY HAVE THREE KIDS AT
THE C. P. IN SAN JOSE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MICHELLE SNYDER FROM DOWN --
FROM SAN JOSE I TWO CHILDREN --
AND THEY GO TO DOWNTOWN COLLEGE
PREP.
AMERICAN SAN JOSE AND THEY ARE
THRIVING PLEASE I AM A VERY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SAM SNYDER AND AND I
DO OPPOSE HIS BILL.
FINISH AMATUS AND I POST THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SIMON LOPEZ THE
CPO CAMINO AND AYE OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
HI AMBER SEVERAL HIGHS ON A MOM
PORN -- HIGH SCORES TO THEN AND
THE SEPIA PER METAL AND THAT
BOTH HIS BILL.
I AM ALSO A CO -- PARENT OF A
KID AT DCP AND ANOTHER ONE A
ROCKET SHIP IN SAN JOSE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. FOR ALL OF SO
MONEY AND THEN GONE IS TO THE
NTH IN THE C. B. S. STORY AND
GONE THROUGH -- IN I'VE BEEN IS
THE KING SAYS SETTLE SEE AT THE
GLASS IF.
HI MY NAME IS MIA FLOORS WERE
COMING FOR EXAMPLE SAY.
IN -- WE MIGHT THAT MUCH I JUST
WANT TO DOWNTOWN COLLEGE PREP WE
ARE SUPPORT -- WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MIL.
AND ME NUMBER AS HE SAID BY THAT
I'M ALSO A MAD AT A NESTLE INTO
THE LEAD SQUAD LE DOWNTOWN
COLLEGE PREP.
YES THEY INLAND I STEPPED UP
WITH THE I'M CARLA HERE AND I'M
A RISING NINTH GRADER FOR
DOWNTOWN COLLEGE PREP IN SAN
JOSE AND I OPPOSES BILL.
MY SERVICE CANADA HONDA A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER IN SAN JOSE
AND AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS MELISSA ORNELAS HI TO
CHILDREN THROUGH THE CONNECTING
WATERS CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MONICA
MARTINEZ AND FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA I HAVE TWO CHILDREN
THAT I HOME SCHOOL THROUGH SELF
SUTTER AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SHEILA SCOTT I'M FROM
THE CENTURIES AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS SERRA MAY HEAR FROM
SUCH A SIZE CALIFORNIA PARENT OF
A CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BUT MY NAME IS
A MAKE YOUAND I AM A STUDENT.
AT JOHNS ACADEMY IN ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
OKAY FOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
PACIFIC CHARTER INSTITUTE BOARD
MEMBER SEVERAL COUNTY SCHOOL
BOARD AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS A MINOR PERKINS
AND I'D GO TO ROCKET SHIP
THEY'LL SURPRISE IN.
ANY ON CALIFORNIA.
I WILL KNOW ALL AND FIFTEEN OF
SEVEN HI MY NAME IS CYNTHIA
KATHY AND I HAVE TWO CHILDREN A
RIDERSHIP DELTA PREBEN ENIAC AND
AYE OPPOSES BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CREATION STOKES
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF ROCKETED
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME NINETY TAG THAT'S
ROCKCHIP DEBT TO PREP.
HIGH SCHOOL I POSED THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LIVING ARE WELL AS A
MY PERRIN AT ROCKET SHAPING
ANTIOCH AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TANYA GENTRY AND I'M
A PROUD PARENT OF A RACKETEERING
ANY OUT CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S OLIVIA GRABS HANK I
COME FROM OUR COULD YOU PUT THE
ROCK I MAKE.
I AM OPPOSED TO FOR THESE BILLS.
MY NAME IS ERICA MIKE THAT
LYNOTT AND NOW BOASTS THIS BILL.
NOT IN A SOLARI FROM SAN JOSE
AND FOR SUPPORTING I KEEP AREA
SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME CITIES GARCIA COMMUNITY
OUTREACH MANAGER FOR A CHARTER
SCHOOL IN SAN JOSE AND AYE
OPPOSED.
MY NAME IS IS OTHERS HELLO DEAL
AND I AM A ROCKET SHIP ALUMNA
AND I'M GOING.
TO START MY FIRST YEAR AT A FOR
UNIVERSITY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
AT THE END OF YES IN YOUR I AM A
PRODUCT OF A OF A PUBLIC
DISTRICT CHARTER SCHOOL AND
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROSE MERRY CHAVEZ
SCOTT I'M A PROUD PARENTS OF AN
EIGHT YEAR OLDS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS THAT.
ROCKET SHIP DISCOVERY PROP IN
SAN JOSE CHARTER SCHOOL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME SABRINA LEONARD I AM A
FORMER GRADUATE OF HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL AND NOW
AN EMPLOYEE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SHANNON FAIR I AM A
SPECIAL NEEDS PARENT AND A
FOSTER PARENT AND STUDENT
CHARTERS.
HIGHLANDS CHARTER SCHOOL
MASTERING OPPOSES BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS TANYA BILL I AM
THE FUTURE GRADUATE OF HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL.
NIGHT STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THAT ASSEMBLY
LOPEZ AND I'M A STUDENT AND
HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL IN I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SHANNON
RUN.
AND I AM A STUDENT HIGHLANDS
COMMISSION IS COOL AN OPPOSING
THIS BILL.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SHERRY TAURUS AND I'M A GRADUATE
OF THIS YEAR OF HIGHLANDS
CHARTER SCHOOL IN NORTH AREA IN
OPELOUSAS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SYDNEY VALIDATION
I OPPOSE.
OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE HERBAL
AND I AM A PROUD STUDENT AT
HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
MY NAME IS GINNY STEIN I'M OUR
WISH DIRECTOR AND STUDENT
LEADERSHIP PRESIDENT AT
HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI JOANNA HOLE APPARENT AT
GOLDEN VALLEY CHARTER SCHOOL IN
SACRAMENTO AND A TRUSTEE BUT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION IN OPPOSITION TO
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAITLYN AHOLA I
AM -- GOLDEN VALLEY CHARTER
SCHOOL ALANIS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TO
DIRECT SOME A THIRTY YEAR
AIRFORCE VETERAN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS FRAN RACKS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALEX TO CARE AND THIS
UNIT CORE CHARGE CORNEIL
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND MY NAME IS IDEALLY CARE I'M
A PARENT OF TWO CHILDREN AT A
CHARTER SCHOOL AS WELL AS A
BOARD MEMBER AND I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME S
MEDICAL CARE I'M A STUDENT COR
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NEARING SHARP AND MY
SCHOOL IS CORD CHARTER SCHOOL
AND AYE OPPOSES BILL.
NEWS MISSION SHARP I'M A PARENT
OF A CORE CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT
NOT OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ISABEL JOHNSON I AM A
PARENT TO CHILDREN WHO ATTEND A
PUBLIC CHARTER.
AND I AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AS
IT REMOVES RESOURCES FROM OUR
CHILDREN.
MY NAME IS JACKIE ROBERTSON AND
THE CHIEF OF STAFF AT ALL TO
SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO AND WE
OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN A SEVEN TIM
TUTOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ALL TO
SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL
MY NAME IS NATALIE.
AM OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANDREA LEBRON AND I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK.
HI MY NAME IS AMY TAYLOR AND I'M
A SPECIAL EDUCATOR AND A PARENT
OF A CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JEFFREY TAYLOR AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KERA MORALIS I'M A
CALIFORNIA CREDENTIALED TEACHER
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PLEASE REFER.
TO I CAN SEE.
MY NAME IS MADELINE VALDEZ
VASQUEZ AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HIS FELLOW
CONTENDERS ON HERE FROM SAN AND
I REPRESENT THE PARENT UNION I
HAVE KIDS AND BOTH CHARTER AND
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN HI MY NAME IS
PAUL CONTRAIRE SEVEN SANTA ANA
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME IS ANNA
MARIA ROLE HAS I'M A TEACHER AT
THE CHARTER SCHOOL OF SAN DIEGO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTY
NO.
SEVEN MY NAME IS KAMAL MARTIN
PARENT OF SAN DIEGO PUBLIC
SCHOOL CHILDREN VOTE NO ON
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME IS THE
LORD DRESS YAK I'M A TEACHER AT
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS IN DIEGO AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS VERONICA BALMAIN
SCHOOL COORDINATOR FOR IDEA
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HALEY BEAUPRE SCHOOL COORDINATOR
FOR GROSSMONT SWEETWATER
SECONDARY SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME IS
BARBARA MURPHY I AM A HOME
SCHOOL MOM OF THESE TWO BOYS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CAROLYN FRANK I'M
FROM APPLE VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JULIE EDWARDS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DAY EDWARD CHEN AYE
OPPOSED.
MY NAME IS BATES FLIES I ATTEND
A PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JEANETTE HARRIS
AND I AM A PROUD PARENT OF TWO
STUDENTS AT SENSE IN A VALLEY
ACADEMY.
AND EIGHTY A PREVIOUS GRADUATE I
CAL STATE FULLERTON NOW AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS VANESSA CHAVEZ
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY WITH
INSPIRED CHARTER I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN THERE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELENA CHAVEZ AND
I'M A STUDENT INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GINNY EDWARDS A HOME
SCHOOL MOM AND A HOME SCHOOL
TEACHER THROUGH PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KILEY.
MARKARIAN.
I'M A STATE AND I INSPIRE AND I
STRONGLY VERY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MY NAME IS PRASANNA
MARKARIAN [inaudible]
I ENABLE AYE SAYS [inaudible]
AB HOW.
MY NAME IS PRETTY MARKARIAN I'M
FOR MARINO VALLEY I'M AT PARENT
WITH INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KIM CARPENTER MY
PUBLIC SCHOOL TURNER PARENT AND
AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
I AM MILES CARPENTER
[inaudible]
THIS MAIL.
IMAX CARPENTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JESSICA HALL IMAGE
CHARTER SCHOOL PARENT AND
CONSIDERED INVESTOR KEN COOLEY
AND I OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS POPPY APPARENT AT
WITH WINSTAR CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I OPPOSE.
MARK ONE DOLLAR FROM CINEMA
CALIFORNIA.
OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA -- I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SARAH CARTER AND FROM
FRESNO COUNTY WE ARE WITH
INSPIRED CHARTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JACOB BEATEN MENDER
I'M A JUNIOR WITH SELF SUTTER
CHARTER SCHOOL A LIFELONG
CHARTER SCHOOL ATTENDEE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS PARRIS LAUDERDALE AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JORDAN LAUDERDALE AND
MY NAME IS SHANNON LAUDERDALE A
PARENT OF TWO CHILDREN IN A
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS J. C. B. MENTOR AND A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EMMA BEATEN BENDER
CHARTER SCHOOL PARENT WAS SOUTH
CENTER CHARTER FOR TWELVE YEARS
AND I IT RUN A HOME SCHOOL GROUP.
IN CITRUS HEIGHTS CIRCLE OF
HOMESCHOOLERSWE HAVE ABOUT --
FIVE HUNDRED CHARTER SCHOOL
THANK YOU YOU OPPOSE.
YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH FRANCE
WHILE I'M A STUDENT AT SOUTH
CENTER CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SUZANNE FRIENDS WHILE
I'M THE MOTHER OF EIGHT CHARTER
SCHOOL EDUCATED CHILDREN CELL
SUTTER CHARTER SCHOOL HOME
SCHOOL CHARTER SCHOOL AS WELL AS
JOHN ADAMS ACADEMY ROSE BILL.
AND I OPPOSE THE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROSE FRANCE WHILE I'M
STUDENTS ARE SENATOR TO SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M CLAIRE FRANCE WHY MR AT
SOUTH SUTTER CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M DOCTOR KATIE GUINAN I AM
FROM STANFORD UNIVERSITY SCHOOL
OF EDUCATION AND I POSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS NAOMI HARRISON AND
AYE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LISA JENKINS I'M A
PARENT VOLUNTEER WITH PARENTS
UNITED FOR KIDS I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M PASTOR DEBORAH CAMARA
MEMBER SCHOOL SITE COUNCIL ON
FORTUNE SCHOOL AND A BRAND
MOTHER MOTHER OF CHILDREN IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MATT THE CAMARA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS RAY THANK YOU I'M
INSTEAD OF FOUR TO SCHOOL AND
AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS I SECURE TELL AND I
STRONGLY STRONGLY STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS HANNAH MOTHER OF TWO
FOURTEEN SCHOOL KIDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CLARA NAMER -- WERE
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL PUBLIC
TO HOME IF YOU WANT TO SAY
ANYTHING.
MY NAME IS ALEX WELL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A REVIEW WAY HAN I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BETH.
I'M A PUBLIC CHARTER HOME SCHOOL
PARENT AND I REPRESENT A GROUP
THAT CAN MAKE IT THE HAS ALMOST
A HUNDRED FAMILIES AND WE LONGER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
HI KRISTIN CROSS SOME SORT TRIED
ACADEMY AND ALSO PROUD PARENT OF
A HOME SCHOOL CHILD.
TRICIA LANCASTER DIRECTOR OF
SORTS CHARTER ACADEMY AND A
PARENT OF A STUDENT WHO GOES TO
GORMAN LEARNING CENTER.
MY NAME IS JODY LEON I'M A
PUBLIC CHARTER HOME SCHOOL
PARENT AND AYE OPPOSED.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME IS
REBECCA BLOOM.
I AM NOT.
A A HOME SCHOOLED AND OF THE
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL EVENTS
FIRE.
AM I ALSO AM.
I HAVE A STUDENT AND THAT IS
[inaudible]
DISABLED.
MY NUMBER IS ONE OF RUN INS YOU
MISTER ENCOMPASS THE LA KINGS
ASSOCIATE THE PERFORMER WHAT THE
MOWING THE GRASS.
AUSTIN MORALIS BIGELOW SUNLESS
IMMOBILE ACCUSES IT'LL SEE IF
THEY CAN ASSIST.
HELLO AND THE NIGHT IS PROUD
PUBLIC CHARTER ALUMNI I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
LAURYN TREMBLAY PINE MOUNTAIN
CLUB CALIFORNIA I AM A PUBLIC
CHARTER HOME SCHOOL PARENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BY THE MUSAEUS IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL I'LL BE HAVE A FAMILY
SAID IN THE SALLY THANK YOU.
A LOT OF RIDER FROM LOS ANGELES
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MARIA FLORES FROM PROCLAIM A
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY DIESEL ALONSO FIRM PACOIMA
CHATTER OUT OF SCHOOL.
AND OPPOSED TO THIS.
AB TEN FIFTEEN ALL.
SEVEN I'M A PART IN VICTOR WAS
DERIVED FROM IS LOS ANGELES --
PUTS HIS BILL.
BRENDA ALONSO FROM SOUTH LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
RUBY GOT THE ADDRESS CHARTER
ALUMNI AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
RACHEL SULLIVAN TWENTY YEARS
CERTIFICATED PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER MY TWO CHILDREN ARE WITH
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL.
HELLO I AM A STUDENT AT INSPIRE
CHARTER.
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NICOLE RAFFERTY FROM
LAKE ARROWHEAD CALIFORNIA WE ARE
I HAVE TWO CHILDREN AND INSPIRE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS [inaudible]
HE OPPOSES.
TODAY'S.
EXCUSE ME DENISE SMITH FROM
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA SECOND
GENERATION HOME EDUCATOR OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOHNNY ANDERSON I'M
AN ADMINISTRATOR AT SO SUTTER
CHARTER SCHOOL AS WELL AS A
PARENT OF SIX CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JULIA ANDERSON I GO
TO SOUTH SUTTER CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I PROCESS FILL.
MY NAME IS JAY SLEAZE CHARTER
LEVINE I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS MAY BE -- I GO TO A
COULD I MEAN ABOUT THE CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS FELICIA OFFERED FROM
LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA I'VE TWO
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER GLAZER WE DO HAVE
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO SAY.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE OF ADAM SHARE AND
FOR FOR EVERYONE'S PATIENCE AS
WE TALK ABOUT AN IMPORTANT TEST
SUBJECT HERE AGAIN THIS MORNING --
AS I READ THAT THE BILL AND AS I
READ THE THE ANALYSIS.
IT SEEMS THAT THE THE FOCUS THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS HIS -- RESTORING
THE RIGHT OF ANGEL TO INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICTS TO HAVE OVERSIGHT OF
THE SCHOOLS IS THE HAS THE
ESSENCE OF OF THE CONCERNS THAT
ARE TRYING TO BE ADDRESSED IN
THIS BILL [inaudible]
AND SO IN SOME WAYS THAT THE THE
THE THE CRITICISM IS A PROCESS
CRITICISM NOT A SUBSTANCE
CRITICISM.
LIKE GIVE THE DEBATE HERE TODAY
WAS ABOUT -- WHERE AN AUTHORIZED --
HAS FAILED TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
IN A SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCE AND
WE WERE EXAMINING THAT.
I THINK THAT'S A WORTHY OF THAT
OF OUR TIME IN THAT EXAMINATION
BECAUSE HERE WE ARE.
TRYING TO IDENTIFY A FAILURE AND
WE WANT TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO
MAKE IT BETTER FOR THE STUDENTS
IN THOSE FAMILIES.
OF THE BY PRODUCT OF THAT MAY BE
WHAT'S BENEFIT OFFICIAL TO A
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR NOT.
BUT THE FOCUS WOULD BE ON THE ON
THE SCHOOL AND THE KIDS.
AND THE PARENTS AND ALL THAT
HAPPENS AND ALL THAT HAPPENS
THERE.
BUT THE COULD BUT THE CRITICISM
THAT'S TRYING TO BE OVERCOME
WITH THIS BILL IS THE PROCESS
FOR HOW.
THESE CHARTERS ARE AUTHORIZED --
AND I GUESS THAT'S WHERE I HAVE
SOME SOME CHALLENGES BECAUSE
THAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT LINES
ARE INCREDIBLY DIFFERENT
EVERYWHERE I WAS LOOKING AT LOS
ANGELES AND LOOKING AT JUST A
LITTLE MATH WITH.
ALL THE CITIES IN DIFFERENT
COLORS AND YOU KNOW WE LOOK AT
THE CITY CITY LINES WE LOOK AT
SENATORIAL LINES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LINES IT'S AWFULLY ARBITRARY.
I KNOW THAT THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE LAW ARE THAT YOU CAN
AUTHORIZE OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTY
SO LEASE WE HAVE SOME BOUNDARIES
THAT UNDER EXISTING LAW ARE PUT
IN PLACE YOU CAN AUTHORIZE
OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTY.
BUT THEN IT IT GETS TO BE A
QUESTIONABLE.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S WHAT'S REALLY AT
STAKE HERE IS IT THE IS IT --
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ONE
BLOCKING ANOTHER THAT ARE NEXT
TO EACH OTHER IN A LINE DIVIDES
THEM.
OR IS IT SOMETHING MORE
SUBSTANTIAL.
IF IF THERE WAS CRITICISM THAT
WE WERE TRYING TO OVERCOME --
WITH PAY TO PLAY AND HOW
AUTHORIZATION IS DONE THAT HAS --
CERTAINLY RESIDENTS WITH ME --
AND IF THERE WAS IF THERE WAS
FOCUS ON THIS OVERSIGHT AND HOW
IT WAS POORLY DONE AND LET'S
FOCUS ON THAT AND TALK ABOUT HOW
WE CAN DO THAT BETTER.
I I KNOWLEDGE THAT AUTHORIZING
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH
AUTHORIZING IT IT'S IT'S VERY
COMPLEX.
AND IT'S VERY COSTLY AND THERE
ARE SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
ARE CAPABLE OF DOING IT AND SOME
THAT ARE NOT AND THAT DOES GET
IN THE WAY OF THE ABILITY TO
AUTHORIZE.
A BECAUSE OF THAT -- BUT WITH IT
COMES DOWN TO THE ISSUE OF LINES.
THAT'S WHERE IT REALLY IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A STOPPER FOR ME.
IF WE THOUGHT THAT TAX EIGHTY ON
THE TESTIMONY THAT'S BEEN
PROVIDED TODAY AND AND THROUGH
CORRESPONDENCE.
THAT RAISES SOME IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS.
THE ABILITY TO GET A CLASSROOM
SPACE FOR A CHARTER IS NOT EASY.
AND AND AS WE TALKED ABOUT IN
THE OTHER IN THE EARLIER BILL
THAT THERE'S SOME SELF INTEREST
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS NOT --
AUTHORIZING A CHARTER BECAUSE
IT'S TAKEN AWAY THEIR MONEY.
AND IT MADE ME TAKEN AWAY THEIR
CLASSROOM SPACE.
AND SO THESE ARE THINGS THAT --
WE COULD CREATE INHERENT
CONFLICTS THAT ARE HARD TO
OVERCOME -- IF BUT I CHARTER
WANTS TO BE ESTABLISHED IN A
COMMUNITY AND THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OPPOSED TO IT AND THEY
DON'T WANT TO GIVE UP IN A
CLASSROOM SPACE WHAT'S THAT
CHARTER SUPPOSED TO DO.
WERE THEY SUPPOSED TO GO.
AND NOW DOES A LINE SEPARATING
ONE BLOCK FROM ANOTHER ONE CITY
FROM ANOTHER ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT
FROM ANOTHER -- IS THAT'S GOING
TO BE NOW UNDER THIS BILL THAT
THAT CHARTER TO THRIVE AND FIND
SPACE.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE AT THE AT THE
LOCATION NEXT TO TRANSIT LINES.
WERE MAKE IT EASIER FOR KIDS TO
GET TO SCHOOL.
NOW THAT DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
LINE.
AND SOME CASES NOT EVEN -- I
CITY LINE IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
TRANSIT LINE.
A BUS OR TRAIN AND THAT'S A
PRETTY GOOD REASON TO TRY TO
FIND A LOCATION FOR SCHOOL
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO TRY TO MAKE
IT.
EASIER FOR KIDS.
SO I DO FIND THAT THAT THEY'LL
THE ISSUE OF LINES IS SOMEWHAT
ARBITRARY.
AND I THINK IT IT IT FOR ME AT
LEAST IT.
IT DIVERTS FROM A FOCUS ON WHAT
SHOULD BE MOST IMPORTANT OF THE
WORK THAT WE DO AND THAT'S THAT
THE QUALITY.
OF THE INSTRUCTION -- THE THAT
THE STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT THAT IS
OCCURRING OR NOT OCCURRING IN A
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
HI AND THEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
BROADER PROBLEM OF EDUCATION IN
OUR STATE.
AND YOU SAY WE'VE GOT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE FOR
PERFORMING SCHOOLS.
OF WHICH THIS BILL WILL DO
NOTHING TO CHANGE.
THEN I START THINK WELL IS OUR
FOCUS REALLY IN THE RIGHT PLACE.
IS IT ON IS IT ABOUT LINES OR IS
IT ABOUT -- STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
AND THAT'S WHERE I HAVE TROUBLE
UNFORTUNATELY WITH YOUR BILL
TODAY IT'S AS I WANT TO FOCUS ON
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT OR LACK
THEREOF.
AND NOT ON LINES -- THE LAW
ITSELF TODAY SAYS IT HAS TO BE
WITHIN A COUNTY OKAY THERE ARE
SOME BOUNDARIES.
IF WE HAVE ABUSE THAN WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON THAT ABUSE AND THE
COMPLEXITY OF CHARTERING IS
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW --
TOGETHER HAS TO AND PAID SOME
ATTENTION TO I THINK WE PAY SOME
ATTENTION TO AND THAT'S A GOOD
THAT'S A GOOD FOCUS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY FOR ME ARE THE
FOCUS JUST PURELY ON LINE SECOND
THIS IS THE THE AT THE TENSION
THAT I THINK WE SHOULD BE PAYING.
TO UNDERPERFORMING SCHOOLS AND
THAT'S WHY I CAN'T BE SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TODAY.
BECAUSE CENTER GLAZER ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SENATOR DRAW SO.
YES THANK YOU.
SEE WHEN YOU THOUGHT IT WAS THE
EASIER -- ONE I MEAN IT SEEMS TO
ME THIS IS.
A SIMPLE.
ISSUE THAT UNFORTUNATELY -- HAS
BECOME TOO COMPLICATED -- THE
OTHER LINES THESE LINES IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
HIS LINES THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
IN TERMS OF WHO RUNS WHO AND
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE WHO'S HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
SO LET'S BE REAL AND LET'S BE
PRACTICAL ABOUT WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT.
AND LOCAL CONTROL.
IS EVERYBODY POUNDS ON THE TABLE
ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL WELL LET'S
ACT ON IT LET'S BELIEVE YOU KNOW
LET'S ACT ON WHAT WE BELIEVE IN.
SO I THOUGHT IT WAS AN EASY --
ONE TO SORRY TO SAY.
OF IT JUST BECOMES ANOTHER --
GROUP VERSUS ANOTHER GROUP SO
I'M SORRY YOUR IN THE MIDDLE OF
SUCH HARD WORK ANDTAKING ON THE
SIMPLE ISSUE SO I WILL
DEFINITELY BE SUPPORTING THANK.
THANK YOU CENTER DORADO SENATOR
WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
COMPLICATED ISSUE AND COURSE WE
ALL LIVE FIRST HAND -- THE TO
USE THAT COULD HAPPEN IN THE
SENATE CREATIVE VALLEY I'M HAPPY
TO REPORT THAT PARTICULAR SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS A NEW
SUPERINTENDENT THE NEW BOARD
MEMBERS AND SO.
HOPEFULLY THAT THAT'S BEEN
THAT'S BEEN CORRECTED SO I GOT A
COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR THE
OPPONENTS FIRST ONE BECAUSETHIS
IS SOMETHING I WAS THINKIN
ABOUT AND THEN YOU BROUGHT IT UP
IN YOUR TESTIMONY.
BUT YOU COULDN'T ARTICULATE MORE
ON IT BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET TWO
MINUTES SO -- COUPLING IF
FIFTEEN OH FIVE IN FIFTEEN OH
SEVEN IF THEY BOTH WERE TO PASS
YOU BELIEVE THAT YOUR SCHOOL --
SCHOOL WHICH I GOOGLE IN SCOTT
FABULOUS REVIEWS IT WOULD BE
POTENTIALLY IN PERIL SO CAN YOU
EXPAND EXPAND ON THAT.
YES AFTER.
WE WILL HAVE TO GO OF ODYSSEY
WAS JUST RENEWED BY LA COUNTY --
IN IS MY MY NOT ON HE TURNED IT
ON FOR YOUR GOOD OKAY THANK YOU --
SO AND WE WERE REACH WE ARE JUST
RECENTLY NEW TO RENEW THAT OUR
TWENTIETH YEAR -- AND SO IF WE
HAD TO GO BACK TO PASADENA
UNIFIED TO SEEK AN AMMO YOU AT
OUR FIT AT OUR FIFTH YEAR AND
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND THEY SAID
NO T THIS MOMENT AS I
UNDERSTAND THE BILLS TO BE
MOVING QUITE QUICKLY -- BUT WHAT
I UNDERSTAND IS IS THAT WE WOULD
AND THEN HAVE AN APPEAL PROCESS
EITHER -- AND THAT ARE WITHIN
THEIR BY WE WOULD HAVE TO
PROBABLY CLOSE WE CURRENTLY ARE
IN AND HAVE BEEN IN A FEW ES DE
FACILITY FOR SIXTEEN YEARS --
AND HAVE BEEN LIVING WITH IN THE
LAW OF HAVING ONE SCHOOL OUTSIDE
THE JURISDICTION OF OUR
AUTHORIZED -- IF WE HAVE TO GO
BACK UNDER THE WAY IT'S
CURRENTLY WRITTEN -- WE WOULD WE
WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK TO SOUTH
PASADENA AND THERE WOULD BE NO
PLACE FOR US TO GO THERE THAT'S
A DISTRICT OF FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
AND HE WAS THE AS A DISTRICT OF
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS SO
IT'S QUITE SMALL TO TRY AND FIND
A FACILITIES WITHIN SOUTH
PASADENA.
GREAT THANK YOU -- SO QUESTION
FOR THE FOR THE ATTORNEY SO
WANTED THE CRITICISM I HEAR
ABOUT CHARTER SCHOOLS IS AS AT
THE CHERRY PICK.
AND THEY AVOID.
ENGLISH AS SECOND LANGUAGE
LEARNERS OR CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AND SO I I THINK
YOU HAVE A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVES
CONSIDERING YOU GUYS REPRESENT
TWO THIRDS OF ALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
SO I LIKE TO KNOW MORE ABOUT THE
RESOURCE CENTER AND HOW.
ALL THAT IS USED TO DELIVER
SERVICES TO THE STUDENTS.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION A YES YOU KNOW CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE TO ENROLL STUDENTS
WHO WISH TO ENROLL IN THE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND ONLY AFTER
THEY ARE AT CAPACITY IS A MOMENT
DETERMINED BY PUBLIC RANDOM
DRAWING.
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE LIMITED TO SERVING
STUDENTS WHO RESIDE WITHIN THEIR
COUNTY AND ADJACENT COUNTY SO
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
POTENTIALLY HAVE STUDENTS COMING.
FROM WITHIN THEIR COUNTY AND
ADJACENT COUNTIES AND THE
CHARTER SCHOOL LAW SAYS YOU MUST
ENROLL STUDENTS WHO WISH TO
ATTEND.
WHAT THAT MANS IS THAT WE NEED
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES TO ALL
THOSE STUDENTS THE EDUCATION
CODE -- FIVE ONE SEVEN FOUR SIX
SAYS THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE THE
SAME RESOURCES THAT THEY WOULD
GET IT OTHER PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
THAT WOULD INCLUDE LEARNING
CENTERS -- LEARNING CENTERS
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTING TO DURING
SPECIAL EDUCATION SUPPORTS ITS
ULTRA HOT THAT'S ALSO THE THAT'S
ALSO THE PLACE WHERE WE ALLOW
FOR THE INTERACTION BETWEEN.
NON DISABLED PEERS -- AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS AS
WELL AS SO IF WE LIMIT -- IF WE
LIMIT THE RESOURCE CENTERS --
JUST TO THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHERE THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS AUTHORIZED WE LOSE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE THE
STUDENTS WHERE THEY LIVE.
SO IF THE CHARTER SCHOOL
PREDOMINANTLY -- IS LOCATED --
LET'S JUST TAKE FOR EXAMPLE IN
SAN DIEGO IN SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
BOUNDARIES -- THAT IS A LARGE
VERY LARGE COUNTY -- IF WE ONLY
LIMIT OUR FACILITIES TO TO THAT
DISTRICT -- AND WE ARE AND LET'S
SAY WE'VE GOT FIVE TO TEN KIDDOS
THAT ARE AN ORANGE COUNTY --
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO REQUIRE
THEM TO TRAVEL ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO SAN DIEGO UNIFIED IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES AND ASSESSMENTS.
I MEAN EVEN ARGUABLY
STANDARDIZED TESTING -- WHICH IS
REQUIRED BY LAW -- BECAUSE THE
LAW IS SO BROAD TO TOES TO LIMIT
US TO HAVE NOT HAVING RESOURCE
CENTERS MEETING SPACES OR ANY
OTHER SATELLITE FACILITY.
OF RIGHT NOW I BELIEVE THE LAW
IS LIMITING ENOUGH IT SAYS THAT
WE CAN ONLY HAVE A FACILITY.
AND AN ADJACENT COUNTY IF WE ARE
PRIMARY EDUCATIONAL SERVICES ARE
WITHIN -- WITHIN THE COUNTY IN
WHICH WERE AUTHORIZED AND THE
MAJORITY OF SERVE AS STUDENTS
THAT WE SERVE ARE RESIDING
WITHIN THE AUTHORIZING COUNTY I
THINK THESE LIMITS ARE ENOUGH
AND I I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE.
RIGHT THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
ANSWER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE CERTAINLY THANK YOU I
WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO ADDRESS
AT SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY MY SENATE COLLEAGUES HERE.
TODAY AND AND BY THE OPPOSITION --
PART OF THE REASON IT'S SO
CRITICAL THAT WE GET THE COUNTY
AUTHORIZATION PROCESS RIGHT IN
FIFTEEN OH FIVE IS BECAUSE IT
ADDRESSES SOME OF THESE ISSUES
THAT THE OPPOSITION HAS RAISED --
THERE ARE MEANINGFUL REASONS FOR
COUNTY AUTHORIZED CHARTERS TO
EXIST SOME OF THOSE REYES BY
SENATOR GLAZER WERE SOMETIMES
LINES ARE SIMPLY ARBITRARY AND
THE ABILITY TO FIND A FACILITY
DOESN'T FIT LEARN ARBITRARY LINE
HAS BEEN DRAWN.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT AT
THAT BILL CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD AND WE REALLY REALLY
REFINED NOT.
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
EQUATION WE HAVE GOT IN THIS
WHOLE CONVERSATION TO STOP
LETTING THE PERFECT BE THE ENEMY
OF THE GOOD.
AND THE RIGHT AND THE ETHICAL WE
ARE AT A CROSSROADS IN NEEDING
TO REFINE AND DEFINE HOW CHARTER
SCHOOLS OPERATE IN TANDEM AND IN
COOPERATION WITH THE DISTRICTS
WHERE THEY ARE SERVING STUDENTS.
AND IF WE DON'T ESTABLISH A
SYSTEM WHERE THE RIGHT POINT OF
INTERACTION FOUR CHAIR CHARTER
PARENTS AND THEIR ADMINISTRATION
TEAMS IS THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THESE BINARY.
AN OPPOSITIONAL CONVERSATIONS
AND NOT COME TO THE TABLE AS
COMMUNITIES.
AND AS AN INSTITUTION WE HAVE
GOT TO BE CRITICALLY CAREFUL OF
WAITING INTO A SPACE OF CHECKING
THE JURISDICTIONAL SOVEREIGNTY
OF DULY ELECTED LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT SCHOOL BOARDS ARE.
I THINK WE WOULD ALL AGREE THAT
A CITY GOVERNMENT IS A DULY
ELECTED MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENT.
AND IF THE CITY ABOUT GROVER TO
SAY TO THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO WE
NEED MORE POLICING WE THINK WE
DO COMMUNITY COMMUNITY POLICING
WITH A BETTER MODEL.
AND INCIDENTALLY WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH SPACE TO LOCATE A NEW
POLICE FACILITY WITHIN OUR CITY
BOUNDARIES.
SO WE'RE GONNA LOCATED A FEW
BLOCKS AWAY IN SACRAMENTO I KNOW
BY THE WAY OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WILL BE POLICING YOUR
STREETS.
AS A STATE LEGISLATURE WOULD WE
ALLOW THAT MUNICIPAL GOVERNANCE
OVERREACH.
I THINK NOT.
AND I THINK IT'S TIME TO COME TO
TERMS WITH THE FACT THAT A
LOCALLY ELECTED SCHOOL BOARD HAS
JURISDICTIONAL SOVEREIGNTY IT
ALSO HAPPENS TO BE THE PLACE OF
GOVERNANCE WHERE WE HAVE GOT TO
ALLOW CHARTERS TO START TO
ENGAGE IN A MEANINGFUL WAY.
THIS IS ONE STEP TOWARD DOING
THAT.
THERE WAS MAJORITY CONSENSUS ON
THE TASK FORCE THAT THIS IS ONE
AREA WE NEED TO IMPROVE WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO PROVIDE
AN IMMEDIATE REMEDY FOR
SOMETHING THAT IS MORE THAN A
DECADE LONG PROBLEM.
WHEN I SAW THEM AND SERVED ON
THE NEW HOME SCHOOL BOARD WE
STARTED DEALING WITH THIS THE
YEAR I WAS ELECTED SO NINE YEARS?
I HAVE WATCHED THIS AND WHILE
THEREARE OF COURSE WELL
INTENTIONED GREAT OPERATING
CHARTERS WHO ARE SERVING
STUDENTS WILL WELL WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AND
FIND OPTIONS FOR THEM.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE RECENT
HEADLINES TIME AND AGAIN WE'VE
SEEN ABUSES AND INDICTMENTS AND
WASTE OF TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER FUNDS WHICH
FRANKLY SHOULD BE GOING ALL OF
THESE KIDS.
CHARTER KIDS IN TRADITIONAL
SCHOOL PUBLIC KIDS MORE OFTEN
THAN NOT IT IS IN CASES LIKE
THESE WHERE THERE HAS BEEN AN
OUT OF DISTRICT AUTHORIZATION.
AND THE PERSON OR THE BOARD
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT OVERSIGHT
IS HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY A
SLEEP AT THE SWITCH COLLECTING
OVERSIGHT FEES.
SO I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN WE HAVE
A MOTION.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DORADO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HIM TO AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL KNOW WILK NO CHIANG
LASSELL BUDDHA SO I GLAZER.
GLAZER NO MCGUIRE PAN.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT BELONG CALL.
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
HAS GRACIOUSLY CEDED HIS PLACE
IN LINE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
SO WE ARE GOING TO GO TO FILE
ITEM.
TWENTY AB
.
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE WELCOME
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WILL WAIT JUST A
MINUTE UNTIL IT QUIETS DOWN A
LITTLE BIT.
ALRIGHT PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I BRING
YOU GOOD NEWS.
WE LIKE GOOD NEWS NOT REALLY A
CONTROVERSIAL BILL SO.
YOU'VE HAD A LONG MORNING
ALREADY AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR ALLOWING ME TO TO
JUMP IN HERE TO BECAUSE WITH THE
MIDST OF A LOT OF THINGS GOING
ON ON OUR SIDE OF THE HOUSE.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU
AB THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THE
LAOTIAN AMERICAN HISTORY
CURRICULUM -- THIS BILL HAS --
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION
TO INCLUDE THE HISTORY AND
CULTURAL STUDY OF LAOTIAN
AMERICANS DURING THE DEVELOPMENT
OF CURRICULUM RELATIVE TO THE
VIETNAMESE WAR REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE IN AMERICA.
LAST YEAR SB EIGHT NINETY FIVE
REQUIRES THE AYE AYE QC TO
DEVELOP A MODEL URRICULUM
RELATIVE TO THE VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN REFUGEE EXPERIENCE.
HOWEVER THE HISTORY OF LAOTIAN
REFUGEES AND THE COUNTRY OF LAOS
WHICH IS INSEPARABLE FROM THE
HISTORY OF THE VIETNAM WAR WAS
NOT INCLUDED IN SB EIGHT NINETY
FIVE AS AN OVERSIGHT.
THIS IS NOT A NEW A NEW
CURRICULUM BILL THIS IS A CLEAN
UP LANGUAGE TO CORRECT
UNINTENTIONAL EXCLUSION OF
LAOTIAN AMERICAN HISTORY IT IN
SB.
EIGHT NINETY FIVE THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND HAS
BASICALLY BEEN ON CONSENT ALONG
THE WAY -- IN ALL THE POLICY
COMMISSIONS AND ON THE FLOOR AND
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE ALLOWS
COMMUNITY AT AT AMERICAN
ADVANCEMENT ORGANIZATION.
AND I WAS WAS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND I'LL ASK
THEM TO INTRODUCE THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD HAVE MY COLLEAGUES --
SPEAK FIRST AND THEN I'LL FOLLOW.
GOOD INSTITUTIONS OF I GOOD
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF AS SENATE
EDUCATION [inaudible]
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS QUITE CHOICE I CHAO
AND REPRESENTING THAT YOU ME AND
COMMUNITY AND ADVOCATE FOR YOU
WE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE THOUSAND HISTORY AND
CULTURAL STUDIES.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT I CAME
TO THE UNITED STATES AS A
REFUGEE FROM LAOS.
MY FAMILY OF FOUR WHAT THE FOODS
YOU ME AND TO SETTLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
MAJORITY ABOUT YOU ME AND CAME
TO THE U. S. IN EARLY EIGHTIES
THEY OP PROXIMATE A FIFTY
THOUSAND YOU MEAN AMERICAN IN
THE UNITED STATES AND THIRTY
THOUSAND A MALL.
ARE RESIDING IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
IT ALLOWS.
HOW YOU MILLION MEN AND WOMEN
SERVE IN THE SPECIAL GORILLA
UNIT?
WHICH SUPPORTED THE U. S. SECRET
WAR IN LAOS DURING THE VIETNAM
WALL.
I PERSONALLY WHAT'S ONE OF THE
STUDENT IN THE BOARDING SCHOOL
THAT WAS SUPPORTED BY US
OPERATION -- CID. FOR THE HILL
TRIBAL PEOPLE WORKING NOT TEN
DOLLARS.
DAY OUT VERY FEW OF OUR AMERICAN
FRIENDS AND CALL WILL GO DEBT NO
OFF YOU ME AND AND LAOTIAN
COMMUNITIES.
INCLUDING OUT NEW GENERATION
POOL WILL BORN AND RAISED HERE.
THEY DID NOT KNOW WHY.
WE ARE HERE.
AND NO UP TO ME AND SACRIFICES
IN THE U. S. SECRET WALL IN LAOS.
WE WON OUR FUTURE LAOTIAN
GENERATION TO KNOW ABOUT OUR
HISTORY AND PEACE SO I'LL REACH
CULTURE AND TO BE PRODUCTIVE
CITIZEN IN AMERICA.
THEREFORE I URGE YOU TO PASS THE
A. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE DIDN'T
MATTER TO ME AND MY COMMUNITY I
ALSO ONE MY SEVEN GRAND CHILDREN.
TO LEARN ABOUT OUR LAOTIAN RICH
HISTORY AND CULTURE IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL [inaudible]
PLEASE.
PASS THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS THANK
YOU.
SO -- GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KHAN HAD
LITTLE LEAGUE LIAM TALKING SO
MUCH I AM AN EDUCATOR I'VE BEEN
WITH THE SECOND CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS.
AS AN EDUCATOR I AM TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF WHY WE NEED A MODEL
CURRICULUM THAT REPRESENTS THE
STUDENTS DEMOGRAPHIC THAT WE
SERVE.
IN ADDITION TO THAT I'M
REPRESENTING THE LAOTIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN WE
LEARNED THAT AS BE EIGHT NINE
FIVE PASS AND IT WAS NOT
INCLUSIVE.
THAT THE HISTORY WOULD BE
DEPICTED IN A WAY THAT IT'S AN
ACCURATE BECAUSE THE VIETNAM WAR
WHICH IS ALSO KNOWN AS THE
SECOND WAR A SECOND INDO CHINA
WAR WAS ALSO FOUGHT.
NOT JUST IN VIETNAM BUT WHICH
WAS ALSO FOUGHT IN LAOS AND
CAMBODIA AND TO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY LEVELS OUT OF THAT
HISTORY IS NOT WHAT WE WANT AS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE NEED
TO LEAD.
THE WAY IN TERMS OF MODEL
CURRICULUM FOR YOUNGSTERS SO --
BE HAVE OF THE LESION AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY BECAUSE IT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO SB EIGHT NINE
FIVE WAS AN OVERSIGHT AND YOU
THE LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE HERE.
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO WRITE
THAT OVERSIGHT AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY GOOD
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
COPYING CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO GO HERE WITH THE SOUTHEAST
ASIA RESOURCE ACTION CENTER AND
SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS LANI IS HE
WON'T SAY A VACATION AND I'M
ALSO REPRESENTING THE LAOTIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY -- FRESNO AND
WE ENCOURAGE AND I SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS COME MONEY MIGHT HAVE
LONG CITY.
OF FROM SAN FRANCISCO
REPRESENTING LYLE AMERICAN
CULTURAL CENTER THEY WERE CHIU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS NóI JENNA CAM
I REPRESENT LAO COMMITTEE
CULTURE CENTER FRESNO I'M A
FIRST GENERATION REFUGEE CAME TO
FRESNO OF FROM LAOS IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX I HAVE TWO
DAUGHTERS ARE NOW IN SIX AND
NINTH GRADE.
I WOULD LIKE MY DAUGHTERS TO BE
ABLE TO LEARN ABOUT ALLOW
HISTORY INVOLVING HIS SUPPORT
PLEASE YOUR NAME IN SUPPORT
PLEASE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS QUITE A QUITE AWAY
ALL CASES SUCH OUR TOP OF THE
PERCENTAGE WOULD ALLOW YOU ME
AND CULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS HAVE
FRANCISCO BAY AREA I WILL BE
STRONG.
SUPPORTER -- A. B. [inaudible]
FOR THE THIRTEEN NINETY THREE
THEM TO MAKE THAT IN A STUDENT
INSTEAD OF ALL STATE AND A
STRONG SUPPORTER BILL. THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE TO BE THE BEST
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI LORETTA MCFADDEN I'M A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND I IN SUPPORT.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS CHRIS AGAIN
JACKSON I'M ELEMENTARY EDUCATOR
IN SACRAMENTO HERE IN SUPPORT.
ZERO FROM THE HALF OF THE CSU
STANSTED ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENT STRONG SUPPORT.
JULIE SAID RICH I MEAN AS A
MAKES THAT IS DETERMINED TO
REPRESENTATIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
FLANAGAN BUT I STAND STATE
ALUMNI IN SOCIOLOGY AND ETHNIC
STUDIES AND I SUPPORT THIS.
HOW WE -- LASTED A CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY STANISLAUS AND
SUPPORT.
I NEED A DENTAL NAM SUPPORTING
LAW COMMUNITY IS GENERALLY
SUPPORT.
NEWS SAYING W. ONE COMPOSED OF
BILL -- COFOUNDER Là COMMITTEE
PUT ILLNESS ONLY SUPPORT A. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE BILLY
PARKER SENT.
OUR FIRST BORN US CITIZEN FROM
REFUGEE FAMILY.
TRANSPORT AB.
THIRTY NINE THREE HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME SO YEAH FEELS
A PARDON.
HI Là EVEN COMMUNITY I SUCCESS
SAID.
I SPOTTED THEM.
SB THIRTY NINETY SEVEN OR NINETY
THREE HELLO I'M TIFFANY BORN OF
LONG AND I'M A NINTH GRADER.
EMINA JOSH GOING ON FROM PORT OF
THOUGH AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
IN. THIRTEEN NINETY THREE
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE OKAY
DOCTOR REVENUE DESERVE CIVIL
RIGHTS AND HUMAN RIGHTS AND YOUR
SUPPORT.
BUT THE WEAPONS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TO
DOCTOR WEBER.
MIND YOU BRING YOUR FONG AN FROM
PORTABLE AND BY HIGH SCHOOL THAT
I GO TO IS HARD.
HOW MANY MAGNET CALAMY I SUPPORT
A. B.? THIRTEEN NINETY THREE MY
NAME IS PETER COMP -- TONE SAN
DIEGO LAO AGASSI ORGANIZATION OF
SAN DIEGO REPRESENTING.
FIVE LAO ANTI ARE NON PROFITS IN
SAN DIEGO OR STRONGLY SUPPORT
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE VOTE HI.
KEVIN KELSEY BELONG REPRESENTING
LAW COMMUNITY OF SAN JOSE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE SUSAN
HIM A COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES
CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE SO THAT MY PARENTS
SACRIFICES.
WILL BE LOST TO HISTORY IN VAIN
THANK YOU.
AND SANDY IN THE SANDY AG LEARN --
ELIGIBILITY SPECIALISTS WITH
TEAM ACCOUNTING DEPARTMENT SO
SERVICES AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB.
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THE END OF
OUR INCOME -- FROM THE HIT HIM
MY COUNTY A STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT.
AB.
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE HI H. AND
R. PETTIJOHN MANAGING EDITOR FOR
JAIL THE MAGAZINE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE THANK YOU.
I AM SANDRA I'M FROM PORTABLE
AND I SUPPORT STRONGLY.
HI MONEY MINE PULLED BUT THE AS
PART. THIRTEEN NINETY THREE
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME SAYS JOSE ABOUT HALF
FROM SACRAMENTO.
I SUPPORT A BEAT THE T..
NINETY THREE HI MY NAME'S SIDORA
EVIL RETIRED TEACHER FROM TO AND
WE WERE YOU KNOW VICE.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WORKING
THERE FOR TWENTY YEARS TEACHING
MATH THANK YOU I SUPPORT AB.
THIRTY NINETY THREE MY NAME
SADDAM CAM SONG I WILL PER
SECOND OR INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT
I SUPPORT THE BILL.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME WAS SO FONG CIVIL.
FROM A LOT ONE POWER SO SESSION
SACRAMENTO I SUPPORT.
RUBIO THIRTEEN NINETY THREE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY OTHER
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING HER MENTAL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE DR PAM.
THANK YOU AND I WANT THANK YOU
IS SOME OR WHATEVER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I KNOW THAT
MANY OF THE MEMBERS A LOCK ME
AND APPROACHED ME ACTUALLY ABOUT
pSAID WELL I HEARD THAT SEC.
I KNOW SOMEONE OR WHOEVER'S
DOING THE BILL WE SHOULD THAT
TWENTY OTHER BEHIND HER BILL AND
MAKES MUCH MORE SENSE TO DO IT
THAT WAY AND APPRECIATE -- YOU
LEADERSHIP CENTER WEBER AND US
CERTAINLY STAND STRONG SUPPORT
THE BILL I WOULD BE HONORED TO
BE A CO AUTHOR AND I THINK AND
THAT WOULD BE DEVELOPED
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN HAVE
CENTER GLAZER IN THE CENTER
CHIANG [inaudible]
SENATE CHECK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH HER MANAGER
WOMAN I ALSO WANT TO ECHO DR
PENS -- COMMENTS AND WOULD LOVE
TO BE ADDED ON AS CO AUTHOR AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU CENTER CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU -- SO THE ANALYSIS
SAID TALKS ABOUT YOUR BILL IN
GREAT DETAIL IN TERMS OF THE
PROCESS THAT THE OF COMMITTEES
BOTH HOUSES OF CRIED TO SET UP
IN REGARD TO THESE TYPES OF
THINGS -- AND BUT ALSO IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT GOES THROUGH THE
PROCESS THAT THE INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION IS GOING
THROUGH. TO TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON
SENATOR WINS BILL FROM.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND SO I
WANTED TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SELL YOUR
SUPPORTERS TO COMMENT ON THAT.
SO A FEW LOOK ON PAGE THREE IT
IT IT LAYS DOWN BY DATE THAT --
HOW THEY'RE FOLLOWING THROUGH ON
THAT REQUIREMENT AND -- THEY
WERE AT A PERIOD OF TIME IT
APPEARS WHERE THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO OF PRESENTED DRAFT CURRICULUM.
FOR PUBLIC REVIEW IS SET OUT IN
IS THAT BEEN -- AVAILABLE FOR
YOU TO SEE NO IT'S NOT OUT YET
OKAY.
SO I GUESS ONE OF THE THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE IS THAT.
THEY COULD VERY WELL IN INCLUDE
LAOTIAN HISTORY IN THAT REVIEW --
IN THAT CORRECT THAT DRAFT
CURRICULUM.
AND SO IT RAISES A QUESTION AT
AND THE ANALYSIS RAISES THIS
QUESTION IS THAT SHOULD WE ALLOW
THAT PROCESS TO RUN ITS COURSE
AND SEE WHETHER AN INJUSTICE OR
AND AN OVERSIGHT IS IS YOU
DESCRIBED IN TERMS OF THE NEED
FOR THE BILL.
REALLY IS PRESENT THAT THEY
COULD VERY WELL INCLUDED ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU WANT TO INCLUDE.
IN THAT DRAFT CURRICULUM THAT
WITH THAT IS THAT A FAIR
OBSERVATION THEY COULD.
AND THEY COULD NOT [inaudible]
NOT [inaudible]
OF ONE OF THE CHALLENGES OF
COURSE IS -- TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS INCLUDED IN IN A
PRESS IN A IN A IN A JUDICIOUS
MAN AN APPROPRIATE TIME RATHER
THAN WAITING TO SEE IF THERE'S
GONNA BE A FALL OUT AND IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN THEN WE COME BACK.
IT WAS CLEAR THAT WAS NOT AT IT
OKAY AND IT WAS AN OVERSIGHT FOR
EVERYONE WHO WAS INVOLVED
BECAUSE I THINK THERE WAS SOME
OTHER OVERSIGHTS IN PEOPLE THAT
IN.
AND 
OF THE OF THE LAW COMMUNITY.
THEY YOU KNOW THEY'RE AS THEIR
CONCERN IS THAT THEY ARE QUIET
GROUP OF PEOPLE OFTENTIMES NOT
INVOLVED IN THE POLITICAL
PROCESS WHEN THEY CAME TO ME.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY WANTED TO
BE INCLUDED IN A DISCOVERED THAT
EVERYBODY ELSE WAS NAMED EXCEPT
FOR THEM.
AND AND SO WE LOOKED AT VARIOUS
WAYS OF HOW WE CAN APPROACH IT
WHETHER WE WOULD JUST GO AND TRY
TO DO IT IN A BACK WAY OR
WHATEVER AND WE SAID NO.
THEY NEEDED TO HAVE THEIR STORY
TOLD.
THEY NEED TO BE A PART OF THE
FISH A RECORD THEY NEED TO BE
INCLUDED BY THIS HOUSE SO THAT
WE WOULD ALWAYS RECOGNIZEWHO
THEY ARE.
AND IF THERE'S MORE THAN JUST
ONE GROUP OR TWO GROUPS THAT WE
TALKED.
TO AND SO WITH THAT IN MIND --
WE DECIDED TO DO THE BILL --
KNOWING THAT THIS PROCESS WAS
OCCURRING BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE WERE INVOLVED IN
THE IN THE IN THE COMEDIAN I'M
ON THE INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE NOW -- BUT WE KNOW
THAT IT'S THERE WE'VE BEEN ASKED
TO DO IT IN A TIMELY MANNER TO
HAVE IT INCLUDED WITHOUT WAITING
FOR SOMETHING TO GO WRONG AND
THEN CORRECT -- DOESN'T COST US
ANYTHING TO CORRECTED IN THE
BEGINNING TO DO THE INCLUSION
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY.
VERY GOOD AND I I I I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE THE BEST
OF INTENTIONS AND WHICH YOU'VE
ADVANCE THIS BILL.
THAT THE THE COMMITTEE --
ANALYSIS.
HE DOES THE DRESS THIS BROADER
ISSUE OF IDENTIFYING -- BUT WELL
DESERVED -- MATTERS OF HISTORY --
THROUGH LEGISLATION AND THEY SAY
THAT.
THAT -- BOTH HOUSES HAVE TRIED
TO AVOID THIS TYPE OF PARTICULAR
REQUEST.
AND IT SAYS THAT THE THAT THAT
THAT THEY THE GENERAL.
POLICY I DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW IT WAS LAID OUT --
DISCOURAGES MEMBERS FROM
INTRODUCING MEASURES THE CREATE
NEW MODEL CURRICULA NO QUESTION
IT DOES -- AND THE REASON WHY
THIS IS BECAUSE OF WHAT WE DID
LAST YEAR -- IF WE PROBABLY NOT
DONE THAT AND BASICALLY DECIDED
TO JUST RELY UPON THE CURRICULUM
COMMITTEE WE WOULD LET THAT GO
FORWARD -- BUT WE DIDN'T DO THAT
AND I THINK IN GOING FORWARD
BEYOND THIS OF PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT HOW THAT INSTRUCTIONAL
COMMITTEE OUGHT TO OPERATE.
AND AND SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN
SOME KIND OF WAY AND WE'VE HAD
SOME ISSUES WITH IT BUT UGH
GIVEN WHAT WE'VE ALREADY DONE
THIS IS AN EFFORT.
TO CORRECT WHAT WAS DONE LAST
YEAR -- THAT'S WHAT IT IS IS AN
EFFORT TO CORRECT WHAT WAS DONE
LAST YEAR BECAUSE THIS IS THE
PROCESS THAT THE OTHERS WILL BE
INCLUDED.
AND TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
INCLUDED THIS IS PROBABLY THE
BEST WAY FOR US TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU.
SENATE GLAZER MEMBERS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE DOCTOR WEBER SURE
I WANT TO THANK THE LAO
COMMUNITY FOR COMING UP AND FOR
BEING INVOLVED IN THIS -- THEY
CAME TO ME OVER YEAR AGO AND
THEY SAID THEY CAME BECAUSE I'M
A FIGHTER.
AND I FIGURED I'D WIN AND I SAID
WELL THIS IS NOT A REALLY HARD
FIGHT I'VE BEEN IN SOME HARD
FIGHTS BEFORE IT MOST OF YOU
KNOW THAT.
SO THIS IS NOT A HARD FIGHT BUT
I RESPECT THEM BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MANY OF THEM IN MY COMMUNITY
AND YOUR COMMUNITY AND AROUND
THE STATE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO DO.
THAT WHAT WE NEED TO DO WE NEED
TO DO IT CORRECTLY AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE IS
INCLUDED THEY WERE THE ONLY ONES
LEFT OUT.
AND SO WITH THAT IN MIND WE
DECIDED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
BILL AND THEY HAVE BEEN THIS IS
BEEN EMBRACED BECAUSE EVERYONE
REALIZES THAT IF YOU WANTED
LISTED RIGHT.
LET'S INCLUDE THEM AND NOT
EXCLUDE THEM UP AS AN OVERSIGHT
AND I WOULD HATE FOR US TO THINK
THAT WHILE WE WAIT FOR THE
PROCESS TO GO THROUGH AND THEN
DISCOVER THAT SOMETHING GETS
DROPPED AGAIN.
AND THEY'RE NOT THERE SO WITH
THAT IN MIND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOU I BILLS AB THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE THEY'LL THE LAOTIAN
AMERICAN HISTORY CURRICULUM
PROPOSAL THAT'S HERE.
AND THAT THEY BE INCLUDED WITH
THE OTHERS AS THEY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOUR SUPPORTER
SOMETIMES I THINK YOU SHOULD PUT
US SUPPORT MY BILLS AND PRESENT
MY BILLS.
YOU CAN PICK A BETTER AUTHOR.
THE OTHER DAY THE THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY US SENATOR PAN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM TWENTY A. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE WELL HI WILK I CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE LASSELL WHO DOES SO I
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN PAN.
I WILL ADD THOSE NAMES IN
APPROPRIATIONS THOSE WANT TO BE
ADDED VERY GOOD THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT
ON CALL THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE'RE HERE IN SENATE
EDUCATION LOOKING FOR AUTHORS
COME ON DOWN.
WE'RE WAITING WE WILL DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ON CAN THANK
YOU.
ON CONSENT WE HAVE ITEM FIVE AB
ONE TWENTY FIVE ITEM SIX AB
THREE TWENTY ITEM ELEVEN AB TEN
NINETY EIGHT ITEM FOURTEEN AB.
TWELVE THIRTY THREE ITEM
NINETEEN AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX A
CONSENT AS AMENDED ITEM THIRTEEN
AB.
TWELVE TWENTY NINE OF THE
CONSENT COUNTER HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR WILK MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LEAVE THEM HI LEYVA AYE WILK HI
I CHANGE CHIANG I'D WRESTLED.
WITH US SO I GLAZERS.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT BUT WE WILL WAIT FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON
OKAY [inaudible]
YES
[inaudible]
BUT OKAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I AM SORRY I
WOULD ALMOST OVERLOOKED YOU GOOD
STAFFING SEVEN OR AGUIAR-CURRY
COME ON DOWN LOOKS LIKE YOU RAN
OVER THANK YOU.
YOU ALMOST MADE IT MISTER JONES
SAWYER.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
FILE ITEM TEN AB TEN THIRTY SIX
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
[inaudible]
HEY.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I WILL START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
EVERY EFFORT WE MAKE TO REDUCE
BARRIERS BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENS AND UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES HOLDEN
COURAGE FULLER PARTICIPATION.
IN OUR TO MARCUS DEMOCRACY
INCLUDING THE CENSUS.
AB TEN THIRTY SIX WILL REDUCE
BARRIERS TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS IN TWO WAYS.
FIRST IT REQUIRES THE SECRETARY
OF STATE TO UPDATE EXISTING
REGULATIONS DIRECTING COUNTY
OFFICIALS TO DEVELOP VOTER
OUTREACH PROGRAMS SECOND.
AB TEN THIRTY SIX CREATES A HIGH
SCHOOL VOTER EDUCATION PILOT
PROGRAM AND YOLO COUNTY.
POSTERS GOT ME.
THE PILOT WILL STUDY MOCK
ELECTIONS AT HIGH SCHOOLS INYO
COUNTY CONDUCTED WITH OFFICIAL.
ELECTIONS EQUIPMENT LIKE VOTING
MACHINES AND BALLOTS THIS TYPE
OF MARKET ELECTION IS AFFECTED
FOR TEACHING YOUNGER GENERATIONS
HOW TO CAST A BALLOT SO THEY ARE
EXCITED AND CONFIDENT WHEN THEY
GO THE FIRST POLL.
CREATING THIS PILOT WILL
LEGITIMIZE THE EFFORTS OF YOLO
COUNTY HIM SURE.
THE RESULTS OF THIS PROGRAM CAN
FORM AND IMPROVE MOCK ELECTIONS
STATEWIDE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WELL DONE ASSEMBLY WOMAN WELL
DONE.
AND HE'S ARE SWOLLEN AND NINE
WANT TO SIT DOWN WE DO HAVE
MICROPHONES OF THE CHAIRS -- ANY
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCHOTHERS IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS WE
HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR CHIANG
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR FIVE
VOTE AND PERFECT.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR CHIANG MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM TEN AB
TEN THIRTY SIX THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILK.
WILK I CHIANG CHIANG I'D RUSSELL
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU FORGET OVER HERE SO QUICKLY.
MY EXERCISE PROGRAM TOMORROW.
ALL RIGHT MISTER JONES SAWYER
YOU HEALTH FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB.
TWELVE NINETEEN BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AB TWELVE NINETEEN WILL REQUIRED
THAT ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
INCLUDING CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
MONITORED FOR TEACHER MISSUS I'M
IN AT ANNUALLY.
AND TWENTY IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR
HISTORIC CIVIL RIGHTS VICTORY --
WILLIAMS FIRST CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT FOUND
THIS CERTAIN FACTORS AMONG THEM
QUALIFIED TEACHERS ARE
FUNDAMENTAL TO ENSURE A STUDENT
SUCCESS.
AS A RESULT OF THE SETTLEMENT
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING CREDENTIALING
BECAME RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING
THAT TEACHERS HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE CREDENTIALS FOR THE
COURSES THEIR TEACHING.
HOWEVER ONLY THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SCHOOLS UNDER THE
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE INDEX WERE
REQUIRED TO BE MONITORED
ANNUALLY RESEARCH OVER MANY
DECADES HAVE MADE ONE THING VERY
CLEAR.
THE PRESENTATION AND
CERTIFICATION OF TEACHERS IS THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT PREDICTOR
OF STUDENT SUCCESS.
THE PROPER ASSIGNMENT OF TEACHER
IS ESPECIALLY -- IMPORTANT WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR HIGH POVERTY
SCHOOLS BECAUSE THE MISA SIMON
OF TEACHERS IS MORE COMMON THERE.
ADDITIONALLY MISSES SIGN
TEACHERS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
LEAVE THE PROFESSION.
CREATING AN UNSTABLE AND LESS
EFFECTIVE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
FOR STUDENTS WHO NEED THE MOST
SUPPORT.
AB TWELVE NINETEEN AUTHORIZES
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING TO UTILIZE
EXISTING FUNDS TO MONITOR
TEACHER ASSIGNMENTS AND ALL
SCHOOLS TO AN AUTOMATED DATA
SYSTEM.
DISTANCE INFORMATION WILL BE
USED TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS MY
TEACHER QUALIFICATIONS THE
HIGHLIGHT SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT
PROPERLY ASSIGN THEIR TEACHERS.
MEMBERS AB TWELVE NINETEEN WILL
PROVIDE ADVOCATES AND LAWMAKERS
THE ABILITY TO HOLD SCHOOLS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR FAILING TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH A QUALITY
EDUCATION STUDENTS ARE
GUARANTEED UNDER OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE.
MICHELLE PEARL.
WITH THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU AND I'M GONNA KEEP IT
SHORT BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
VERY LONG MORNING AND I'M NOT
ONE TO JUST REITERATE SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THEY HAVE MENTIONED AGAIN MY
NAME'S MICHELLE CRAWLED I'M THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES DIVISION
DIRECTOR FOR THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING AND WE ARE
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
AB TWELVE NINETEEN A IS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED WILL
HELP US TO AUTOMATE OUR STATE
ANNUAL ASSIGNMENT MONITORING
PROCESS ALLOWING US TO EXAMINE
ALL K. TWELVE TEACHERS
ASSIGNMENTS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS A PAPER
DRIVEN SYSTEM -- AND IT IS IS
MENTIONED TIED TO THE STATE API
SCORE WHICH IS AS WE KNOW NO
LONGER RELEVANT SO THE STATUTE
NEED SOME CLEAN UP.
IN ADDITION THE ANNUAL
MONITORING IS NECESSARY IS
MENTIONED TO COMPLY WITH A
FEDERAL REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
UNDER ESTARá.
AND TO PROVIDE A GREATER
TRANSPARENCY TO TEACHER
ASSIGNMENTS OF FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE PUBLIC ACROSS
THE STATE WITH THAT OLD.
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
VERY MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ISABEL ISABEL GARCIA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
CATHERINE OF ARAGON ON BEHALF OF
COPYING CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER IN
SUPPORT.
PHYLLIS I CURRENTLY HAVE A
PUBLIC ADVOCATES WERE CURRENTLY
A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION
WE'RE CONCERNED ELEAZAR DO NOT
HAVE AN OBLIGATION.
TO CORRECT MATH ASSIGNMENTS AS
THEY DO UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THANK YOU.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF
EDUCATION JUST WEST IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL.
MADAM CHAIR JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON
THE ACCOUNT CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION FIRST LIKE
DOT -- THINK THE AUTHORED IS
STAFF THE DATA OPEN DOOR POLICY
ON THIS BILL AND FEDERALLY GOOD
DISCUSSIONS -- WE DO HAVE A FEW
TECHNICAL CONCERNS AROUND
SERVICE CREDENTIALS AND NON CORE
THAT WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS I BELIEVE THE
SPONSORS ACTUALLY HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH. ONE OF OUR
PEOPLE TODAY SO -- WE WE LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT CURRENTLY ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS CONVERSATION.
SIX THANK YOU ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
WE HAVE A MOTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WHICH I TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- OPEN WE'RE I THINK WE
ALL WANT THE BEST TEACHERS IN
BOTH CHARTERS PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
AND IS THIS COMMITTEE I THINK
WE'RE ALL GOING TO WORK TOGETHER
TO ENSURE THAT AND AT IT THIS
BILL MAKES AS COMMITTEE I
GUARANTEE YOU THAT.
WE WILL RESOLVE ALL ISSUES ARE I
THINK WE'RE WELL.
ON OUR WAY TO TO HAVING THAT --
GET TO THAT POINT SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE BOAT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR DORADO
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HIM TWELVE AB TWELVE NINETEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEAVE A AYE WILK CHANGE CHIANG
I'D TO WRESTLE THE RUSSELL AYE
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME
EMILY WOMAN RAY IS AND THE SAME
OLD WE GOT A WHOLE SLEW OF YOU
OKAY -- TECHNICALLY GIBSON IS
FIRST.
YES WE'RE GOING FILE ITEM ORDERS
SO SORRY FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB NINE A ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON.
PLEASE BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATORS.
LET ME START OFF BY I'M TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS.
IN THE COMMITTEE.
CONSISTENT WITH THE ANALYSIS AND
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR.
AND THE STAFF WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY WITH US. TO IMPROVE
THIS BILL THERE WAS A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AB NOT A ONE WHICH SEEKS TO
ENCOURAGE.
APPROPRIATE INTERVENTION FOR
YOUTH WHO ARE AT RISK OPPOSED TO
BEING CRIMINALIZED ON THE BASIS
OF TRUANCY.
AND OTHER BEHAVIOR ISSUES.
WHICH ARE UNRELATED.
TO ACTUAL CRIMES [inaudible]
IN. NINETEEN EIGHTY AND THE
NINETIES FUELLED EIGHT TOP ON
CRIME APPROACH WHICH EXPANDS OF
LONG PRISON SENTENCE.
YOU THE TRANSFERRING INTO ADULTS
SYSTEMS.
AND THE ADOPTION OF LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE SENTENCE FOR JUVENILES.
THE MOST THIS MOSTLY TARGET
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND LATINO
YOU'VE.
WHAT ARE JUSTICE OUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS EXPERIENCING A
DRAMATIC CHANGE EXPRESSLY
LOOKING AT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL SHIFTING TOWARDS THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN?
SERVICE AGENCY.
WITH THIS IN MIND WE MUST KEEP
MOVING FORWARD.
ON EARLY PREVENTION AND
DETERRENCE.
AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL SEEKS
TO REDUCING THE CRIMINALIZATION
OF YOUTH BY.
ONE CLARIFYING THE SCOPE OF
PROBATION DEPARTMENT REFERRING
TO YOUTH AND TO DIVERT AND A
DIVERSION PROGRAMS.
TO AND REMOVING TRUANCY AS THE
BASIS OF A CRIED.
AB NOT ALL.
ONE WOULD ENSURE THAT YOUTH
RECEIVING APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTION.
ARE NOT CAUGHT UP IN THE COURTS
IN THE COURTS FOR TYPICAL CHILD
ADOLESCENT BEHAVIOR.
THIS WILL HELP US TO CORRECT THE
MISTAKES OF THE PAST AND PUSH US
FORWARD TOWARDS RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS IRVING --
COURT COULD OWN A WITH THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION AND ANGELA
TURNER WITH THE PUBLIC COUNSEL
WHO WAS SELF INTRODUCE.
SORRY WE WERE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT ROOM ARRANGEMENTS AD
SETTINGS ARE GOING TO BE MOVING
HERE SHORTLY.
PLEASE PROCEED TO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH.
MORNING MY NAME IS IRVINE CORD
ON I'M A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT.
AND A YOUTH ORGANIZER EITHER
JUSTICE COALITION.
WE HONOR TO BE CO SPONSORS OF
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE A ONE THAT
WILL IN THE PRACTICE OF
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE.
THAT PUT YOU WHO HAVE NEVER BEEN
CHARGED WITH A CRIME UNDER
PROBATION SUPERVISION.
INCLUDING REPORT INTO A
PROBATION OFFICER BEING PART OF
A PROBATION CASE LOAN OR HAVING
TO FOLLOW PROBATION CONDITIONS.
IT IS SOMETIMES CALLED VOLUNTARY
PROBATION BUT IN OUR EXPERIENCE
IT'S NOT VOLUNTARY.
IN LA COUNTY.
WE ORGANIZE INTO THIS PRACTICE
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
THOUSANDS OF YOUTH IN LA COUNTY
ALONE WERE REPORTING TO A
PROBATION OFFICER. 81% OF THE
81% FOR SCHOOL ATTENDANCE OR LOW
GRADES.
INSTEAD OF GETTING TUTORING OR
COUNSELING THAT WE DESERVE WE
DON'T GET.
YOU FOR PUT ON VOLUNTEER
PROBATION REPORT TO THE SAME
PROBATION OFFICERS.
BASS HE WOULD -- HAVE JUVENILE
CASES.
CERTAINLY YOU FOR STRUGGLING
ACADEMICALLY ARE SEEN BY OTHER
STUDENTS STAFF AND THE SYSTEM AS
CRIMINALS.
I KNOW THIS FIRST HAND AS I WAS
A PERSONAL STRUGGLE IN SCHOOL
AND THEN GET ACADEMIC SUPPORT
WHEN I WAS PUT ON COURT ORDERED
PROBATION.
MY FIRST COURSE IS SPECIAL AT
THE AGE OF THIRTEEN FOR CUTS IN
CLASS.
AS AN IMMIGRANT I WAS LEARNING
ENGLISH AND WAS PRACTICING YOU
WORDS I HAD LARNED I TRIED TO
APOLOGIZE BUT THE IN SCHOOL
SUSPENSION FOR TWO DAYS.
AND HAD TO FACE THE WALL IN
RIGHT I WILL NOT BE
DISRESPECTFUL THREE HUNDRED
TIMES.
AFTER I STARTED TO FEEL INSECURE
AND FEAR FOR SCHOOL.
I WAS.
AND IT FOR SKIPPING CLASS.
INSPECTIONS LET ME FURTHER
BEHIND EMBARRASSED I WOULD SIT
IN THE STADIUM BLEACHERS DURING
CLASS UNTIL SCHOOL POLICE
OFFICER WOULD DRAG ME TO THE
PRINCIPAL'S OFFICE. FOR MORE
SCHOOL SUSPENSIONS.
ON THE DAYS I WAS SUSPENDED ON
SUPERVISED BY WORKING PARENTS I
STARTED DRINKING AND SMOKING
MARIJUANA.
AT AGE SIXTEEN I WAS AT A PARK
DURING SCHOOL HOURS WHEN A
POLICE OFFICER JOE BY.
I WAS ARRESTED HOUSING AND SO
TWO YEARS PROBATION THE JUDGE
TOLD ME THAT IT WAS MANDATORY
FOR ME TO ROLL IN SCHOOL.
BUT I WAS NEVER SUPPORTED BY MY
PROBATION OFFICER [inaudible]
THAT'S FINE. TO FIND A SCHOOL.
I ONLY THEIR WEEKLY CHECK INS
AND DRUG TESTED.
I WAS DETAINED FOR THE FIRST
TIME WHEN I AND MY WHEN I WAS
LATE TO MY PROBATION APPOINTMENT
FOR THE CRIMINALIZATION OF
TRUANCY AS OPPOSED TO PROVIDING
YOU WITH.
REAL EDUCATION SUPPORTS IS ALSO
ADDRESSED BY EIGHTY NINE A ONE I
WAS RELEASED FROM JUVENILE HALL
WITHOUT PROBATION REFERRING ME
TO SCHOOL.
N. S. SO FAR BEHIND I THOUGHT I
WAS NO LONGER A SCHOOL WAS NO
LONGER FOR ME.
EVENTUALLY I STARTED DOING MORE
SERIOUS CRIMES.
I WANT THE STATE PRISON AT AGE
EIGHTEEN FOR CARJACKING.
CAN THE ADULT SYSTEM I WAS
OVERWHELMED BY RACIAL
SEGREGATION AND POLITICS OF
GANGS.
SOMETHING I'VE NEVER BEEN A PART
OF I WAS SEXUALLY AND PHYSICALLY
ASSAULTED LIKE MOST YOUTH IN
OCTOBER JAILS AND PRISONS.
HOUSE FOR SYFY AND COSTLY TO
PROVE MYSELF.
I WAS IN A WEAK PERSON NO YOU
SHOULD EVER FEEL SO THE PRESS.
HOPELESS AND FULL OF YOURS I DID.
SINCE RETURNING HOME FROM PRISON
pI HAVEN'T WROTE IN HIGH SCHOOL
WHEN I AM NEARLY FINISHED.
I'M WORKING PART TIME.
I'M STILL FAR BEHIND.
IT'S NOT A SURPRISE TO ME THAT
85% OF PEOPLE INCARCERATED
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
DON'T HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
I NOW SEE INSTEAD OF COLLEGE
PREPARATION I GOT PRISON
PREPARATION ARE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON AB.
ONE OH NINE AND PROBATION
SUPERVISION FOR YOU WHO HAVE
NEVER BEEN ACCUSED OF CRIMES.
AND IT IS IMPORTANT STEP IN
DISMANTLING THE SCHOOL TO JAIL
TRACK THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
AND I WANT TO APOLOGIZE THAT WE
LET YOU DOWN THE SYSTEM LET YOU
DOWN SO I THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THE COURAGE TO BE HERE AND I
HOPE THAT THIS BILL.
WILL MAKE IT BETTER FOR OTHERS
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY SHAHRAM NOT
ANGELA TURNER ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD
CO SPONSORS OF AB -- NINE OH ONE
THE ISSUES AND THAT NINE OH ONE
ADDRESSES CAME TO THE ATTENTION
OF THE ACLU AS A RESULT OF OUR
WORK IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY --
THERE BETWEEN THE YEARS OF TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT PLACED OVER
THREE THOUSAND CHILDREN ON
PROBATION CONTRACTS. FOR NORMAL
YOUTHFUL BEHAVIOR BASED ON THE
BROAD AUTHORITY GRANTED UNDER
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTION.
SIX FIFTY FOUR TOGETHER WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW WE
FILED SUIT AGAINST THE COUNTY OF
RIVERSIDE OVER THE VIOLATIONS TO
THE RIGHTS OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
THERE -- BASED ON THIS PROGRAM --
SADLY WE HAVE ALSO FOUND OUT
THAT THESE PRACTICES ARE GOING
ON THROUGHOUT THE STATE UNDER
BOTH -- SECTION SIX FIFTY FOUR
AND SECTION.
TWO THIRTY SIX YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
OFTEN REFERRED TO PROBATION FOR
VIOLATIONS OF WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE SIX OH ONE
WHICH MAKES IT AN OFFENSE FOR
JUVENILE TO BE TRUE AND OR TO
PERSISTENTLY OR HABITUALLY
REFUSE TO OBEY THE REASONABLE
AND PROPER.
ORDERS OF SCHOOL AUTHORITIES.
REASONS FOR PLACING IS ON
PROBATION IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
HAVE INCLUDED CREE DELINQUENT
SCHOOL MISBEHAVIOR INCORRIGIBLE
EDDIE DEFIANCE OR EVEN POOR
GRADES.
IN ONE CASE A STUDENT WAS PLACED
ON PROBATION FOR BEHAVIOR
RELATED TO THE GRIEF.
FROM THE DEATH OF A BABY SISTER.
ENFORCEMENT FALLS
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON STUDENTS
OF COLOR AGAIN THESE ARE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE NOT COMMITTED
CRIMES.
ONCE REFERRED YOUTH AND THEIR
PARENTS ARE OFTEN TOLD IF THEY
DON'T AGREE TO PROBATION THEIR
CASES COULD BE REFERRED TO THE
DA ALTHOUGH IN MOST OF THESE
CASES THERE IS NO OFFENSE FOR
WHICH A PETITION WOULD BE FILED.
UNDER SECTION SIX FIFTY FOUR IN
FROM FORMAL PROBATION PROGRAMS
OPERATE WITH NONE OF THE
SAFEGUARDS OF JUDICIAL PROCESS
SUCH AS ACCESS TO COUNSEL OR
ADEQUATE NOTICE OF THE CHARGES
OR UNDERLYING FACTS OR ANY KIND
OF IMPARTIAL DECISION MAKER.
YOUNG PEOPLE END UP ON PROBATION
CONDITIONS THAT ARE OFTEN MORE
PUNITIVE THAN WHAT A JUDGE WOULD
ASSIGN.
YOU THE GREEDY TERMS INCLUDING
SEARCHES OF THEIR PERSONS AND
HOMES AS WELL AS RANDOM DRUG
TESTING WE KNOW THAT THIS KIND
OF SURVEILLANCE BASED PROGRAM
DOES NOT WORK WITH USED TO
PREVENT FUTURE MISBEHAVIOR.
AND INSTEAD PUSHES YOUNG PEOPLE
INTO THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
STUDENTS ACCUSED OF SCHOOL
MISBEHAVIOR OR LOW LEVEL
OFFENSES SHOULD BE REFERRED TO
APPROPRIATE COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICE PROVIDERS NOT TO
PROBATION. EIGHTY NINE A ONE
LIMIT THE USE OF VOLUNTARY
PROBATION TO THOSE CASES WHERE
IT IS APPROPRIATE. TO ENSURE
MORE EFFECTIVE AND SUPPORT OF
OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WE
URGE YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE WAY
OVER TIME IF YOU CAN ADD YOUR
NAME AND SUPPORT PLEASE I'M JUST
CAN GO FROM THE JUST COALITION
JUST IN CASE THERE'S TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE.
NAME ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT
PLEASE.
KAELIN DEAN WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AT
POLICY LINK PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THE BILL.
NEARLY ROPE ON BEHALF OF THE SEA
ISSUE STANSTEAD ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENT I SUPPORT A. B..
NINE ZERO ONE DAPHNE DESIGNING
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
LORELAI STRIP NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW AND SUPPORT.
JULIE SO REGION WITH A CERTAIN
EXPERTISE THAT CSU STANISLAUS
AND EIGHTY TOLD DELEGATES IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ANGELA TURNER PUBLIC COUNCIL IN
PRAGUE COSPONSOR STRONG SUPPORT.
FRANCESCA SHE WHEN NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW IN STRONG
SUPPORT -- THE LASTED A
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
STANISLAUS A STRONG SUPPORT.
SELENA CONTENT STAND STATE
ALUMNI IN STRONG SUPPORT.
A YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION PRO
COLD SPONSOR IN SOLIDARITY WITH
IRVING AND OTHER FOLKS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
MALINA ABDUL THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS RESPONSE WICH OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND OUR YOUTH
ORGANIZATION THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM NETWORK AND STRONG SUPPORT.
DAVID TENNANT BY THE SUN CELLS
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT SO YOU
ARE JUST.
AND STRONG CSU STANISLAUS
SUPPORT.
TIM'S MCFADDEN -- ANY STATE'S
MAJOR SAYS ALL STATE INTEREST OF
FULL SUPPORT. TO BE THE BEST
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THIRTY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
WE COULD JUST MAKE A LITTLE ROOM
BECAUSE SAY THEY'RE JUST MOVE ON
TO THE OTHER SIDE THAT BE FINE.
MAKE SOME ROOM UP HERE. TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF WALKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
AND ALSO TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF THE KERN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
OUR POSITION ON THE BILL THAT IS
IN PRINT TO HIS OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
AND WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL POSITIVE
MEETINGS WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF
AND WITH THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL.
IN THE ISSUES -- ARBOR THAT WE
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT ARE
OUTLINED ON PAGES EIGHT AND NINE
OF YOUR ANALYSIS AND IT HAS TO
DO WITH THE INTERACTION BETWEEN.
THE WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTIONS THAT ARE BEING AMENDED
BY THE BILL AND THE EDUCATION
CODE SECTIONS THAT GOVERN THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
THAT COUNTIES RECEIVE DISTURBS
SERVE STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS.
AFTER THE POSITIVE MEETINGS --
THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
SEE OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS.
CREATES A DIFFERENT STRUCTURE
THAN THAT WHICH CURRENTLY EXISTS
IN LAW BUT WE BELIEVE IT IS ONE
THAT WORKS -- PARTICULARLY THE
AMENDMENT TO EDUCATION CODE
SECTION TWO FIVE SEVEN FOUR
THERE'S A LITTLE MORE WORK TO DO --
OF WHAT MISTER DARNELL REFERS TO
ANY ANALYSIS AS CONFORMING
LANGUAGE BUT THAT'S REALLY JUST
A TECHNICAL ISSUE.
AND SO ONCE WE SEE THESE
AMENDMENTS AND PRINT AND
COMPLETE THAT WORK ON THOSE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS THERESA
DRY NECK I'M HERE -- FOR ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE -- I
ALSO WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL VERY --
FRUITFUL MEETINGS WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OFFICE DOWN
WITH THE CO SPONSORS.
AT THIS POINT WE ARE OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED AND I'D LIKE TO
START OFF BY SAYING WE SHARE IN
THE SPONSORS -- HOPE AND YOUR IS
THAT.
WHAT WE CAN DO AS DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS IS TO WORK?
IN ORDER -- TO KEEP YOUTH AND
YOUNG PEOPLE OUT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND WE KNOW THAT
ONE OF THE MAIN.
FACTORS IS THE LACK OF DAILY
ATTENDANCE AND NOT GRADUATING
FROM HIGH SCHOOL -- BUT WE'VE
BEEN WE'VE HAD OUR TRUANCY IN
ATTENDANCE PROGRAM FOR OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS NOW AND IT WAS IN
LARGE PART CREATED BY THE
REQUEST OF OUR EIGHTEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE COUNTY WHO CAME
TO US AND SAID.
WE HAVE DONE EVERYTHING FROM ANY
OF THESE FAMILIES THAT WE CAN WE
HAVE MET WITH THEM AT THE SCHOOL
SITE LEVEL AT THE SORT OF LEVEL.
AND YET AND HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO BRING THESE YOUNG PEOPLE BACK
INTO THE SCHOOL SETTING CAN YOU
PLEASE HELP AND WORK WITH US WE
ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT.
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE YOU YOU
FULLY SKIPPING A DAY HERE THERE
WERE TALKING ABOUT KIDS WHO ARE
MISSING.
HUNDRED A HUNDRED AND FIFTY FULL
DAYS OF SCHOOL EVERY SCHOOL YEAR
AND DESPITE ALL OF THE BEST
EFFORTS AT TIMES OF THE SCHOOLS
IN THE DISTRICTS.
THE CHILDREN AND THE FAMILIES
ARE STILL NOT COMPLYING WITH THE
MANDATES.
THEY'RE NOT TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE TUTORING OR THE COUNSELING
OR THE MENTORING THAT IS BEING
OFFERED AND WHEN THERE IS A
CARING.
PROCESS WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WITH THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT AND WITH
THE COURT THAT IS SPECIFICALLY
SET UP TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
WE DO HAVE SUCCESS WE SEE
SUCCESS IN OVER.
THE MAJORITY OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT COME BEFORE US WHO
OFTENTIMES NEVER MET WITH CASE
MANAGEMENT NEVER MET WITH HEALTH
CARE.
PROFESSIONALS NEVER MET WITH
GRIEF COUNSELORS AND THEY ARE
DOING SO.
THE CONNECTIONS THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO MAKE AND SO WE ARE ASKING
THATTHIS BILL BE AMENDED TO A
ALLOW FOR OUR PROCESS TO
CONTINUE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
OF TRUANCY MEDIATIONS WHEN
NECESSARY AND THAT WE SHOULD
STILL BE ABE TO BRING AT TIMES
THE VERY.
MOST SERIOUS SCHOOL ABSENTEEISM
SCHOOL TRUANCY CASES INTO A
COURT THAT IS SPECIFICALLY SET
UP AND DESIGNED AS A
COLLABORATIVE CARING WELL
INFORMED TRAUMA INFORMED TRUANCY
COURT SYSTEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
PERFECT.
THANK YOU ANDREA BALLING THE
HALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WE HAD
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED WERE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE STAFFS
WORK WITH US ALSO.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
BEFORE WE GET TO OTHER
OPPOSITION IS ONE LET EVERYONE
KNOW THAT IN THREE MINUTES WE
ARE BEING KICKED OUT OF THIS
ROOM BECAUSE SENATE BUDGET WILL
BE TAKING OVER HERE.
SO ASSEMBLY WOMAN RAY AS WE WILL
RECONVENE IN TWENTY FORTY AT ONE
THIRTY OPPOSITION PLEASE.
TV MATTHEWS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE ALSO POSE A
MUST AMENDED AND I LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
THERESA GENIC.
CODY BOILS ME HALF THE CHEAPER
VERSION OFFICERS CALIFORNIAN
OPPOSITION.
KAREN LAYING OUT OF THE SOLANO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO
THE PREVIOUS VERSION OF THE BILL
HOPEFULLY WITH THE AMENDMENTS
BEING TAKEN TODAY THEY COULD
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU SOME.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
MEMBER OF HIS STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THESE
AMENDMENTS.
AS ADOPTED I BELIEVE THAT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSE POSITION ON THE MEASURE
AND LOOK FOR THE FOR THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ACTUALLY HERE
IN SUPPORT AND RUN FAST ENOUGH
TO GET HERE BUT I'LL HANDLE THEM
ON BEHALF OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER OPPOSITION
CITY IN HEARING THAT WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS QUESTIONS CONCERNS
SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU AND SOME MEMBER GIPSON
A LOT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL.
FOR UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO NOTE
THAT TO MY COUNTY IT OPPOSES --
THE THE BUILD BUT I AM GOING TO
BE SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL TODAY --
I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THOSE
THE EXCELLENT WORK OF OUR
PROBATION DEPARTMENT THE PATIENT
OFFICER SO I THINK THE A DAY --
HE'S TRULY INNOVATE HIS
DEPARTMENTS TRULY INNOVATIVE I
THINK THEY JUST RECENTLY IS
RECOGNIZED FOR WHAT THEY'VE DONE
WITH THE JUVENILE FACILITY.
BUT I ALSO BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT
WE SHOULD NOT -- CRIMINALIZE --
AS IS THE PURPOSE OF YOUR BILL
SO I I DO HOPE AND I NOW
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S SOME
MINUTES STATE COMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH -- I THINK
THOUGHT LEADERS LIKE TO
PROBATION SEALS HE'S -- HE'S
SOMEONE WHO REALLY I THINK
REALLY DOES WANT YEAH IT HAS A
RIGHT VALLEY'S WANTS TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND I SO I IS ONLY A
HOPE THAT.
BY THAT YOU IS THE AUTHOR AND WE
CAN TRY FIGURE OUT HOW TO WORK
TOGETHER ON SOME OF THESE THINGS
BUT I DO WANT TO SAY THAT TIME
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY EVEN THOUGH MY OWN COUNTY
OPPOSE IT BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
AND I THINK MAYBE WE CAN FIGURE
OUT HOW TO LAND AND IN THE SPOT
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE ALL SHARE
THE SAME VALUES ABOUT WHAT.
ABOUT.
HELPING OUR USE SO -- SO WITH
THAT NOW AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL TO PROTECT.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN SENATOR
WILK BECKY MADER CHARGES WHEN A
LINE MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES SINCE IT'S IT'S THE
ONE O'CLOCK HOUR SHALL BE VOTING
FOR YOUR BILL TODAY.
LOOKING FORWARD TO YOU WORKING
WITH ALL PARTIES TO BRING US A
PERFECT PRODUCT BACK.
WHEN I SEE IT ON THE FLOOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH?
THANK YOU AGAIN WANT TO THANK
YOUR WITNESS YOU COME HERE AND
TESTIFYING TODAY MAKES A HUGE
DIFFERENCE A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE
CAN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS AND WHAT MAY BE HAS GONE
WRONG.
SO WE'LL BE ABLE TO HELP OTHERS
BECAUSE YOU CAME FORWARD SO
THANK YOU JUST ONE APPRECIATE
YOU.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITHIN IN
THE INTERESTS OF TIME I'D IS ONE
OF OUR GOAL MY CLOTHES REMARKS
HIM TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
LINE.
MY COMMENTS WITH YOU WITH YOURS --
IRVING WE FAILED YOU WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN TO
ANY OTHER CHILD IN CALIFORNIA --
AND WE WILL DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT NO ONE FALLS
IN THE CRACKS AND MY PLEASURE TO
WORK WITH THOSE WHO'VE EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION -- SO THAT WE CAN GET
TO A POINT WHERE THEY'RE
COMFORTABLE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIMPLY
MEMBER THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM EIGHT EIGHTY NINE A ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILL WILK I CHANGED TO
RUSSELL RUSSELL I'D GLAZER
REQUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
VERY GOOD WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
BRIEF RECESS FOR SENATE
EDUCATION WE WILL RECONVENE AT
ONE THIRTY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME BACK TO
SENATE EDUCATION.
WE ARE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE A. B. SIXTEEN
SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
OF YOUR HELP ON THIS PARTICULAR
BILL.
I PRESENT AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX A
LATINO CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNTY
CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY OFFICE TO
PARTNER WITH LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO MAKE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
AVAILABLE AT SCHOOL SITES TO
STUDENTS PARENTS AND GUARDIANS.
AS MANY OF US KNOW THE TWENTY
TWENTY DECENNIAL CENSUS IS OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE WITH
PROPOSED CHANGES FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SUCH AS A
POTENTIAL.
ADDITION OF A QUESTION OF
CITIZENSHIP IS BECOMING.
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THE CALIFORNIA
MUST MAKE EXTRA EFFORTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT TO COMMUNITIES
REGARDLESS OF ETHNICITY OR
RESIDENT STATUS ARE PROPERLY
COUNTED.
AND RECEIVE THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
FEDERAL FUNDING.
SCHOOLS OFFER A SAFE HAVEN FOR
FAMILIES TO RECEIVE INFORMATION
REGARDING THE IMPORTANCE OF AN
ACCURATE COUNT AND CAN HELP TO
MITIGATE THE EFFECTS THAT MANY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FACE.
A HESITATION TO ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS FOR STRENGTH FROM
STRANGERS ABOUT THEIR FAMILY AND
HOUSEHOLDS.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE MY ENSURING THAT OUT
AT SCHOOL SITES FAMILIES BE
PROVIDED INFORMATION REGARDING.
THE IMPORTANCE OF COMPLETING THE
CENSUS THE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
POLICY SET FORTH BY THE U. S.
CENSUS BUREAU.
THE COMMUNITY BASED RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO ASSIST WITH
COMPLETING THE FEDERAL CENSUS
QUESTIONNAIRE.
HOW O ASSESS RESOURCES PROVIDED
BY THE US CENSUS BUREAU AND ANY
OTHER INFORMATION THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT CENSUS
TWENTY TWENTY HOUSE?
THIS BILL OUTLINES THE STATE'S
PRIORITY ON WHAT INFORMATION
SHOULD AT LEAST TO BE PROVIDED
TO THESE FAMILIES.
WHILE GIVING THE COMPLETE COUNT
OFFICE THE FLEXIBILITY TO ADD
MORE IF THEY SO CHOOSE.
HERE TO TESTIFY -- HE MAY SHOW
UP OKAY THERE IT IS.
ALL RIGHT ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
COME ON UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE STAFF OF PAMELA
GIVES REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
I CAN'T REALLY IMPROVE ON THE
SENATOR'S COMMENTS BUT WE TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND AS A BEING IN AN AREA THAT
IS THE HARDEST ACCOUNT REGION IN
THE NATION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL IN OUR DRIVE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN AS SOON
AS WE HAVE SOME MORE MEMBERS WE
WILL VOTE ON YOUR BILL AND I'M
SURE SOME WILL MAKE A MOTION TO
SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH
[inaudible]
CORY HERE -- YOU'RE PRESENTING
NUMBER GLORIA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YEAH IT'S ON CONSENT AND
GET IT -- CHANNEL MY INNER
TODDLER OKAY VERY GOOD ANYTHING
ELSE FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
TWO THIRTY EXCUSE ME NINE THIRTY
YEAH A LITTLE BIT.
NINE THIRTY SEE WHEN YOU'RE
READY OKAY OKAY OR DO YOU WANT
TO AT NINE THIRTY OR FOUR NINETY
THREE WELL TO FOUR NINETY THREE
I GOT IT SO WELL OKAY SEVEN AB.
FOR NINETY THREE SORRY ABOUT
THAT WE DON'T WORK ROOMS AND
LOSE IT AND YES OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YOU'RE
WELCOME AND MEMBERS OKAY --
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY THREE WILL
CREATE A MORE SUPPORTIVE AND
SAFE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR
LGBT Q. STUDENTS BY PROVIDING
TEACHERS WITH THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO SUPPORT OUR LGBT YOUTH.
BOTH AT SCHOOL AND IN THEIR
COMMUNITY DESPITE AN
OVERWHELMING INCREASING
HARASSMENT MANY LGBT STUDENTS TO
NOT REPORT THEIR TROUBLES TO
SCHOOL STAFF BECAUSE THEY
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT.
EFFECTIVE INTERVENTION WILL
OCCUR.
THIS IN RETURN CREATES AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE STUDENTS DO
NOT FEEL SAFE AND AREN'T ABLE TO
TRULY BE THEMSELVES.
THIS IS WHY IT IS CRITICAL THAT
TEACHERS AND STAFF BE EQUIPPED
WITH A TRADING TOOLS THEY NEED
TO SUPPORT OUR LGBTQ YOUTH.
AB FOR NINETY THREE SUPPORTS OUR
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS BY
REQUIRING ONLINE TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS OF GRADES.
SEVEN TO TWELVE AND ALL OTHER
CERTIFIED EMPLOYEES AT THOSE
SCHOOLS THE TRAINING WILL
INCLUDE SCHOOL SITE AND
COMMUNITY RESOURCES FIRST
SUPPORTING LGBT Q. STUDENTS. TO
TESTIFIED SUPPORT.
QUIPUS ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMAN'S
OFFICE AND VINCE POMPEII A
FORMER EDUCATOR AND ON BEHALF OF
A SEVEN MEMBER TODD GLORIA I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
GOOD TO ME TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE.
DEAR DEAR MEMBERS MY NAME IS.
SORRY YOUR TURN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DOCTOR VINCENT PALM PAY ON
I'M REALLY HONORED TO BE HERE
AND SPEAK OF SUPPORT OF AB.
FOUR NINETY THREE AS A FORMER
TEACHER SCHOOL COUNSELOR -- PAST
PRESENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL COUNSELORS
AND AUTHOR OF IN CALIFORNIA --
SHOULD BE TO YOUTH REPORT I KNOW
FIRST HAND THE DESPERATE NEED
FOR STAFF TRAINING ON SOME.
PARENTING HIGH LEVELS OF YOUR
BILLING AND FAMILY REJECTION BUT
VERY FEW ARE FINDING SUPPORT AND
AFFIRMATION FROM THEIR EDUCATORS.
A RECENT STUDY FOUND THAT ONLY
5% OF LGBT Q. STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA SAY THAT ALL OF THEIR
SCHOOL STAFF OR SUPPORTIVE OF
LGBT PEOPLE.
AND ONLY 32% SAY THAT THEY
ALWAYS FEEL SAFE IN THEIR
CLASSROOMS THIS IS CALIFORNIA
DATA.
ARE THESE CALIFORNIA'S
STATISTICS ARE TRULY
UNACCEPTABLE FOR ANY STUDENT OF
ANY POPULATION IN ANY STATE IN
OUR COUNTRY.
RESEARCH PROVES TIME AND TIME
AGAIN THAT WHEN STUDENTS FEEL
SAFE AND CONNECTED AT SCHOOL
THEIR ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT GOES
UP.
THEIR ATTENDANCE RISES AND THEIR
LIKELIHOOD OF GRADUATION GOES UP.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NO IN FACT
IS OFTEN IGNORED WHEN IT COMES
TO LGBT Q. STUDENTS.
AND I'M GONNA BE HONEST ARE
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THE SUBJECT
MATTER TYPICALLY MAKES DISTRICT
DECISION MAKERS UNCOMFORTABLE.
I WOULD NEARLY TWENTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
DISTRICTS ON THESE ISSUES I'VE
YET TO FIND A SCHOOL THAT A SAFE
AND WELCOMING PRETTY STUDENTS
WITH OUT MANDATORY STAFF
TRAINING.
I'M HAPPY TO SHARE THAT THE
HARDWORKING EDUCATORS OF
CALIFORNIA ARE HUNGRY FOR THIS
TYPE OF TRAINING -- THEY JUST
NEED THIS BILL TO PASS SO WE
MAKE THIS TRAINING A REALITY.
AB FOR NINETY THREE ISN'T ONLY
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
IT IS OUR ETHICAL OBLIGATION AS
INDIVIDUALS WHO CARE ABOUT ALL
STUDENTS I URGE YOU TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF THIS LIFESAVING BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DRINK WELL AS DIRECTOR
OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND
CALIFORNIA PART OF EDUCATION.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AND CO SPONSOR OF AB
FOR NINETY THREE IN SUPPORT.
THOSE STUDIES SHOW THAT WE HAVE
SO MANY STUDENTS ROUTE THE STATE
THAT ARE NOT PERFORMING AT
LEVELS THAT THEY ARE CAPABLE OF
DO NOT FEEL SAFE AT SCHOOL.
HAVE HIGHER RATES OF
HOMELESSNESS SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
SUICIDE.
WITH OUR KIDS SPENDING SO MUCH
OF THEIR YOUTH IN OUR HOMES CAN
YOU IMAGINE GOING TO A PLACE FOR
THAT MANY HOURS A DAY AND NOT
FEELING SAFE OR ACCEPTED.
STUDIES FURTHER SHOW THAT ONLY
32% OF LGBTQ YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA
ALWAYS FEEL SAFE IN THE
CLASSROOM.
AND THAT ONLY 10% OF LGBT Q.
YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA SEE THAT ALL
OF THEIR SCHOOL STAFF OR
SUPPORTIVE OF LGBTQ STUDENTS.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT WE CAN
DO BETTER.
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT WANTS
TO ENSURE THAT WE PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH SAFE AND
PRODUCTIVE LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS.
HE WANTS TO PRIORITIZE
CURRICULUM IN SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS THAT TEACH
TOLERANCE ACCEPTANCE AND PROMOTE
DIVERSITY.
AB FOR NINETY THREE WOULD HELP
BUILD THAT.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOLS WITH THE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THE LGBT Q.
STUDENTS SO THEY HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A QUALITY
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
IN A BEEN A BUYER MEANT THAT
SUPPORTS THEM FOR WHO THEY ARE.
WE WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIAAND QUALITY CALIFORNIA
FOR THEIR CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
PARTNERSHIP IN THIS IMPORTANT
EFFORT.
AND THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
MANAGER MEMBERS BRIAN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WAS FROM SUPPORT THANK
YOU SIR.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I AM LOOKING AT A SPROUT LGBT
COMMUNITY MEMBER AS WELL AS ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FEEL YOU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
MAKE.
ROOM FOR HER TO SIT DOWN WITH
BOTH OF THEM FOR THE GENERAL IF
YOU CAN JUST STEP BACK THAT
WOULD BE GREAT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT. TWO MINUTES EACH I'LL LET
YOU DECIDE WHO BEGINS.
UP AGAIN OKAY VERY GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RACHEL
BILSON AND I HAVE BEEN HONORED
TO BE TEACHING TKA THROUGH THIRD
GRADES AND THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS.
TODAY I'M SPEAKING AS AN
INDIVIDUAL.
I WOULD TAKE A BULLET FOR ANY
CHILD REGARDLESS OF THEIR RACE
RELIGION OR GENDER.
HOWEVER I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
FOUR NINE THREE IF AB FOUR NINE
THREE BECAME LAW IT MAY HAVE
HARMFUL EFFECTS ON MANY STUDENTS
AND THE RIGHTS OF EDUCATORS.
AND THE CLEARLY ELEMENTARY
GENDER TRAINING I RECENTLY
RECEIVED FOR GRADES T. K.
THROUGH.
EIGHT I WAS TOLD TO USE
PREFERRED PRONOUNS TO ADDRESS
STUDENTS TO STOP REFERRING TO
STUDENTS BY THEIR BIOLOGICAL
GENDERS AS BOYS AND GIRLS
AND TO TEACH SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND VARIOUS GENDER IDENTITIES.
ALL OF WHICH SEEK TO COURSE
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS TO ACCEPT
AN EXPRESS IDEAS ABOUT GENDER
AND GENDER IDENTITY THAT MAY
VIOLATE THEIR INDIVIDUAL BELIEFS
AND CONSCIENCES.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO SUBSCRIBE
TO THE GENDER BINARY WHICH IS
ROOTED IN OBJECTIVE BIOLOGY AS
OPPOSED TO SUBJECTIVE THOUGHTS
OR FEELINGS BIOLOGY IS NOT
BIGOTRY.
THIS BILL MAY VIOLATE THE
ESTABLISHMENT CLAUSE OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT WHICH REQUIRES
GOVERNMENT NEUTRALITY ON
RELIGION.
LGBT Q. TRAININGS OFTEN CAST
pRELIGIOUS BELIEFS OF MANY PUBLIC
SCHOOL EDUCATORS.
THE US SUPREME COURT HAD
DETERMINED THAT THE GOVERNMENT
THE GOVERNMENT.
PRESS IDEAS OR THOUGHTS WITH
WHICH THEY DISAGREE THE US
SUPREME COURT ALSO ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT PARENTS HAVE THE PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY TO RAISE THEIR
CHILDREN NOT THE STATE.
TOLERANCE IS A TWO WAY STREET
FAMILIES AND STUDENTS WHO HAVE
DIFFERENT VIEWS OF SEXUALITY AND
GENDER THAT ARE PROMOTED BY AB
FOUR NINE THREE FOR EXAMPLE
THOSE WHO ARE FIRM THE GENDER
BINARY.
MUST HAVE THEIR BELIEVES
TOLERATED IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THAT IS THE LAW IN IT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
THIS BILL WILL LIKELY LEAD TO
MORE FAMILIES AND STUDENTS
LEAVING OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO
JOIN GROWING RANKS OF PRIVATE
AND HOMESCHOOLS THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
SENATOR LEYVA AND OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
I AM DOCTOR LORI HAYNES
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGIST REFUSING
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS LISTED IN
MY HAND OUT WITH.
WE ALL WANT VICTIMIZATION FOR
LGBT STUDENTS AND STUDENTS ALL
STUDENTS TO DECREASE.
BUT AB FOUR NINE THREE WILL
CAUSE AN INCREASE.
AN ALARMING HARRIS POLL FOUND
THAT YOUNG ADULTS AGES.
EIGHTEEN TO THIRTY FOUR OUR
FEELING PROGRESSIVELY LESS
COMFORTABLE WITH LGBT Q.
INDIVIDUALS.
AND WITH AND WITH AFFIRMATIVE
EDUCATION.
THEY'VE HAD IT WAS A TAX ON THE
RIGHTS OF PARENTS WOMEN AND
GIRLS AND RELIGIOUS FREEDOM.
SO DOING THE SAME THING ONLY
MORE OF IT.
IS IN AB FOUR NINE THREE WILL
NOT END WELL.
THERE IS A BETTER WAY THE
GLISTEN SURVEY FOUND TRADITIONAL
RELIGIOUS SCHOOLS HAD THE LOWEST
BOWLING AND VICTIMIZATION OF L.
G. B. KEEP STUDENTS OTHER
BROACHES WORK.
THE GLISTEN SURVEY ALSO FOUND
MANY SCHOOLS ALREADY HAVE
GENERIC ANTI BULLYING POLICIES
TEACHERS AND MINISTERS JUST NEED
TRAINING TO ENFORCE THEM
EFFECTIVELY. TEN PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS SAY LGBTQ FEELINGS
ARE NOT JUST BIOLOGICALLY BORN
THAT WAY OR WHO SOMEONE IS THERE
A PSYCHOLOGICAL AND SOCIAL
INFLUENCES.
TO LGBT Q. AND QUESTIONING
FEELINGS COMMONLY DIMINISH OUR
RESOLVE FOR SOME MINERS BY
ADULTHOOD.
BUT SOCIAL AFFIRMATION BY
TEACHERS AND PEERS THAT AB FOUR
NINE THREE MANDATES LOCK IN LGBT
Q. FEELINGS THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
HAVE RESULT FOR MANY.
DO YOU WANT TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS.
BLOCKING AND TRANS GENDER
IDENTITY ST STUDENTS DONE A
TREATMENT PATH OF HORMONES AND
SURGERIES LEADING TO LOSS OF
SEXUAL PLEASURE.
FERTILITY ARRESTS IN
REPRODUCTIVE ORGANS AND HIGHER
RATES OF PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALIZATIONS DEATHS FROM
HEART DISEASE AND CANCERS.
I AM NINETEEN TIMES MORE
COMPLETED SUICIDES DO YOU WANT
TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS.
PLACE AB FOUR NINE THREE WITH A
TRULY INCLUSIVE AND SAFE POLICY
FOR ALL.
STUDENTS TEACHERS AND PARENTS
CAN GET BEHIND THAT IT COULD
WORK.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP TO THE MICROPHONE
THERE.
GREG BURKE WITH CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT I'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE BUT BEFORE I DO
THAT I JUST WANT TO SAY AS THE
PROUD MOTHER OF A GAY DAUGHTER I
FIND A LOT OF WHAT THE THE
OPPOSITION SAID TO BE QUITE
OFFENSIVE.
AND I THINK THAT IF WE AS A
SOCIETY DO NOT LEARN ABOUT OTHER
PEOPLE.
THAT IS ONE WE HAVE BULLYING AND
THAT IS WHEN WE HAVE PROBLEMS
AND I WILL PUT MY DAUGHTER UP
AGAINST ANYONE'S STRAIGHT
DAUGHTER WHICH WE HAVE A
DAUGHTER WHO IS STRAIGHT.
THEY ARE BOTH WONDERFUL YOUNG
WOMEN AND WHO SHE LOVES SHOULD
NOT CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT THE
WAY SHE LIVES HER LIFE SO THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL I
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
AND I WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
GOOD THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
WILL TAKE A VOTE AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I THINK YOU JUST
DID MY CLOSING.
ITEM SEVEN A. B. FOR NINETY
THREE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE WILK.
CHIANG WRESTLE WITH US SO I
GLAZER REQUIRES PAN.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB NINE THIRTY
THANK YOU WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS -- AB NINE THIRTY WILL
PROMOTE COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
TRANSPARENCY BY PROHIBITING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BOARD OF TRUSTEES FROM
INCREASING EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION.
IN YEARS WHEN STUDENT TUITION IS
INCREASED.
THE U. S. C. AT YOU SO US.
YOUTH.
YOU U. S. WE CSCO SORRY ABOUT
CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR CHANGES
TO THE SALARIES OF EXECUTIVES
VOTE TO INCREASE TUITION BY 5%?
FOR THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FISCAL YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY AND JULY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
VOTED TO INCREASE SALARIES FOR
PRESIDENTS BY 3% DESPITE
GOVERNOR BROWN'S.
URGE TO REJECT THE AUGMENTATIONS.
AB NINE THIRTY WOULD ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE BY REQUIRING THE
FOLLOWING.
FIRST EXECUTIVE PAY CANNOT
INCREASE IN YEARS IN WHICH THERE
IS A TUITION INCREASE SECOND ANY
CHANGES TO POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES OR INCREASES TO
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION MUST BE
PLACED ON THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
AGENDA. FOR AN INITIAL PUBLIC
HEARING.
WITH A VOTE TO TAKE PLACE AT THE
AT THE SECOND CONSECUTIVE
HEARING.
FINALLY CSU CHANCELLOR MUST
MANDATE EACH CAMPUS TO PREPARE
AND REPORT.
BY AN OLD COMPARISONS OF THE%
CAMPUSES BUDGET TO ITS ACTUAL
SPENDING LEVELS.
LAST YEAR WHICH WAS A HUGE WIN
IN SECURING STUDENT ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY AND EQUITY WITHIN
THE CSU SYSTEM WE MUST CONTINUE
THIS TREND BY PUTTING STUDENTS
FIRST. EIGHTY NINE THIRTY DOES
JUST THAT.
I WILL LET MY WITNESSES HERE
TESTIFY AND INTRODUCE THEMSELVES --
AND THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND ON BEHALF OF US IN
THE MEMBER TODD GLORIA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER EGAN ON
THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATIONS POLITICAL
ACTION AND LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
AND I'M A PROFESSOR OF
PHILOSOPHY AND PUBLIC AFFAIRS
AND ADMINISTRATION AT CAL STATE
EAST BAY.
I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AS THE SPONSOR OF AB. NINE
THIRTY EIGHTY NINE THIRTY SIX TO
ADDRESS A LONG STANDING PROBLEM
OF THE CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
IT'S LACK OF PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY
AND FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
AS WE ALL KNOW STUDENT TUITION
HAS DOUBLED OVER THE PAST DECADE
AND IF IT WASN'T FOR THE
INVOLVEMENT OF FORMER GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN AND CURRENT GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM.
STUDENT TO ISSUE STUDENT TUITION
WOULD HAVE CONTINUED TO INCREASE.
AS NOTED IN THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT RELEASED JUNE TWENTIETH
LAST YEAR THE CSU ACCUMULATED A
DISCRETIONARY SURPLUS WORTH MORE
THAN ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ITS OPERATING FUND.
A SURPLUS THAT HAS COME
PRIMARILY FROM STUDENT FEES AND
TUITION.
THE AUDIT CONCLUDED THAT
STUDENTS LACK THE INFORMATION
THAT WOULD HAVE ENABLED THEM TO
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT AND
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT THE NEED FOR
THOSE TUITION INCREASES. ONE OF
THE MAIN COMPONENTS OF AB NINE
THIRTY IS TO PROVIDE AND A
WINDOW FOR MEANINGFUL PUBLIC
COMMENT PRIOR TO BOARD ACTION
WHEN MAKING DECISIONS ON
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION -- AND TO
PROHIBIT EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION
FROM INCREASING IN YEARS IN
WHICH STUDENT TUITION GOES UP.
THE REASON FOR THIS IS THAT
APPROXIMATELY 50% OF THE CS USE
ANNUAL OPERATING BUDGET IS
FUNDED BY STUDENT TUITION.
AND ITS EXECUTIVE OFFICERS ARE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. FOR THE MORE
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY REQUIRES ALL
TWENTY THREE CSU CAMPUSES TO
SUBMIT BI ANNUAL BUDGET REPORTS
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO VERIFY
THEIR FINANCIAL ACTIVITY
SOMETHING THAT IS CLEARLY NEEDED
AND LONG OVERDUE.
LASTLY IT IS IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THE CSU FALLS
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
WHICH HAS THE DISCRETION TO
EXPAND OR LIMIT OR REPEAL THE
AUTHORITY OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES.
AND WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY IS TO
TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT THE
BUSINESS OF USUAL BEHAVIOR OF
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
AND ASK YOU TO PROVIDE GREATER
OVERSIGHT OF OUR NATION'S
LARGEST FOR YOUR PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
SO THANK YOU AND ON BEHALF OF
CFA WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
EITHER.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR LEYVA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
HANNAH BRAG SAD AND I AND
LEGISLATIVE POLICY ANALYST FOR
THE CALIPHATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS THE
NEARLY HALF A MILLION.
CSU STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE WE
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA AND CFA FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD.
AS YOU KNOW TUITION FOR THE CSU
SYSTEM HAS INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY IN RECENT YEARS AND
YET AT THE SAME TIME SO HAVE
THEIR EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION
PACKAGES.
BECAUSE OF THAT WE ARE PLEASED
TO SEE THAT THIS BILL ENCOURAGES
TRANSPARENCY IN OUR SYSTEM BY
REQUIRING THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES TO INCLUDE PROPOSED
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION INCREASES
ON THEIR AGENDA.
INFORMATIONAL ITEM AND PUBLIC
HEARING PRIOR TO BEING
CONSIDERED FOR A VOTE AT THE
NEXT CONSECUTIVE MEETING.
I STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING MORE
AND MORE TO MAKE ENDS MEET THEY
HAVE BECOME INCREASINGLY
FRUSTRATED AND HAVING TO BEAR
THE BIGGEST FINANCIAL BURDEN AND
AS A RESULT ARE FACING HIGH
AMOUNTS OF STUDENT HOUSING AND
SECURITY.
AND THIS LAST YEAR OUR BOARD IS
SUPPORTED TO RESOLUTIONS CALLING
FOR BETTER MORE TRANSPARENT
PRACTICES OF THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AS IT RELATES TO
INCREASES IN EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION.
WHICH IS WHY OUR STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN SO EXCITED TO SEE THIS BILL
INTRODUCED WE ASK FOR YOU TO
SUPPORT AB NINE THIRTY SO THAT
SALARY INCREASES DO NOT FALL ON
THE BACKS OF OUR STRUGGLING
STUDENTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MARIO GROUND THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATIONS
MENTION WERE COSPONSOR I'M ALSO
ACTION FACULTY AT SACRAMENTO
STATE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ELAINE NEWMAN PROFESSOR OF
MATHEMATICS AND STATISTICS FOR
TWENTY ONE YEARS AND FORMER
CHAIR OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE AT
CINEMA STATE.
RAY BY CO LECTURE IN HISTORY AND
SALAS A STATE AND CFA --
POLITICAL ACTION CHAIR SAM IS A
KEVIN WHERE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND PROFESSOR OF
SOCIOLOGY AT SACRAMENTO STATE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY OF THE CSU.
REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH S. YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
PRESTON RUDY I'M A SOCIOLOGY
PROFESSOR AT SAN JOSE STATE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
STEPHEN FILLING PROFESSOR OF
ACCOUNTING AT STANISLAUS STATE
UNIVERSITY ENSURE THE ACADEMIC
SENATE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN YOU RUN FOR FOR POLITICAL
SCIENCE A COMFY STAY STRONG
SUPPORT.
MELISSA MORENO CHAIR OF ETHNIC
STUDIES AT WOODLAND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JAN. THIRTY WHEN YOU'RE LUXURY
NOT APOLOGY TENNESSEE STATE
UNIVERSITY A STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL WILL BRNG MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY TO THE CSU
ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU.
HI AND CHAIR OF SOCIOLOGY
DEPARTMENT AT CSU STANISLAUS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANKS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORT
THIRTY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
COME ON DOWN.
GO FROM LIKE A GUEST ROOM TO THE
SMALLEST ROOM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A GOOD
AFTERNOON EDGE MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY --
WE REGRETFULLY MUST BE OPPOSE
THE MEASURE -- WE TAKE SERIOUSLY
THE AUTHORITY GIVEN TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY MORE
TRUSTEES TO MANAGE THE SYSTEM
HAS BEEN IT HAS.
S. MASTER PLAN HAS PROVIDED US
THAT BENEFITS.
WE ARE VERY PROUD OF OUR
PRESIDENTS ARE CSU CAMPUSES AND
MORE THAN HALF OF THEM ARE
FEMALE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THE
HISTORY OF THE SYSTEM.
WE DON'T SEE THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE THE THE TWIST EVERY
CHARGE WHICH IS BASED ON CERTAIN
FEES AND THE GENERAL FUND FROM
THE STATE.
AND THE CONCEPT OF RIGHT FOR
EMPLOYEES.
THAT WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OF THE
OPPOSE THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
[inaudible]
CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU I AM COMING IN LATE
WHICH I APOLOGIZE FOR WERE
DOUBLE BOOKED HERE IN THE
CAPITAL -- I DID HAVE A CHANCE
TO LOOK AT THIS BILL PRIOR TO
THE HEARING OF THE ME.
FOR SIX IN IT IT'S A COUPLE
THINGS -- I GUESS YOU'RE
PRESENTING IT FOR YEAH.
IN TRYING.
TO YOU KNOW LOOK I'LL DO MY BEST --
I REMEMBER MY I WAS APPOINTED TO
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES -- IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN BY GOVERNOR
BROWN AND I VIVIDLY REMEMBER MY
FIRST -- BOARD MEETING.
BECAUSE ON THE AGENDA WAS A
SELECTION OF THE NEW PRESIDENT
AT SAN DIEGO STATE.
ALONG WITH A SUBSTANTIAL RAISE.
I IN HIS COMPENSATION.
AND OF COURSE IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WE WERE IN
BIG BUDGET MELTDOWN.
AND WHILE WE DID NOW WHAT KIND
OF TUITION INCREASE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT YEAR.
THIS IS THE SYSTEM LOST A HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS SO WE WERE IT
WAS AND AND ND AND AND HIGH.
END AND REAL PROBLEMS.
AND I OF COURSE WENT TO SAN
DIEGO STATE.
AND I HAVE GREAT ADMIRATION FOR
THE SELECTION OF THE PRESIDENT.
BUT WHEN THAT VOTE. TO TO
PROVIDE THAT COMPENSATION I I
WAS ONE OF I THINK -- TO
TRUSTEES VOTE NOW -- AND THEN
THROUGH THE COURSE OF MY FOUR
YEARS ON THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
I DIDN'T SUPPORT ANY --
INCREASING PRESIDENTIAL SALARIES.
AND I I SAY THAT BECAUSE HEY I
SEE THAT YOU I AND I WAS FORCED
TO VOTE A NUMBER OF TIMES TO
RAISE TUITION.
NOT NECESSARILY IN THE SAME YEAR
THAT I HAD TO VOTE FOR THE
SALARY INCREASE BUT IT WAS THE
TIMES WERE VERY DIFFICULT.
THIS MUCH IS A I NOBODY WANTED
TO RAISE TUITION.
I GUESS WHAT TROUBLES ME ABOUT
THIS BILL IS A FROM A COUPLE
DIFFERENT PLACES NUMBER -- ONE
THIS IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
AND WHAT DO YOU LIKE THE MARIA
DR ALL APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR.
NOT ALL OF THEM IF CONFIRMED BY
THE SENATE THEY'RE THERE TO
EXERCISE THEIR BEST JUDGMENT.
ABOUT HOW TO RUN THE SYSTEM AND
THIS IS BASICALLY SAYING TO THEM.
GONNA TAKE AWAY THAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA DICTATE HOW
YOU HAVE TO IMPLEMENT OKAY SO I
HAVE A PROBLEM ON THAT LEVEL.
BUT THE THE OTHER LEVEL THAT I
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT IS THAT IT
SEEMS LIKE.
IT'S IT'S RIGHT FROM THE
DEREGULATION.
IT SEEMS THAT YOU CAN -- SAY.
THAT I MEAN DID YOU WANT TO
PRESIDENT. TO ALLOW A SYSTEM
DETERIORATE MEANING I'M NOT
GOING TO INCREASE TUITION SO
THAT THEY CAN GET A RAISE.
IS THAT THE PERVERSE INCENTIVES
CREATED IN THIS BILL.
BECAUSE OF ITS ALL ABOUT THEM
THAT'S REALLY THE PREMISE.
THAT MEANS THEY'RE GONNA NOT DO
WHAT'S NECESSARY TO PROTECT AND
PRESERVE THE QUALITY AND THE AT
THE SYSTEM.
IN ORDER JUST GET COMPENSATION
FOR THIRTY PEOPLE.
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE PERVERSE
INCENTIVE THAT'S CREATED IN THIS
BILL.
IT SEEMS TO ME AS SOMEONE WHO
DOESN'T LIKE TO WISH INCREASES.
AND DOESN'T LIKE TO PAY OUR
PRESIDENTS A LOT OF MONEY FOR
CERTAINLY.
HAS THAT AS A LOT OF TIMES IT'S
PROPOSE.
AND AND THAT'S THE DILEMMA FOR
SOMEONE [inaudible]
LIKE ME.
YOUR FEEDBACK ON THAT.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER YES WE
RESPOND TO THAT -- YOU KNOW AND
I APPRECIATE.
YOU SENATOR GLAZER WHEN YOU ARE
ON THE BOARD SHOWING RESTRAINT
REGARDING EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION
I THINK THE HISTORY ON THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES HAS SHOWN THAT VERY
FEW TRUSTEES.
HAVE SHOWN RESTRAINT IN
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION SIMILARLY
THE BORDER THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
HAS NOT SHOWN RESTRAINT WHEN IT
COMES TO INCREASING STUDENT FEES
ALMOST ALL OF THE HOLES ON THE
INCREASE IN STUDENT FEES HAVE
BEEN FROM THE EXECUTIVE FROM
FORMER GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN.
AND NOW GOVERNOR NEWSOME WHO
MADE SURE THAT STUDENT FEES WERE.
NOT AND NOT TO THEIR ADVANTAGE
IN THE CURRENT BUDGET -- AND
WE'VE SEEN THE RESULTS OF THAT
LACK OF OVERSIGHT IN THE RECENT
AUDIT WELL ON THE I STARTED
TEACHING AT BAY IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE SO I GUESS THIS IS
MY TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY.
AND AND YOU KNOW WHEN I WHEN I
FIRST STARTED TEACHING WE DID
NOT HAVE FOOD PANTRIES ON EVERY
CAMPUS AND WE DO NOW AND WE
DON'T NEED WE DID NOT HAVE ANY.
NO ONE WAS TALKING ABOUT LEADING
STUDENTS SLEEP IN THEIR CARS
BECAUSE THEY WERE HOMELESS.
THE EFFECTS OF THE CHOICES OF
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES HAVE.
HI HELD UP OVER THE YEARS AND
LET US TO WHERE WE ARE AND WE
FEEL AS AT THAT THE CSU NEEDS
MORE OVERSIGHT.
THEY HAVE BEEN WITHHOLDING THOSE
STUDENT FEES PROP FROM PROVIDING
REAL STUDENT SERVICES.
AND THEY HAVEN'T BEEN GOOD
STEWARDS OF THE SYSTEM THE CSU
ISN'T STATUTE AND WE FEEL THAT
DAY IT IS TIME.
FOR THEM TO BE UNDER THAT
CONSTRAINT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER GLAZER IS AT ALL DO YOU
REALLY QUESTIONS.
WELL I I THINK THERE WAS NOBODY
ANSWERED THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
PERVERSE INCENTIVES SECURE.
REYES SALARIES AND A YEAR IN
WHICH YOU HAVE.
A TUITION INCREASE THEN DO YOU
PUT THE PRESSURE IN THE WRONG
PLACE BECAUSE THEN THEY'RE NOT
GONNA I KNOW NO ONE LIKES TO
RAISE TUITION RIGHT BUT IT'S ALL.
IT'S ALL ON US IT'S ABOUT HOW WE
COMPENSATE HOW WE HOW WE PUT IN
THE BUDGET EACH YEAR. TO PROVIDE
FOR WHAT THE SYSTEM NEEDS TO RUN
AND WE'VE BEEN IN A COUPLE GOOD
YEARS BUT THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS
GOOD YEARS.
AND SO IT'S A VERY TOUGH CHOICE
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE
CERTAINLY FOR THE TRUSTEES AND
SO DO YOU CREATE A WAY A
PERVERSE INCENTIVE WHEN YOU SAY
TO THE LEADERSHIP YOU CAN'T HAVE
A REYES YOU CAN HAVE YOUR 3%.
WHATEVER IT IS COST OF LIVING
WHATEVER IT IS YOU CAN'T HAVE
THAT.
IF YOU RAISE TUITION IS THAT
REALLY GONNA.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S GONNA WORK
THAT DECISION WOULD NOT YOU WANT
TO MAKE THE BEST DECISION YOU'RE
PUTTING THEIR SELF INTEREST NOW.
INTO A DECISION ON TUITION.
AM I RIGHT ABOUT THAT WELL I
HAVEN'T MET A BOARD OF TRUSTEES
YET -- IS AN ENTIRE BOARD THAT
WASN'T REALLY QUITE EAGER TO
RAISE STUDENT FEES SO I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO REEL
THEM IN.
THIS DOES CREATE SOME PRESSURE
THAT THEY APPARENTLY DON'T FEEL
INTERNALLY.
OKAY WELL I'M NOT SURE YOU'RE
ANSWERING THE QUESTION JUST TO
BE CLEAR.
AND FROM THE TRUSTEES POINT OF
VIEW.
THEY'VE TO THE FROZEN
PRESIDENTIAL SALARIES THE LAST I
DON'T KNOW SEVEN EIGHT YEARS.
AT EIGHT EIGHT WHEN YOU HIRE AT
A A NEW PRESIDENT OF THE CAMPUS
DID THEY PAY THEM MORE THAN THE
PREDECESSOR.
AND HUMBLED THOSE JUST SELECTED.
AB THAT THE SYSTEM CAN ANSWER
THAT. FOR THE FOR THE POLICY
ADOPTED BY THE BOARD THEY CAN GO
UP 210% THEY DO NOT GO ABOVE 10%
THE BILL PAY THE PREVIOUS SALARY.
OKAY SO THE BOARD SET OF POLICY
THAT YOU CAN'T GO ANY HIGHER
THAN 10%.
OVER THE EXISTING SALARY OF THAT
PRESIDENT WHO COULD HAVE BEEN
THERE FOR TWENTY YEARS.
RIGHT HAVING A LOT MORE
EXPERIENCE BUT THANK YOU
CREATING A IN A LOT I DON'T
THINK THAT ONE ANSWER THAT.
YEAH I DON'T THINK THAT YOU SEEN
THAT THE TRUSTEES JUMPING UP AND
DOWN TO GO RAISE TUITION EITHER.
IT'S BEEN ONE TUITION INCREASE
IN WHAT SEVEN YEARS IS THAT
RIGHT.
OKAY ONE TUITION INCREASE IN
SEVEN YEARS HAVE A PRESIDENTIAL
POLICY THAT PUTS A LIMIT A CAP
ON HOW MUCH THEY CAN.
PAY A PRESIDENT.
SO WHERE IS THE REASON FOR THIS
BILL. TO ANSWER YOUR CALL YOUR
EARLIER QUESTION.
MADAM CHAIR -- YOU LAST IF THIS.
PROVIDES A PERVERSE INCENTIVE.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT DOES NOT
NOTHING IN THIS BILL PROHIBITS --
A AN INCREASE IN COMPENSATION.
WHAT IT DOES IS IT SETS FOR THAT
YEAR JUST THAT YEAR WHERE THERE
IS AN INCREASE IN TUITION THERE
IS NO I EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION
INCREASE?
YOU JUST SAID YOURSELF THAT IN
SEVEN YEARS HAS BEEN ONE SO THAT
ONE YEAR THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO RACE -- EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION BUT ALL THOSE OTHER
YEARS THEY CAN CERTAINLY
CONSIDER THAT.
RIGHT WITH THE IF THE WHOLE IDEA
IS TO LIVE PUT A LIMIT ON
PRESIDENTIAL SALARIES.
REALLY AT THE HEART OF THIS
ISN'T IT YOU'RE NOT TRYING TO
RAISE TUITION HERE.
TRYING TO CAP PRESIDENTIAL
SALARIES.
RIGHT THAT'S NOT THE GOAL.
THE GOAL IS ACCOUNTABILITY --
AND TO ENSURE THAT THE BOARD IS
A GOOD STEWARDS OF THE FUNDING
AND THAT IF YOU'RE GOING TO
RAISE.
EVERYONE IF WE ARE HURTING AS A
STATE.
THAT NOT IF THE STUDENTS ARE
GONNA HURT THE EXECUTIVE
SHOULDN'T NECESSARILYBENEFIT AT
THAT TIME ONE FINAL FOLLOW UP
AND SHARE.
IS THAT WELL THEN SHOULD YOU PUT
THAT ON US THAT WERE THE ONE WHO
PROVIDES THE BUDGET TO THE
SYSTEM.
SO SHOULD THIS LOSS SAY THAT WE
CAN INCREASE LEGISLATIVE
SALARIES IN A YEAR IN WHICH WE
DON'T FULLY FIND.
THE SYSTEM SO THEY HAVE TO RAISE
TUITION I MEAN IS THAT IS NOT
THE ACT OF PUTTING IT WHERE IT
REALLY STARTS WHICH IS US.
NOT THE PRESIDENT'S THEY'RE NOT
THE ONES DECIDING ON TUITION.
RIGHT THROUGH THE US IN THE
BUDGET THAT WE FIND EVERY YEAR
ISN'T IT MADAM CHAIRMAN ANSWER
THE QUESTION SO WE THINK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS -- IN -- ARE.
THEIR OWN ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES FOR EXAMPLE YOU DON'T
GET COMPENSATED OF THE BUDGET
DOESN'T PASS SOMETIME.
THAT'S GREAT IN TERMS OF THIS
BODY.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS AUTHORITY
OVER.
THE CSU IT'S A CREATURE OF THE
BODY AND YOU CAN CERTAINLY
CHOOSE TO GIVE THEM ADDITIONAL
POWERS OR EXERCISE ADDITIONAL
COME.
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
DO TO EXERCISE ADDITIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I WOULD JUST SAY TO A CENTER
GLAZER TO YOUR POINT THAT YOU
KNOW IF WE'VE GIVEN.
SALARIES FOR PRESIDENTS HAVE
GONE UP ONCE IN SEVEN YEARS AND
EXCUSE ME THE TUITIONS KIND OF
POINTS IN SEVEN YEARS I THINK A
LOT OF THIS IS OPTICS AS WELL WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS
DON'T FEEL LIKE.
PEOPLE ARE BENEFITING WHEN
THEY'RE SHELLING OUT MORE MONEY
SO IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT DOING THE
RIGHT THING IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE
OPTICS AND MAKING SURE THAT.
THOSE THAT ARE IN POWER AREN'T
IN REACHING THEMSELVES IN A TIME
OR IN A YEAR WHEN STUDENTS ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO SHELL OUT MORE
MONEY TO GO TO SCHOOL.
AND IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE IT'S
HAPPENING EVERY YEAR WE KNOW
IT'S NOT HAPPENING EVERY YEAR SO
IT'S JUST WAY TO BE A LITTLE
SMARTER.
AND THINK ABOUT IT IF YOU KNOW
WE'RE GONNA GIVE OURSELVES A
RAISE WE SURE XIN ELSE FOR
TUITION INCREASE AS WELL.
AND I HATE TO SAY IT BUT
SOMETIMES PEOPLE NEED TO HAVE
THAT PUT RIGHT IN FRONT OF THEM
SO THAT THEY WILL THINK ABOUT IT --
BUT I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS CENTER DRAWS A DID YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS THAT YOU
WANTED TO MAKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
PASSED FROM MY VERY GOOD ARE WE
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER DRAWS -- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NINE EIGHTY NINE THIRTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK CHIANG WHO
ASSELIN TO WRESTLE I'D GLAZER
[inaudible]
MCGUIRE CAN.
I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA YOU DID A
GREAT JOB FOR HIM.
ALL RIGHT MISTER SANTIAGO.
YOU HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB TWO COME ON DOWN.
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE.
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY GIVE
ME MAYBE ONE SET FOR MISTER
MCCARTY TO WALK UP [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO.
PRESENT YOUR BILL WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE UP TO BE
ABLE TO PRESENT AB.
TWO AS MOST OF YOU KNOW THIS
BEGUN ABOUT FOUR FIVE YEARS AGO
WE STARTED THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND NOW WE'RE ON THE EVE OF OF
GETTING THIS BILL SIGNED -- TO
MAKE SURE THE POLICY PIECES TO
THE BUT THE THE BUDGET -- FIT IN
PLACE AND WILL HAVE TO USE A
FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE -- HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE THE A THE JOINT AUTHORS
HERE WHO ELSE LIKE PERCENT IT'S
OKAY WITH YOU MANAGER.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY OKAY.
UBER MCCARTY HAS VERY GREAT WELL
OF COURSE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACHIEVE SOME SUCCESS IN THE
BUDGET THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IN
THIS -- BUILDS UPON THAT TEN
MISTER SANTIAGO TALKED ABOUT THE
BILL ALSO SAY YOU KNOW WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR OUR MUTUAL
INTEREST HERE IN CALIFORNIA
FOCUSING ON OUR STUDENTS.
ARE COLLEGES AND OUR ECONOMY AS
WE KNOW.
STUDENT DEBT IS A HUGE HUGE --
ISSUE FOR THIS GENERATION -- IS
NOT JUST -- TUITION ITS BOOKS OF
HOUSING WHICH WERE TRYING TO
ADDRESS BUT SHE OF THE COMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND THE STICKER SHOCK ISRAEL SO
HAVING LESS DEBT FOR STUDENTS
WHEN THEY GRADUATE I REALLY
MATTERS AND HAVING THEM GO FULL
TIME ALLOW THEM TO GRADUATE
WITHOUT LAST DEBT IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE FACING
DECLINING ENROLLMENT SO WE'VE
SEEN HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN LA.
THIS WHOLE -- MONTROSE BARS FREE
COLLEGE ISN'T JUST A BUMPER
STICKER BANNER IT'S REALLY
GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE SIDELINES
TO ENROLL IN THE COLLEGE'S.
BUILDING AT THE ROMAN AND AGAIN
THE STUDENTS HAVE HIGHER SUCCESS
RATES BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING.
A FULL TIME LASTLY WE KNOW THAT
IN OUR ECONOMY WE NEED MORE
EDUCATED INDIVIDUALS IN THE WORK
FORCE.
NOW WE HAVE THIS -- DEGREE GAP
FOR PEOPLE WITH COLLEGE DEGREES
BUT ALSO AGREED CAP PER
CERTIFICATES WHICH YOU CAN GET
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE THIS
WILL HELP.
OUR STATE -- REMAIN COMPETITIVE
IN THE GLOBAL ECONOMY AND SO
THIS MEANS ALL OF OUR CALIFORNIA
GOALS AND CERTAINLY ASK FOR HI
BUT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
A TALE SHE WAS TALKING TO A
REPRESENT LOS ANGELS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT OTHERS SPONSORS
OF AB.
TWO WE LIKE TO THANK US AND IN
OUR THOUGHT SANTIAGO FOR HIS
PIONEERING EFFORTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE THIS
IS THE SECOND PIECE OF
LEGISLATION HE'S INTRODUCED.
ON THE SUBJECT BUT WE ALSO LIKE
TAKE A SIMILAR MCCARTY FOR HIS
WORK ON THE BUDGET AND
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT OF PUTTING
THE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET.
TO FUND THE SECOND YEAR -- AS
WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS
TO INTRODUCE IN THE BUDGET.
WITH ALL THAT THERE'S STILL A
COUPLE OF LOOSE ENDS IF YOU WILL
OR THINGS THAT WE LIKE TO SEE --
ROUND OUT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE COLLEGE PROMISED ONE IS THAT
THE BILL STILL CALL FOR A STUDY
TO ANALYZE HEALTH DISTRICTS ARE
USING THE FUNDS ARE THAT THEY
ARE RECEIVING TO SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS IN THE COLLEGE PROBLEMS
PROGRAM.
AND THE SECOND THING IS A
PROVISION THAT GIVES THE
COLLEGES DISCRETION TO ACCEPT
DISABLED STUDENTS FROM THE FULL
TIME TWELVE YOU KNOW REQUIREMENT
UNDER CERTAIN CONDITIONS.
GIVEN THE SITUATION AND
DISABILITY SO. FOR THOSE REASONS
WE THINK THAT AB TWO SHOWS
BEFORE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I AM THE CONTACT US ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT NOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE A
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING HEARING THEN I'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE CENTERED
RAZA MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH JOHN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YEAH I WOULD -- I WAS BRIEF IN
MY EARLIER TO MAKE SOMEONE TO
MAKE SURE WE WE ALWAYS GOT THAT
ALL THE PRESENTATIONS BUT HERE'S
WHAT'S KEY ABOUT THE BILL I MEAN
ABOUT THE ABOUT THE MOVEMENT OF
FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
NUMBER ONE IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IT'S
ABOUT SUCCESS RATES IN IN LA
COUNTY AREA WE SAW ON THE SECOND
HOLE COURTS AT ABOUT 83% SUCCESS
RATE FROM ONE YEAR TO FIRST YEAR.
THE OTHER PIECE IS OFTEN A
MISSED.
INCLUDED WITHIN THIS MOVEMENT IS
THE ABILITY TO SIGN UP EVERY
STUDENT FOR THE PASSIVE FORM.
WHICH IS THE NON TUITION COSTS
SO YOU COULD HAVE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN.
TEN TO TWELVE TALKING WHO GOES
THREE TWENTIES COHORT.
I AND MORE IMPORTANTLY IT'S D.
IT EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT IS THE
ABILITY TO TALK TO A COUNSELOR.
AND IT'S ALL PART OF THE PIECES
THAT WE TALK ABOUT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING ON AND LIKE ANY OTHER
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WILL KEEP
WORKING ON ON A ON ON THIS OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS ENSURE
THAT IT'S DONE RIGHT.
AND WITH THIS ALMOST.
BEFORE HERE IN THE MINUTE THAT
THAT HOPEFULLY THAT IT SIGNED.
ALSO THAT WE GET THE POLICY
PIECES RIGHT TO THE BUDGET -- TO
THE BUDGET ASPECT OF THIS OF
HAVING SAID THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIGEL.
THANK YOU SIMILAR MCCARTY YOU
WANNA CLOSE VERY GOOD THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ALSO
M. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM THREE AB TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WILK CHAIN WRESTLE.
WITH US ALL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE
PAN.
WE BELIEVE THAT BELONG CALL AND
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER OFF
AUTHORS SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT TIME I THINK YOU HAVE
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
FOUR YES.
ARE YOU A START WITH EIGHTEEN
YOU HAVE I TAKE THE I THINK THAT
MORE SIMPLE ONE FIRST IF YOU'RE
LOOKINGFOR FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR YES I WILL SERVE WITH FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR ABC ARE SIXTY
FOUR MCCARTY YET AGAIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY YES BUT BEFORE THAT
IT TO ANOTHER.
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL ON
CONSENT TODAY THAT SUPPORT ON
THAT'S A BILL RELATED TO
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR EASY
PROGRAMS AND WE'RE BOTH WORKING
ON THAT AND I KNOW THAT THE BIG
DIFFERENCE MAKER TO MAKE SURE
THE PROGRAMS ARE VIABLE.
YES.
THIS MEASURE HERE AC SIXTY FOUR
IS THAT.
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS REFORM
PACKAGE I THINK THEY'RE FIVE
BILLS OVER HERE IN THE SENATE.
KIND OF A A REACTION TO WHAT
HAPPENED THIS PAST WINTER WITH
THE OPERATION VARSITY BLUES WITH
A COLLEGE ADMISSIONS.
IT WAS CERTAINLY SHOCKING TO
MANY OF US READING ABOUT IT THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO STARTED THIS
WHOLE PROGRAM LITERALLY STARTED
IN MY DISTRICT YEARS YOU'RE VERY
FAMILIAR.
WITH THE WORK AND ONE OF THAT
THE SCANS THAT WE SAW.
WAS CHEATING RELATED TO THE
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS -- TESTS SO
IN SOME CASES THEY HAD THE
PROCTOR GOING CHANGE THE ANSWERS.
IN SOME CASES THEY HAD --
INDIVIDUALS FAKE DISABILITIES
AND GET MORE TIME TO TAKE THE-SAT AND SAT AND ACT EXAM.
THIS OF COURSE IS WRONG BUT ALSO
SOMETIMES A NUYS A SPOT FOR
QUALIFIED CALIFORNIANS OF THAT
WHY THIS REALLY MATTERS BUT THIS
REALLY -- BAGS.
LARGER QUESTION WHETHER THESE
TASKS ARE REALLY APPLICABLES IN
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY SO WE
KNOW THAT -- THAT YOU SEE IS
TAKING UP A LOOK AT THIS -- WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE DOZENS OF
COLLEGES ACROSS THE NATION THAT
I'VE CHANGED OR STANDARDS FOR
THESE.
STANDARDIZED TESTS AND WHAT THIS
MEASURE HERE WOULD ASK THE UC
SYSTEM AND THE CSU TO CONDUCT A
STUDY.
ON THE USEFULNESS OF FACT IN
THIS THE NEED FOR THE SAT TO
DETERMINE WHETHER IT IS.
STILL NEEDED TODAY WE KNOW THAT
THE SYSTEMS -- CERTAINLY I'D
NEEDED TO FOCUS ON THE HUGE
VOLUME OF APPLICATIONS THE KIND
OF SORT PEOPLE IN SORT PEOPLE
OUT.
I THINK WE HAVE A LARGER
SOCIETAL QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT
THIS TRULY ON MEASURES STUDENT
SUCCESS AND THERE ARE OTHERS
STATE -- FUNDED UNIVERSITIES
ACROSS THE NATION THAT HAVE GOT
RID OF THE SYSTEM WE THINK THAT
WE CAN.
I TAKE A LOOK AT THE SAME THING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AGAIN THIS
ISN'T.
AT CERTAIN REMEDY THIS CERTAINLY
ASK THE SYSTEMS THIS WOULD.
IN ESSENCE AS A SYSTEM TO DO A
THOROUGH STUDY IN EVALUATION
REPORT BACK TO US I WITH ME ARE
TO STUDENTS.
I'M SORRY ONE STUDENT AND ONE
ADVOCATES TO TALK ABOUT THE NEED
FOR THIS.
VERY GOOD TWO MINUTES EACH LA
DECIDE WHO GOES FIRST.
PLEASE PROCEED.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAROL OF MONEY
I'LL AND I'M A SECOND YEAR
STUDENT AS YOU SEE MERCED --
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL I TOOK
THE SAT AND ACT AND?
AS A STUDY FOR THE EXAMS I FOUND
THAT THE ONLINE QUIZZES AND
STUDY GUIDES THAT WERE -- THAT
WOULD PROVIDE FOR US DID NOT
PREPARE ME AS WELL AS A COSTLY
EXAM PREPARATION THAT.
I FORTUNATE COLLEAGUES HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF ACCESSING --
ALTHOUGH WE HELD SIMILAR GPAS IN
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES ARE
TEST PREPARATION AND
CONSEQUENTIALLY OUR SCORES
RESULTED IN DIFFERENT EMISSIONS
INTO UC'S MCSE IS.
WHILE I WAS ABLE TO GET ACCEPTED
INTO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA MANY MY WELL ROUNDED
PEERS WHO DID NOT RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL EXAMS APART WERE
DENIED MISSION.
THIS STORY IS NOT UNIQUE AND
WHEN ANALYZING THE SAT SCORES OF
STUDENTS ACROSS THE NATION.
THEY'RE JUST.
DISPARITIES AMONG MINORITIES AND
LOWER INCOME SINCE COMPARISON TO
THOSE AND HIGHER SOCIOECONOMIC
[inaudible]
TEARS.
I WAS UNABLE TO RECEIVE PRIVATE
TUTORING OR TEN PREP.
I IN THIS COURSE A DEAD.
AS IN MANY OTHERS MY COMMUNITY.
THE SAT AND ACT IS ARE DESIGNED
TO TEST STUDENTS COLLEGE
READINESS AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPERATIVE TO ENGAGE STUDENTS IN
A CONVERSATION WITH THAT.
I WILL WHETHER THEY BE IN THE
YOU SEE THE CSU.
ESSENTIALLY THOSE WHO TOOK THE
EXAMS AND WE SHOULD ASK THEM IF
WHERE THEY TRULY EFFECTIVE.
IF NOT WE'LL CONTINUE TO EXCLUDE
QUALIFIED AND HARD WORKING
STUDENTS FROM HIGHER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORT EXAMS
UP FAVOR INDIVIDUALS HIRES THAT
SOCIO ECONOMIC BACKGROUND.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
EXPECT THE ASPIRIN I'VE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN I THOUGHT OF
THIS MY GOLLY CAM KATE WITH
ADVOCATES WE SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION TO EXAMINE THE
USEFULNESS OF THE SAT AND ACT
AND COLLEGE ADMISSIONS.
THESE HIGH STAKES TESTS CAN ACT
AS BARRIERS TO COLLEGE ADMISSION
FOR MANY LOW INCOME AND STUDENTS
OF COLOR WHO CANNOT AFFORD
EXPENSIVE TEST PREP AS WE HEARD
OR WHO ATTEND HIGH SCHOOLS.
THAT DON'T PROVIDE THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO GO TO COLLEGE
RECENTLY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
COLLEGE BOARD ADMITTED THAT
WEALTH INEQUALITY HAS PROGRESSED
TO SUCH A DEGREE.
THAT IT ISN'T FAIR TO LOOK AT
TEST SCORES ALONE AND THAT WE
MUST LOOK AT THEM IN CONTEXT OF
THE ADVERSITY STUDENTS FACE.
AND ACCORDING TO THE UC CENTER
FOR STUDIES IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
QUOTE OF ALL COLLEGE ADMISSION
CRITERIA SCORES ON NATIONALLY
NORM TESTS LIKE THE SAT AND ACT
ARE MOST AFFECTED BY THE SOCIO
ECONOMIC BACKGROUND OF THE
STUDENT.
FACTORS SUCH AS FAMILY INCOME
PARENTS' EDUCATION AND RACE
ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT 35% OF THE
VARIATION OF SAT TEST SCORES
THAT YOU SEE.
AS OPPOSED EXPLAINING ONLY 8% OF
THE VARIATION.
WITH USING HIGH SCHOOL GPA.
RESEARCH BY POLICY ANALYSIS FOR
EDUCATE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
ALSO FOUND THAT HIGH SCHOOL GPA
IS A STRONGER PREDICTOR OF FIRST
YOUR COLLEGE GPA AND SECOND YOUR
PERSISTENCE AT THE CSU.
USING HIGH SCHOOL GPA COMBINED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSESSMENT
OF STUDENT PERFORMANCE AND
PROGRESS RESULTS IN A MORE SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY AND RACIALLY
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE APPLICANT.
AS OPPOSED TO USING GPA AND THE
SAT.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAVE ALREADY MOVED
AWAY FROM CONSIDERING THE SAT
AND ACT IN ADMISSIONS.
AND INSTEAD ARE USING CLASS RANK
OR HIGH SCHOOL GPA.
ASKING THE CSU AND THE UC TO
STUDY NEED AND USE OF THESE
TESTS IN THEIR ADMISSIONS
POLICIES.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE ARE MORE
EQUITABLE MEASURES IS REASONABLE
AND LONG OVERDUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ECONOMY WE HAVE A SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
I HAD A CONTEST ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF FORMER UC DAVIS DIDN'T
SACRAMENTO GRADUATE.
PUSH OFFICE STARTING WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THURMOND MAJID WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIVE CHANCE
OFFICE OR BOARD DOES NOT YET
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON THIS
RESOLUTION -- BUT WE ARE
SUPPORTER OF THE OFFICE ATTACK
AND HOPE TO HAVE A FORMER
SUPPORT -- LATER THIS MONTH
THANK YOU.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CATHERINE YOU'RE GONNA ON BEHALF
OF COPYING CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER
IN SUPPORT.
LISTEN WHAT IT NO UC SANTA CRUZ
ALARM AND FORMER C. S. U. M. B.
FACULTY.
AND STRONG CSU STANISLAUS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
GLAZER.
ONCE AGAIN I THE PRESS OF
BUSINESS TODAY HAS.
LOBBIED IN THIS I'M SURE YOUR
WONDERFUL TESTIMONY BUT I HAVE A
CHANCE TO READ THE BILL AND THIS
IS THE I'M SO GLAD YOU'RE DOING
THIS BILL THIS MAY BE THE BEST
BILL.
CERTAINLY TODAY IN EDUCATION
THAT I'VE SEEN -- ALL.
AT ONCE.
AND AND THE REASON AND THE REST
I DIDN'T MEAN TO DISPARAGE ANY
OTHER.
I JUST WANTED TO GIVE THE AUTHOR
PROPS.
THIS IS THAT THIS IS AN AREA
THAT'S REALLY TROUBLE ME FOR A
LONG TIME IN FACT I SENT TO YOU.
EARLIER TODAY AN OPINION PIECE I
WROTE -- IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE MANY YEARS
AGO WAS THAT. THIRTY ALL WHILE --
AND IT WAS ON THE SUBJECT OF
TESTING AND THE SAT IN THE A. C.
T..
AND IT'S TROUBLED ME FOR A LONG
TIME THAT.
THE WAY THAT THESE TESTERS.
DEVELOPED AND ADMINISTERED IN.
AND THE ANY THE PROFESSOR'S.
BELIEF THAT A DATE IT DEFINES
WITH YOU CAN BE SUCCESSFUL IN
COLLEGE.
IS REALLY ALL ROCK [inaudible]
AND THE I AM SO GLAD THAT THAT
YOUR BILL IS GOING TO TRY TO
ADVANCE THE FORMAL REVIEW OF IT
AS A AS A CONDITION -- I THINK
WE WANT TO PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF OUR KIDS
TO SEE TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
COLLEGE.
AND I THINK THAT IT
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST MANY MANY
PEOPLE.
HERE IN OUR STATE.
SOMEHOW BRANDS THEM AS AND IN
CAPABLE OF DOING COLLEGE LEVEL
WORK.
AND SO NOT ONLY DO I PRAISE YOU
FOR ADVANCING THE STUDY BUT I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT.
OUR ACADEMICIANS AND PEOPLE
SMARTER THAN ME.
WILL UNDERSTAND THAT.
YES IT'S GONNA REQUIRE A LOT
MORE WORK TO DO DIFFERENTIATE
WHO CAN GET INTO COLLEGE.
THE WAY TO DO IT SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND HAVE.
TIME.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
GOOD VERY GOOD WHICH I TO CLOSE.
I THANK YOU I THINK A THANK YOU
SENATOR I GLAZER AND I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS BEEN AN
ISSUE FOR A LONG TIME AND
FRANKLY IT'S ONLY GOTTEN WORSE.
BUT THE TEST PREP INDUSTRY WITH
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY
THERE IS AN EQUAL DISTRIBUTION
OF THAT ASSET.
AND CERTAIN PEOPLE WE HEARD FROM
CARLOS MAYBE THEIR FAMILY DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT -- HOW THE
INFORMATION TO GET TEST BUT
MAYBE THEY COULD BUY A TWENTY
DOLLAR BOOK AT THE BOOKSTORE?
AND THOSE AREN'T THE PREDICTORS
OF SUCCESS YOU KNOW YOU CAN
CERTAINLY USE GPA BUT ALSO LIKE
TO DO IN TEXAS AND ACTUALLY DO
AT THE UC.
IS THE NEW ELSE PLAY THE LOCAL.
SO IF YOU SUCCEED IN YOUR SCHOOL
IF YOU'RE IN THE TOP 10% OF YOUR
CLASS THAT SHOWS THE HAVE THE
MOXIE AND HOSTILE TO SUCCEED.
AND THAT'S JUST AS MUCH A
PREDICTOR IS HOW YOU WILL DO AT
UC SANTA CRUZ UC BERKELEY OR
ANYWHERE.
THEN THE ACT OR SAT AND THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT TO EVALUATE THIS
ISN'T A CERTAINTY IT'S GONNA
COME BACK WITH THE CONCLUSION --
BUT THE SOUL PUT THE LEGACY
LEGISLATURE ON RECORD SAYING
THAT WE THINK THERE ARE.
TWO HIGHER ASSISTANCE OUGHT TO
BE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER GLAZER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FOR A C.
R. T. FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE WILK CHAIN FOOD AXLE.
TO AXLE AYE GLAZER.
PLEASE THEIR AYE MCGUIRE CAN.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL
ON CALL WILL NOW MOVED FILEITEM
EIGHTEEN AB THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GET MY WITNESSES APPEAR.
OKAY MADAM CHAIR A LEAVE IN
SENATORS FIRST I WANT.
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR GREAT
STAFF HERE FOR WORKING WITH US
OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS AND WE
CAN OVER THE THE HOLIDAY -- TO
TO HELP GET THIS RIGHT ON THIS
IS RELATED THE FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE INDUSTRY PART OF A
PACKAGE OF BILLS WE HAVE HERE IN
THE SENATE.
AND THIS ONE REGARD IS RELATED
TO THE RECRUITMENT PRACTICES --
FRANKLY SOMETIMES ON
UNFORTUNATELY TARGETING STUDENTS
FRANKLY LOW INCOME STUDENTS
MARGINALIZE INDIVIDUALS ALMOST
EVERY MAJOR SCANDAL IN THIS
FIELD STARTED WITH THE SAME
THING.
THE SO CALLED A RECRUITER.
THESE RECRUITERS ARE REALLY HIGH
PRESSURE SALES PEOPLE TO GET
BODIES ARE BUT IN THE SEAT --
FRANKLY SCAMMING STUDENTS AND
TAXPAYERS OUT OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS -- KINDA
LIKE BOILER ROOM PRACTICES OF
RIGHT NOW THE MOVIE BOILER ROOM.
WHAT'S WORSE IS THAT THESE
RECRUITERS OFTEN TARGET SPECIFIC.
INDIVIDUALS VETERANS TEENAGERS
FIRST GENERATION INDIVIDUALS AND
LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
THIS MEASURE WOULD CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLES AND CURRENT LAW
ALLOWING FOR PROFIT COLLEGES TO
PROVIDE RECRUITERS WITH
KICKBACKS INCENTIVES.
AS PART OF THEIR AS PART OF
THEIR COMPENSATION.
CURRENT LAW ONLY PREVENTS
KICKBACKS BY EMPLOYEES AND
DOESN'T INCLUDE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS IN THIS BILL CLOSE
THAT LOOPHOLE.
IN ADDITION CURRENT LAW DOESN'T
EXPRESSLY PREVENT KICKBACKS
BASED UPON AWARDS THE FINANCIAL
LATE.
THIS BILL ALSO CLOSE THAT
LOOPHOLE.
SOME WILL SAY THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE ARGUE ADDRESSED BY FEDERAL
LAW.
AND THAT WE KNOW THAT ONLY THE
US SECRETARY OF EDUCATION
CURRENTLY BETSY TO BOSS CAN
FORCE THIS AGREEMENT SO WE THINK
WE ARE DO BETTER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS.
WE CAN'T -- LET THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PROTECT US FOR OUR
CONSUMERS AND THEY FAIL TO DO SO
MANY TIMES BEFORE THAT SO WE'RE
LOOKING TO BUY CODIFYING THIS IN
THE STATE LAW.
ALLOWING OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
GO AFTER.
A MALICIOUS VIOLATORS.
THIS BILL LIKE OUR PACKAGES
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF VETERANS CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS LABOR STUDENTS.
ARE COMMUNICATED SYSTEM.
AND OUR FOCUS ON PUTTING AN END
TO THIS -- FRAUD AND ABUSE BY
SOME IN THE FOR PROFIT INDUSTRY
AND LET'S FACE IT NOT ALL FOR
PROFITS ARE TERRIBLE PEOPLE WHO
ARE.
CAR MECHANICS -- WHO WORK IN THE
IN THE HEALTHCARE FIELD WHO GOT
A GREAT CAREER IN THE FOR PROFIT
HISTORY BUT THERE ARE SOME IN
THERE?
THAT ARE THAT ARE CAUSING A LOT
OF DAMAGE FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
PREY UPON.
THE VULNERABLE AND SELL IT OUT
WITH ME TODAY WE THINK IS A IS A
FAIR COMPROMISE I WILL NOTE THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING.
WITH THE OPPOSITION UP UNTIL TEN
MINUTES AGO IN THE HALLWAY.
WE ARE CERTAINLY -- I'VE CLOSER
THAN WE WERE EARLIER TODAY AND
WE WERE LAST WEEK AND THOSE ARE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS -- WE HAD A
SET OF AMENDMENTS WAS PROPOSED
BY THE INDUSTRY -- LAST WEEK WE
TRY TO INCORPORATE THESE IN THE
ANALYSIS BY THE WAY I DO WANT --
TO AGREED TO THE ALL THOSE IN
THE COMMUNITY ANALYSIS OF THANK
YOU.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES TRY TO COME TO EVEN
STRONGER -- THE BILL BEFORE US
HERE THIS YEAR ALSO WITH ME --
ARE INDIVIDUALS LIKE TESTIFIED
SPORT THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD ALL IT YOU CHOOSE WHO
GOES FIRST TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE THANK YOU.
BOB CHAIRMAN -- MUST SENIOR
FELLOW AT THE CENTURY FOUNDATION
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY SALES QUOTAS AND
COMMISSIONS ARE A CENTRAL
ELEMENT OF MOST COLLEGE
OPERATIONS THAT END UP TURNING
PREDATORY.
THEY LEAVE STUDENTS WITHOUT A
QUALITY EDUCATION AND WITH DEBTS
THAT THOSE STUDENTS CANNOT REPAY.
PAYING RECRUITERS FOR EACH
ENROLLMENT INVITES ADVISORS WHO
SHOULD BE ADVISING STUDENTS AND
PROVIDING THEM WITH QUALITY
INFORMATION. TO INSTEAD TARGET
THE VULNERABLE AND TO AVOID
PROVIDING THE AND INFORMATION
THAT MIGHT DIRECTLY HIT TO THEIR
OWN PAYCHECK.
THAT'S WHY THE PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS COUNSELORS HAVE
PROHIBITED THIS PRACTICE OR
THEIR MEMBER INSTITUTIONS SINCE
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO AND WHY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BANNED IT
SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THE FEDERAL
BAN HOWEVER HAS BEEN UNSTABLE
WITH THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION
CREATING A NEW SET OF LOOPHOLES
AND ENFORCEMENT BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
UNRELIABLE CALIFORNIA NEEDS ITS
OWN BAND SO THEY CAN ENFORCE THE
LAW INDEPENDENTLY.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE BILLS
THAT NEED AND ADDRESSES SOME
IMPORTANT LOOPHOLES WITH THE
AMENDMENT WITH THE AMENDMENTS
DESCRIBING THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE BILL INCORPORATES
MOST.
MOST OF THE CHANGES REQUESTED BY
OPPONENTS A FEW ISSUES REMAIN
AND WE REMAIN IN CONVERSATION
WITH THE OPPONENTS TO SEE IF
THEIR WAYS TO CLARIFY.
BUT WITHOUT OPENING UP LARGE
LOOPHOLES -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU I MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
GREG HAYES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES.
IT'S A CONSORTIUM OF SEVEN NON
PROFITS AROUND CALIFORNIA THAT
SIR VETERANS IN GREATEST NEED.
HI THIS IS THE POPULATION OF
VETERANS THAT SERVED US AND HAS
RETURNED AND HAVE CHALLENGES SO
WE WORK ON MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
VETERANS WE SERVE -- REALLY ARE
AT IT SORT OF A BASIC LEVEL
WE'RE TRYING TO GET THEM OUT OF
HOSPITALS AND INSTITUTIONS BUT
MANY OTHERS.
WE'RE TRYING TO GRADUATE TO
GREATER LEVELS OF INDEPENDENCE
AND TRAINING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
SO WHAT HAPPENS OFTENTIMES IS
WILLING COUNTER THESE VETERANS
AND THEIR GI BENEFITS ARE GONE
THEY'RE NOT EVEN AWARE THEY'RE
GONE IN MANY INSTANCES AND THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION IS OFTEN
TARGETED BY VERY AGGRESSIVE
RECRUITING PRACTICES.
THEY MIGHT SIGN AWAY THEIR J.
BENEFITS NEVER HAVING ATTENDED A
CLASS AND ONCE THAT BENEFIT IS
GONE IS GONE AND WE HAVE TO FIND
OTHER WAYS TO HELP THEM.
THE THING FOR THAT A BY THIS
COMMITTEE I HOPE YOU TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION IS THAT -- WE ARE
OFTEN IMPLEMENTING GRANT
PROGRAMS -- THROUGH A STATE
MENTAL HEALTH GRANTS AND OTHER
THINGS SO THOSE ARE INVESTMENTS
WE THE TAXPAYER DOLLARS HAVE
MADE I IN THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
BOTH TO I THANK THEM FOR THEIR
SERVICE BUT ALSO.
TO ASSIST THEM IN BEING
CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF SOCIETY --
IF THEY ARE VICTIMS OF VERY
AGGRESSIVE TACTICS IN THIS
REGARD.
WHICH I THINK THIS BILL MAKES
VERY REASONABLE --
CONSIDERATIONS IN ORDER TO REIN
THAT IN -- THEN THEY HAVE A
BETTER CHANCE OF SURVIVING SO
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA PERRY WITH THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION A
STRONG SUPPORT.
REALLY RESONATED WITH SK YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
I LANDED ON ON BEHALF OF NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY VALLEY KINCAID
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
IRAN **** ON BEHALF OF THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE COLLEGE A
CHANCE OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER SUPPORT. FOR ANY OF
THE BILL.
IF WE CAN MAKE A LITTLE ROOM.
WE'RE AT THE LITTLE TABLE NOW.
ALL RIGHT TWO MINUTES EACH I'LL
LET YOU DECIDE WHO BEGINS
[inaudible]
SURE.
WHEN YOU'RE READY?
AND I'M SURE MATH BACK
REPRESENTING CAPS IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION A PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY SCHOOLS I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE CERTAINLY THE AUTHOR.
I'M WE DID OFFER AMENDMENTS
AFTER BMP COMMITTEE WE DID HAVE
A CHANCE TO SIT DOWN.
THIS IS A VERY TECHNICAL ISSUE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EMPLOYMENT.
TALKING ABOUT HOW WE PAY OUR
EMPLOYEES WERE TALKING ABOUT
THEIR CONTRACTS.
ON THESE AGAIN ARE COMPLICATED
ISSUES THAT ARE VERY LEGAL
ORIENTED WHERE YOU KNOW EVERY
WORD DOES MATTER.
SO IT IS ACCURATE TO SAY THAT
THEY ACCEPTED A LOT OF OUR
LANGUAGE.
BUT SOME OF THE MORE IMPORTANT
PIECES THAT THAT MATTER TO US
THEY DID NOT SO THOSE ARE THOSE
ARE THE ISSUES THAT WE STILL
NEED TO RESOLVE IF WE ARE GOING
TO COME TO A RESOLUTION.
AND WHY IS THAT SO IMPORTANT.
WE AGREE WITH THE FUNDAMENTAL
CONCEPT OF THE BILL RIGHT WE WE
ARE NOT PAIN ARE EMPLOYEES OF
BASED ON THESE QUOTAS IT'S
AGAINST FEDERAL LAW IT'S AGAINST
STATE LAW.
OUR TITLE FOR ELIGIBILITY IS
DEPENDENT ON SO THIS IS UNDER
FEDERAL LAW AND THEY MENTION THE
PREVIOUS WITNESS MANSON BUSH AND
TRUMP.
IT WAS ACTUALLY OBAMA AND A BOMB
IS ADMINISTRATION THAT SET THE
CURRENT GUIDELINES.
THE RELEASED THEIR RAGS AND THEY
RELEASED A DEAR COLLEAGUE LETTER
THAT IS VERY SPECIFIC.
TO THESE ARE THE THINGS YOU CAN
DO THESE ARE THE THINGS YOU
CAN'T DO LOTS OF QUESTIONS LOTS
OF EXAMPLES WE DO NOT HAVE THAT
GUIDANCE IN THIS LAW.
AND FOR THOSE WHO WORK WITH THE
BUREAU I DOUBT WE WOULD GET THAT
SORT OF GUIDANCE FROM THEM -- I
DON'T EVEN KNOW FORGET
REGULATIONS ON THAT SO WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE STATUTE IS
SO CLEAR FOR US.
BECAUSE AGAIN THIS IS HOW WE'RE
SETTING OUR CONTRACT WITH OUR
EMPLOYEES THIS IS HOW WE'RE
PAYING OUR EMPLOYEES.
WE BELIEVE SOME OF THE WORDS AND
THE BILL NOW ARE VERY VAGUE AND
WILL CAPTURE EMPLOYEES THAT ARE
NOT DIRECTLY INVOLVED.
IN THE ENROLLMENT FOR ADMISSIONS
PROCESS THIS COULD BE THE
ACCOUNTANTS THIS COULD BE THE
LAWYERS THIS COULD BE THE
RECEPTIONIST.
THERE.
WE INVOLVED BUT THEY'RE NOT THE
ONES THEY'RE NOT THE FRONT LINE
THEY'RE NOT THE ONES TALKING TO
THOSE STUDENTS BUT THE BILL IS
WRITTEN IN A WAY THAT WE STILL
BELIEVE IS BIG ENOUGH THAT TO
CAPTURE THAT.
THOSE OF YOU KNOW SORT OF AGAIN
FUNDAMENTALLY WE AGREE WITH THE
BILL WE'VE TRIED IN EARNEST TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND I
BELIEVE WE STILL WILL.
BUT AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED AND
NEGOTIATED IN TEN MINUTES AGO
OUT IN THE HALLWAY WE ARE STILL
NOT THERE AND WE ARE STILL
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS LAURA
BROWN ON BEHALF OF TO YOU AND ON
BEHALF OF COURSE ERA IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE ARE
ONLINE PROGRAM MANAGERS WHO WORK
WITH NONTRADITIONAL EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERS. TO PROVIDE ONLINE
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA -- AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY OBVIOUSLY
WE WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER OF THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS
AND ALWAYS BEING AVAILABLE TO
DISCUSS OUR CONCERNS.
WE HAD WORKED WITH THE AUTHOR TO
SECURE AN EXEMPTION FOR A SMALL
NARROW SUBSET OF INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE NONPROFIT REGIONALLY
ACCREDITED INSTITUTIONS -- AND
THAT BECAME A RESULT OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING FROM THE AUTHOR
THAT HE DIDN'T MEAN TO AND
CAPTURE THESE SCHOOLS UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
IN WHAT WE DID WAS PROVIDE AN
EXEMPTION FOR THE SCHOOLS IN THE
ARTICLES OF EXEMPTION FROM THE
ACT THAT MAY HAVE BEEN AN
OVERSTAFFED -- BECAUSE THE
SENATE BMP AND OF COURSE YOUR
COMMITTEE ARE.
THE ART LOOKING AT THOSE BIGGER
ISSUES DURING SUNSET REVIEW.
BUT OUR ISSUE SPECIFICALLY IS
WITH THE REMOVAL OF THE FEDERAL
INCENTIVE COMPENSATION ROLE
WHICH ALLOWS FOR AN EXCEPTION
FOR THESE INSTITUTIONS OUR
PARTNER INSTITUTIONS TO PROVIDE
REVENUE SHARE.
AN ONLINE PROGRAM -- JUST BY WAY
OF BRIEF BACKGROUND ALL
pINSTITUTIONS WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE EXEMPT FROM THE ACT THOSE
ARE LAW SCHOOLS AS YOU KNOW ALSO
ALL NONPROFIT REGIONALLY
ACCREDITED INSTITUTIONS OUTSIDE
OF CALIFORNIA ARE EXEMPT FROM
THE ACT.
I EAT COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY LET'S
SAY BUT AS SOON AS AN OUTSIDE
NONPROFIT.
HAS A BRANCH WITH IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE AN IRONIC SITUATION
WHERE THEY'RE NOT EXEMPT HIM
FROM THE ACT.
SO BY WAY OF REMOVAL OF THE
FEDERAL AND SENT ROLE -- THOSE
PARTICULAR SUBSET OF INSTANT.
WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE AND NOT RULE WHICH
WOULD PROHIBIT ONLINE SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA SO JUST TO FURTHER
ELIMINATE PEPPER DYING HERE
WOULD BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE FEDERAL ROLE.
SO WOULD COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY
FROM ITS NEW YORK.
BASED RIGHT -- BUT IF THEY HAVE
A BRANCH CAMPUS IN CALIFORNIA
AGAIN THEY COULD NOT AND THAT
WOULD SEVERELY LIMIT THEIR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE AN ONLINE
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
SO WE'RE JUST SEEKING.
CLARITY AND TO CURE THAT ISSUE
SO THAT WE ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE
OUR INNOVATION INVESTMENT AND
OPPORTUNITY TO ENROLL CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ONLINE AND NOT
ARBITRARILY DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
THE SUBSET OF SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR SCOTT GOVERNOR
UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX IN
OPPOSITION.
FRED JONES ON BEHALF OF THE
PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY FEDERATION
CALIFORNIA WHICH INCLUDE SALON
OWNERS BUT ALSO THE SCHOOLS SOME.
OF THE SCHOOLS.
WANT TO BE.
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE OFFER FOR
WHAT YOU'VE DONE SO FAR IN THE
BILL AND FOR YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF.
BUT I DO ASSOCIATE OURSELVES
WITH MATH [inaudible]
THANK.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TOWARDS
MILAN HALF ASH FOR UNIVERSITY --
ALL ALONG WITH THE WAR BROWN'S
COMMENTS AND REGRETFULLY
OPPOSABLE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS IRAN ALL
TOMORROW ON BEHALF OF SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY COLLEGE IN
CARRINGTON COLLEGE.
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS THUS FAR
BUT WILL ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS
WITH THAT AMOUNT BACK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF OUR ON BEHALF OF YOU
WE AYE UNIVERSITIES WHILE WE ARE
PART OF THIS ONGOING
CONVERSATION REMAIN OPPOSED
TODAY INTO OVER.
FIXED.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
JENNIFER TANNA HILL WITH
AMERICAN CAREER COLLEGE IN WEST
COAST UNIVERSITY YOU ALSO MUST
TO REMAIN OPPOSED.
I KATHY VENISON MBM STRATEGY
GROUP OF ON BEHALF OF SOPHIA --
ALSO OPPOSED HOPING TO TO TO
WORK THINGS OUT SO WE CAN GO
NEUTRAL.
MICHAEL ARNOLD ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NORTH STATE
UNIVERSITY IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS STATED.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
BEFORE I GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I WOULD JUST --
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO KEEP
DOING WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE WANT TO GET
AFTER THE BAD ACTORS.
WE KNOW WE ALSO DON'T WANT TO
HARM THE GOOD ACTORS -- AND AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS SOME.
CREEK TECHNICAL SCHOOLS IN MY
DISTRICT IN RIGHT OUTSIDE MY
DISTRICT THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING
A REALLY GOOD JOB WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE DON'T HARM THEM.
BUT I JUST SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
STILL WORKING TOGETHER SO KEEP
UP THE GOOD WORK.
OF BRINGING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS CENTER GLAZER.
I  A CERTAINLY ASSOCIATE MYSELF
WITH THE JURORS REMARKS ON THIS
THIS SITE.
I DID GET OUT OF BE IN KEY WITH
THE CáC COMMITMENT TO WORK ON
THESE ISSUES.
AND I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
GOOD INTENTIONS OF CONTINUING TO
DO THAT BUT THERE IS A NEW
ELEMENT HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE
THAT WAS NOT ADDRESSED WAS AN
ISSUE IN THE EMPTY.
AND THAT'S THE ISSUE OF THE
NONPROFIT A REGIONALLY
ACCREDITED INSTITUTIONS WHICH I
THOUGHT WERE NOT A PART OF THIS
BILL.
THANK THE WHOLE FOCUS WAS ON FOR
PROFIT SO I'D LOVE TO HEAR FROM
THE AUTHOR ABOUT HOW WE HAVE NOW.
LAST TO DAN HAVE GROUP THAT.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS HAVE BEEN GOOD
ACTORS HAVE REGIONAL
ACCREDITATION.
WHY WHY IS THAT NOW PART OF THIS
BILL?
WELL IT IS CERTAINLY -- WAS --
CHANGED SINCE BEING A IT'S A
IT'S A PART OF THE NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THE AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND AS NOTED ON THE ANALYSIS --
THEY DID RAISE THIS ISSUE I
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THEN YOU DOWN THE ROAD WITH
THIS -- SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS TO
TO FURTHER.
ADDRESS THAT'S RIGHT I THINK
THAT I A GOOD PLACE FOR THESE
KINDS OF ISSUES TO BE ADDRESSED
AS IN SUNSET REVIEW WHICH WILL
BEGIN IN THE FALL.
AND CERTAINLY CARRY INTO NEXT
YEAR BUT IT IS DOES THIS BILL
INCORPORATE THAT.
WELL I I THINK I WANT TO GO BACK --
TO MY OPPONENTS.
NOT REALLY HAVE MORE POLITE.
THE OPPOSITION'S -- TESTIMONY
AND SHE SAID THAT WHEN THEY
DRAFTED THE FIRST TRACK AND THAT
MAYBE WAS A LITTLE TOO BROAD AND
SO WE IT WE ARE WORKING WITH
THEM AND HOPEFULLY WE GOT THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY WILL GO THE
PREPARATIONS AND SO.
WE'RE GOING.
TO TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT THAT AND
IF WE COULD COME UP WITH
SOMETHING WILL CERTAINLY SENT.
OUT SENATE BACK -- TO COMMITTEE
STAFF HERE THEN AND COMMITTEE TO
SEE IF IT GETS ME.
IF I COULD JUST ADD THE ON THE
NONPROFIT EXEMPTION THAT WAS
CLARIFIED.
WAS -- ADDED HAD HAD BEEN ADDED
IT WAS -- TAKEN OUT IN THE
SENATE B. AND P. [inaudible]
I COMMITTEE.
TAKE IT OUT HERE BUT IT WAS
FEEDBACK AT THAT AT THE
COMMITTEE THAT YANKED IT OUT I
THINK WE NEED TO END UP WE NEED
WE GO SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN
BECAUSE IT WAS TOO BROAD OF AN
TO BROUGHT OF AN EXEMPTION.
BUT I THINK THAT'S DOABLE AND
I'VE BEEN IN CONVERSATION WITH
OUR BROWN ABOUT HOW WE MIGHT BE
ABLE. TO TO DO THAT [inaudible]
OKAY.
IS THIS THIS ISSUE A BUNDLED
SERVICES CONTRACT.
IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE THEY ARE
CONTROVERSIAL BUT IT'S A MUCH
BIGGER ISSUE THAN.
THESE FEW NONPROFIT SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IT INVOLVES
THE PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS THAT IN
BRAWL INVOLVES NON.
NON POFITS MORE BROADLY AND SO
IT SHOULD BE HANDLED IN THAT.
IN THAT TERRITORY SO I IS I
THINK I THINK THAT WE CAN FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THIS.
BILL -- DELAYED THAT
CONVERSATION I WITH A MORE
NARROW AMENDMENT TO THEN HAD
GONE TO THE THAT HAD BEEN IN THE
BILL BEFORE -- OKAY WELL I KNOW
THAT I'M GONNA BE ASKED TO VOTE
ON THIS BILL TODAY.
AND SO -- MY HEARING FROM THE
AUTHOR.
THAT YOU'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THE LANGUAGE.
ON HOW THIS COMPENSATION IS --
IS WRITTEN THERE'S STILL A LOT
OF CONCERN WITH.
WITHOUT THAT THAT THE LANGUAGE
IS BEFORE US TODAY.
THAT MAKES ME UNCOMFORTABLE THAT
IT HASN'T BEEN FULLY VETTED OUT
AND I DON'T WANT TO INCLUDE.
I DON'T WANT TO SUPPORT A BILL
THAT INCLUDES.
HE'S VERY REPUTABLE NONPROFITS
THAT ARE NOT PART OF THE BAD
APPLES THAT WE ALL WANT TO TRY
TO GET OUT SO.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR IS.
TO WHAT YOUR INTENTIONS ARE
GOING.
FOR SURE AND AND THEN SHARED.
AFTER I RESPOND HERE I WANT TO
SEE IF WE CAN ALLOW THE
OPPOSITION TO FURTHER.
DISCUSS HER SUGGESTION IS THAT --
WE HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO TO
ATTEMPT. TO TO TO ADDRESS AND I
REALIZE THAT.
YOU HAD A DIRECTIVE FROM YOUR
COMMITTEE HERE WERE AND ED CAME
IN THERE KIND OF TOO LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT OPINIONS BUT WE THINK
THERE'S A CHANCE.
TO MEET IN THE MIDDLE WE DO HAVE
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
MIKE NAME IS OFF THE ONLY GO
BACK TO YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
BEFORE WE TAKE IT OUT.
DANCE ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
AND RESERVE THE RIGHT -- TO TO
YES NOT GET ARE SET FOR A MORE
POORLY I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE TRY.
TO HAVE A MEETING OF THE MINDS.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT. FOR YOU
IF IT GETS OUT OF APPROPRIATIONS.
FOR BRINGING UP ON THE FLOOR THE
YOU'LL GIVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ABOUT I COMMITTEE AS TO
WHETHER IT MEETS THAT OUR OUR
TEST.
YEAH AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
DO THAT BEFORE IT GOES THE FLOOR
I KNOW OF IS GHOST
APPROPRIATIONS RIGHT.
YES AND SO ARE HAVE HOPE THAT
OVER THIS -- BREAK WE GET USED
TO WORK ON IT [inaudible]
ENSURE.
IF YOU WANT RESPOND TO BE FINE
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE IT I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTARY THANK
YOU SENATOR.
I THINK THERE IS A MIDDLE GROUND
HERE AND YOU YOU RAISE A VALID
POINTS I DON'T THINK.
OF CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO SPEAK
FOR HER LEYVA BUT I DON'T THINK
THE INTENT HERE IS TO CAPTURE
THE SMALL SUBSET OF THE
INSTITUTIONS THIS IS A FOR
PROFIT.
A BILL PACKAGE MY MY
RECOMMENDATION IS TO I MEAN M
SUGGESTION WOULD BE TO HAVE A
SMALL TO A NARROWER EXEMPTION
WITH IN THE PROVISION IN WHICH
WERE SPEAKING ABOUT WHICH IS THE
FEDERAL RULE.
SO THAT YOU WOULD USE YOU WOULD
SAY THAT THESE INSTITUTIONS
NONPROFIT REGIONAL INSTITUTIONS
WOULD NOT BE IMPACTED.
BY THE FEDERAL RULE WHICH IS
SUBDIVISION M. AND I THINK WE
COULD WORK THROUGH THAT -- I I
DO THINK THE ISSUE OF EXEMPTIONS
I'M I CONCUR WE DIDN'T NEED TO
OVERSTAFFED AND PUT THE
EXEMPTION AND THE LARGER
ARTICLES OF EXEMPTION.
AND OBVIOUSLY -- THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT ISSUES TO DISCUSS
DURING BOTH COMMITTEE SENSE THAT
REVIEW I THINK THE IMMEDIATE.
SUGGESTION AND I MAKING WOULD
CURE THIS ISSUE FOR US.
AND I THINK THAT IT WOULD FOR ME
AS WELL I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
HEAR FROM THE OUGHT NOT TODAY
THAT HAS THAT.
AS THE CONVERSATION CONTINUES
YEAH AND THEN BIG PICTURE.
YOUR ACCURATE THE GOAL OF THIS
IS LOOKING AT THESE FOR PROFIT
ENTITIES THAT DON'T ALWAYS HAVE
THE BEST INTERESTS.
OF OUR TAXPAYERS AND OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR FAMILIES AND SO.
NONPROFIT.
OUR OUR LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT AND
SO WE WILL.
ATTEMPT.
TO EXCEPT IN A NUANCED SOLUTION
IT'S RIGHT VERY GOOD ANYTHING
ELSE FROM COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT.
A SOME OF WHICH ARE TO CLOSE AS
HE ARRIVED AT THE VERY GOOD TO
HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER ALSO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK CHANGE TO LASSELL.
WHO DOES SO I GLAZER PLEASE
THEIR AYE MCGUIRE PAN?
WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB THIRTEEN FORTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU.
COME ON DOWN PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR SENATORS APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON A.
B. THIRTEEN FORTY TODAY THIS
BILL IS ALSO PART OF THE BILL
PACKAGE.
RESPONDING TO RECENT ACTIONS BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND SECRETARY TO
BOSS WHO HAD BEEN IN CRITICAL
PROTECTIONS FOR STUDENTS
VICTIMIZED BY PREDATORY COLLEGES
THAT PRIORITIZED.
PROFIT OVER STUDENT SUCCESS.
THIS BILL WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS FROM OVER
PRICED INEFFECTIVE CAREER
TRAINING PROGRAMS BY PROVIDING
ESSENTIAL DATA. TO PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS IN THE PUBLIC ON
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES AT
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS.
THE ORIGINAL FEDERAL GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT RULE WAS IMPLEMENTED
TO ADDRESS AN ALL TOO COMMON
STORY STE OF STUDENTS PROMISED
BY RECRUITERS THAT THEY WILL
FIND A JOB IN AN INDUSTRY TO
TAKE OUT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN LOANS.
ONLY TO FIND UPON GRADUATING
THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET THE
JOB THAT THEY BELIEVE THEY WHAT.
THERE THAN ON EMPLOYER UNDER
EMPLOYED BUT STILL FACE
ASTRONOMICAL DEBT REPAYMENT.
BASED ON INITIAL DATA FROM THE
FEDERAL EDUCATION APARTMENT OVER
TO A FIFTY PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA FAILED THIS TEST.
THESE PROGRAMS GRADUATED FIFTY
SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO LEFT
SCHOOL WITH CLOSE TO A BILLION
DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
SCRAPPING THE ROLE -- WHICH
ACTUALLY HAPPENED -- TWO WEEKS
AGO UNDER THE DIRECTION OF BACK
TO THE BOSS THROUGH THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
HAS ELIMINATED A CRITICAL SOURCE
OF INFORMATION ON THE WAGES
STUDENTS AREN'T AFTER GRADUATING.
IN THE ABSENCE OF THIS DATA.
THERE'S ONLY BEEN UNRELIABLE
ALUMNI SURVEY DATA THAT WE HAVE.
AS AMENDED IN SENATE BMP THIS
BILL WILL TAKE A MAJOR STEP NO
ACTUALLY THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER GLAZER.
THIS BILL WILL TAKE A MAJOR STEP
TOWARD MAKING FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
MORE ACCOUNTABLE AROUND GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT BY CLOSING THE GAP IN
OUR STATE OUTCOME DATA.
BY CREATING A PROCESS FOR A WAGE
DATA MATCH WITH EDT THIS DATA
WILL BE AGGREGATED BY PROGRAM
AND BY INSTITUTION AND POSTED IN
A DATABASE FOR THE PUBLIC. TO
HELP SHED LIGHT ON THE ACTUAL
WAGES THAT STUDENTS GAIN AND
ALLOW AGAIN PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS
A PUBLIC ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS SO WITH
THAT WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES.
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS ARE.
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS ANGELA
PERRY I'M A POLICY ANALYST WITH
THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS AND I'M HERE TO
OFFER SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FORTY WHICH WOULD MAKE
RELIABLE VERIFIED OUTCOMES DATA
FROM FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS TAXPAYERS
AND POLICY MAKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
STUDENTS A PRIVATE COLLEGES OR
IN POST SECONDARY EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE HISTORICALLY NOT
HAD ACCESS TO RELIABLE OR VERIFY
DATA ON THEIR EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES.
MANY STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO NO
DATA AT ALL AND THE DATA THAT IS
AVAILABLE IS UNRELIABLE AND
INCOMPLETE.
THIS MEANS THAT STUDENTS ARE NOT
ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT THE INVESTMENT THEY ARE
MAKING WHEN THEY ND ROLL AND TO
MANY BAD ACTORS HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THIS TO PREY UPON
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS FOSTER KIDS SINGLE
MOTHERS AND VETERANS.
THIS LACK OF DATA ALSO LEAVES
POLICYMAKERS WITHOUT THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT HIGHER
EDUCATION POLICY IN CALIFORNIA.
ALL THREE OF THE PUBLIC SEGMENTS
HAVE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE OUTCOMES
DATA FOR THEIR GRADUATION FOR
THEIR GRADUATES CREATED THROUGH
AN IDENTICAL DATA MATCH WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT.
AND IS PLANS DEVELOPED TO CREATE
A STATEWIDE LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA THAT EDT
DATA WILL LSO PROVIDE THE WORK
FORCE OUTCOME FOR ANY
LONGITUDINAL SYSTEM.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THAT EDT
DATA AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS AT
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES AS WELL.
I WILL MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO
INCORPORATE THOSE STUDENTS INTO
THE CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
AS IT DEVELOPS.
AB THIRTEEN FORTIES MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS OF STREAMLINED THE
BILL WHILE STILL PRESERVING THIS
IS CENTRAL DATA MATCH ENSURING
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WILL
HAVE ACCURATE DATA.
EVEN AS THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
HAVE BEEN WITHHOLDING
INFORMATION AND ROLLING BACK
PROTECTIONS. FOR THESE REASONS
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS BOB
SHERMAN WITH THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION ALSO SUPPORTING -- AB
THIRTEEN FORTY AS A CRITICAL
FIRST STEP FOR THE STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY VALLEY KINCAID
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND A VETERAN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
REALLY RESONATE WITH SK YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER ON REPRESENT
NEXT IN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
IMAGES BUT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE CALL CHANCE OFFICE IN
SUPPORT.
THANKS THIRTIES AT WOODLAND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
[inaudible]
SEEING [inaudible] ONE DOWN.
YOU MIGHT LEARN REPRESENTING A
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL MOVING FORWARD TODAY THE
AMENDMENTS -- LOOK GOOD TO US
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO REVIEW
THEM THANK YOU SO MUCH TERRIFIC.
ANY OPPOSITION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS CENTER GLAZER.
THANKS YOU'RE LEVERAGES THE
THANK YOU AGAIN THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA THIS
IS A TERRIFIC BILL.
AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE IT
CORPORATE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHICH I CLOSE
SORT OF THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
AND MISTER GLAZER FOR YOUR WORK
WITH US ON THIS -- I'LL SAY TO
FINAL THINGS -- THIS BILL IS
AROUND DATA IT'S AROUND
TRANSPARENCY AS THE OLD SAYING
GO.
SUNSHINE IS BEST DISINFECTANT
OUR HOPE IS A STATE WILL SHED
LIGHT ON WHAT'S REALLY HAPPENING
AND OUR HOPE IS ONCE WE HAVE THE
STATE WE CAN DETERMINE NEXT
STEPS. TO FOR THE PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS AND WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER GLAZER I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN
FORTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILL CHANGE TO WRESTLE.
WITH US SO I A GLAZER PLEASE ARE
AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
VERY GOOD WE WILL LEAVE THAT
BILL A CALL AND I BELIEVE YOU'RE
PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF
OUR DAYS ARE BECAUSE YES -- THIS
MEASURE BERMAN THAT IS NOT BAD
GLAD.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO CELEBRATE MEMBER BERMAN IT
WOULD BE GREAT IF I CAN READ MY
NOTES.
WELCOME YOU ARE THE PROJECT
START WITH YOUR OWN ITEM FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN I WOULD LOVE TO
EXCELLENT SIR AB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU OF AN INSURANCE
SANDERS.
SB THIRTY FORTY ONE WOULD
PREVENT.
COVERT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES FROM
INVADING STATE OVERSIGHT.
SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD REQUIRE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
DETERMINE WHETHER AN INSTITUTION
THAT CLAIMS TO BE A NONPROFIT
COLLEGE IS ACTUALLY OPERATING AS
A NON PROFIT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
RECEIVING AN EXEMPTION.
FROM STATE OVERSIGHT.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS THE
APPROPRIATE ARBITER GIVEN ITS
EXISTING ROLE IN REVIEWING
NONPROFIT STATUS OF OTHER
ENTITIES.
WHICH IS DISCUSSED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN NARROWED IN
THE SENATE AND WOULD ONLY FOCUS
ON NONPROFIT COLLEGES THAT
PREVIOUSLY OPERATED AS A FOR
PROFIT COLLEGE.
ON OR AFTER JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND TEN SOME FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES ARE STARTING TO USE
NONPROFIT IS ARE CERTAINLY USE A
NONPROFIT LABEL.
MISLEADING STUDENTS ALL THE SAME
TIME DODGING APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT.
THESE COVERT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
ARE TRYING TO GAME THE SYSTEM.
RECLINING ENFORCEMENT OF
NONPROFIT STATUS BY THE FEDERAL
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE.
IS ALLOWING SOME FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES TO GET AWAY WITH USING
COMPLICATED FINANCIAL SCHEMES
AND SHELL CORPORATIONS TO LAY
CLAIM TO NONPROFIT STATUS.
THIS EMERGING PROBLEM IS ALREADY
AFFECTING CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
FOR EXAMPLE GRAND CANYON
EDUCATION INCORPORATED IS A FOR
PROFIT COMPANY TRADED ON NASDAQ.
THEY CREATED AT GRAND CANYON
UNIVERSITY AND CLAIM IT IS A
NONPROFIT COLLEGE.
HOWEVER THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NONPROFIT GRAND CANYON
UNIVERSITY IS ALSO THE CEO OF
THE FOR PROFIT GRAND CANYON
EDUCATION INC.
IN ABOUT 60% OF THE TUITION
REVENUE AT THE NONPROFIT COLLEGE
RECEIVES FLOWS THROUGH TO THE
FOR PROFIT COMPANY.
AS GEORGETOWN LAW PROFESSOR IN
NONPROFIT LAW EXPERT BRIAN
GALLEY SAID.
THE NONPROFIT IS ESSENTIALLY A
TRUSTWORTHY LOOKING WRAPPER
AROUND A FOR PROFIT BUSINESS.
THE ARANGEMENT MAKES A MOCKERY
OF THE CONCEPT OF A NONPROFIT.
WITHOUT AN OBJECTIVE CHECK ON
THE NONPROFIT CLEAN THESE COVERT
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES WILL
CONTINUE TO MISLEAD STUDENTS AND
AVOID APPROPRIATE STATE
OVERSIGHT.
IN FACT OTHER COLLEGES ARE
ALREADY FOLLOWING GRAND CANYON
UNIVERSITIES EXAMPLE IN CLAIMING
NONPROFIT STATUS.
THEREFORE CALIFORNIA MUST STEP
UP AND STEP IN TO PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS AND ENSURE THAT
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT REMAINS
FOR COVERT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
TRYING TO GAME THE SYSTEM.
I WANT TO REITERATE THAT I AM
COMMITTED TO CLARIFY HOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WOULD PROVIDE
NOTICE TO AN INSTITUTION.
IN THE BUREAU FOR PART FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
OF THE DETERMINATION AND WANT TO
THANK THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE --
ENSURE GLAZER OF THAT COMMITTEE
FOR THE SUGGEST A CLARIFICATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WHEN THIS IS IN
SUPPORT OF LIKE A GEYSER
FLIPPING SEE.
MAKE SURE.
YES INDIVIDUAL DIVERSITY I LIKE.
HE'LL BE BOB CHAIRMAN OF THE
SOUTH.
ASIAN -- SO BOTH CALIFORNIA AND
FEDERAL LAW HAVE LONG RECOGNIZED
THE NONPROFIT AND PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS HAVE BUILT IN
RESTRICTIONS AND STRUCTURES THAT
PROTECT CONSUMERS AND TAXPAYERS.
NONPROFITS MUST USE ALL OF THEIR
REVENUE FOR EDUCATIONAL AND
CHARITABLE PURPOSES AND NO ONE
IN A POSITION OF AUTHORITY IS
ALLOWED TO EXTRACT FUNDS IN THE
WAY THE FOR PROFIT OWNERS DO.
IT ALTERS THE INCENTIVES AND
THUS THEIR BEHAVIOR FUNDAMENTAL.
HOWEVER THE INTEGRITY OF THESE
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCES IS BEING
THREATENED BY A LACK OF
ENFORCEMENT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
AB THIRTY FORTY ONE TRIGGERS A
REVIEW FOR CALIFORNIA'S
REGULATORY PURPOSES OF COLLEGES --
OF THOSE COLLEGES THAT HAVE
CLAIMED.
THAT HAVE THAT HAVE CONVERTED TO
NONPROFIT STATUS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
INDEPENDENT AND THE WAY THAT
THEY ARE GOVERNED AND FINANCE.
AS IN MOST STATES ARE TURNING
GENERAL OFFICE IS THE OVERSIGHT
AGENCY FOR CHARITABLE ENTITIES
WITH DIVISIONS DEDICATED BOTH TO
THAT PURPOSE AND TO RELIEVE THE
RELATED CONSUMER PROTECTION
RESPONSIBILITIES.
SOME HAVE SUGGESTED THAT THE
FEDERAL THE BE -- FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD COULD BE ANOTHER PLACE FOR
THIS ROLE WELL THE FRANCHISE TAX
OR DOES HAVE AN EYE ON NON
PROFITS.
TAX PURPOSES THE CORPORATE
GOVERNANCE AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION ISSUES HERE MAKE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AN APPROPRIATE
AGENCY FOR THIS RESPONSIBILITY
ALONG WITH OF COURSE. FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION.
COURAGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS --
ANGELA PERRY WITH THE ISSUE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S FAILURE TO
EXERCISE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
AND SCRUTINY OF NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS PUTS CALIFORNIANS
AT RISK AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
WOULD PREVENT THESE COVERT FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS RENOVATING
STATE OVERSIGHT AND DECEIVING
STUDENTS.
WE ARE DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY VALLEY KINCAID
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
REALLY RESONATE WITH ESCAPE
CALIFORNIANS.
FOR I'LL HAVE ANOTHER NUMBER
PERCENT NEXT IN CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS.
I AM VERY SORRY YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE THE FASTEN SAID ROLLING.
OKAY.
ROOM AT THE TABLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M TRYING TO KEEP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
GEORGE MILLER HALF OF ASHFORD
UNIVERSITY -- WHILE WE AGREE
WITH THE INTENT OF THE BILL AND
THE ADDITIONAL SCRUTINY I WAS
THAT SOME IN THE REFERENCE TO
SOME OTHERS THINK THAT IT SHOULD
BE THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
THEY SHOULD LOOK AT THIS WE KNOW
THAT THAT IS NOT GOING TO BE THE
CASE -- SENATOR GLAZER MADE THAT
VERY CLEAR LAST WEEK.
IT IN OUR HEARING -- BUT WE
WOULD LKE TO AT LEAST HAVE SOME
ACCESS TO TO THE COURTS FOR
JUDICIAL REVIEW.
I THINK -- WE WERE LOOKING AT
THIS BILL AND WE WOULD SUGGEST
THAT IT POSSIBLY BE AMENDED TO
PERMIT INSTITUTIONS TO SEEK
DIRECT APPROVAL FROM THE COURTS.
WHICH IS SIMILAR TO THE CURRENT
PROCESS FOR REVIEW BY THE AG OF
OTHER SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES BY NOT
FOR PROFIT SUCH AS A CELL
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL THE ASSETS --
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T HAVE OUR
LEGAL COUNSEL WITH US TODAY BUT
THAT WAS MY UNDERSTANDING WE
WOULD JUST LIKE TO HAVE SOME
RECOURSE. TO IN ADDITION TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR POST
ATTORNEY GENERAL REVIEW AND HIS
DECISION.
TO SEEK SOME SORT OF REDRESS
THANK YOU.
KATHY VAN AUSTIN MBM STRATEGY
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE SOVIET SO --
CERTAINLY ECHO -- GEORGE
MILLER'S COMMENTS -- WE AGREE WE
SHARED THE INTEREST AND AND
SEEKING APPROVAL FROM -- SEE AT
HAVE TO BE.
UNDERSTAND IT'S PROBABLY NOT A
POSSIBILITY -- SO THEREFORE I
SOME SORT OF REDRESS TO THE
COURT.
OF WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL -- AND
SO WE CERTAINLY.
ENDORSE THAT REQUEST AND STANDS
STRONGLY BEHIND IT.
AND WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN
AMENDMENT THAT DEALS WITH THE
THE TERM CORE FUNCTION -- WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT CHANGE TO AN
INHERENTLY ACADEMIC FUNCTION IN
THE BILL AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS
IS THAT RIGHT STRENGTHENS -- THE
INTENT OF THE BILL IN TERMS OF
WHAT TYPE OF I FUNCTIONS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THERE ARE.
I. T. FUNCTIONS THERE ARE OTHER
TYPES OF ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS.
THERE ARE ACADEMIC FUNCTION SO I
THINK THIS WOULD GO A LONG WAY
TO SEPARATING OUT THE TO FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE SO WITH.
SERBIA WOULD BE HAPPY TO REMOVE
ITS OPPOSITION CERTAINLY WANT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME YOUR
STAFF'S BEEN GREAT.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
CENTER DRAWS YES JUST IF YOU
COULD RESPOND TO THE ISSUE OF
OTHER RECOURSE BESIDES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HAPPY TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
THAT WAS THE FIRST THAT I'VE
HEARD OF THAT BUT I WILL ADMIT
THAT I MISSED -- THE HE AND
ANOTHER SOMETHING OVER COVER
THAT FOR ME WHILE I WAS HAVING A
CROWN.
BUT IT'S A HABIT IT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT -- AND AND TALK
WITH THE THE FOLKS ARE CURRENTLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
SEE THAT'S POSSIBLE BUT DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE HAVE MUCH
THOUGHT TO THE TOP OF MY HEAD I
DON'T KNOW IF.
YOU WANT TO WEIGH IN YEAH.
VERY GOOD CENTER GLAZER.
YEAH I WAS AT THE HEARING AND
THEN THIS IDEA DIDN'T COME UP SO
THIS IS A NEW IDEA.
ABOUT A FOR THE FIRST TIME AND I
WOULD JUST ECHO.
MY COLLEAGUE SAID I REQUEST FOR
YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND SEE
IF YOU THINK IT WOULD DIE.
THIS OF THE BECOME AWARE AND
HAVE AND I'D LOVE TO GET
FEEDBACK HAVE A TAKE A LOOK.
AT THE EVIDENCE OF THE BILL.
OKAY VERY GOOD ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WHICH LIKE A CLOSE FAMILY MEMBER
RESPECT THIS RUBBLE VERY GOOD
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER GLAZER MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA I BELIEVE
THAT I WILL.
CHANGE.
SOMETIMES MODESTO I'D GLAZER
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
THE BILL HAS BEEN OPPOSED TO GET
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON I WAS TRYING
TO GIVE AWAY YOUR DUTIES A
LITTLE WHILE IT.
I'M GLAD YOU ARE HERE TO PRESENT
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB -- THIRTEEN
FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BEAR QUE HOT SO PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THEN SINCE THE SUMMER.
BEGAN WAS KIND ENOUGH TO PRESENT
MY BILL AND BE IN P. -- THAT
DIED AND I'M RETURNING THE FAVOR --
LIKE THAT HOPE WORK HOPEFULLY
I'M AS SUCCESSFUL AS SHE WAS.
NOT MY BILL.
MENTIONED CENTERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF
THE SOMETHING OVER POWER CAN.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS TO
SAFEGUARD THE NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
ENROLLED ONLINE AT FOR PROFIT
OUT OF STATE INSTITUTIONS.
THE LARGEST SHARE OF
CALIFORNIANS AND ROLLED ONLINE
AT SCHOOLS AND OTHER STATES
AREN'T ROLLED IN FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS ONE OF THE MOST
TROUBLED BUSINESS SECTORS TODAY.
ONLINE OUT OF STATE INSTITUTIONS
AT AND ROLL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
WORSE STUDENT.
LOAN REPAYMENT OUTCOMES IN
CALIFORNIA BASED DISTANCE
EDUCATION PROVIDERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE TOOK
STEPS TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS FROM POSSIBLE PREDATORY
OUT OF STATE ONLINE BUSINESSES
ARE REQUIRING THEM TO REGISTER
WITH THE BUREAU OF POST
SECONDARY PRIVATE EDUCATION.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW APPLIES ONLY
TO SCHOOLS PHYSICALLY LOCATED
WITHIN CALIFORNIA NOT
INSTITUTIONS BASED OUT OF STATE
THAT IN RURAL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ONLINE.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR EXTENDS
ALL THESE REFORMS IN CURRENT LAW
AND EXTENDS THESE PROTECTIONS TO
STUDENTS WHO CHOOSE TO ENROLL IN
ONLINE.
OUT OF STATE INSTITUTIONS
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS A
REGISTRATION PROCESS FOR OUT OF
STATE SCHOOLS.
BUT NO WAY FOR THE STATE TO
IDENTIFY PROBLEMS AT THE SCHOOLS
OR REMOVE THE ABILITY TO ENROLL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AT A SCHOOL
WHICH MAY POSE A RISK TO THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA.
THESE INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE INFORMATION
TO THE BUREAU WHICH MIGHT SIGNAL
THAT THERE'S REASON FOR CONCERN.
INCLUDING PENDING INVESTIGATIONS
AND LAWSUITS AS WELL AS
ACCREDITATION ISSUES.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE THESE DISCLOSURES AND
ADDITIONALLY OFFER A COMPLIANT
PROCESS EXCUSE ME COMPLAIN
PROCESS. FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AS WELL AS AS CREATE KEY
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS.
I WILL CLOSE THE GAP BETWEEN
STUDENTS ENROLLED AT IN STATE
INSTITUTIONS AND THOSE WHO
CHOOSE TO ENROLL ONLINE AND
PROGRAMS LOCATED OUT OF STATE.
AND WITH ME TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT IS ANGELA PERRY POLICY
ANALYST FOR THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
THANK YOU WELCOME BACK THANK YOU
SO MUCH -- I WILL START WITH THE
FACT THAT WELL WELL SOME HOPE
THAT ONLINE EDUCATION CAN HELP
MORE STUDENTS -- NOT COLLEGE
DEGREES THE PROMISE OF DISTANCE
EDUCATION ALSO HAS PERILS.
THE CHALLENGES IN ASSESSING
ACADEMIC RIGOR AND STUDENT
OUTCOMES FOR ONLINE PROGRAMS CAN
BE EVEN GREATER THAN IN
TRADITIONAL PROGRAMS AND THERE'S
A LONG HISTORY OF OVER PRICED
AND POOR QUALITY PROGRAMS
LEAVING STUDENTS WITH AN
AFFORDABLE DEBT.
AS YOU HEARD THERE ARE NEARLY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ENROLLED ONLINE IN
PROGRAMS THAT ARE LOCATED OUT OF
STATE.
AND THE LARGER SHARE OF THOSE
STUDENTS ARE A FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES WERE STUDENTS ARE
PARTICULARLY LIKELY TO END UP
WITH THE DEBT THEY CANNOT REPAY.
COMING IN LIKE A HURRICANE.
THE AVAILABLE DATA SHOW THAT
THERE IS REASON FOR CALIFORNIA
TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
STUDENTS OUT OF STATE
INSTITUTIONS THAT IN ROLE
CALIFORNIANS ONLINE HAVE A WORSE
STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENT OUTCOMES.
THAN TO CALIFORNIA BASED ONLINE
PROGRAMS.
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY WITH
PREDATORY FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
HAS LED TO THE CREATION OF MANY
LAWS DESIGNED TO PROTECT
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN CALIFORNIA
PROGRAMS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THESE LAWS
HAVE TRADITIONALLY ONLY APPLIED
TO THE STUDENTS.
IT'S A IN SCHOOLS LOCATED WITHIN
CALIFORNIA'S BORDERS NOT TO
SCHOOLS IN ROLLING CALIFORNIANS
BUT BASED ELSEWHERE.
CALIFORNIA TOOK AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN TWENTY SIXTEEN BY
REQUIRING OUT OF STATE COLLEGES
TO REGISTER WITH THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE EXISTING
REGISTRATION SYSTEM SUFFERS FROM
THREE KEY FUNDAMENTAL FLAWS.
FIRST THE STATE LACKS THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO IDENTIFY
REST TO CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
SECOND THE STATE LACKS THE
AUTHORITY TO REVOKE A SCHOOLS
REGISTRATION IF THE RISK IF
RISKS TO STUDENTS ARE IDENTIFIED.
AND THIRD OF THE SYSTEM LACKS A
COMPLAINT PROCESS MEANING
STUDENTS HAVE NO WAY TO IDENTIFY
ISSUES TO THE BUREAU PROACTIVELY.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WOULD
TAKE STEPS TO ADDRESS EACH OF
THESE ISSUES AND OFFER BETTER
PROTECTION TO STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN ONLINE OUT OF STATE PROGRAMS.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FOR THE STUDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE HI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
AROUND THE HAVE A CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY GARLIC IN KATE
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
THE SAME ORDER EVERY TIME CAN
REALLY ROSENBERGER WHEN I SEE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
IN ORDER. TO TAKE FROM THERE
WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER NUMBER PER SE
NEXT IN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
IMAGES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIVE CHANCE
OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
I'M HAIRMAN WITH THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
GOOD JOB.
I WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
SURVEYS ANY COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- THE BILL'S
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO LET ASSEMBLYMEMBER BEAR
QUE HAN KNOW THAT YOU DID A
GREAT JOB FOR HER THANK YOU AND
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER GLAZER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SEVENTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN
FORTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA I
BELIEVE AYE WILL HI WILK I
CHIANG TO WRESTLE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
WE WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE DOWN TO OUR
ALMOST LAST BILL OF THE DAY.
OF FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ.
WHEN SHE IS READY?
AND SHE'S HAD A BUSY DAY AS WELL
.
VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO LIVE CALLS ON BILLS FLOOR
WAITING FOR A LAST AUTHOR.
MADAME SECRETARY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY
.
ITEM THREE AB TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
HASN'T VOTED TWO ZERO WILK HI
WILK I CHIANG GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL. SEVEN
SEVEN OKAY.
ITEM SEVEN AB FOR NINETY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HAS ABILITY
TO ZERO WILK HI WILK I CHANGED.
GLAZER PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE
PAN.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL.
ITEM EIGHT AB NINE OH ONE THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FOUR
ZERO CHIANG GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE. TO LEAVE
THAT BILLING CALLS WELL.
ITEM NINE A. B. NINE THIRTY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE HASN'T VOTED
TWO ZERO WILK HI WILK I CHIANG.
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
WE THAT BELONG CALLS.
IF YOU INTEND SO ITEM TEN AB TEN
THIRTY SIX THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I FOUR ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
REALLY THAT PHONE CALL.
ITEM TWELVE AB TWELVE NINETEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
THREE ZERO WILK HI WILK I GLAZER
[inaudible]
MCGUIRE CAN.
THAT PHONE CALL.
I AM FIFTEEN AB THIRTEEN FORTY
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED TO
APPROACH.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE VICE
CHAIR HASN'T VOTED THREE ZERO
WILK.
HI WILK I CHIANG [inaudible]
MCGUIRE PAN.
USUALLY THAT FELL ON CALL.
WE CAN GO [inaudible]
NEXT.
WE NEED. FOR THIS. ONE TWENTY
WHEN WE NEED A MOTION.
YEAH.
LEFT FILE ITEM.
TWENTY ONE WHICH IS I. A. B.
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAY IS THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR GLAZER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TWENTY ONE A. B. SIXTEEN
SIXTY SIX THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL HI WILK I CHIANG
WHO WRESTLED GLAZER PLEASE ARE
AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
HI CAN I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON
CALL AND WE HAVE OUR AUTHOR HERE
SO WE ARE GOING TO INVITE YOU
RIGHT UP.
COME ON DOWN FILE.
HE HE MOVES VERY QUICKLY.
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE ACA
FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ WELCOME BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AC FOURTEEN
IT'S SIMPLY A RESOLUTION THAT
ASKED VOTERS WHETHER THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
ENSURE THAT ALL WORKERS WHO
PERFORM SUPPORT SERVICES AT THE
UC.
ARE FOR THE SAME EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY STANDARDS
AS YOU SEE EMPLOYEES.
BEYOND PROVIDING WORLD CLASS
INSTRUCTION AND RESEARCH IT IT'S
CAMPUS MEDICAL CENTERS THE UC IS
THE STATE'S THIRD LARGEST
EMPLOYER IN AS AN ANCHOR IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH IT OPERATES.
IN RECENT YEARS THE UC HAS
OUTSOURCING ESTIMATED SEVEN
THOUSAND SUPPORT JOBS WHILE THE
SAME TIME INCREASING NUMBER OF
HIGHLY PAID ADMINISTRATORS TO
APPROXIMATELY.
EIGHT THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED THIS
RESULT IN ANNUAL A MYSTERY
PAYROLL COST INCREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS.
THIS MATCHES THE MAIL THE UC HAS
PREVIOUSLY ESTIMATED WOULD COST
OFFER OUTSOURCED WORKERS A FULL
PROTECTIONS AND EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY STANDARDS ENJOYED BY
THE UC EMPLOYEES.
ACA FOURTEEN WILL PROTECT
SERVICE WORKERS THAT YOU SEE
FROM THE POLICIES THAT PRODUCE
ECONOMIC RACIAL AND GENDER
DISCRIMINATION.
IN RESPONSE TO CONCERNS RELATED
TO THE NEED FOR FLEXIBILITY TO
HANDLE EITHER MEDICAL
EMERGENCIES OR UNANTICIPATED
NEEDS ANYWHERE IN THE UC SYSTEM.
WE TOOK AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY THAT INCORPORATE UC'S
CURRENT POLICIES FOR THE USE OF
TEMPORARY PER DIEM UNIVERSITY
EMPLOYEES. TO BE CLEAR NEITHER
THE LEGISLATURE NOR THE GOVERNOR
CAN ADDRESS A SYSTEMATIC
INEQUITIES THAT OCCUR DUE TO
UC'S AUTONOMY UNDER ARTICLE NINE
OF THE CONSTITUTION.
HOWEVER ARTICLE TO THE
CONSTITUTION GIVES THE
LEGISLATURE THE POWER AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO ALLOW VOTERS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS IN OUR
STATE.
I SIMPLY ASK THAT YOU ALLOW THE
VOTERS DECIDE WHETHER LOW INCOME
SERVICE WORKERS AT THE UC.
THOSEWHO CLEAN THE TOILETS MOW
THE LAWN SERVE OUR FOOD AND
CLEAN CLEAN THE BED HANDS SHOULD
ENJOY THE SAME STANDARDS ENJOYED.
ARE YOU SEE EMPLOYEES DOING THE
EXACT SAME WORK.
I'VE WITNESSES HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU CAN WHEN YOU'RE READY
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CAPTION WEINBERGER PRESIDENT OF
APPS ME.
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE THE
PEOPLE WERE TALKING ABOUT AN ACA.
FOURTEEN ARE CLEANING TOILETS
AND TING BED PANS PICKING UP
TRASH.
THERE COOKING THE FOOD
MAINTAINING THE BUILDINGS
SUPPORTING DOCTORS.
FACULTY NURSES STUDENTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
POINTS.
FIRST THE ACA APPLIES AT THE
EXPIRATION OR RENEWAL OF
EXISTING CONTRACTS.
SO THAT MEANS THERE IS A BUILT
IN PHASE IN PERIOD FOR UP TO TEN
YEARS [inaudible]
SECOND.
NOTHING IN THE ACA REQUIRES THE
UC TO HIRE THE SAME NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES.
OR ANY SPECIFIC INDIVIDUAL
EMPLOYEE.
IN ADDITION TO THE EXCEPTIONS
FOR MEDICAL EMERGENCY NEEDS THE
SECOND AMENDMENT ON PAGE FIVE OF
THE ECA IS TAKEN DIRECTLY FROM
UC'S CURRENT POLICY.
IT IS A BROAD EXEMPTION FOR PER
DIEM UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES AND
GIVES YOU SEE FLEXIBILITY TO
ADDRESS ANY ADDITIONAL SHORT
TERM.
TEMPORARY STAFFING NEEDS.
THIS INCLUDES EVERYTHING FROM
CLEANINGS STUDENT DORMS TO
CLEANING A MEDICAL PATIENTS BUT
PAN.
FINALLY BECAUSE NEITHER THE
GOVERNOR NOR THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE THE POWER TO ENSURE SUPPORT
SERVICES WORKERS ARE TREATED
EQUALLY.
I ASK YOU TO CONSIDER YOU
EXERCISE YOUR ARTICLE TWO POWERS.
TO PLACE ON THE BALLOT FOR YOUR
VOTERS TO DECIDE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
HI MY NAME IS QUITE A PER
PRODUCT IS HERE TO ANSWER
POTENTIAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WELCOME TO THE FRONT OF THE LINE
THIS TIME.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH US
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA I'LL BE
HORSE RENDON THOUSAND MEMBERS
INCLUDING OUR CLASSIFIED AT THIS
YEAR'S HUMAN K. THROUGH.
TWELVE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS.
STEVEN LEVERETT ASKED ME
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JOHN RUN DIDN'T ARE WITH THE YOU
SEE YOU SEE A. F. T. THE IN THE
REPRESENTS LIBRARIANS LECTURES
AT THE DOORS OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
RIGHT NOW THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
I CAN MAKE LITTLE WOMEN A FRIEND.
THANK YOU. FOR IN THE SMALL ROOM
RIGHT NOW.
AT THE SMALL TABLE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY TO
MINUTES EACH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- JASON MURPHY ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA -- HERE TODAY
UNFORTUNATELY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE I
WANT TO FIRST SAY THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA CARES
DEEPLY ABOUT THE NEED.
TO PROVIDE FOR A FLEXIBLE OF A
BLAND APPROPRIATE BLEND OF IN
HOUSE STAFF AND CONTRACTORS
STAFF WOULD TAKE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY VERY SERIOUSLY
THINK IT'S A SHOWN.
IN TERMS OF OUR INTEREST
ENSURING THAT ARE LOWER WAGE
WORKERS PARTICULARLY CONTRACT
WORKERS.
EARN A FAIR WAGE.
IN FACT THAT AND PRESENT
APARTADO ANNOUNCED BACK IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE FAIR WAGE FOR
WORK PROGRAM WHICH BY THE FIFTY
DOLLAR PER HOUR.
MINIMUM WAGE IS NOW IN EFFECT
FOR ALL EMPLOYEES AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA -- AS
WE'VE ALSO MENTIONED IN OUR PAST
TESTIMONY -- THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD IN OUR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
FOR MANY YEARS.
REQUIREMENTS AND RESTRICTIONS ON
OUR ABILITY TO CONTRACT OUT
THOSE REQUIREMENTS AS CONTRACT
OUT ONLY IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE CERTAIN
TYPES OF SPECIALIZED SERVICES.
SPECIALIZED EQUIPMENT ARE
REQUIRED OR IN CASES WHERE FOR
EXAMPLE THE SERVICES ARE TAKING
PLACE. TEN MILES AWAY FROM
CAMPUS OR THE MEDICAL CENTER AND
SO FORTH -- AGAIN THESE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE.
WHERE DODD TRIMMING TREES OR
WASHING WINDOWS ABOVE THE FIRST
FLOOR AND SO FORTH REQUIRES
SPECIALIZED EQUIPMENT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE WE DON'T?
MAINTAIN WE DON'T -- HAVE
PURCHASED ON ON CAMPUS.
HEY A ONE SPEAK FOR A MOMENT
ABOUT THE THE NOTION IS
EXPRESSED IN THE PAST ABOUT THE
NOTION OF DISPLACEMENT AND HOW
THE UNIVERSITY IS.
SHEDDING WORKERS AND STAFF I
WOULD NOTE IN OUR LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT YOU ALL RECEIVED
IT NOTED THAT.
IN FACT OUR DATA ON REPRESENTS
STAFF INCLUDING STAFFERS AND BY
ASKED ME HAS SHOWN OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS THOSE NUMBERS HAVE
GROWN.
WAS NUMBERS HAVE GROWN FOR
ASKING WORKERS BY 17% IN FACT.
AND SO IT IS THE CASE THAT THE
NUMBERS OF FOLKS IN HOUSE ON HER.
ARE NORMALLY -- NOT DECLINING
THE GROWING AS WELL.
I'VE ALSO -- HURTING COMMITTEE
TODAY THIS NOTION THAT.
THE UNIVERSITY'S AUTONOMY
PREVENTS -- THE LEGISLATURE OR
THE GOVERNOR FROM ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE ABSENT IN A CA.
I WANT TO MENTION I DON'T THINK
THAT'S ENTIRELY ACCURATE IN FACT
THIS IS THE FIFTH YEAR THAT ASK
ME IS BROUGHT THIS TYPE OF BILL
THIS TYPE OF EFFORT FORWARD.
EACH OF THE LAST FOUR YEARS
INCLUDING THREE YEARS OF BILLS
BY CENTER LARA AND THE BILL LAST
YEAR BY MISS WEBER.
UNIVERSITY HAS STATED VERY
CLEARLY THAT IF THE BILLS WERE
TO PASS THESE ARE BILLS THAT
AFFECTED THE UNIVERSITY OF
PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE.
THAT THOSE WOULD IMPACT
UNIVERSITY DIRECTLY AND WE WOULD
BE PROHIBITED FROM BEHAVE IN THE
WAY THAT THOSE BILLS WERE
OTHERWISE PRECLUDING US FROM. TO
THE POINT THAT WAS RAISED
EARLIER ABOUT THIS BEING A ALONG
PHASE AND THE A. C. A. B. ALONG
PHASE AND I THINK THERE'S A
MISNOMER THAT SOMEHOW THE
UNIVERSITY HAS A LARGE NUMBER OF
TEN YEAR CONTRACTS.
AND IT TO EXTEND THE DAC WERE TO
PASS WOULD BE A TEN YEAR
GRADUATED PHASE AND I ALSO
DISAGREE THAT THAT'S THE CASE I
THINK THAT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA TYPICALLY HAS TWO AND
THREE YEAR CONTRACTS.
AND AS WE READ THE THE LANGUAGE
OF ACA FOURTEEN IT SUGGESTS THAT
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS ACA WOULD
TAKE EFFECT AT THE EARLY STATE
UPON WHICH I THE CONTRACT
EXPIRES.
OR WHEN THE CONTRACT COULD BE
AMENDED.
THE CONTRACT COULD BE AMENDED AT
ANY TIME SO IN OUR MINDS
EFFECTIVE FOR THE FIRST EIGHT
THIS IS A C. WERE TAKE AFFECT.
THOSE CONTRACTS TO BE SUBJECT TO
THE EFFECTS OF THIS A CA AS WELL.
AND THEN LASTLY -- I JUST WANT
TO TOUCH ON THE FISCAL FOR A
MOMENT I KNOW THIS ISN'T THE
FISCAL COMMITTEE BUT OUR LETTER
HAS ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THE FISCAL
ESTIMATE OF A HUNDRED SEVENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IF THIS A CA
WERE TO PASS.
JUST WANT TO REITERATE THAT IS
THE EFFECT OF BOTH THE WAGE --
PREMIUM AND THE BENEFIT PREMIUM
THAT THE UNIVERSITY BE REQUIRED
TO COVER IN THE EVENT THAT WE
HAD TO BRING THIS WORK IN HOUSE
IS -- CERTAINLY THE CASE THAT
THE LANGUAGE A CA DOES NOT SAY
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE THE SAME
NUMBERS WORKERS IF THE AC WERE
TO PASS AS WE HAVE NOW ON
CONTACTED STATUS.
BUT THE FACT IS THE WORK DOES
NEED TO BE DONE AND WE DO EXPECT
TO BRING ON EACH AND EVERY
PERSON THAT WOULD BE AFFECTED --
IF THE AC OR TO PASS SO WITHOUT
I WANTED TURNED OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE -- FROM YOU SEE HEALTH.
HE USED UP ALMOST ALL YOUR TIME
YOUR ABOUT FORTY FIVE SECONDS.
A QUICKLY GREAT NAME IS ANGELA
KELLY ITEM THAT STATE POLICY
DIRECTOR.
FOR ARE YOU SEE HOW -- AND IT
JUST DIDN'T SHORT.
THE LIMITATIONS THAT A CA -- IT
WOULD IMPACT WOULD IMPACT --
PATIENT CARE -- THERE'S AN
AMENDMENT IN THE BILL AND WE'VE
HEARD REPEATEDLY THAT PER DIEM
WORKERS CAN BE USED PRETTY AND
WORKERS ARE WORKERS THAT.
ARE UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES BUT
THEY'RE ALSO EMPLOYED AT OTHER
PLACES SO WHEN WE CALL A PER
DIEM WORKER TO COME TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM SHE OR HE CAN SAY
I HAVE IT'S SHIFTED SATTAR
KAISER MERCY.
OTHER HOSPITALS AND MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE SO WHAT IT IS IT IT IS
NOT A COMPLETE SOLUTION IT IS
NOT.
IT IT'S IT'S A SOLUTION WE WE WE
USE -- AS A PRIORITY OVER
CONTRACT WORKERS AND IT IS NOT
SUFFICIENT SO WE HAVE AN AVERAGE
NUMBER VAGUE VACANCIES AT THE
UNIVERSITY THAT ARE VERY
DIFFICULT TO FILL SO I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
PERFECT THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
TURKEY SCENE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WERE AND
WHERE POST.
KELLY BROOKS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS
WERE ALSO OPPOSED.
MAURICE RICHARDSON -- REPRESENT
A CALIFORNIA HOUSE WITH
ASSOCIATION WE ALSO OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEE NO OTHER
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
BEFORE WE GO OPEN OF THE
COMMITTEE I JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT I'M PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER.
WELL THANK YOU.
I KNOW THAT.
THE AUTHOR AS A CHAMPION FOR
WORKERS IN AND I THINK THAT'S
THE HEART OF WHY SHE'S BRINGING
THIS TO US AND I APPRECIATED
ADMIRE YOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THAT.
AND YOU KNOW FOR ME THIS IS A
NUCLEAR OPTION IN MANY WAYS AND
SO I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND BETTER.
WHAT AT WHAT STEPS HAVE GOT HAVE
HAVE?
THOSE WHO CARE ABOUT THIS GONE
THROUGH WITHIN THE SYSTEM ITSELF.
THIS IS BEEN A SUBJECT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ASSISTANCE
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN AGENDAS BY
THE REGENTS AND IF SO HOW HAVE
THEY ACTED I APPRECIATE THAT A
LIMITATION.
AND IF IT'S OKAY I'LL I'LL DEFER
TO CATHERINE WHO.
HAS HIS LIVED EVERY MOMENT OF
THIS.
AS HAS BEEN RAISED THERE WERE
PREVIOUS ATTEMPTS -- TO APPROACH
THIS ISSUE LEGISLATIVELY THOSE
WERE ATTEMPTS TO REGULATE THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
THIS IS AN EFFORT TO ACTUALLY
BRING THIS PUBLIC INSTITUTION IN
LINE WITH SISTER PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS.
MY QUESTION IS IS THIS A MATTER
IS AT THAT AND DISCUSSED IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WITH THE
WITH YOU SEE.
THIS IS A CONCERN FOR WORKERS AT
UC HOWEVER THE ACA IS A MATTER
OF PUBLIC POLICY IT IS DIFFERENT
FROM AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN TWO
PRIVATE PARTIES.
RIGHT I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT BEFORE PULLING THE
TRIGGER ON AN ACA.
WHAT IS THE PROCESS THAT'S GONE
FORTH WITHIN THE INSTITUTION
ITSELF TO JUSTIFY THIS TYPE OF
ACTION?
NO YOU'RE NOT ASKING FOR
LEGISLATIVE ACTION ALTHOUGH YOU
NEED US TO PUT THIS ON THE
BALLOT.
REALLY TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IS
THE SUBJECT OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING LET'S START THERE.
IN THE UC SYSTEM.
THERE ISN'T EFFORTS -- TO
ADDRESS THIS IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
RESPONSE TO THE PREVIOUS YEAR'S
EFFORTS.
LEGISLATIVELY AND REPEATED CALLS
FROM WORKERS AT THE UNIVERSITY
IS ACTUALLY AN EXPANSION.
OF A CONTRACTING OF THIS WORK SO
WE HAVE SEEN ACTUALLY MORE
OUTSOURCING.
OF THIS WORK NOT LESS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MY QUESTION IS IS
THIS A MATTER THAT'S BEEN
SUBJECT TO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
THIS IS A CONCERN IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AND ACT AND DO YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY WITHIN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING TO REACH
THESE TYPES OF AGREEMENTS ABOUT
OUTSOURCING.
THROUGH COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WE
DO NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO REACH
A PUBLIC POLICY THAT ENSURES
THAT PEOPLE ARE TREATED EQUAL AT
THE UNIVERSITY WHICH IS.
WHAT THIS IS?
I THINK IN IN FOR CLARIFICATION
SO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IS
GOING TO DETERMINE THE WORKERS
AT THE UNIVERSITY ALREADY THIS
DOESN'T TOUCH THE WORKERS -- AND
IN THE APPS ME COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING UNIT IT TOUCHES
WORKERS THAT DON'T HAVE A UNION
WHO ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS SO
THAT'S I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
MAKES IT MORE CLEAR.
AND SO THAT GOES BEYOND THE THE
THE SCOPE OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING FOR IT ASKED ME
THIRTY TO NINETY NINE WORKERS.
OKAY SO CONTRACTING OUT IS NOT
AN S. AND SUBJECT OF THAT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WITHIN
YOUR DISTINCT -- UNIONIZED
WORKFORCE THAT WHAT I'M
UNDERSTANDING THEN.
WE HAVE AND WE DO RAISE THE
CONCERN OF CONTRACTING OUT IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
THAT IS A SEPARATE PROCESS FROM
THE CONCERNED WE'RE ADDRESSING
HERE WHICH IS CREATING AS A
MATTER OF POLICY PUBLIC POLICY.
THAT CAN EXTEND. FOR GENERATIONS.
THAT THOSE DOING THE SAME WORK
AT THE UNIVERSITY BE TREATED
EQUAL.
OKAY LET ME TRY THANK YOU THAT
THAT HELPS ME THERE AND THEN THE
SECOND QUESTION WAS ABOUT.
THERE'S A BOARD OF REGENTS THAT
TOUGH SETS POLICY FOR THE FOR
THE INSTITUTION.
HAVE YOU HAS THIS BEEN A JAN
DIES AMONG THE REGION'S OR
DISCUSSION AND THEIR PUBLIC
POLICY DECISION MAKING OF THIS
THAT HAPPENED WITHIN THE THEN
YOU WERE SU CALIFORNIA.
MANAGER CAN ANSWER THAT QUESTION
PLEASE -- MISTER GLAZER -- YES
THE ANSWER IS YES WE D HAVE A
NEW BOARD CHAIR A REGION JOHN
PEREZ WHO TOOK A AFFECT JUST A
FEW DAYS AGO AND WE HAVE A CHEN
DIES AT THE JULY.
MEETING THE REGION'S A
CONVERSATION IS QUESTION ITEM
ABOUT PRINCIPLES -- SURROUNDING
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
PROPERLY CONTRACT OUT.
I IF I MAY ALSO GO BACK TO YOUR
ORIGINAL QUESTION I WOULD STATE
VERY CLEARLY THAT -- DISCUSSION
AROUND AND AND ISSUES AROUND
CONTRACTING OUT ARE CLEARLY AND
SQUARELY BEING DISCUSSED RIGHT
NOW AT THE BARGAINING TABLE TING
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND ASKED
ME.
IF I WERE TO CHARACTERIZE THE
KIND OF THE THREE BROAD AREAS OF
DISCUSSION WITHIN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING OF DESCRIBING HIS
WAGES.
RETIREMENT AND CONTRACTING OUT
LANGUAGE AND CLEARLY AS I WAS A
TESTING TO EARLIER -- OUR PAST
AGREEMENTS WITH ASKED ME HAVE
CONTAINED ARTICLES WITHIN THE
CONTRACT THIS SPEAK TO
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA CAN
CONTRACT OUT.
THOSE WERE THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
DESCRIBED EARLIER ABOUT -- NOT
SOLELY SAVE MONEY BUT IN THE
CASES WHERE HE SPECIALIZED
EQUIPMENT SPECIALLY SERVICES AND
SO FORTH.
SO THOSE ISSUES AGAIN ARE ARE
BEING DISCUSSED WE'VE TRADED
LANGUAGE WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
TRADE LANGUAGE WITH ASKED ME.
IN THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
CONVERSATION AS RECENTLY AS LAST
WEEK OR TWO ABOUT JUST WHAT THAT
PARTICULAR LANGUAGE WOULD LOOK
LIKE.
THE AMOUNT OF LANGUAGE IN THE
LAST -- CONTRACTING.
SELECT BARGAIN AGREEMENT WAS TWO
OR THREE PAGES OF MATERIAL
RELATIVE TO CONTRACTING OUT
TERMS AND OBLIGATIONS AND SO.
THAT'S THE CONVERSATION WE'RE
HAVING RIGHT NOW AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE AS WELL.
CAN I ADD TO THAT BECAUSE IT'S A
LITTLE FRUSTRATING AND I'M NOT
INVOLVED IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING OF OF THIS UNION -- I
WILL SAY LIKE ANYTHING TWELVE
YEARS AGO I WAS ARRESTED AT A UC
REGENTS MEETING BECAUSE WE WERE
FIGHTING FOR THIRTY TO NINETY
NINE WORKERS WHO -- WE'RE
FIGHTING CONTRACT -- SO HAS IT
BEEN BROUGHT UP YES IT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP FOR WELL OVER A
DECADE AT THE UC REGENTS -- IN
THE MEANTIME THEY CONTINUE TO
APPROVE CONTRACTS OF OF MASS --
AT CONTRACTING OUT SO -- BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN A CHEN DIES BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED BECAUSE IT'S
EIGHT CONDITION OR OR SOMETHING
THAT IS BROUGHT UP IN AND THIS
IS IN PRODUCT AND COLLECT PART
WHAT'S BROUGHT UP IF COURSES.
IS DISPLACEMENT OF CURRENT
COLLECTED OF CURRENT UNION
MEMBERS -- YES THE DISCUSSION
HAPPENS DOESN'T GET RESOLVED
ABSOLUTELY NOT I MEAN THE THE
NUMBER OF TIMES WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION AND CONTINUE TO
FIGHT THIS BATTLE IS RIDICULOUS
IT EVEN IF.
THIS REGION AT THIS ORDER
REGION'S WHO ARE FACING NOW --
AN ACA IN AND AND FACING GOING
TO THE VOTERS TO TRY TO EXPLAIN --
THEIR BIZARRE UP PUBLIC POLICY
WHEN IT COMES TO TO OTHERWISE
LINE WORKERS -- IT EVEN WITH
THAT ANYTHING THEY DO OR OR WHAT
WOULD SUGGEST TO DO CAN BE
UNDONE THE VERY NEXT DAY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS MAKE A
PERMANENT PUBLIC POLICY.
THAT ENSURES THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ACTS AS A RESPONSIBLE
PUBLIC AGENCY AND TREATS WORKERS
EQUALLY -- WHETHER THE UNION OR
NONUNION WHETHER THEY WORK FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OR THEY'RE
CONTRACTED OUT THAT'S I THINK
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
TODAY -- SO DESPITE.
YEARS AND PROBABLY LONGER BUT
THEN I WAS IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT
A DECADES OF OF DISCUSSION --
THE RESOLUTION -- IN IN NAME IS
THERE CAN BE A RESOLUTION THIS
TIME WOULD BE WOULD BE JUST A
TEMPORARY RELIEF.
I'M JUST OF CLOTHES THAT WILL
THANK YOU I KNOW THAT THE
INTENTIONS ARE GOOD ONES AND I
CERTAINLY I CAN'T ARGUE WITH
THAT WITH THE GOALS THAT YOU
HAVE AND I GUESS THE FOR ME AT
LEAST IT'S YOU WANNA YOU WANNA.
MAKE SURE THAT -- THE REMEDY
MATCHES THE YEAH BUT THE PROBLEM
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
SOME FRUSTRATION.
ABOUT I GUESS THIS ISSUE --
WITHIN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING I
GUESS THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
ACTIVELY AND CONVERSATION.
IT'S CERTAINLY THE BETTER PLACE
TO HAVE THESE THINGS SETTLE.
AND CERTAINLY THE BOARD OF
REGENTS IS A BETTER PLACE -- AND
AND EVEN THE LEGISLATURE LET
ALONE.
IN A CA ON THE BALLOT SO THAT
THAT'S REALLY.
THE HESITATION THAT I BRING TO
THIS AND DIED I'M NOT OUT OF
RESPECT YOUR GOOD INTENTIONS AND
WHAT YOU WANT BUT ARE THERE
OTHER WAYS TO RESOLVE THIS.
WITHOUT IT HAS DRAMATIC AS AN AC
SO I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU SIR WILK.
I THANK YOU FOR BRING THIS FOR
IS IS PRINCIPLE COOPER THIS BILL
IS A QUESTION OF EQUITY.
AND AS WELL WERE IN THE PURSUIT
OF SO SOMETHING IS IT IS LIKE.
THE BUZZ CUT AND ALL AND IN OUR
HOUSE IS IS HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLAR FIGURE THAT THE
UC'S THROWING OUT THERE.
SO I WANT TO KNOW IF YOU HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION TO THINK.
IF THAT IS A LEGITIMATE NUMBER
THAT'S JUST A SCARE TACTIC AND
HOW WOULD THAT NUMBER COMPARE.
WITH IF THEY TRANSFERRED OVER IN
AND DID THE RIGHT THING
[inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU SO THE UNIVERSITY SAYS
THAT THEY ARE CURRENTLY ALREADY.
SPENDING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. THREE HUNDRED MILLION
OF THAT.
IS LABOR COSTS BASIC LABOR COST.
AND THEN TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
WOULD BE THE OVERHEAD COST
[inaudible]
SO.
THEY SAY ALSO THAT THE ACA WILL
COST AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO MILLION.
LEAVING YOU WITH THE IMPRESSION
THAT THE TOTAL COST.
IS SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION.
LEAVING OUT THE ONE AS THESE
CONTRACTS EXPIRE.
THE OVERHEAD COSTS [inaudible]
GOES AWAY [inaudible]
LEAVING US.
WITH WHAT THE UC IS ALREADY.
CURRENTLY SPENDING [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
AGAIN SENATOR [inaudible]
THE ACA.
ACTUALLY KIND OF PAYS FOR ITSELF
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
PART OF ME CHAIRMAN K. CORNELIUS
BURKE WITH A MAYOR COUNCIL WE'RE
CURRENTLY WHERE.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
BEFORE I ASK YOU TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN I JUST WANT TO
SAY I THINK SOMETIMES A SOMEONE
WHO WORKED IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT
FOR TWENTY YEARS AND AGO SHE
CONTRACTS. FOR MANY OF THOSE
YEARS -- I THINK SOMETIMES
PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T NEGOTIATED A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
SEE IT AS THIS PANACEA AS A
GLOBAL JUST COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN
IT IS JUST SO EASY -- AND IT'S
NEGOTIATIONS ARE INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH WORKERS AND YOU'RE DEALING
WITH MANAGEMENT -- IT IS
WONDERFUL WHEN WORKERS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN
BUT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND
GOSHEN ASIANS ARE NOT DIFFICULT
ARE NOT EASY EITHER VERY
DIFFICULT.
IF WE LOOK WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
YOU OF CW CURRENTLY THEY HAVE
TAKEN A STRIKE VOTE NAY MET VERY
WELL BE UP AND DOWN THE STATE
GOING ON STRIKE -- SO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IS SOMETHING ALL
WORKERS SHOULD BE AFFORDED BUT
NO ONE SHOULD SEE IT AS
SOMETHING IT'S EASY. ONE OF THE
REASONS I RAN FOR OFFICE IS
BECAUSE I WANTED TO BE HERE AND
HELP CHANGE LAWS THAT WOULD HELP
WORKERS I SEE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS GOING TO HELP WORKERS.
ARE OUTSIDE OF THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS THAT THERE
MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE.
US I AM VERY HAPPY TO BE
SUPPORTIVE TODAY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
SURE AND I WILL I'LL JUST NOTE
THAT -- YOU KNOW FOR YEARS YOU
SEE HAS HAS TO CREDIT CARD YEAH
YES THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
WHETHER THIS WOULD AFFECT THEM
THE WAY THE BILLS WERE WRITTEN
BEFORE BUT THEY HAVE DECLARED
THEIR INDEPENDENCE.
AND THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS FOR YOU HAVE THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT THAT
SOMETIMES WE WOULD LIKE.
AND WE RESPECT THAT WE RESPECT
IT SO MUCH THAT WE WANT TO GO TO
THE CONSTITUTION AND SAY IS THIS
A PUBLIC POLICY.
THAT VOTERS THINK IS IMPORTANT --
YOU KNOW WE OFTEN HEAR OF OF YOU
SEE JUST BY MYSELF ALMOST AS A
FOURTH FORM OF GOVERNMENT IN
CALIFORNIA I'M THEY ARE SO
INDEPENDENT AND SO.
THE ONLY WAY THAT WE CAN IN
TRYING PUBLIC POLICY THE WAY
THAT WE WOULD WANT -- TO
LEGISLATIVELY IS TO ALLOW THE
THE VOTERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN ON A DECISION LIKE THIS
AND I THINK IT'S THAT IMPORTANT
WHEN YOU READ OUR CONSTITUTION
YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE TRYING THEIR AT IT IT'S
AMAZING YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO FISH.
YOU KNOW -- PROBABLY IS PRETTY
IMPORTANT I THINK I I THINK I
AYE JOCKEY TO BILL FOR YOU ABOUT
RAIN WATER AND AND TAX YOU KNOW --
THAT WITH THAT WAS IT IT'S NOW
I'M TRYING TO NOT CONSTITUTION
ALL ALL IMPORTANT I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT THEY'RE NOT
IMPORTANT.
BUT SO IS EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY AT THE THIRD LARGEST
EMPLOYER IN THE STATE AND THAT'S
ALL WE'RE SAYING IS IT IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT THE VOTERS ONE
WAY AND ON TO SAY IT'S IMPORTANT
ENOUGH TO IN TRYING IN OUR
ONSTITUTION AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR WE'RE NOT
ASKING. FOR YOU -- TO TO SUPPORT
THAT IDEA BECAUSE MAYBE YOU
DON'T I MEAN I I UNDERSTAND
PEOPLE CAN HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS
ON THAT WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
ALLOW THE VOTERS TO DECIDE.
RESPECT LAST NIGHT.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM TWENTY THREE AC A FOURTEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS LEYVA.
AYE LEYVA AYE WILK WILK I CHIANG
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER.
WHERE CAN I CAN I?
THAT IS ENOUGH THOSE TO GET OUT
BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS BEFORE WE OPEN
THE ROLE ON BILLS THAT -- FOLKSY
TO ADD ON TO WE HAVE AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
AND THIS IS FOR A VOTE ONLY.
THE BILL FAILED PASSAGE IN THIS
COMMITTEE ON JUNE TWENTY SIX HAS
NOT BEEN AMENDED THERE'S NO
DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION MAY STATE THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY.
SO AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO CALL
UP ANY SUPPORT FOR A BI FOURTEEN
SIXTY TO THE MICROPHONE.
NAME AND SUPPORT PLEASE JOHN
KERR PERCENT OF THE STATE
UNIVERSITY I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
RAY BY CO SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY HAS TO SUPPORT THE
BILL STRONGLY THANK YOU.
IS THE MARINO FORMER CSU FACULTY
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MALINA ABDOULAYE PAN AFRICAN
STUDIES AT CAL STATE LA
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND BLACK LIVES MATTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ELAINE NEWMAN CINEMA STATE
UNIVERSITY STRONG SUPPORT.
STEPHEN FILLING STANISLAUS STATE
STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL PROCTOR SOCIAL ACTIVISM
I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
AND STRUM CSU STANISLAUS OF
STRONG SUPPORT ALSO WE HAD ABOUT.
TEN ETHNIC STUDIES STUDENTS FROM
STAND STATE HERE AND SO I'D LIKE
TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT AS WELL
THANK YOU.
RARE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OBVIOUSLY SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AND ALSO AS A GYM
FACULTY AT SACRAMENTO.
JULIE SEVERAS I MADE AS A DOUBLE
MAJOR STUDENT AT CSU STANISLAUS
WITH EXPERTISE REPRESENTING
MATCHA OF CENTRAL VALLEY AND
EIGHT EIGHTY TWELVE DELEGATE IN
STRONG SUPPORT -- DIMS MAKE THAT
IN DOUBLE MAJOR WITH I THINK
STAYS IN BUSINESS FROM
STANISLAUS STATE AND IN FULL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
CATHERINE NELSON ACADEMIC SENATE
CSU WE RESPECTFULLY CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
HOW THRILLED ASSOCIATE VICE
CHANCELLOR OF ACADEMIC PROGRAMS
INNOVATIONS AND FRANKLY
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE CSU THE CSU
CONTINUES TO OPPOSE THIS BILL?
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO BRING
THIS BACK TO THE COMMITTEE --
WE'RE NOT DISCUSSING IT BUT DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I AM TWENTY FIVE A. B. FOURTEEN
SIXTY THE MOTION IS TO TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILK CHIANG.
WRESTLE WRESTLE AYE GLAZER
MCGUIRE CAN.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON ALL RIGHT WE
ARE NOW GOING TO LIFT THE CALL
ON BILLS WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH [inaudible]
FINAL.
RESTORE WITH FILE ITEM IS A
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR FOUR
SENATOR WILL CAUSE BEEN HERE
ALMOST THE ENTIRE TIME.
SO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ITEM TWENTY FOUR AC ARE SIXTY
FOR THE MOTION AS YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
THREE ZERO WILK HI WILK I CHIANG.
REQUIRE PAN HI CAN I WE BELIEVE
THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
YEAH WE'RE GOING TO START
.
SO ITEM ONE AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO TO
TO CHANGE.
MCGUIRE PAN PAN HI.
THAT PHONE CALL.
ITEM TWO A. B. FIFTEEN OH SEVEN
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS OF THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO.
TO TO CHANGE.
CHIANG NO.
FIRE PAN.
PAN I THE BILL ON CALL.
ITEM THREE AB TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE I SURE
VOTING I FOUR ZERO CHANG.
CHANG I REQUIRE PAN.
PAN I BELIEVE THAT THE LONG CALL.
ITEM SEVEN AB FOR NINETY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FOUR ZERO CHIANG.
MCGUIRE PAN CAN I THAT PHONE
ITEM EIGHT AB NINE A ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FIVE
ZERO CHIANG [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
WITH THAT PHONE CALL.
ITEM NINE A. B. NINE THIRTY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
THREE ZERO CHIANG.
I GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN CAN I LEAVE
THAT PHONE CALL.
ITEM TEN A. B. TEN THIRTY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO MCGUIRE PAN.
CAN I WITH THAT PHONE CALL.
ITEM TWELVE AB TWELVE NINETEEN
THE MOTION ISTO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE I SURE VOTING I FOUR
ZERO GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE THAT PHONE CALL.
ITEM FIFTEEN AB THIRTEEN FORTY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FOUR ZERO CHANG.
CHANG AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN HI WITH THAT PHONE CALL.
I AM SIXTEEN AB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING
THREE ZERO WILK CHANG.
CHANG AYE MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
THE BILL ON CALL.
ITEM SEVENTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN
FORTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
THREE ZERO CHANG.
CHANG I ASAL LASSELL AYE MCGUIRE
PAN PAN I BELIEVE THAT BELONG
CALL.
I AM EIGHTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN
FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING THREE ZERO WILK
CHANGE -- MCGUIRE PAN.
YES YES CAN I PHONE CALL.
I AM TWENTY AB THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE VICE
CHAIR VOTING I SIX ZERO REQUIRE
[inaudible]
WITH.
THAT WHEN I CALL.
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SIX THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FOUR
ZERO CHANG.
CHANG I DO NOT SELL WITH US SO I
AM MCGUIRE.
IS THAT PHONE CALL.
I AM.
TWENTY THREE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AC
ARE SIXTY FOR THE MOTION IS YOU
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I FIVE ZERO CHANG.
CHANG I MCGUIRE.
I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL.
I AM TWENTY FIVE AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE NOT VOTING.
TWO ZERO WILK CHANGE CHANGE I
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
WELL IS THAT THE LONG CALL IF.
YOU CAN SEVERAL QUICK
[inaudible]
YEAH.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
SO CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING
I FIVE ZERO MCGUIRE PAN.
CAN I VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU SIR PANEL BE OVER SOON
AS I CAN.
ALL RIGHT SOUNDS GOOD.
THEY WOULD WAIT AND THEN WE HAVE
ITEM.
ONE ONE ITEM ONE AB FIFTEEN OH
FIVE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE I SURE VOTING NO.
THREE TO TO CHANGE CHEN NO
[inaudible]
WIRE.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILLING CALLS
WELL ALL RIGHT WE'RE JUST
WAITING FOR CENTER MCGUIRE
.
THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT.
FORTY THREE I AM TOO AB FIFTEEN
OH SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE I
SURE VOTING NO.
THREE THREE FIRE MCGUIRE AYE THE
BILL IS OUT.
FORTY THREE ITEM THREE AB TO THE
MOTION AS YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO FOUR NINETY THREE THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
FIVE ZERO CHIANG MCGUIRE.
HI MCGUIRE ICE.
THE BILLS OUT.
SIX ZERO ITEM EIGHT AB NINE A
ONE THE MOTION AS YOU PASSAS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I FIVE ZERO CHIANG
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI.
THAT BILLS OUT.
SIX ZERO ITEM NINE EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO GLAZER MCGUIRE.
I BILLS OUT.
SIX ZERO ITEM TEN AB TEN THIRTY
SIX THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THE BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM TWELVE AB TWELVE
NINETEEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS BUT THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
I FIVE ZERO GLAZER MCGUIRE.
THAT BILLS OUT.
FIVE ZERO ITEM FIFTEEN AB
THIRTEEN FORTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM SIXTEEN A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE THE MOTIONIS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AS CHAIR
NOT VOTING FIVE ZERO WILK
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
BILLS OUT.
SIX ZERO ITEM SEVENTEEN A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY FOR THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THE BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM EIGHTEEN A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
FOR ZERO WILK CHIANG MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE THAT BILLS OUT.
FIVE ZERO ITEM TWENTY EIGHTY
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THE BILL IS AL SEVEN
SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU.
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB SIXTEEN SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THE BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM TWENTY THREE AC
EIGHT FOURTEEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I FIVE ZERO GLAZER
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SIX THAT BILLS OUT.
SIX ZERO I AM TWENTY FOUR AC ARE
SIXTY FOR THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AYE
STRUGGLING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THE BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM TWENTY FIVE A.
B. FOURTEEN SIXTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AYE SURE
NOT VOTING.
THREE ZERO WILK GLAZER MCGUIRE
FIVE MCGUIRE I CAN GET THOSE OUT.
FOUR ZERO ALL RIGHT CONSENT
CALENDAR REALLY QUICK.
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE MCGUIRE I CAN SAY
CALENDARS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK
YOU EVERYONE SENATE EDUCATION.
STANDS ADJOURNED